GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM CALLING THE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER.
I WILL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
[inaudible]
HERE.
O'DONNELL HERE.
KILEY.
KILEY HERE KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH HERE WEBER.
THANK YOU CORPS HAS BEEN
ESTABLISH I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO TODAY'S HEARING.
WE HAVE THIRTY EIGHT BILLS ON
FILE TODAY INCLUDING TWELVE THAT
ARE ON CONSENT THE MEASURES ON
CONSENT ARE AS FOLLOWS A. B.
THIRTY AB TWO SEVENTY TWO WITH A
MOMENT'S AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS.
AB SEVEN ONLINE WITH AMENDMENTS
AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS AB ELEVEN NINETEEN
WITH THE MOMENTS AB TWELVE FORTY
A. B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS A BEACH.
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT WITH THE MOMENTS AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
HERE THANK YOU FOR CORRECTING ME.
THEREFORE MEASURES HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA OF THOSE
MEASURES ARE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO A.
B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY FOUR EIGHT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING ON THESE MEASURES.
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE A. B. FIFTEEN
OH SIX A. B..
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN IN ORDER TO IT
THE OKAY OKAY.
IN ORDER IN ORDER IN ORDER TO EX
EX BUT I THE SETTING THE BILL'S
ANOTHER COMMITTEES AUTHORS WILL
BE AGREEING TO AMENDMENTS TODAY.
AND THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
PROCESSED AND THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
AUTHORS THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ONLY TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SPEAKING FOR AN HOUR FOR NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES TO TWO INTO.
ALL OTHER SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
MAY LINE UP AT THE MICROPHONE
AND STATE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
SORT I MEAN BY THAT.
WE'RE GONNA THE MAIN WITNESSES
COME UP THEY'RE GONNA TESTIFY
THERE TYPICALLY TWO FOR EACH
BILL THERE'S ONE BILL TODAY
THAT'S THREE WHICH IS UNUSUAL
BUT WE'RE DOING IT THAT WAY.
ON THE FIRST BILL OF THREE MAIN
WITNESSES THEY'RE GONNA COME TO
THE TABLE -- BUT WHEN WE GO TO
THE PUBLIC WHEN YOU LINE UP --
SO WHAT YOU SIMPLY DO IS WALK UP
TO THE MICROPHONE STATE YOUR
NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY IF YOU STATE ANYMORE
YOU WILL BE CUT OFF AND KEEPS
HAPPENING WILL CUT EVERYBODY OFF
SO PLACE AN ORDER TO HEAR
EVERYBODY'S OPINION.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THAT
PROTOCOL THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE ARE WE READY TO
BEGIN WITH OUR SPECIAL ORDER I
WILL BE PRESENTING THE FIRST
MEASURE -- AND THAT IS AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE AND THAT IS FILE
ITEM.
IT'S FILE NUMBER TWENTY NINE I'M
GONNA HAND THEY GETOVER TO MR
KILEY MY VICE CHAIR THAT IS NOW.
THE CHAIR THERE WE GO MR KILEY.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU I MISTER BOND WHO'S
GOING TO SENATE WITH ME AS WELL
TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK FIRST
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE REFORMS THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZATION
APPEALS AND RENEWAL PROCESS.
WE ARE ALL AWARE THAT THIS IS A
TOPIC OF MUCH DISCUSSION INSIDE
THIS CAPITAL AND OUTSIDE THIS
CAPITAL.
IN FACT THERE ARE MANY RECENT
AND NOT SO RECENT MEDIA REPORTS
ABOUT THE NEED TO REFORM THE
CURRENT PROCESS.
NOT TO ELIMINATE IT BUT TO
REFORM IT IN FACT THERE BEEN
MANY MEDIA REPORTS HERE SOME
HEADLINES RECENT.
CALIFORNIA'S BROKEN CHARTER
SCHOOL LAW HAS DEFIED REFORM.
CAN NEWSOME BREAK THE GRIDLOCK.
HOW A COUPLE WORK CHARTER SCHOOL
REGULATIONS TO MAKE MILLIONS?
SMALL DISTRICTS REAP BIG PROFITS
BY APPROVING CHARTER SCHOOLS
WITH LITTLE OVERSIGHT.
HOW A TINY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT SPARK CALLS FOR CHARTER
CRACKDOWN?
CELEBRITY CHARTER SCHOOL FOUNDER
TO PLEAD GUILTY TO CONSPIRACY
CHARGES.
PROSECUTORS SAID.
AND THERE ARE MANY MORE.
AGAIN RECENT ARTICLES IN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS DOCUMENT THE REASONS
WHY IT IS TIME TO REFORM CHARTER
SCHOOL OUT LAWS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND LET'S REMEMBER THERE ARE
MORE CHARTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEN THERE ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
CLEARLY SOME BUT NOT ALL.
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE WEAKNESSES IN
CURRENT LAW.
WHICH IS LED TO PERSISTENT
CORRUPTION AND DAMAGE TO OUR
DISTRICT SCHOOLS AND ALL
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CLEARLY WE NEED TO SHORE UP THIS
LAW.
THIS LAW DOES NOT GET RID OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT SHORES UP A
LAW THAT AUTHORIZES AND OVER
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS -- LAWS ALLOW THOSE
SEEKING TO OPEN A CHARTER SCHOL
TO GO AUTHORIZED YOUR SHOPPING.
SIMPLY PUT WAS AUTHORIZING
SHOPPING ME.
SIMPLY PUT THIS MEANS THAT AFTER
BEING REJECTED BY ONE BOARD THEY
CAN GO SEARCHING FOR AN OTHER
BOARD FOR APPROVAL AND THIS IS
OFTEN HAPPEN.
WHY IS THAT A PROBLEM?
THE DISTRICT WHERE THE CHARTER
IS LOCATED NOT ONLY LOSES THEIR
STUDENTS TO A SCHOOL THEY DID
NOT BELIEVE WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR STUDENTS.
BUT MUST PROVIDE FACILITIES AND
OTHERWISE A COMEDY THAT CHARTER
IN THEIR OWN DISTRICT EVEN
THOUGH THEY DID NOT APPROVE IT.
FURTHER THE OVERSIGHT OF THAT
CHARTER IS BY AN ENTITY THAT IS
NOT LOCATED.
IN THEIR DISTRICT AND IN FACT
MAYBE HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY.
THIS LACK OF OVERSIGHT CAN LEAD
TO POOR FISCAL MANAGEMENT AND
POOR STUDENT OUTCOMES AND IN
FACT.
HAS MANY TIMES ACROSS OUR STATE.
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND
ADMINISTRATORS KNOW THEIR
DISTRICTS AND THEIR STUDENTS
BEST AND SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DETERMINE WHICH CHARTERS CAN
BEST SERVE THEIR STUDENTS THEIR
LOCAL STUDENTS.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES RATHER THAN
REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO APPROVE
CHARTER PETITIONS.
THIS GIVES LOCAL DISTRICTS THE
SAME AUTHORITY THAT THEY
ORIGINALLY HAD WHEN THE LAW WAS
WRITTEN IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WE MUST
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CONSIDER ANY FISCAL ACADEMIC OR
FACILITIES IMPACT A CHARTER
SCHOOL MAY HAVE.
A NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AND ONCE CHARTERS ARE APPROVED
THIS BILL REQUIRES AUTHORIZE
RESTRICT SITTER THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
DURING RENEWAL.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE AUTHORIZED
TO IDENTIFY AND RESPOND TO A
PROBLEM BEFORE IT BECOMES AN
EMERGENCY.
WHEN I CHARTER SUDDENLY CLOSES
OR SHUT DOWN IT IS DEVASTATING
FOR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST PICK
UP THE PIECES TO MAKE SURE?
THOSE STUDENTS ARE SERVED
EDUCATED.
AN EXAMPLE LAST YEAR IN
SACRAMENTO A CRISIS SITUATION
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED IF THIS
DISTRICT HAD LOCAL CONTROL.
THURMOND COLLEGIATE ACADEMY WAS
INITIALLY DENIED BY SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND TONIGHT AGAIN BY THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL PROBLEMS.
THE SCHOOL WAS APPROVED.
BY THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
IT'S WERE NOTIFIED THAT THE
SCHOOL WAS CLOSING ON THE VERY
DAY IT CLOSED DUE TO FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS.
THIS SCHOOL CLOSURE LEFT
STUDENTS STRANDED AND IT COULD
HAVE EASILY BEEN AVOIDED.
APPROVED ON APPEAL.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE MANY
STORIES LIKE THIS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL REFORM THE APPEAL
PROCESS SO THAT SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS.
ARE NOT REPEATED.
THIS BILL GIVES CHARTER
AUTHORIZES THE TOOLS TO HOLD
CHARTER SCHOOLS MORE ACCOUNTABLE.
BY ALLOWING THE AUTHORIZED TO
SHORTEN THE RENEWAL PERIOD. FOR
STRUGGLING SCHOOLS.
FURTHERMORE ANOTHER WAS RIGHT
NOW IT'S IT'S FIVE YEARS THEY
CAN ACTUALLY.
DESIGNATE A NUMBER UNDER THAT.
OF COURSE BECAUSE FIVE IS JUST
TOO LONG.
WHEN THEY HAVE FISCAL PROBLEMS
FURTHER TO ENSURE THAT CHARTER
TEACHERS ARE QUALIFIED THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT ALL TEACHERS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS MUST HOLD?
THE REQUIRED CREDENTIAL FOR
THEIR ASSIGNMENT.
ALLOWING CHARTERS TO HIRE AND
TRAIN TEACHERS ONLY HURTS
STUDENTS.
FINALLY.
THE BILL ALLOWS CHARTERS TO
RECEIVE VALUABLE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN A TIMELY MATTER AS
CURRENTLY PROVIDED FOR OTHER
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN CHARTERS ARE STRUGGLING
ACADEMICALLY?
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS.
THIS BILL CLOSE EXISTING CHARTER
SCHOOLS NO.
THIS BILL WILL NOT SHUT DOWN
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL MAY POTENTIALLY SLOW
THE GROWTH OF NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHY BECAUSE SOME OF THE
NEFARIOUS OPERATORS WILL RECEIVE
MORE SCRUTINY AND POTENTIALLY.
NOT BE APPROVED BUT IT WILL
AUTOMATICALLY CLOSE ANY SCHOOL.
IF YOU'RE A GOOD CHARTER
OPERATOR THERE'S NOTHING FOR YOU
TO WORRY ABOUT IN THIS BILL
AGAIN.
IF YOU ARE A GOOD CHARTER SCHOOL
OPERATOR THERE'S NOTHING FOR YOU
TO WORRY ABOUT IN THIS BILL.
THIS BILL GRANDFATHERS IN ALL
EXISTING CHARTERS THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THERE ARE TWENTY NINE CHARTERS
AUTHORIZED BY THE STATE BOARD
THAT WILL NEED TO RETURN TO THE
LOCAL DISK SCHOOL DISTRICT WHEN
THEY ARE UP FOR RENEWAL.
THIS WILL RETURN OVERSIGHT.
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AS THEY HAVE BEEN VERY LAX.
WELL THIS BILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CLOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AT RENEWAL FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT FINANCIAL ACADEMIC OR
FACILITIES IMPACT.
THE INTENT IS TO ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CONSIDER THE FISCAL
IN THE FISCAL ACADEMIC AND
FACILITIES IMPACT DURING THE
REVIEW OF A PETITION FOR A NEW
CHARTER SCHOOL OR FOR A SCHOOL.
THAT IS EXPANDING ENROLLMENT.
BUT NOT FOR EXISTING SCHOOLS I
AM HAPPY TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES TO CLARIFY THE INTENT OF
THIS.
AND WE ALL DRESSES AND FUTURE
MOMENTS WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
NEXT HOW THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT'S TASK FORCE ON
FISCAL IMPACT AND CHARTER
AUTHORIZING IMPACT THE BILL.
I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR IN
SUPERINTENDENT FOR CLEARLY
SIGNALING THAT MORE CHARTER
REFORM IS NEEDED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE TASK
FORCE WHICH MAY HELP INFORM AND
CHANGE THE BILL.
THE LEGISLATURE IS A SEPARATE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND WE
SHOULD IT TURMAN OUR PRIORITIES
AND MOVE FORWARD WE SHOULD NOT
KICKED THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD WE
SHOULD ACT TODAY WE SHOULD NOT
WAIT FOR A COMMITTEE THAT IS
OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING. TO COME
AND TELL US WHAT TO DO WHAT WE
LISTEN TO THEM ABSOLUTELY WILL
INCORPORATE SOME OTHER IDEAS I'M
SURE WE WILL -- AND WITH THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA IT WAS ONE
OF THE JOINT AUTHORS OF THE BILL
AND HE WOULD LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS FOLLOWED BY THREE
WITNESSES MISTER CHAIR.
WHICH IS APPROVED PRIOR TO THE
HEARING OAKLAND UNIFIED BOARD
PRESIDENT ANYTHING.
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED A TRUSTEE
RICHARD BARRERA AND REMOVE THE
WORLD UNIFIED TRUSTEE CITY
GARDENER SPEAKING ON BEHALF TO
THE STANDARD YOU KNOW COUNTY
OFFICE AND OTHER AREA DISTRICTS.
MISTER CHAIR I TURN ABOUT YOU
MISTER BONTA I THINK IT'S NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
ON AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE TODAY AS A
CO AUTHOR THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT HAS.
LARGELY BEEN UNTOUCHED SINCE IT
WAS ENACTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO CALIFORNIA
NOW FINDS ITSELF FAR REMOVED
FROM THE ORIGINAL MISSION AND
VISION OF THE ACT WHICH WASN'T
PART MEANT TO HELP GENERATE
INNOVATION. TO BENEFIT STUDENTS
IN ALL SCHOOLS.
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES THE
GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS HAS
STEADILY DRAINED MONEY AWAY.
FROM TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AS A RESULT NUMEROUS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE FACING SERIOUS
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
IN MY OWN HOME DISTRICT.
THEY TO THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATIONS.
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
WITH NEARLY 30% OF STUDENTS
ATTENDING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN OPEN UNIFIED
FACED A FISCAL SHORTFALL OF
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
OTHER DISTRICTS LIKE SAN DIEGO
SANTA CLARA AND INGLEWOOD.
ALSO FACE SIMILAR FISCAL
PRESSURES THESE DISTRICTS ALSO
HAVE A LARGE CHARTER SCHOOL
PRESENCE.
SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARD TO MAKING
CUTS IN STAFFING AND FACILITIES
AS STUDENT ENROLLMENT DECLINES
BUT DISTRICTS.
ARE AT A BREAKING POINT.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS HAVE A
FIDUCIARY DUTY TO ENSURE THE
FISCAL HEALTH.
OF THEIR DISTRICT THAT IS THEIR
MOST FUNDAMENTAL A CRITICAL ROLE
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE A VIABLE
FISCALLY SOUND SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AB FIFTY NO FIVE WOULD
AUTHORIZED LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
TO CONSIDER.
HOW A PROPOSED CHARTER SCHOOL
WHEN SEEKING ORIGINAL
AUTHORIZATION COULD IMPACT A
DISTRICTS FISCAL HEALTH?
AS WELL AS HOW IT MAY IMPACT IT
DISTRICTS EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
AND FACILITIES.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN THE ABILITY OF
CHARTER AUTHORIZES THE WHOLE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
AB FIFTY NO FIVE WOULD PERMIT
THE CONSIDERATION OF A CHARTER
SCHOOLS FINANCIAL STABILITY.
DURING THE RENEWAL PROCESS SO
THAT A SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
IDENTIFY AND APPROPRIATELY
RESPOND TO A PROBLEM.
WITH ASSISTANCE BEFORE IT
BECOMES.
AN EMERGENCY.
MOREOVER SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED
PARTNERS IN INNOVATION NOT
COMPETITORS.
ALONG WITH THE OTHER GOALS OF
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT CARTER
SCHOOLS ARE MEANT TO GENERATE
INNOVATION.
NOT PROVIDE DUPLICATION.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CHARTERS
IN THEIR PETITION TO DESCRIBE
WHY THEY'RE PROPOSED MODEL.
COULD NOT BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHIN.
THE EXISTING TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL STRUCTURE.
LASTLY SCHOOL BOARDS ARE ELECTED
BY AND ACCOUNTABLE.
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
ENTRUSTED TO MAKE FINAL
DECISIONS ABOUT THE EDUCATION OF
THE STUDENTS LIVING WITHIN THE
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
AUTHORIZED AND OVERSEEN.
BY LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
BEST UNDERSTAND THE EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS OF THEIR LOCAL STUDENTS.
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AB FIFTY NO FIVE WILL CREATE
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY AND A
STRONGER EMPHASIS ON EMPOWERING
LOCAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE WE
HAVE WITNESSES HERE.
STARTING WITH OAKLAND UNIFIED
BOARD PRESIDENT.
A MEETING.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
MISSING.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS A MEETING PRESIDENT
OF THE BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE DIRECTLY SERVE THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS VERY DISTRICT
SCHOOLS.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE FORTY FOUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS OPERATING IN
OAKLAND SERVING SIXTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
THIS MEANS THAT ARE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOW SERVING 27% OF
OAKLAND'S PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
OF STUDENTS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
IN THE STATE.
IN THIS RATIO IS EVEN HIGHER AT
THE MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL WHERE
OVER A THIRD 34% OF OUR MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS ARE NOW IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
THE FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT AND
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES ARE
COMPLEX AND NEED TO BE SUPPORTED
BY STATE LAW IN ORDER TO BE
BETTER ADDRESSED AND BEST
ADDRESSED LOCALLY. FOR EXAMPLE
THE CURRENT CURRENT APPEALS
PROCESS HAD LIMITED THE
DISTRICT'S OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
IN OUR ROADS OUR ABILITY TO PLAN
FOR LONG TERM FISCAL HEALTH.
OF OAKLAND'S FORTY FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS NINE ARE APPROVED BY THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION MANY
AFTER INITIAL REJECTION BY THE
LOCAL UST BOARD.
AND ONE WAS APPROVED BY THE
STATE LAST SUMMER AT THE SAME
TIME THAT VIC MAC AND OTHER
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY GRAND JURY.
CRITICIZED OUR DISTRICT FOR
OPERATING TOO MANY SCHOOLS IN
ASKING US TO GET OUR FISCAL
HOUSE IN ORDER.
THERE IS A CLEAR FINANCIAL
EDUCATIONAL IMPACT TO THE EXTENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS CONTRIBUTE TO
THE CONCENTRATION OF OUR HIGHEST
NEED STUDENTS INCLUDING LATE
ARRIVING NEWCOMER AND SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS.
AS A WHOLE OAKLAND CHARTER
SCHOOLS SERVE.
LAST SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
AND ALSO LESS.
MODERATE TO SEVERE US STUDENTS
WITH MODERATE AND SEVERE
DISABILITIES.
AS USTA'S OVER ALL STUDENT
POPULATION DECREASES OUR
PROPORTION OF STUDENTS WITH
SEVERE DISABILITIES IS
INCREASING IN OUR DISTRICTS
CONTRIBUTION TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES HAS INCREASED.
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
LAST THREE YEARS TO NEARLY A
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTION FROM OUR GENERAL
EDUCATION FUND.
AND OUR POPULATION -- OUR
SPECIAL JEKYLL EDUCATION
POPULATION IS CONTINUING TO
INCREASE.
ONLY SIX OF THE THIRTY FOUR OPEN
AUTHORIZED CHARTER SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATE IN OUR O. U. S. D.
SELVA.
WHICH ALSO LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ECONOMIES OF
SCALES IN TERMS OF SERVING OUR
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
EFFECTIVELY.
FINALLY DISTRICTS US SUCH AS
OAKLAND UP THAT ARE LARGE HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME BEING NIMBLE
ENOUGH TO WOULD MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE ENROLLMENT LOSS.
OR IN ROMAN LOSSES SPREAD ACROSS
THE CITY'S EIGHTY SEVEN DISTRICT
SCHOOLS MEANING IT'S DIFFICULT
TO CUT STAFF FOR PROGRAMS TO
ANYONE SCHOOL -- IT IS ALSO
DIFFICULT TO MAKE FURTHER
ADJUSTMENTS SUCH AS MERGERS
CONSOLIDATIONS ENCLOSURES TO GET
THE DISTRICT BACK ON SOLID
FINANCIAL FOOTING.
THE LAST TIME THE DISTRICT TRIED
TO CLOSE SCHOOLS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN AND TWELVE THEY TRY TO
CLOSE FIVE SCHOOLS AND ONE OF
THOSE SCHOOLS.
CONVERTED TO A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND WAS APPROVED TO THE COUNTY
IN THE DISTRICT LOS THOSE
STUDENTS.
THE ABOVE CHALLENGES HAVE IS
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL IMPACT
WITH WHICH LEADS TO UNCERTAINTY
AND ABILITY TO MAKE THOUGHTFUL
AND STRATEGIC DECISIONS ON
BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS IN IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF OUR STUDENTS.
WHICH LEADS -- TO AND WHICH
ULTIMATELY HAS AN IMPACT ON
STUDENT LEARNING.
AND THE ABILITY TO HAVE MORE
LOCAL CONTROL OVER AUTHORIZATION
INTO MANAGE CHARTER GROWTH
PARTICULARLY JUST TRICKS SUCH AS
OURS WITH OUR HIGHEST RATIO OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL.
ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND WE URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
AB FIFTY NO FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR STAYING
WITHIN THE TWO MINUTES VERY
CLOSE VERY GOOD.
YOUR NEXT OUR NEXT WITNESS HI
I'M RICHARD PERERA I'M WITH THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE ARE THE SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA WE SERVE A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND STUDENTS --
WITHIN OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE --
FORTY SIX CHARTER SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY OPERATING ARE ROUGHLY
17% OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION.
I CERTAINLY I SUPPORT OUTSIDE
THE AYE ISSUES ARE REGARDING THE
IMPACT THAT OAKLAND UNIFIED I
JUST SPOKE TO AND AND WE'VE
EXPERIENCED MANY OF THE SAME
ISSUES AND SAN DIEGO BUT I I
PARTICULARLY WANT TO SPEAK TO
THAT LOCAL CONTROL.
ASPECT OF THIS BILL -- WE TAKE
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS ELECTED
OFFICIALS -- VERY SERIOUSLY WHEN
A CHARTER PETITION COMES TO US
OR WHEN A RENEWAL COMES TO US.
I AND IN FACT WE I IN OVER THE
LAST SIX YEARS.
HI ON RENEWALS WE HAVE RENEWED
FIFTY EIGHT PETITIONS THAT HAVE
COME FORWARD TO OUR DISTRICT AND
WE DID NIGHT THREE WE ARE HARDLY
A DISTRICT THAT IS HOSTILE -- TO
TO OUR EXISTING CHARTER
COMMUNITY BUT WE DO HAVE AN
EXAMPLE I'D THAT IS VERY CURRENT
THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT HI
FREDA I KNOW ABOUT IF YOU DON'T
ALREADY.
WE HAD A SCHOOL SEVERAL EITHER
FIVE YEARS AGO THRIVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THEY CAYMAN PETITION TO
OUR DISTRICT.
WE HAD SERIOUS CONCERNS IN THE
PETITION ABOUT THE ABILITY OF
THRIVE -- TO SUCCESSFULLY
PROVIDE A QUALITY EDUCATION
PARTICULARLY HI TO YOU I
STUDENTS -- FACING SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED ENGLISH LEARNERS
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS TO
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
I AND WE DENIED THAT PETITION
AND AGAIN IT'S RARE I AND I'VE
IT IS MY ELEVENTH YEAR ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD IT'S RARE THAT WE
DID NOT AND AND INITIAL PETITION
BUT WE DENIED THAT.
ONE THRIVE IN APPEAL TO THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION WHICH
DENIED THE PETITION FOR MANY OF
THE SAME REASONS THAT WE HAD
IDENTIFIED.
THRIVE AN APPEAL TO THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION WAS GRANTED
IT AYE AYE CHARTER.
I AT THE TIME WAS GRANTED A
CHARTER FOR AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WITH FEWER THAN ONE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION TWICE APPROVED
MATERIAL REVISIONS THAT ALLOWED
THRIVE TO EXTEND TO A MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
AND NOW HAS A THOUSAND STUDENTS.
WHEN DR CAME TO US FOR RENEWAL
WE SAW SOME OF THE WORST
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES THAT WE'VE
EVER SEEN IN A CHARTER PETITION
WE DENIED THE STATE BOARD THEN
DENIED THE RENEW ALL?
AND NOW WE'RE IN A POSITION THAT
WE ARE READY TO WORK WITH ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO FIND
PLACEMENTS FOR THEM I THAT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED IF
OUR LOCALAUTHORITY THAT ARE
EXPECTED IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
WE ARE SUPPORT FOR THIS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU I'M A GARDENER.
IS -- IT IS ON GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CINDY GARDNER AND THE
TRUSTEE VICE CHAIR FOR SAND DABS
WHICH IS DECEMBER NINETEEN OH
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS AND ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD PRESIDENT PROGRAM IN THE
WORLD UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AT THE MARCH SAND DABS MEETING
WE VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BELIEVING THAT CHARTER
SCHOOL DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND STAY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WHILE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN DECEMBER
NINETEEN OH COUNTY HAVE GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
CHARTERS OPERATING WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES WE ALL
AGREED THAT THE DECISIONS REALLY
NEAT NEED TO BE REMAINING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
INCLUDING IN THAT DISCUSSION WAS
COUNTIES ASSEMBLY DINO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT TED ALL HUNDREDS.
OF VOICE OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AGAIN AGREEING COLLECTIVELY
WITH ALL OF US REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY THAT THE DECISIONS NEED
TO BE MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WITH THE DATA THAT DISTRICTS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO CONSIDER
THE FACTORS OF FINANCE
FACILITIES IN ACADEMICS.
RAN FACE TO CHARTER SCHOOL
PETITION WITH A MYRIAD OF RED
FLAGS FOR A BOARD AND DISTRICT
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS OF
SERVICES PROVIDED TO ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
THIS ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION
PROGRAM HAD CONTINUOUS BORDERS
ALL THE WAY TO SAN DIEGO AND WE
KNEW OUR SMALL DISTRICT STAFF
COULD NOT EFFECTIVELY OVERSEE A
MONITOR THIS ORGANIZATION.
WE KNEW WORKING WITH OUR
ATTORNEY ON THIS ISSUE WE COULD
NOT INCLUDE ISSUES OF FACILITIES
ALTHOUGH WE ONLY HAVE ONE HIGH
SCHOOL WITH ONE FOR FOOTBALL
FIELD ONE BASEBALL ONE STOP ALL.
AND WE SHARE THESE FACILITIES
WITH OUR YOUTH SPORTS PROGRAMS
BECAUSE FLAT SPACE IS A PREMIUM
ON THE MOUNTAIN AND WE'RE IN THE
MOUNTAINS.
SO A THIRD ENTITY CHALLENGING US
FOR THESE FACILITIES WOULD BEEN
HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC WE ALSO KNEW
THAT WE COULD NOT INCLUDE THE
ISSUES OF FINANCIAL HARDSHIP WE
ARE DISTRICT WOULD FACE.
IF THIS DISTRICT OPERATE WITHIN
OUR BOUNDARIES BECAUSE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IT'S READ A 5%
DECLINE FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WE ALSO ARE NOT THE
WINNERS OF THE LCS THAT FORMULA.
AND MOST OF THE HOMES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAPPEN TO BE RESORT
SECOND HOME OWNERS ONLY ABOUT
3240% OF OUR FAMILY.
OUR HOMES ARE ACTUALLY FAMILY SO
WE HAVE A VERY -- TIGHT
POPULATION WE KNEW WE WERE
FACING ARREST TO DENY THIS
CHARTER YET WE FELT BASED UPON
THE PETITION DOCUMENT.
THAT WE MADE THE BEST CHOICE FOR
OUR SCHOOLS WHERE THE FIGHTING
SCOTS EVERYBODY ON THE MOUNTAIN
IS A FIGHTING SCOTT AND SAN
BERNARDINO.
ALSO BELIEVES THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE THEIR OWN CHOICES THANK YOU
ARE WELL DONE I WILL HAVE ONE
THAT'S ONE OF THE OPPOSITION OF
THREE WITNESSES I BELIEVE THIS
ROUTE IS A FOR THE OPPOSITION.
THEY CAN COME FORWARD.
I'M SORRY MY FAULT I'M AHEAD OF
THINGS I APOLOGIZE MY HEAD WAS
SOMEWHERE ELSE -- STAY THERE --
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE REST OF
THE SUPPORT SO IF YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AND YOU ARE MEMBER THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO TO TO SPEAK TO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHAT YOU DO
IS YOU WALK UP TO WHAT ONE OF
THREE MICROPHONES THERE'S
THERE'S THREE OF THEM.
AND WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO IS
STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION MAYBE YOU'RE WITH A
GROUP MAYBE YOU'RE NOT YOU KNOW
YOU SAY IF YOU'RE NOT.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
THIS IS A UPS UP STAIRS THERE'S
A MICROPHONE TO SOMEWHERE.
THE SERGEANTS WILL POINTED OUT
UP THERE.
AND THERE'S ONE HERE SO.
THAT'S WHAT HOW AN OPERATOR'S
GONNA GO PRETTY QUICK HERE I
WANT EVERYBODY. TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN.
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
WELL.
THIS IS THE CHAIR SET BERMAN
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WERE CO SPONSORS I'M
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
IS THE DRIVER THANK YOU OP.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT MAY COME
FORWARD PLEASE MELANIE I CAN
ALTHOUGH ON BEHALF OF FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
JEFF FROST ON BEHALF OF THE OUR
DOCTOR ALMA HORACE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT IN ORANGE COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
LARA STRAND FLORIDA'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OR
CO SPONSORS WE ARE TRIBAL.
THE INJURY ON THE HALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
SEARS MORRIS SECOND GRADE
TEACHER IN RALEIGH CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HEATHER MAROS LEAVES FROM
WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT CUP ACROSS THE RIVER
AND THAT WE SUPPORT CSEA --
SPONSORED LET'S JUST LEGISLATION.
JOHN KERRY A TEACHER AND HE
LOOKS CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
KAREN FRIEDLAND WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M THE
STOREKEEPER AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY S. LIKE SIX THREE TEACHER
HURT SOME OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
SAN DIEGO AND I SUPPORT THE BILL.
JUST THAT I WOULD TERRACE THAT
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JEFF AFRAID AS PRESIDENT ELECT
OF C. F. T. AND WE'RE CO
SPONSORS THE BILL WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
AS WELL THE FERNANDES NOT THOMAS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS PRIDE ALSO NUMBER
HALF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES --
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VERONICA SANCHEZ AUBURN UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT
THIS.
A HUNDRED METERS TEACHER IN LOS
ANGELES -- THE GRANDPARENT
IMPAIRING THE PUBLIC SCHOOL KIDS
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK.
TERRY HOFSTETTER SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'M DENNIS **** THAT WITH THE A.
B. C. FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
I'M A RETIRED SCHOOL TEACHER AND
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ASK YOU TO VOTE YES.
KAREN SMITH THE SAM ONE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES AND SEE IF CA.
NICOLE PART TEN LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TWELFTH
GRADE ENGLISH TEACHER AT UCLA
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SALLY TO MARS TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED I'M A SCHOOL BUS DRIVER
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MICHAEL YOUNG ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IS
WHEN THE PRODUCT WILL SPONSOR
THE BILL THE SPORT.
LYNN ACOSTA WHEN RIVERS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
CARL WILLIAMS PRESIDENT OF THE
LAW AND FEDERATION OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES I'M A SENIOR CUSTODIAN
AT AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DEAR DEAR ALMOND SIMI FROM SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SANDRA SOTO THIRD GRADE TEACHER
MY PARENT.
MS WITH UT LA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
AND I BELIEVE NINE YEARS
POLITICAL DIRECTOR WITH UNITED
EDUCATORS OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
RAFEAL LOCUSTS FIRST GRADE
TEACHER AND PARENT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL I'M WITH YOU TELLING.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VICTORIA CASAS THIRD GRADE
TEACHER PARENT AND UNION
ACTIVIST RISING UP IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
DAM PLANS THE MATH TEACHER AT
BERKELEY HIGH -- PARENTS AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JOE HAD Y. DEL PRESIDENT LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE FACULTY GUILD IN
SUPPORT THANKING THE AUTHORS
URGING A YES VOTE -- EVERYBODY
KASKI SERENA'S COLLEGE CO CHAIR
I CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
DAVID LOOSE ALL WITH THE EL
CAMINO CLASS -- HELPING A
COLLEGE -- DISTRICT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
A SMALL FARM ABOUT A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER OAKLAND.
AND THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT
OAKLAND EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
AND WE SUPPORT AS WELL.
MATTHEW COGAN ADULT EDUCATION
UNITED TEACHERS LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THE TOY MORE A. F. T. CHAIR
LOCAL FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER REDONDO
BEACH AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YES HE JACKSON MEMBER OF THE
POTTER VALLEY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THIRTY YEAR VETERAN IN
WATSONVILLE CALIFORNIA I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BILL PHILLIPS RETIRED CUSTODIAN
SANTA CRUZ I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
SERRA HENNY PARENT AND TEACHER
IN THE POP ROVELLI UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DAVID HI AND HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
AND BUILDING UP WITH A. B. C.
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THE MAN WAS SERRANO
TEACHER -- PERRIN A HORRIBLE IF
I SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CONNIE MARTIN PRESIDENT.
OF COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE AND
PARENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PLEASE SANDRIDGE CALL CALIFORNIA.
I'M.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE SCHOOL BUS
DRIVER AND I AND I STAND FOR
THIS BILL SPORT.
JAMIE CROWDER CAUSE FEDERATION
OF CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
HUNTINGTON BEACH I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
LORI JONES GOAL TO LAMENT THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT CLASSIFIED.
SUPPORT.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CATHERINE MAPS TEACHER BERKELEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOT ELECTION READY I LIVE IN
CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL.
YOU HAVE THE HUSSAINI TEACHER
AND PARENT AT THE BERKELEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KAREN CHANDLER I LIVE IN SAN
JOSE I'M A PARENT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M TIM MCFADDEN I'M A TEACHER
IN NEWPORT MESA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUDGETS ARE GOING OUT THERE
GREAT TEACHER BERKELEY IF I
SCHOOL DISTRICT A MEMBER OF
BERKELEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WE GO TO MY PRESIDENT OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD T. K. TWELVE
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIPERS CFT AND
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THEN -- DODGE WHAT CITY
WATSONVILLE CA REAL COLLEGE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
STEVE MCDOUGAL PRESIDENT SLEAZE
BY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HARVEY A LEVELS AND I ASK USED
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M SEVENTY POLLUTES CAM A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER IN ABC AND A
MEMBER OF EIGHTY C. F. T. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MICHAEL SANDY.
CTF APPLESAUCE CAREER COLLEGE
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATIE BASSLER ENGLISH TEACHER
SALINAS CALIFORNIA SALINAS
VALLEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JILL YES A TALKIE TEACHER FROM
THE ABC FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SURE HE DAHLE MERCHANT.
OUR TEACHER SALINAS UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CATHERINE PASSED QUAL HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER A. B. C. F. T.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RACHEL SMITH FOURTH GRADE
TEACHER IN ABC UNIFIED AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY JONES RETIRED HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TOM HERMAN UNITED EDUCATORS OF
SAN FRANCISCO CLASSIFIEDS
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
VIDEOS AND JONES RETIRED TEACHER
FROM OAKLAND FORMER PRESIDENT
THE OAKLAND EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION I SUPPORT THIS BILL --
SEVENTY VACATE PARENT OF TWO
CHILDREN IN WEST CONTRA COSTA
UNIFIED AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LAUREN STEINER MY SON WENT TO
WEST WOULD CHARTER IN LAUSD IT
WAS RUN BY THE DISTRICT I AM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE
INVESTOR DRIVEN.
I REMEMBER.
HE STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
YOU WANT TO WIN ONE TIME.
NO NO NO NO NO THANK YOU.
BUT SHE'S SHE'S SHE'S THE
AUDIENCE RIGHT NOW GO AHEAD
MA'AM.
OKAY -- JIM MORDECAI RETIRED
TEACHER OAKLAND EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER
I SUPPORT THIS BILL I STAND IF I
COULD.
JEFF BEARS SUPERINTENDENT OF LOS
ALTOS SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MY CAPTION SEN FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA -- REPRESENTING OPEN
OPEN PUBLIC EDUCATION NETWORK IN
THE JOURNEY FOR JUSTICE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
STRESSING BROWN CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND CHECK
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS.
WE'RE GONNA HEAD UP STAIRS NOW.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU FOR THESE COMPANIES
WITH A BOTTLE VALLEY FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND A PARENT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SURE IT'S AROUND A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER IN STATE REVENUE PER
MESA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SANDRA LARSON PRESIDENT PETALUMA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND FIRST
GRADE TEACHER AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
KELLY COME HONEST I'M A TEACHER
AND A PARENT AT HELLO MY HIGH
SCHOOL AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I THAT GOT I KNOW I'M A MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHER A PARENT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RIGHT A CONCORD MAN TEACHER IN
POTTER VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARZUK -- OFFENDER -- HER ABOUT
A FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPECIAL
ED TEACHER AND MOTHER OF A CHILD
A DAUGHTER WITH SPECIAL NEEDS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY.
LAURIE SMACKED.
RETIRED TEACHER PARENT
GRANDPARENT NEWPORT MESA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ELENA ALLEN HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER IN SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
AND PART OF U. S. SCTA AND CFT.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
LARA SORROW ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER WITH THE PA HER --
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SEE IF TEAM MEMBER AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SERRA ALL WATER MY
FOURTH GRADE TEACHER AT NEWPORT
MESA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND CF TEAM MEMBER
AND PARENT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS BRIANNE CALL I AM A
SIXTH GRADE TEACHER AND NEWPORT
MESA AND A MEMBER OF THAT AND M.
F. T. AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
DAHLE FLORA IS ENGLISH TEACHER
IN THE NEWPORT MESA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CASEY CARLSON SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER SANTA CRUZ AND
GRANDMOTHER OF TWO DOT
GRANDDAUGHTERS IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
INGRID GET NOW UNITED TEACHERS
LOS ANGELES -- AND A PARENT OF
TWO BOYS IN GLENDALE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
TANYA GOLDEN TEACHER OF ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ELECTORAL HISTORY TEACHER
PRESIDENT OF A RANCHO FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND PICK RIVER I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PATTY I FOUND THAT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR ADD ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
STAND IN SUPPORT.
EVELYN JIMENEZ HOT ON FEDERATION
A CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND WE
STAND AS A PART OF THIS BILL.
MELINDA DART JEFFERSON
ELEMENTARY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN DALY CITY AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT.
POLYGON SIX GRADE TEACHER
PRESIDENT JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLINE PLEASE
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER FROM SALINAS
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
LYELL WILL CONSENSUS EDUCATION
TEACHER BFT AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JOSH AUSTIN TEACHER AT BERKELEY
HIGH SCHOOL IN BERKELEY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SAID REP.
REPRESENTING MY MEMBERS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION FACULTY AT
BERKELEY HIGH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DR BRIDGE JODIE WITH THE NEWPORT
MESA FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SEE IF T<c.cyan>ARENT OF THREE AND</c>
FOUND VALLEY IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE KISS SMITH ACCOUNTING
TECHNICIAN -- QUEEN A CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES SECRETARY TREASURER
LUCK FOR SEE IF T. AND I RISE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NO SCHNEIDERMAN -- STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY I SCHOOL IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL.
ROB SCHNEIDERMAN PRESIDENT OF
THE BECAUSE FEDERATION EDUCATORS
ORANGE COUNTY FACULTY UNION AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JOHN THE SUBKEY UNITED EDUCATORS
OF SAN FRANCISCO I RISE TO
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
DICEY CHAN BLACKBURN FIRST GRADE
TEACHER FOR UNITED EDUCATORS A
SALMON CISCO I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
CAROLINE SAMOA VICE PRESIDENT
FOR PARA EDUCATORS FOR UNITED
EDUCATORS AS SAN FRANCISCO I
RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LISA BLANC UNITED EDUCATORS A
SAN FRANCISCO RETIRED I RISE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JANE HARDLY PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATOR FOR NEWPORT MESA
UNIFIED I RISE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JOHN WITHOUT EVER RELATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR THE LA COLLEGE
FACULTY GUILD WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBER SISTER DEALS
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA ST
PATRICK'S COUNCIL.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS WE SUPPORT THIS
BUILD SUPPORT OUR TEACHERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW -- ONE MORE GO AHEAD
SIR.
THIS IS NOT GONNA GO OKAY --
WELL NOW MOVES TO THE
OPPOSITION'S.
THE MAIN SPEAKERS.
WILL COME FORWARD.
AND THEN WE'LL TURN TO THE
PUBLIC AFTER THEY HAVE
[inaudible]
PRESENTED
.
SO WE'LL HAVE THREE WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE THREE
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HASTEN
THOMAS I'M THE CEO OF EDUCATION
FOR CHANGE PUBLIC SCHOOLS A
CHARTER MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION
THAT OPERATES SEVEN CHARTER
PUBLIC SCHOOLS OAKLAND.
SERVING OVER THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS 90% OF WHOM QUALIFY FOR
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH I CAME TO
THE CHARTER SECTOR AFTER FIFTEEN
YEARS WITH AN OPEN UNIFIED TO
SEE IF THE FLEXIBILITY IS
EMBEDDED IN CHARTER LAW COULD
FACILITATE XCELERATED.
ACADEMIC GROWTH FOR HIGH POVERTY
STUDENTS IN EAST OAKLAND.
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY POORLY SERVED
FOR DECADES?
I AM DISMAYED BY THE DIVISION
AND SCAPEGOATING THAT AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE AS INVITED INTO AN
OTHERWISE REASONABLE DEBATE
ABOUT SUSTAINING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THE RESEARCH BY GORDON LATE FOR
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS RELYING ON
LEX RIGOR AND BASIC REVIEW.
THERE'S LITTLE CREDIBLE EVIDENCE
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS OF THE
CHIEF CAUSE OF DISTRICT
FINANCIAL DISTRESS AND FAXES
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION SKYROCKETING PENSION
AND BENEFITS COSTS.
WERE IDENTIFIED BY STANFORD
RESEARCH.
GETTING DOWN TO FAX IT TO REPORT
AS THE MAIN DRIVERS OF DISTRICTS
FILE JUST FISCAL DISTRESS AND
FRANKLY CHARTER FISCAL DISTRESS.
CHAIR O'DONNELL INDICATED THAT
AB FIFTY NO FIVE GRANDFATHER'S
EXISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ADD CODE FOUR SEVEN SIX OH SEVEN
NAMES AT RENEWAL STANDARDS ARE
GOVERNED BY CRITERION AT CODE
FOUR SEVEN SIX OH FIVE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION MODIFIES WHICH THIS
LEGISLATION MODIFIES TO ALLOW
DENIAL FOR NEGATIVE FINANCIAL
ACADEMIC OR FACILITIES IMPACT.
SO AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE STILL
GRANT SCHOOL DISTRICTS EXPANSIVE
DISCRETION TO CLOSE EXISTING
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND DENIES
EXISTING SCHOOLS MEANINGFUL DUE
PROCESS. TO OVERTURN DECISIONS
THAT ARE ENTIRELY DIVORCED FROM
THE EDUCATIONAL VALUES THE
CHARTERS ARE PROVIDING FOR MRS
MOST DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS.
STANFORD'S REPORTER FROM THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER THAN DISTRICT SCHOOLS IN
URBAN AREAS AND FOR
TRADITIONALLY LOWER PERFORMING
STUDENT GROUPS.
ISN'T THIS THE PRIORITY OF OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM TO SERVE
THE CHILDREN AND NOT THE
INSTITUTION.
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE IT'S TO
STARTING SCHOOL SYSTEMS AGAINST
EACH OTHER HOLD ON HOLD ON WE
CAN'T HAVE OUTBURSTS LIKE THAT.
IN THIS ROOM HEY.
EVERYBODY GETS A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD BY THE A LIKE IT OR YOU
DON'T THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS
OKAY AND WE'RE GONNA WORK RIGHT
NOW SO PLEASE PROCEED.
AB FIFTY NO FIVE PITS TO
STARVING SCHOOL SYSTEMS AGAINST
EACH OTHER DOES LITTLE TO
ADDRESS THE ENVIRONMENT A
SCARCITY THAT WILL TO LOOK
DOUBLE DEBILITATE ALL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE LONG TERM.
I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR AND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR BRINGING A
GROUP OF DIVERS PRACTITIONERS
TOGETHER TO RECOMMEND REVISIONS
I AM NOT OPPOSED REVISIONS TO
CHARTER LAW.
I BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT
PRACTITIONER VOICE THE VOICES OF
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND DOING THE
WORK MUST INFORM THE REVISIONS
THAT WILL HAVE A VERY REAL
IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF HUNDREDS
OF POTENTIAL CHILDREN.
IN HUNT THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL
CHILDREN AND HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT.
HI MY NAME IS LET THE GOMEZ AND
I HAVE THREE CHILDREN ONE OF
WHICH HAS A LEARNING DISABILITY
I AM ALSO A PROUD FOUNDING
PARENT OF A HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOL IN EAST SAN JOSE
WERE MY YOUNGEST CHILD ATTENDS.
HERE'S MY YOUNGEST DAUGHTER WITH
ME G. ANA WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE I NEIGHBORHOOD TRADITIONAL
DISTRICT SCHOOL IS A K. THROUGH
EIGHT SCHOOL AND ONLY 16% OF
STUDENTS ARE PROFICIENT IN MATH
AND 21% ARE PROFICIENT IN
ENGLISH.
I MY DAUGHTER'S CHARTER SCHOOL
IN THE SAME COMMUNITY 57% OF
STUDENTS ARE PROFICIENT IN MATH
AND 56% ARE PROFICIENT IN
ENGLISH ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA.
WHO IS MY REPRESENTATIVE EIGHTY
TWENTY SEVEN HAS COLD WATER THIS
BILL EVEN THOUGH IN HIS DISTRICT
FIFTY FIVE POINT 8% OF STUDENTS
THAT ATTEND CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO ATTEND A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY?
COMPARED TO ONLY TWENTY NINE
POINT 5% OF STUDENTS THAT ATTEND
DISTRICT SCHOOLS MY DAUGHTER'S
CHARTER SCHOOL IS THE TOP
PERFORMING SCHOOL IN ALUM ROCK
DISTRICT.
YET THIS BILL WILL GIVE POWER TO
LOCAL DISTRICT TO DENY RENEWALS
BASED ON FINANCIAL IMPACT ON
THEIR DISTRICT INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT ACADEMIC RESULTS.
GIVEN FINANCIAL POWER BACK TO
ALUM ROCK IS AN INJUSTICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY WHEN THE RECENT GRAND
JURY.
REPORT FOUND THAT THEY WERE MISS
MANAGING TAXPAYERS DOLLARS THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO TAKE AWAY OUR
COMMUNITY RIGHT.
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE
RIGHT TO SCHOOL CHOICE.
AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY I CAN NOT
AFFORD PRIVATE SCHOOL FOR MY
DAUGHTER AND WITH THE CURRENT
COST OF LIVING I CANNOT AFFORD
TO MOVE TO IN ORDER TO FIND A
SCHOOL THAT BEST SUPPORTER.
I WILL BE LEFT WITH THE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL IN THE EAST
SIDE OF SAN JOSE.
WHY ISN'T ANYONE TALKING ABOUT
FIXING FAILING SCHOOLS I HAVE
BEEN WAITING OVER THIRTY YEARS
FOR OUR PART EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE I CAN NOT CONTINUE TO
WAIT AT THE EXPENSE OF MY
DAUGHTER'S EDUCATION?
WE DESERVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION OPTIONS
THAT OUR COMMUNITY WITHOUT ALLOW
WE ARE DIFFICULT TO DEFINE OUR
CHILD OUT CUP WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER FOR ALL STUDENTS.
IF YOU VOTE YES ON THIS BILL YOU
ARE ALLOWING BOARD LIKE ALUM
ROCK TO DO WHAT IS BEST IN THEIR
OWN INTERESTS AND NOT IN THE
STUDENT.
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF STUDENT
LEARNING I ASK ALL OF YOU TO
PLEASE PUT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
FIRST NOT POLITICS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND FOR US
TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR NEXT -- IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DAVE GORDON I
WORK IS THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
TODAY I'M REPRESENTING OUR
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR
SACRAMENTO.
WE HAVE THREE REASONS OUR
BORDERS THREE REASONS FOR
OPPOSING THIS BILL NUMBER.
ONE ELIMINATES THE COUNTY BOARDS
OPPORTUNITY TO APPROVE COUNTY
WIDE CHARTERS GOING FORWARD.
OUR BOARD CERTAINLY HASN'T ABUSE
THAT PRIVILEGE AND FOURTEEN
YEARS.
THEY'VE ONLY APPROVED ONE COUNTY
WIDE CHARTER.
THE FORTUNE CHARTER SCHOOL WHICH
IS BEEN OPERATING FOR ABOUT
EIGHT YEARS NOW AND WAS.
INTRODUCED IN THE FIRST PLACE TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS AND IN FACT.
THE SCHOOL HAS OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS AT SIX
LOCATIONS NOW.
AND IS DOING EXACTLY THAT WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF THE PERFORMANCE OF
THE FOURTEEN SCHOOL.
SECONDLY THE BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE CHARTER APPEAL
PROCESS. FOR EXISTING CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHICH THE BOARD FEELS.
IS NECESSARY IN A DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM TO HAVE SOME -- REDRESS
IF UP IF THE PETITION IS TURNED
DOWN AND AGAIN THE PROCESS
HASN'T BEEN ABUSED IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM.
THERE HAVE BEEN THIRTEEN APPEALS --
NONE OF WHICH WAS APPROVED AND
IN FACT ONE OF THE ONES WAS THE
ONE THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED THAT
EVENTUALLY WENT TO THE STATE
BOARD.
AND WAS APPROVED IT HAD BEEN
TURNED DOWN BY THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BOARD.
AND FINALLY OUR BOARD BELIEVES
A. B. FIFTEEN FIVE FIFTEEN OH
FIVE IS PREMATURE AGAIN.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE WE BELIEVE HAS A HAS A
VERY VERY BALANCED -- MEASURED
GROUP TO LOOK AT THESE ISSUES
AND WE HOPE WILL COME UP WITH
SOME SOUTH SOLUTIONS SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NOW HERE FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC YOU MAY LINE UP --
THEY'LL BE WILL GO TO THE THE
THE FIRST.
FOR THE TWO MICROPHONES AND THEN
WILL GO UP TO THE SECOND AFTER
THE FIRST FLOOR IS COMPLETED.
SO AGAIN WHAT YOU DO SIMPLY IS.
TO BRING.
A CAMPER SEE THERE'S TOO MUCH
NOISE SO WHAT WHAT YOU MAY DO IS
WALK UP TO MY FRONT STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
WE WANT TO CHANCE FOR EVERYBODY
TO BE HEARD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
MY NAME IS SIMEON GANT AND MY
BUT MY FILIATION IS WITH THE
DOCTOR ALLEN ROLE SCHOOL.
DR HARDY BROWN SCHOOL DR HAZEM
HOME SCHOOL THE DOCTOR WILLIAM
LEAST SCHOOL PASTOR EAT FROM
WILLIAM SCHOOL THE REX AND
MARKET FORTUNE SCHOOL AND THE
ENTIRE PORCHES SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM JAZZ MEANS TOWARDS --
STUDENT AREN'T RIO VALLEY
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ALFRED BROWN
I'M THE UP PRESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD.
ALSO PROFESSOR EMERITUS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GENET PRUITT I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO BOYS AND A SPECIAL
NEEDS DAUGHTER -- I REPRESENT
HAZEM HOME COLLEGE PREP --
FORTUNE SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI JOANNA HOLE I I AM THE VICE
CHAIR FOR THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR TRUST
AREA FOR MáS SO A PARENT OF
CHILDREN IN TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND A CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND SAN WHEN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE I'M CHEN AND
NOLAN GRANDMOTHER OF THREE OF
PAYS THE MY HOME. FOURTEEN
SCHOOL IN AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
REBEL AND ONE PARENT OF THREE
CHILDREN IN TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. ONE WAS A FIVE OR PLAN
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KIANA AND I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN AND HAZEM HOME
COLLEGE PREP.
AND APPLES THIS BILL.
LOU SALIVA PARENT COLLEGE READY.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MONICA BLOCKS
AND I HAVE TO SCHOLARS AT HAYES
ON MY HOME -- FORTUNE SCHOOL AND
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CONNIE
RIVER I'M A PARENT ENGAGEMENT
SPECIALIST FOR ALLIANCE CALLS
RATED PUBLIC SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE THERE AND I
ALSO HAVE THREE CHILDREN A HAZEL
HOME COLLEGE PREP OF FORTUNE
SCHOOL AND I'M ALSO.
AND AND HAZEM HOME COLLEGE
PREPARATORY AND AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
PAT BROADENED EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR FROM CAIRO'S
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN BACK OF BILL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TO EACH OF OUR NET
I'M A PARENT AND ADMINISTRATOR
FOR NEW WHICH CHARTER IN LOS
ANGELES AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOANNE CARLY FROM BACK OF BILL
CALIFORNIA THE NEW BOARD MEMBER
AT CAIRO'S CHARTER SCHOOL IN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHARON WE'RE AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR A
HIGH VERY HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOL CALLED NEW WEST
IN LOS ANGELES AND I VIDEO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS FIFTEEN OH
FIVE BELL.
VICTOR BUT HERE I'M A PAR AND MY
SON ATTENDS KEEPS ALL THE KIND
OF MAN THIS LOS ANGELES I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
DR VALERIE A BAD FIFTY YEARS IN
PUBLIC EDUCATION FROM THE
CONSERVATORY OF VOCAL AND
INSTRUMENTAL LARGE COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RUTH
FIVE A LOT PARENTS REPRESENTING
ALLIANCE COLLEGE READY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
STELLAR FIDO I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT MY THREE CHILDREN AND
ALLIANCE COLOR READY -- SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN I STARTED MY NUMBER IS
COMING I A LOT OF MAYOR BLOOM
WELL I LOVE?
HAVING.
KANSAS IT'LL SINGLETON BOASTING
OF CENTERS EXTRACT THEM -- WE GO
TO SOMETIMES CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS DAVID ONE I HAVE TWO
KIDS ONE EIGHTY SAT HIGH SCHOOL
IN ONE A TURMOIL MEANT TO SCHOOL
WHICH IS A LA UFC SCHOOL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO ONE THIRD IN NUMBER TO GET
A FIGHT I'M ABLE SOMETHING WITH
THOSE YOU ALSO WANNA HIGH SCHOOL
LOW DOWN ON MY IS GOING TO BRING
WITH A SINGLE SUNDAYS.
MY NAME IS JOE AT SPENCER
CAMPBELL.
GRANDPARENT PARENT.
OF STUDENTS AND HARDY BROWN
COLLEGE PREP AND COME HOME HIGH
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GUY GOT A WHEN I
CAME FROM KßT BUT I BASED
PAPER ON PLACES PEOPLE NOVATION
ACTUAL THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MEYER
WOOD SKIS I'M THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF AMERICAN EIGHTY MODEL SCHOOLS
THE ONLY SCHOOL IN OUR AREA
RECOGNIZE FOR CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALLED A CORONA
ALLIANCE COUNTY FOR HUNTINGTON
PARK.
I HAVE A TWO KIDS SO I OPPOSE
FOR THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LISA AQUELLOS I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN ONE APPOINTMENT
CHARTER IN ALLIANCE IN MY TEA
AND I PULLED HIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON DENNY SCHAPIRO
COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER FOR A
SPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR THIRTY SIX SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN I SEVEN THE NUMBER IS MADE
UP A CHECK OFF IS THINK WHAT
THAT IS ENOUGH TO BRING ON THE
LIST WHEN I PHONE?
EMAIL BOTH WAYS TO BE A GAS YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE DUSTIN
CATCH ASPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL OPERATIONS
DIRECTOR MY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ROXANNE IS ARE YOU
KNOW I HAVE ONE DAUGHTER WHO
ATTENDS FENTON AVENUE CHARTER
SCHOOL IN LAKE VIEW TERRACE PART
OF LA U. S. D..
AND I STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M DR CHARLES EATEN I
REPRESENT INSPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND THE SCHOOLS IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH SHORT
REPRESENTING THE CHARTER SCHOOL
OF SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY FLORES AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PARENTS FROM HUNTINGTON PARK
FROM ASPYR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HALEY BEAUPRE SCHOOL COORDINATOR
OF GROSSMONT SECONDARY SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TASHA ROBINSON AND
I'M IN THE PARENT OF TWO KIDS TO
GO TO TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. FOR ON A
COUPLE MEN'S SCHOOL COORDINATOR
FRIDAY -- CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN I MAY
COMMITTEE SOCIAL WORKER WITH
SCHOLARS IN A FORTUNE SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DOCTOR GOLDEN ROSE NOW FOUNDER
OF GREAT VALLEY ACADEMIES
MODESTO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LOOK INJURED PIERSON I'M A
FATHER OF TWO UNCLE.
AND I WE REPRESENT HAZEM HOME
COLLEGE PREP BUT WE ARE AGAINST
AB -- FIFTEEN OH FIVE JODY
JEFFERS ADMINISTRATOR FOR MOM
HOMESCHOOL CHARTER AND GLACIER
HIGH SCHOOL CHARTER AND A PARENT
OF TWO CHILDREN HAVE ATTENDED
THEM AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LOVELY TIANA BROWN AND I HAVE
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THEY HAVE ONE WHO
GRADUATED FROM A TRADITIONAL
SCHOOL AND I STILL OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TONY **** AND I
AM A STUDENT A GLACIER HIGH
SCHOOL CHARTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGEL XIN'AN I AM A
PARENT OF TWO SCHOLARS AT HIS
MAHONE COLLEGE PREP.
PART OF FORTUNE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO THERE MICHAEL **** I'M A
PARENT AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
WESTERN SEER CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
MADERA COUNTY.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AZIZA DAVIS GOINGS PRESIDENCY
OVER THE SACRAMENTO BLACK
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SACRAMENTO
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
FOUNDATION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JACKIE ROBERTSON CHIEF OF STAFF
ALL TO SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS ABOUT BRAIN
WITH ROCKET SHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THAT THEY'RE GONZALEZ
I AM A PARENT AT LORRAINE SINCE
AND VALLEY ALSO -- CO CHAIR FOR
OUR STUDENT COORDINATING COUNCIL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ERICA MY BELLY NOW
AND I'M PARENTS PHONE DROPKICK
CHEAP FOOD FOOD OFF.
AND I'D POST FOR THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME ALSO THE SCHOOL
CORDONING COUNSELING MY SCHOOL
REPRESENTING PARENTS IT CAN BE
HERE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT A CITY.
I'M PART INVOLVED -- HAD A
STUDENT HA.
THE ROCKET SHIP IN CONCORD AND I
ARE BOTH OF THIS BILL.
HI I'M RACHEL THOMAS ON THE
CURRICULUM IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COORDINATOR AT ALL
TO SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND I
STAND IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDRE SMITH I'M
A PARENT OF TWO ONE IN HAYS
MAHONE ONE IN THE THOMAS HIGH
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MINDY CLAIMING -- MINISTRY --
WESTERNS HERE CHARTER SCHOOL FOR
MADERA COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI HELLO MY NAME IS NO ZERO
SILAS AND I AM A MOTHER OF THREE
ALLIANCES STUDENTS AND I AM WILL
POST TO THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MONTGOMERY AND I'M A
TEACHERWITH THE AUDIO CHARTER
SCHOOL TOO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AROUND
ALSO A LOT OF SAY HOW -- JAMMED
AND NON I LIONS AND I DON'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KATIE DONTRE FROM
CORPORATE CHARTER SCHOOL AND SHE
GO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ROBERT LATTA ALUMNI OF ANYMORE
RALPH BUNCHE CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
AND CURRENT COLLEGE STUDENT AT
CAL STATE LA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DANIELLE DEFEAT NOW
WITH YOUR CHARTER SCHOOL IN
CHICO AND AYE OPPOSED TO CPOPS.
HELLO MY NAME IS ENOUGH OF FIVE
GONNA I'M A STUDENT SCA CONDOM
ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANNA MARIA ROBUST I'M
A TEACHER AT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
OF SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PAUL I'M YOU KNOW
SOME A SEDAN COMING ON LEVEL
CHARTER ACADEMY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A RATHER DS AND NOW
MY FATHER -- TO GROSS THAT TEND
TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL IN ONE
NUMBER AND AYE OPPOSED. TO THE
AB FIFTY NO FIGHT [inaudible]
TWO SEVEN HELLO MY NAME IS ASHER
REVERSE AYE MY PROD STUDENT OF
ASPECT PACIFIC HOW TO ME AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
WHEN THE STAR THEN THE NUMBER IS
BRING THEM I HAD A MOTHER THAT
IF A MEDIA THAT THIS IS TO THE
NTH BEST GUESS IS THAT -- US BY
IT AT THE NEW MODEL YES BY IT OR
LEADING YOUR ME UP ON WHAT IS
BEING I THANK YOU TO SETTLE
SINGLE POCKET MAYBE IN THAT GET
THAT I'LL OPEN UP IN THE ATTIC
AND WE SEE BECAUSE HE GOT HIS TO
THE OTHER ONE THIS ONE OF THE UC.
BERKELEY THEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS --
MORE SO YOU'RE FROM US BY
PACIFIC ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIE
COLUMBUS AND I HAVE TO LOSE TWO
BOYS THAT GO TO ALLIANCE LIKE MY
LIVING AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AT THE
ST MODEST AND I HAVE FOR ONE OF
OUR CHILDREN CURRENTLY ATTEND --
A SPIRE CHARTER SCHOOL AND
ALLIANCE CHARTER SCHOOL IN THE
HUNTING THE PARK COMMUNITY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS SO THAT
BEING AT AN APARTMENT FROM
ALLIANCE SCHOOL OF LOS ANGELES.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO IT'S TEARING NAPIER FROM
SHERMAN THOMAS CHARTER SCHOOL
MADERA COUNTY HIGH PERFORMING
TERMS SCHOOLS AND WE ASK YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS CALL SAMPSON
PRINCIPAL AND PARENT OF ONE
EXTREMELY ACADEMY IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA AND THE RELEASE OF
KERN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M ROBIN STOUT EXECUTIVE
pROCKLIN ACADEMY FAMILY OF
SCHOOLS THE NATIONAL BLUE RIBBON
IN CALIFORNIA GOLD SIR THE
SCHOOLS PROUDLY SERVING TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS AND PUBLIC
AT SCHOOL STUDENTS IMPOSTER
COUNTY.
MY NAME IS GREG WEST OMITTED
MINISTRY -- A GRAM WAY SCHOOLS
IN KERN COUNTY AND BIG FIELD
AREA AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M JULY IN AND TOWN AN
ADMINISTRATOR AND PARENT AT ROCK
ON THE COUNTY FAMILY OF SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND JOANNA KENDRICK SCHOOL
LEADER IT GRIMLY ACADEMY SHAFTER
IN KERN COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC HAGEN I AM
AN ADMINISTRATOR AND PARENT HAVE
TO AT GLACIER HIGH SCHOOL
CHARTER.
AND I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS REGINA BY YAHOO AND I
WORK FOR ALLIANCE COLLEGE READY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY GARCIA
ADMINISTRATOR WESTERN SEARED HER
SCHOOLS MADERA COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI WHEN IS THAT IS ME NOTICING
BUT EVEN THAT HE AYE YOUR POSTS --
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS REAL SOME MANA
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE IN NOT
MINE NOT A SCIENCE ACADEMY
SAVING IN SOUTH ANOTHER BODY IN
THE U. OPALS THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CATHERINE MALCOLM A TEACHER
PARENT AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
PACIFIC VIEW CHARTER SCHOOL IN
OCEANSIDE AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
AARON GORDON SPECIFIC YOU
CHARTER SCHOOL STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
TINA CAMPBELL IS FOUNDING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PACIFIC VIEW
CHARTER SCHOOL AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER BECAUSE REPRESENTING
JULIAN CHARTER SCHOOL IN SAN
DIEGO IN RIVERSIDE -- COUNTIES
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
J. ARTISTS RIGHT PARENT OF TWO
STANDING WITH STUDENTS AND
PARENTS HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LINDA HARD WITH NUMBER TO DENOTE
A HEARTY BROWN COLLEGE PREP I
HAVE POLLS.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE SURE REMOVED
AMOUNTS OF FORTUNE SCHOOL MY
GRANDDAUGHTER GOES DOWN ON THE
STUDENTS.
AND I POSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
DEBORAH CAMARA.
AND MOTHER OF FIVE THERE ARE TEN
FOURTEEN SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JAMES DRISKELL PARENT AND
VOLUNTEER AT FORTUNE SCHOOL AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRISTINE ALASTOR EDUCATION
CHAIRWOMAN PART AND DOUBLE ACP
SOUTHWEST RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
HOWEVER I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE PARENT UNION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TAMMY STANTON PARENT OF OCEAN
CHARTER SCHOOL TO STUDENTS ALSO
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
CAMINO NO WAY ABOUT CHARTER
ACADEMY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JB ROBINSON PARENT AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AT LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOL SAN DIEGO AND I
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE DEBBIE BUYER FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR A HIGH
PERFORMING CHARTER ON APPEAL
LITERACY FIRST CHARTER SCHOOL IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
LISA WILLIAMS ASSISTANT
PRINCIPAL AT LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO.
I OPPOSE.
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH FIVE JUDY
ADAIR WAS SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL
IN TEMECULA CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CONTRARY BUYER FROM LITERACY
FIRST CHARTER SCHOOL
REPRESENTING THE HIGH PERFORMING
SPECIAL EDUCATION POPULATION AND
WE HIGHLY DISAPPROVE AND OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JACK OUR CALVET.
GRADUATE SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSES.
MY NAME IS TO KIA MINUTES LOW
PASS AND ARM I HAVE A SON IN --
PAYS A MY HOME IT -- THAT'S IN
ON THE THOMAS AND I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTY NO.
FIVE ALEXANDRA THEIR CHILD AND A
TEACHER WITH I LEAD EXPLORATION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PETER SAVILLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ITS CHARTER SCHOOL WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JOHN AND THEIR SPRINGS CHARTER
SCHOOL -- I HAVE TWO KIDS THE
GRADUATE CHARTER SCHOOL A KID
GRANDSON IN CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I AM INSTRUCTOR THERE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOANNA CHRISTIANSEN DOUBLE
CREDENTIAL TEACHER WAS SKY
MOUNTAIN CHARTER SCHOOL FOR ANY
TYPE OF CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SUZANNE ACCORDINGLY FORMER HOME
SCHOOL CHARTER PARENTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI I'M HELEN MACLEOD A RETIRED
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
I'M FROM YUCAIPA CALIFORNIA.
HI MY NAME IS SHANNON CARPENTER
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS I'M
ALSO HOME SCHOOL PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
I IN GENERAL CHRISTIANSEN AND I
AM FROM SKY AROUND CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIE CARPENTER
AND I AM A STUDENT FOR INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN JONES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANA GRECO FROM
INSPIRED A CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARK JONES AND I
MY NAME IS JUSTICE GRECO FROM
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MERRY L. JONES AND I
MY NAME IS SERRA GRECO APPARENT
FROM INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HEATHER JONES I STAND
FOR PARENTS CHOICE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA GONZALEZ
STUDENT AND FAMILY SERVICES ACT
I MEAN ON OF A CHARTER ACADEMY
KANE SIRE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JESSICA BARBARA AND
I'M FROM PLACERVILLE I'M A HOME
SCHOOLING MOM AND I OPPOSE THESE
BILLS.
MY NAME IS JOCELYN ID AND I AND
I AM THE STUDENT AND FAMILY
SERVICES ASSISTANT AT JAMIE I
THINK I MEAN I'M LEVEL IN A POST
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE LIVE FOREVER AND
I WAS THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ERICA GONZALEZ FROM
CAMINO NOBLE CHARTER ACADEMY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SHAUNA MCGREGOR KING I'M A
HOME SCHOOLING PARENT WE DO NOT
EVEN USE THE CHARTER AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALSO DOWN MY **** I
AM A STUDENT ALUMNI OPERATIONS
COORDINATOR AND PARENT
REPRESENTING CAMINO NUEVO
CHARTER ACADEMY.
A VIOLET KING I'M A STUDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EDDIE RAMIREZ I'M
FROM CAMINO A CHARTER ACADEMY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALSO MY IDEA I I
STUDY IN AND HI LANCE COOL.
AND I AM MOST IN THAT.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS TINY
CASTRO IN FAMILY SERVICES
COORDINATOR AT CAMINO NOBLE
CHARTER ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AVAILABLE MENTAL I AM
A STUDENT AND HIGHLAND
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
I AM.
OPPOSE HIP AND A AB FIFTY WAS
CLOSE BY.
LARA FERAL TEACHER OF SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS AND
REPRESENTATIVE CAMINO NOISE --
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ME NUMBER IS ON THE SUN JUST.
YES THEY ARE LESS WELL HIDING ON
THE SECOND MENTAL EMAIL PHONE
WHATEVER WITH THIS YOUNG.
GIVES A SUBTLE SINGLE.
MY NAME IS INDIA QUEEN I AM A
FORMER CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL --
LET ME NUMBER AND THEN HE'S GOT
A IS STILL IS QUITE A LOT HI
LAND HE MOBILE GOLOVKIN SAYS
IT'LL SEEM COOL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MELISSA QUEEN I'M A PAIRED UP TO
FORMER. THREE FORMER CHARTER
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN WERE COLLEGE
GRADUATES IN WITH THIS COLLEGE
RIGHT.
IN THAT YOUR POSITION AND I UP
HOLES THIS BILL STRONGLY THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ELABORATE ALPHA I AM
A STUDENT OF HIGHLIGHTS IS
CHARTER SCHOOL.
I ALSO OPPOSE HEATH IS THE
SIXTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
COMMENDABLE LAWS -- UP AND BUT
IN EITHER FROM ROCKET SHIP OF
THE SCHOOLS AND THE CAPTAIN HARD
WORK.
AND I HAVE A THESE THERE'S FOUR
HONORABLE MAN I JUST YOUR YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
PHONE.
MY NAME IS MAHDI AIDID.
I STUDENT IN THE HIGHLANDS OF
SACRAMENTO.
I WAS AT THE AND THE AB -- FIFTY
ZERO FIVE ME NUMBER NUMBERS
MIGHT ASK WHAT YOUR NAME WAS ON
JOSE -- SO YOU MOTHER MEDIA THEY
LOOK AT YOUR BILL SO I KNOW HE
BLAG MICHAELS AND THEN THIS EAT
RIGHT WITH IT.
I THINK YOU OUGHT.
TO GET MEAN.
DOCTOR DO WRONG Là.
HE SAYS IT'LL SINGLE.
DR JUDY GRASSY PRETENDED VISIONS
IN EDUCATION CHARTER SCHOOL
STAND IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JOE IS CHECK I'M I
HAVE A SON AT ROCKET SHIP QUITE
SAT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I HAVE A LETTER IS FOR HONORABLE
WHAT.
THE RENO GENERAL OF JOHN ADAMS
ACADEMY A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
LILY HAVING TO A LOT I HAVE TO
STUDENTS AND CHARTER SCHOOL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M SIT ON THE CARD
CONVENIENCE ON IS FAR CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I HOW THEIR BOTH THIS.
TIME HI MY NAME IS JARED.
AND I'M FROM ROCKET SHIP FOR
SUCH.
AN ANIMAL POST.
FOR POST FIFTY FOUR OH FIVE IN
THIS LETTER GOES TO AUDIBLE CAM
OCCUR THE CARD THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SOPHIA CACO.
I AM A STUDENT FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I HIGHLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI -- MY NAME IS MONICA IT IS
AND I OPPOSE FOR FIFTEEN OR FIVE
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JAMES CAVACO.
NAME IS JANA CARBONNEAU ARE IN
NAPLES AB FIFTY IN A FIVE I'M A
NUMBER IS NOT A SUPPLEMENT THE
THIS THING WITH A SINGLE CENTER
TO SCHOOL I'M PROBABLY CLOSER.
ARE HOSTED NUMBERS EMAIL PROGRAM
LIKE CONSISTENCY SERVICING.
HI MY NAME IS SUZANNE I'M WORK
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MY NAME IS RUNNING IT AND ALL
FOR THE HERNANDEZ AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS BUSH
CALL.
I HAVE A TWO KEY IT'S AND I
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SO SAN ANDREAS I ATTENDED SCHOOL
CHARGES ONE TIME OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HOW DOES THIS BILL?
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL WOULD GRANT
DIRECTOR OF SIEGE OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND MOTHER OF THREE
CHILDREN ENROLLED AT THE JOB
CHARTER SCHOOL AND IN THE
LEADER'S CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIA I A
MOTHER OF THREE KIDS AND THEIR
ENROLLED IN THE CORE PLACER
CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. FIFTEEN
OH FIVE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JAMIE BLOCK ASSISTANT
IRECTOR AND PARENT OF THREE
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN STAGE OF
CHARTER SCHOOL IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LISA TODD I'M A
GRANDPARENT -- THE KIDS ARE
ENROLLED IN COURT CHARTER SCHOOL
AND TWIN RIVERS CHARTER SCHOOL
I'M A PARA EDUCATOR IN THE
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ERIN BUNCH I WORK FOR
STAGE -- CHARTER SCHOOL I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE TEACHERS IN
RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELA Là CO I AM A
TEACHER AT COR CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LISA THOMPSON I AM AN
ADMINISTRATOR IN PARENT AT SAY
JOB CHARTER SCHOOL I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TEACHERS IN LONG
BEACH AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M MICHELLE KOTAK CORE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SIMPSON I'M
A PARENT OF MY CHILDREN AT COURT
CHARTER SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LUCY BARNETT PARENT
FROM TORQUE CORD CHARTER I
OPPOSE THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY.
AND JOE NOR NIGHT SUPPORT COR
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE A.
B..
FIFTEEN FIVE OH FIVE MY NAME IS
BRENT BARNETT ON THE COURT
CHARTER AND AYE POSES.
I'M DON FLYNN FROM COURT CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M STACEY PELZER I'M A PARENT
COR CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MONEY MILLION A
MOTHER OF TWO GRADUATES ONE FROM
THE CHARTER SCHOOL ONE FROM A
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE IN ONE IN A CHARTER
SCHOOL WHEN IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NEARING SURE.
AND I'M A STUDENT OF COURSE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LYDIA MILLIKEN AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SHARP I'M A
PARENT -- CORE CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY
NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS RANDY MILLIGRAM
A PARENT OF A STUDENT AT COR
CAMP IN BILL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE THINK WHERE.
I GOOD AT CORD CUTTERS SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY DISAPPROVE OF
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBIN PASSED ON FROM --
APPARENT AT MARYSVILLE COR
CHARTER SCHOOL REPAIRED OF THE
GRADUATE AND TO CURRENT STUDENTS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS KAYLA
ST CLAIR AND I'M A PARENT OF A
STUDENT AT FOR CHARTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME'S BEEN
TASK I'M A STUDENT AT COURT
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
ROBERT GIVES -- A PERSONALIZED
LEARNING TEACHER CORPS CHARTER
SCHOOL I SUPPORT THE LEARNING OF
ALL CHILDREN BUT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE -- A. B. ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ONE OF PASS.
I AM A STUDENT FROM COURT A
COURT CHARTER SCHOOL IN A
STRONGLY -- OPPOSE OF FIFTEEN OH
FIVE HI MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
EMMA BEATEN VENDOR AND I'M A
LONG TIME PARENTS OF HOME SCHOOL
KIDS IT WITH SOUTH CENTER
CHARTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE CAUGHT FIRE
AND THEN WAS A STYLE SETTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I'M OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANE B. MENDER I WAS
CELL CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS SHAWNA ANDERSON I'M
AN ADMINISTRATOR AND A PARENT OF
SIX CHILDREN AT SOUTH CENTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JC BEATEN BENDER I'VE
BEEN WITH SELF CENTERED CHARTER
SCHOOL FOR A FOR YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JULY ANDERSON AND
I'VE BEEN US -- I GO TO SELL
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JACOB BEATEN BENDER
I'VE BEEN WITH SOUTH SUTTER
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR ELEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS SHANNON LAUDERDALE
I'M A PARENT OF STUDENTS AT SO
SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE NUMBER IS WELL OPEN UNDER
YOUR REPRESENT THOUGHT MIGHT.
BE SHOULD MIGHT THOUGH SHE DID
YEAH EMAIL PHONE WELL I THAT ARE
MAKING TO SETTLE SINGLE.
MY NAME IS PARRIS LAUDERDALE I
AM WITH CHAO'S SOME SAUCER
CHARTER SCHOOL I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ALL I MEAN NUMBER IS MAYBE THEM
YEAH SO BUT IT IS A ON FINANCING
EVERYTHING.
A LONG WAR I LAB I'VE BEEN HE
SAYS I DON'T THINK OF THAT I
THINK.
HI MY NAME'S ANGEL GARCIA I AM A
PARENT OF CHILDREN IN
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
SACKS CITY UNIFIED AND ALSO A
PARENT OF A CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENT STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
ACADEMIC AND VOCATIONAL ACADEMY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S HE SAID LEVY A
SINCERE AND I'M A STUDENT AT
ALPHA CITY EVERY TIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE WITH.
THIS BILL AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS KATIE PETERSON
I'M A NATIONALLY CERTIFIED
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST WITH K<c.cyan></c>
BAY AREA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NUMBER
FINE I HAVE TO GET SOME VOICES
AND AYE OPPOSED TO AB.
FIFTY FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
LAUREN A SOLO DEAL FOUNDING
PERRIN OF ROCKET SHIP MIGHT
THOUGH SHE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
WHEN I HAVE THIS NUMBER IS MONEY
UP BEING OUT OF BREATH CENTER
OKAY SHE THE SAMPLE SAY NO FROM
WHAT I'VE EIGHT GIVES A SUBTLE
SEEING?
HELLO MY NAME'S ABOUT ALL THE
AND I HAVE A DAUGHTER AND
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STILL DON'T
GO ABOVE -- FIFTEEN OH FIVE WHAT
IS THAT THIS ME NUMBER OVERSIGHT
OF A CONSPIRACY YEAH BUT WHAT
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IS WHEN I
WRITE A CHECK TO THE SCHOOL.
YOUR MEAL PULL WILL PUT THEM IN
THE ACT IS THE LATEST APPLE.
ONE I AM NO BUT I SEE YEAH FROM
ALPHA CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AM ANGELINA TRAVIS FROM A
RISE HIGH SCHOOL IN A I OPPOSE
AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA COPY
YEAH I HAD GETS AND MODIFY.
AND BROKE HIS SHIP AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS.
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL VASQUEZ
I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL LOAN FROM
BRIGHT STAR SECONDARY CHARTER
ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB --
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS OF
THIS BILL LIST OF CARDIO MY
SCHOOL MY SCHOOL ROCKET ROCKET
SHIP MOSAIC [inaudible]
I OPPOSE -- FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI
MY NAME IS JAN JAN.
TEN AND I COME FROM AMERICAN
INDIAN PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
I'VE BEEN TO SANTA AND I'M FROM
OTHER ISSUES ACADEMY SCHOOL.
AND OPPOSE -- BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE GOOD MORNING I'M
ONLY A PERRY I'M A STUDENT AT
AMERICAN INDIAN PUBLIC HIGH IN
OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER TO SLING GO I'M A
STUDENT FROM CALIFORNIA I MEAN.
YES AS COMMUNITY OUT REACH
ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMANDA AND I'M A
STUDENT FROM AMERICAN INDIAN
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS AN ADULT THIS
LAND K. -- FATHER OF NINE KIDS
AND FOUR OF MY KIDS ATTENDING
SUING.
SCHOOL SO I AM A POSITIVE MAYBE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ALREADY I GO TO AMERICAN INDIAN
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE YEAH HI MY NAME
IS BROUGH ME WHO AND I'M STRONG
LEVELS FIFTY NO FIVE THANK YOU.
MY LAST OF THE NUMBER LEARNED
THAT EVER PRESENT ON THE SCHOOL
A LOT OF FATAL COULD CHOOSE YOUR
PHONE GO ON I AND OF THEIR KIDS
TO SETTLE SINGLE LESSON.
MAN THEM AS WELL.
THE YEAH BROUGHT TO LET THE BILL
UP IT'S NOT SITTING ON YEAH I
ACTUALLY HAVE THE VOTES TO DO
LOCAL.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA I'M A
STUDENT AND I'LL FLY IN THEM.
I'M AGAINST AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
LEAH I'M STRIVE OF THIS TO HIGH
SCHOOL I POSED THIS BILL.
THE NUMBERS FOR FOR DEALING ON
THIS OF COURSE IS CONNECTICUT
CHEAPLY MOBILE AVE HE'S AT A
SINGLE.
MY NAME IS IVAN GLUE SCHOOL.
AND I'M FOLLOW FOR KIDS AND I
OPPOSE OF THE FIFTEEN OH FIVE
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSEPH.
AGORA ALPHA AND I OPPOSE.
AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS ANNA -- SO
THIS IS MY SON SO HE WAS A
ROCKET SHIP AND AYE OPPOSED TO
THIS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AND NOT TRY AND
I'M A MOM OF CRICKET AT ALFA
CAUGHT US THOUGHT ACADEMY I
OPPOSE A PPP NO.
FIVE MY NAME MY NAME'S JOSE AND
I I GO TO ALSO AND I I PROCES
BILL.
FIFTEEN FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
CHARLES ARE NOT LIFE REPRESENT
THE UNITY HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND.
A LAWYER PUESTO LIKE ISN'T AYE
HELLO KAMALA.
HE SAID.
THERE'S A SINGLE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN AND I
GO TO A FULL.
BLANCA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RACHEL I AM A
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL ALUMNI
I AM A PARENT OF TWO STUDENTS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN OAKLAND AND
BONTA IS DISTRICT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AN
ACT THAT YOU VOTE NO -- SO YEAH.
IF WE HAVE A NEXT PERSON IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE NEED TO GO HELLO WHEN I
STARTED THEM ENORMOUS GUN THE
OWING ON DAYS SAN JOSE.
ET YOUR MILBORNE ONE AB -- US
GEEZERS SETTLE SINGLE E. AND
ABCS GAINES SAYS THAT ALL SAFE.
YEAH LOSE SAID ALL.
OKAY GUYS THIS.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAURICE ALONE
AND I AM A SENIOR AND COMMUNITY
HIGH.
AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE WHEN I STARTED IN THE
NUMBER ONE OF MY LINKS YET YOU
MAKE WHAT THE AND THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT I FIVE AND GOT ABOUT
I DON'T YOU KNOW FULL WELL I I'M
MAKING TO SETTLE SINGLE.
MY NAME IS LESLIE BECAUSE I AM A
STUDENT O'QUINN UNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARY ROSE MARTINEZ
WILL OAKLEY UNITY CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS ERIN ON IS
ALMOST TWO AND A HALF OAKLAND
UNITY HIGH.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS DANTE VEGA AND I GO
TO OAKLEY THE HIGH AND I OPPOSE
EVEN IF IT'S IN A FIVE MY NAME
IS HIGHER -- GOMEZ AND I AM A
JUNIOR AT OAKLEY UNITY CHARTER
AND I OPPOSE -- A. B. -- FIFTEEN
OH FIVE MY NAME IS GABLE FLOORS
I'M A STUDENT AT UNITY HIGH --
HI JUST BECAUSE SCHOOL CHARTER
AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS JEFF CRUZ I AM A
STUDENT FOR A LOCAL CHARTER
SCHOOL BOOK LEADING CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA MEDINA I GO
TO OPEN THE THE HIGH CHARTER
SCHOOL.
AND AYE OPPOSED TO A. B. FIFTEEN
OH FIVE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELO BECAUSE I AM A
STUDENT AT OAKLAND UNITY TOWARD
OUR SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE CAPITAL HALLERAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN
REPRESENTING OUR MEMBERS WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY WE
OPPOSE THE STILL.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE A THIRTY ARE
MUCH HIGHER LOAN FROM POKEY
COUSIN LOS ANGELES MY STRONGLY
OPPOSES BUT MY NAME IS ANDREW
SILVERED I'M A FORMER CHARTER
PARENT AND FORMER CHIEF BUSINESS
OFFICER CALLED VALLEY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN MINIMALIST HE
SAID ABOUT A MONTH I'M A
COMMUNITY SCHOOL OAKLAND -- A
BULLET PROOF I'LL.
I'LL BILL -- GISA SEVERAL SINGLE.
THE BOOK IN CALIFORNIA.
ERIC PREMEDICAL CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND ALSO
BOARD MEMBER WAS HAVE A CORE IN
OAKLAND IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE AMNESIA AND
I AM A PARENT I COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FOR CREATIVE EDUCATION IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE PROFESSOR HONEST
US THE APPRENTICE I'M FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I AM A
TRUSTEE OF THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL
FOR CREATIVE EDUCATION.
A ROOM PARENTS AND A PARENT OF A
CHILD THERE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO FIVE THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY IS ANY G
CHARTER A LAWMAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO I'M BRENDA
RIGHT HERE RETIRED BOARD CHAIR
OF TWIN RIDGES HOME STUDY
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE
FIFTEEN OR FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS NINA FOR CREE HOW MY
PARENTS A COURT CAPTAIN PHIL FOR
MARY'S SOUL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY
NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS LEVI SO FOR I AM
A STUDENT FROM TWIN RIDGES HOME
STUDY I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I REMEMBER HEARING I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KELLY SOBRE I'M A
TEACHER AND A PARENT OF TWO AT
TWIN RIDGES HOME STUDY CHARTER
AND AYE OPPOSED TO STILL.
MY NAME IS COMIC MCCURRY I'M A
STUDENT FROM COURT CHAMPION PHIL
MARYSVILLE AYE OPPOSED AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE JOANNE SOUNDS
FORMER PARENT TEACHER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TAKES A
MONTESSORI CHARTER SCHOOL AND
AYE OPPOSED AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THIRD JORDAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PATHWAYS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
JOHN GARCIA ADULT AMEND
SOLUTIONS AND PROUD PARENTS OF
TWO AT CALIFORNIA MY SORRY
PROJECT AND I POSE THIS BOTH.
RENEE MAKE PRIDE SUPERINTENDENT
PRINCIPLE HARMONY UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CAN REALLY TO MUMBLING FROM
GORMAN LEARNING CHARTER NETWORK
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHERYL TOWNSEND PRINCIPLE
PATHWAYS CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M JENNIFER F. FROM GORMAN
LEARNING TURN AT WORK AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN I STARTED MY NUMBER IS NOT
MINE IT REPRESENT ON I SQUARE
NOT A LIGHT HOUSE IT ALL STARTED
THEY OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WHEN
ASSEMBLY?
EMAIL PHONE LAW [inaudible]
AVE.
HE SAYS SAID A SINGLE GLASS YES.
HI I'M DANNY SPUR SHUT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GORMAN LEARNING
CHARTER NETWORK AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT IN THE
NUMBERS HERE NAY GONZALEZ MY
MOTHER THEIR MESSAGE YET THEY
THEY'D BE SURE NOT GONNA MAKE AN
UPDATE ON MY PHONE WILL LOVE IT.
HE SAYS THAT -- SINGLE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JASON ESCALANTE --
I'M A STUDENTS -- THAILAND CHART
THAT IS COOL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN I STARTED MY NUMBER IS MY
GUESS ANTECEDENT GO THEY ARE
RIGHT SAY SCHOOL THEY ALL PLAN?
EMAIL BUNGALOW AYE LAVIK
INSISTED A SINGLE.
HI.
MY NAME IS MOHAMMED HAS THAT
DOOR -- STUDENT HOW TO CHICAGO
SCHOOL.
I OPPOSE THIS BOUT.
THANK.
WHEN IS THAT THIS MAY NUMBERS
BUT THEY SAID MATHIS IDEALIST
WILL ARISE? EIGHT MOBILE WHILE
OUT A BIG PIECES THAT ARE SICK
THAT'S HI MY NAME IS JUSTIN KYLE
SOME A TEACHER AT HIGHLANDS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WELL LET ME NUMBER IS HEAVILY
CIRCLES REPRESENT THAT IS QUITE
A COMMUNITY SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
ME A BONE WHILE KEEN SENSE OF ON
I HAVE BEEN KEEN TO SETTLE
SINGLE.
BUT FOR WATER NO BUT WITH THE
CAN I LIVE IN THE US.
MY NAME IS JACOB FLETCHER I GO
TO CAIRO.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME PUT P. MY
CURRENT I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AT THE CIARA -- HIGHLAND
COMMUNITIES TAUGHT AT SCHOOL I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ZERO FLETCHER SCHOOLS
CURRENT PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HI MY NAME'S TYPE YOUR CHIN I'M
A STILL THEM AND HIDE IN CHARTER
SCHOOL AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
HI I'M JOE FLETCHER CARRIAGE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AND TOBY QUARTEY SEVE PARENTS
WITH OCEAN GROVE CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BELT.
HI MY NAME IS LESLIE CHABLIS CO
FOUNDER OF TERRACE PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND COORDINATOR OF CARS AND WE'D
OF SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI AM POPPY DARBY AT WOODLAND
STAR CHARTER SCHOOL IN SUMMIT
CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI JAROD AUSTIN CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CARISBROOK SCHOOLS AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MARK MARK ALERT -- WITHIN CHART
WOODLAND STAR CHARTER SCHOOL
CINEMA I OPPOSE FIFTEEN A FIVE
HI JACQUELINE AND OFTEN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA.
MOTHER OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE I'M LILLIAN OF
VAS -- MY GRANDSON ATTENDS THE
ZERO WALDORF SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTY
NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS DANA HARTLEY AND
I HAVE -- CHILDREN WHO ATTEND
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MY NAME -- LASER.
I AM GROUND PERRANCE.
AS A STUDENT.
MY IS CHILDREN IS STUDYING.
CHAPTER SCHOOL [inaudible]
I HOLDS A I AB. FIFTY ZERO FIVE
HI MARSHALL HARTLEY AND MY
CHILDREN GO TO INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELINA OF EVERY
NOOK AND MY KIDS ARE WAS VISIONS
IN EDUCATION I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSES.
I'M TO CALL MARTINEZ WITH ST
REJOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI NONE TO MEMBERS ASK MY KIDS
GO TO VERIZON CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH
FIVE THANKS.
MY NAME IS DAVID -- I GO.
TO I'M A STUDENT FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
I'M CRISTINA DENIM MY CHILDREN
GO TO CENTER PEAK CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STUFF AND CARP OF
AND I'M A STUDENT.
FROM INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY FLY I'M A
STUDENT AT CENTER PEAK CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DOUBLE KARPOV --
I'M A PARENT OF STUDENTS IN
CHARTER -- INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THINK.
HI MY NAME IS THE FULL A I AM A
STUDENT ANSWER PEAK CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM MY HANDY I
GO TO IS BACK BECAUSE IT KIND OF
MEAN OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN FLY I I GO
TO CENTER BECAUSE CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA I'M A
SUPPORTER FROM ROCKLAND
DEPENDENT CHARTER SCHOOL.
CLOTHES THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
PORTER I AM CURRENTLY A
CREDENTIAL TEACHER WITH SOUTH
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL WORKING
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AS A TEACHER.
AND A PARENT OF FIVE CHILDREN
FOUR OF WHICH YOU ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN CHARTER ONE WHO
GRADUATED SEVENTEEN COMPLETING
TWENTY ONE CALLED UNITS THANK
YOU ROLLED YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL.
AND I'D BE IT MERELY OPPOSE THIS
MY NAME IS JOHN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME
IS NATALIE MUHTAR TIME WITH NEW
DAY CHARTER SCHOOL AS A PARENT
AND I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
JENNIFER YOUNG AND I'M WITH NEW
DAY ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE JENNIFER HAMEL
NEEDY ACADEMY I OPPOSE FIFTEEN
OH FIVE THANK YOU.
MICHELLE BAILEY MEDIA KATERINA
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE LUNA BROWNISH
CAPITOL CHRISTIAN AYE OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI I AM FROM I
JUST TO KIND OF TELL -- FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA -- I STAND WITH
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT TOLERABLE GARI
GATEWAY INTERNATIONAL SCHOOL I
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
NICOLE COLLINS I'M FROM IN SCENA
I STAND WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS IRENE A QUORUM EACH
I'M A PARENT OF STUDENT IN
CAPITOL CHRISTIAN SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH FIVE THE FILM.
HELLO I'M WENDY PELLEGRINI AND
FROM RUN APART CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M A HOME SCHOOL MOTHER I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANASTASIA BE FOND
OF A AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA RISER JEVONS
I AM A TWELVE YEAR BOARD MEMBER
OF THE VITA CHARTER SCHOOL IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
CHARTER SCHOOLS REALLY WORK FOR
INTO.
ALL SHE NEEDED A STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY YOU MAY GO.
SECRETIVE I'M A STUDENT OF
COURSE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE KELLY HARRIS MY
CHILDREN ATTEND I LIED
EXPLORATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI ANGELI CRUISE WITH CORE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE CHRISTINE CAP
ONE L. AND WE'RE WITH COMPASS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA SIR DUKE IN
MY DAUGHTER'S HOPING SHE'S
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU
GOD BLESS YOU.
HI MY NAME'S YOUNGER THERE IT
MOTHER OF THREE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
WE NEED THREE SIR DUKE I AM
WEBER AND CLOSE TO THEM FROM
INSPIRES -- CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
HAVE POLLS.
BEALE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI JENNIFER
VARIOUS MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I DON'T LIKE YOU MISSUS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SAYS MRS LAST TIME WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M HERE WILLIAMS FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA -- MOTHER OF SEVEN
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I'M LONDON MISSUS IN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAILY ON THE
ACADEMIC DIRECTOR AT THE
LANGUAGE ACADEMY OF SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I MATTHEW MISSUS AND I'M HOME
SCHOOLED -- CHARTER PARENT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE -- FIFTEEN
OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS RICHARD A
JONES I'M REPRESENTING ALLEN
WILL COLLEGE PREP.
I'M A PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI I'M JODY
MISSUS IN WITH HORIZONS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS USUALLY YOU
CAME OFF AND I'M A PARENT AND I
BOYS FEET IN THE FIVE AND I ALSO
PLANNING TO HOME SCHOOL MY BABY.
WHEN HE'S OLD ENOUGH?
HI AND TO TELL NAY OF GOLF A LOT
I'M A PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE IN THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LET ME LE KNOWS
YOU'RE NOT AND STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BEALE A. B.. FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE
MY NAME IS SVETLANA BURKLE I'M A
PARENT OF THREE KIDS IF FUHRMAN
SPARSE SCHOOL I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS NOT THAT ANY
GOAL AND PARENTS FIVE CHILDREN'S
AND AB CHECK THE SCHOOL AND I AM
VOIGTS.
BILL.
FIFTY NINE FIVE HI -- MY NAME'S
IN ACETIC I'M WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS LOVER LIMIT CAN
I AM A PARENT OF TWO AND THEN A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER.
AND ICE FROM REBELS -- TO TO
KNOW.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
SCHATZ MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTORIA KEY
SAM WATER FOR TWO CHILDREN AND
ON OPPOSE. FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO
MY NAME IS EVELYN I'M HOME
SCHOOLED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA TEAM WHEN
I'M. TO WHAT IS STRONG OPPOSE.
I'M BILL AB FIFTY AND ALL FIVE
THANK [inaudible]
MY NAME.
MY NAME IS EDWARD DIABLES FIFTY
NO.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS A RENO SALMON
NOW AND WE ARE WITH INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTY NOT.
FIVE MY NAME IS NADIA I'M A
MOTHER OF FOUR KIDS I HOME
SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS A KEY JUST HIM
AND OFTEN AS STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA SUMMONING GO
INTO LICENSE TORIA THE KIDS AND
WE'RE WITH INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE TOWN I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN WITHIN PART OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR MANY YEARS I HAVE
FOUR CHILDREN.
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE AB. ONE
OH ONE FIVE OH FIVE THANK YOU.
I LIKE THE ISLANDS OF AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS IGOR THERE'S LIFE
UNBEARABLE THREE GATES FROM --
WHERE SACRAMENTO CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY AND I POLLS THESE BILL
AB?
ONE FIVE FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
AND YOU GET A I'VE BEEN SELF --
FROM DISTRICT ONE I HAVE SEVEN
CHILDREN WHO ARE HOME SCHOOLED
PLEASE -- OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA CORAL --
I HAVE THREE KIDS.
AND I APPLES -- AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
NOT TALLY OF ALL -- I AM PARENTS
OF TWO AM STRONG APPLES -- A. B.
FIFTEEN ALL.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS -- D'AMICO'S
LONG TIME OPPONENTS AND DAY
POLLS AB. FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH DOES THAT
INTEREST AND I'M A PARENT OF
THREE AND I OPPOSE -- AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
SERGEI CORAL AND FATHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE ON A. B.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA SO ISSUE
AND I AM A MOM OF TWO KIDS I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB -- FIFTEEN
OH FIVE I NEED YOU TO BUT I CAME
FROM ACT TOSSED ORDER TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS EXTENT A GRAND
READ JANET I'M I'M OF TWO HOME
SCHOOLERS SAM ALSO VENDOR AND
FOR DIFFERENT.
HOME SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING -- COAST WOFFORD
FORTY SCHOOL.
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS TO
BOOK A MELODICA I HAVE THREE
KIDS I JUST DON'T GO BOASTS A
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S MARK A LOPEZ AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M I DON'T I'M A BOY -- FOR
ALL THREE AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND THE AYE THE STORM
WILL OPPOSE THE THIS BILL FIFTY
NO FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JORDAN
[inaudible]
AND NO ON AB. FIFTY NO.
FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS BRETT
SALES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MY AND I BOYS AND
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE BOYS THAT
YOU JUST SAW ONE OF THEM.
AND WE HAVE AN ON GOING FOR SIX
YEARS AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE AND BE LONG TO
CORE PLASTER CHARTER SCHOOL
[inaudible]
HI.
MY NAME'S JANICE MILLER.
I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
DMITRY RESIDENT -- EVEN STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR MEMBERS OUT OF CABLE AND I'M
A PARENT OF THE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS AS WELL
AS A STUDENT OF WAS LIKE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I WILL CLOSE.
HI MY NAME IS NINA QUESTIONS
JOKE I AM THE MOTHER OF FIVE
KEYS THREE OF THEM IN HOME
SCHOOLING RIGHT NOW INLAND
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE BRENDAN TO IT ON
BEHALF OF AT VOICE IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIA QUESTIONS
SHOOK.
I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS CALEB
SANDERSON I POST.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ERICA STRUCTURE COME PART OF
HOME SCHOOL PROGRAM AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE MY NAME IS ONLY LARSON I'M
A PARENT OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS KATIE.
CRUISE FIFTEEN NO FROM.
MY NAME IS MADELINE SANDERSON I
AM A HOME SCHOOL MOM OF FOUR
WE'VE BEEN WITH CELLS ARE
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR SEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH
BY.
HI MY NAME IS ISABEL JOHNSON I
HAVE BEEN HOME SCHOOLING FOR
FOUR YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JEFF RICE REPRESENTING THE A
PLUS PERSONALIZED LEARNING
NETWORK ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
MORE THAN SEVENTY THOUSAND K.
TWELVE STUDENTS AND SEVENTY FIVE
PERSONALIZED LEARNING CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO IS WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE SECOND FLOOR.
AND BUT YEAH.
SO IF YOU I I ASSUME YOU'RE
LINED UP OUT THERE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY FROM FLOOR
[inaudible]
TO YEAH.
DO WE HAVE THIS IF IF YOU'RE AT
THE MICROPHONE.
ON THE SECOND FLOOR BEGIN OR
WE'RE GONNA MORALITY ELECTION OF
FOUNDER FOURTEEN SCHOOL
EDUCATION.
BOARD MEMBER PACIFIC CHARTER IS
TO DO.
OPPOSED.
TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME
IS LORRAINE -- JONES I AM A
STUDENT OF HIGHLAND COMMUNITY
CHARTER AND I AM A PARENT OF A
STUDENT FROM FORTUNE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY ALL IN I OPPOSE.
OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S KIMBERLY CLARK I'M
A PARENT OF A STUDENT AT WILLIAM
LEE COLLEGE PREP AS WELL AS A
STUDENT AT REX MARJORIE FORTUNE
EARLY MIDDLECOLLEGE I'M ALSO
THE PARENT SITE COUNCIL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CANDY SOLANO I'M A
GRANDMOTHER OF NINE CHILDREN.
AT THE FORTUNE SCHOOLS WE HAVE
SOME AT WILLIAM LEVY.
EVAN WILLIAMS [inaudible]
AND WHICH FORTUNE.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER SOLANO I'M A
MOTHER OF SIX AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL MY KIDS ATTEND WILLIAM LEE
COLLEGE PREP.
HELLO MY NAME IS WES PEPPER ON
THE DIRECTOR FRANKLIN
INSTRUCTION FOURTEEN SCHOOL.
AND A PARENT OF CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
KELLY SIMON DIRECTOR OF BRIDGES
CHARTER SCHOOL IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA WHERE ON APPEAL WITH
VENTURA COUNTY AND I ALONG WITH
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN OH
FIVE HI MERRY GALVIN DIRECTOR
AND FOUNDER OF INTER CHARTER
SCHOOL OF ARTS.
IN GLOBAL EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF
OUR HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS AT
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS WE STAND
AND STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS BRENDA ALL SHIVER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
MEADOWS ARTS AND TECHNOLOGY
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN THOUSAND
OAKS.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE BEDROOMS
ARE TO TECHNOLOGY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BOARD OF DIRECTORS WE ARE
STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
KRISTIN WALKER FROM MEETS
CHARTER IN THOUSAND OAKS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SHERRI TAURUS -- HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
AND ALSO A PARENT OF A CHILD AT
CCC CC C. S. CHARTER SCHOOL AND
AYE OPPOSED A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
GINNY'S DOLLY HUNT I AM.
A COMMUNITY OUTRAGE DIRECTOR AND
A STUDENT.
AND LEADER AT HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND
FUTURE GRADUATE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMES DEARBORN -- I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AT
TEN HIGHS COMMITTEE CHARTER
SCHOOL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SARAH FALL SOME I'M A
STUDENT AT HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY
CHARTER SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
MY NAME IS LORETTA STEVENSON I
AM A STUDENT IN HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME FROM THE RODRIGUEZ AND I
HAVE A SON THAT GOES TO FOURTEEN
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AMBER NAY TURNER I GO TO THE
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITIES.
CHARTER SCHOOL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS PASSION AARON AND
I GO TO HIGHLANDS COMMITTEE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI AM LINDA HAMILTON AND I'LL GO
TO HOLLINS.
OF CHARTER SCHOOL OUT POSES PIA.
HI MY NAME IS JOYCE TERRACE.
AND NOW GO TO HIGHLAND.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S MICHELLE LOGIN I GO TO
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL I'M A PROUD STUDENT THERE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
STEVE MARTINEZ WITH RICH CHRIS
CHARTER SCHOOL IN KERN COUNTY
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MERRIAM HOLD THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR RIDGECREST
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LILY GARRETT AND I
HAVE -- THE GRANDPARENT OF THREE
STUDENTS AND NOT FOR TO SCHOOL
AND AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THE THE THE ANNA SILVA -- FROM
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER AND
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CLOUDY AROUND THIS
ENORMOUS TO ANOTHER HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
AM.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M COREY PARKER I AM FOR A
JUNIOR I CORPS CHARTER AND A
TEACHER'S AIDE AT THE ERA STEM
ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M MELISSA REMINGTON I AM A
PARENT EDUCATOR WITH CELL CENTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CHAIR GROOMING TO NON
AYE OPPOSED NO.
MY NAME IS STANLEY GROW A PAROLE
LEE STUDENT AT HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY.
CHARTER SCHOOL AND AYE OPPOSED
HIS BAIL.
MY NAME IS DWIGHT DROZ
INNOVATIVE EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
MANAGING CELL SUTTER SKY%
MOUNTAIN AND OCEAN GROVE CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI HI AM JOYOUSLY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL I'M A HOMESCHOOL
ADVOCATE AND A FORMER HOME
SCHOOL PARENT.
I'M AND MASON.
THE MAN MASON FAIRFAX I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI AM JULIE SCHIFFMAN WE ARE A
SUMMIT ACADEMY CHARTER SCHOOL
FAMILY AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M DINEEN HINES ALSO A SUMMIT
ACADEMY CHARTER FAMILY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AM KRISTIN SHEPHERD I AM FROM
WESTMINSTER CALIFORNIA I STAND
HERE WITH TWENTY TWO OTHER
FAMILIES THAT I AM BRINGING YEAR.
ARE WE ALL OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE DANCE OF THE INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL PROGRAM THANK YOU.
HI CLAUDIA ONE TRUCK DIRECTOR
RIVER OAKS ACADEMY CHARTER
SCHOOL THOUSAND OAKS ON BE HARD
BEHALF OF OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS
I MYSELF I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
LYNN ROBINSON I AM A PARENT OF
TWO AND A TEACHER.
AND I OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
DANA SHOEMAKER AND I WORK AT
RIVER OAKS ACADEMY.
AND AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN I STARTED THIS MEDIUM IDEA
FERNANDO INDICTMENT?
TELL US WHO DON'T GOMEZ TO AND
RIVER OAKS ACADEMY IN OXNARD
EMAIL PONGAL AND A KEEN SENSE A
SINGLE WHICH I CAN ASSIST.
MY NAME IS THEY COME FREE AND
I'M A TEACHER RIVER OAKS ACADEMY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LESLIE MAPLE FROM
RIVER OAKS ACADEMY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CHRISTINE RAINER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENT IN A VENDOR I'M ALSO
EDUCATIONAL THERAPIST BEHAVIOR
THERAPIST AN ASSOCIATE MFT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI AM RHONDA YELLIN FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M A HOME SCHOOL
MOM I'M ALSO ON THE PARENT
ADVOCACY TEAM FOR INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MY DAUGHTER
IS A STUDENT AT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
HI I'M LYERLA'S YELLING I'M A
STUDENT AT INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MCKINNEY I'M
HOME SCHOOL PARENT FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I GRADUATED ONE STUDENT
FROM INSPIRE I HAVE TWO MORE
STUDENTS ENROLLED I'M A MEMBER
OF THE PARENT ADVOCACY TEAM AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY MCCAMLY FOR
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOM OF TWO CHILDREN WHO I HOME
SCHOOL TRANSPIRE CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIME MCCAMLY
FROM.
FOR TEN I'M A FATHER TO TWO
DAUGHTERS THAT I HOME SCHOOL
THROUGH INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS --
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
ONE FIVE ZERO FIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JILL
FREDERICKS AND I'M FROM COSTA
MESA CALIFORNIA.
AND I OPPOSE AB.
ONE FIVE OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
MARIA RIVERA AND I'M FROM YORBA
LINDA AND I AM THE MOTHER OF TWO
VACCINE DAMAGED CHILDREN.
WHO WERE DENIED THEIR CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AT TRAVIS
RANCH IN THE PLACENTA YOUR BILL
IN A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
MY KINDERGARTEN -- WAS KICKED
OUT ON HER THIRD DAY OF SCHOOL
AND WE NOW.
AGAIN.
YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
HARMING OTHER PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO SHARE THEIR OPINION TODAY
WHEN YOU GOING YOUR OWN DIATRIBE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. TWENTY ACKLAND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I HOME SCHOOL MY
THREE CHILDREN TO INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHY I'M ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF HOME SCHOOLING AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS THE
CLYDE BOMB CURRENT STUDENTS AND
SACRAMENTO.
HIGHLAND CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OFF I
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MERRY
**** AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CORBY CHARTER SCHOOL IN CHICO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STAR
HENDRIX I'M A PROUD PARENT AND
TEACHER A QUARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
SALLY MAY OUR I'M A TEACHER AT
COR CHARTER SCHOOL AND I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO STUDENTS AT
CHARTER SCHOOL IN NEVADA CITY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX FOR CARE AND I
AM FROM FOR CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I'M SORRY.
MY NAME IS ALEX THE CARE AND I
AM FROM CORE CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS HEIDI LE CARE A
PARENT AND BOARD MEMBER ACCORD
CHARTER SCHOOL IN MARYSVILLE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HI MY NAME IS
MADELINE CARE AND THE STUDENT
COURT TURNED SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MONICA FOSTER A
PARENT OF THREE KIDS A CORE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS LESS SANDERS I'M AND
AEROSPACE TEACHER CORPS CHARTER
SCHOOL AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SILAS FOSTER I'M A
SENIOR STUDENT AT COURT CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LARRY PARKER I ATTEND
COURT CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MATT HARVEY PARENT EDUCATOR
CORBY CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MORGAN DIETZ
PARENTS AND CHARTER ADVISORY
COUNCIL MEMBER A CORPORATE
CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ADAM DATES I AM A
PARENT AND A TEACHER WITH
CORPORATE CHARTER SCHOOL IN
CHICO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THEY STILL ASK US
I'M A STUDENT AND I OPPOSE HIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALAN ROUTE LIVE I
AM A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
DR DAVID PATTERSON PLASTER
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION IN
OPPOSITION.
SUZANNE JONES I'VE SERVED ON THE
PLASTER COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION FOR NINE YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE YOUR STRIKING
OUR CHARTER.
THIRTY HI MY NAME'S STARS YOU
FRONT ENGINEER WITH THAT THE
CARE SETTLEMENT URBAN LEAGUE AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS MAX
BECAUSE SHOOK AND MY DAUGHTER I
KNOW OF WITH THE INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
FIVE HELLO I AM JULIUS I SHOOK
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER MILANA AND
WE ARE WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND WE STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE YEAH AND
MY KIDS GO TO  CO A ELEMENTARY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NOT JUST LOW WE
SHOULD CHECK I'M MOTHER AND GOOD
THEN MOTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S INDIANA IS SAIVA.
OF MOM I DIDN'T MOTHER.
MIGHT INCLUDE CHILDREN PLAY HE'S
DONE A GOOD THEY MADE I OPPOSITE
.
FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE MY NAME IS IT
IS A SOFT COME AYE OPPOSED
[inaudible] OH FIVE HELLO MY
NAME IS MARIA MOCHA AND I PULLED
HIS BILL -- FIFTEEN OH FIVE
HELLO MY NAME IS ANA GARCIA I AM
A MOTHER OF FOUR I HOME SCHOOL
AND I HAVE A CHILD IN PRIVATE
SCHOOL IN A POST.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
NOT ALL THAT BAD SO AND I'M OF
MOTHER OF FIVE KIDS AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA AND I OPPOSE THE BILL
FIFTEEN OH FIVE I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN [inaudible]
IN -- REALLY WORRY ABOUT THEM
TOO SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MISFIT MY NAME IS SVETLANA
PATRICIA AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME'S
LETTERS AT RISK I PAUSE IF
YOU'VE YOUR WORRY FIVE ON THE
FIVE CHILDREN ON THE GROUND.
GOOD ENSURE THAT THEN
.
MY NAME IS VICTOR FOR THE FATHER
OF SEVEN CHILDREN. ONE GROUND
SOON THEN.
WAS FOR FOOD TO A FIRE.
I'M IN A PROMOTED I'M LAMP.
GOOD ON MONDAY ITEM OF SEVEN
CHILDREN ON ONE OF MY WHAT I'M
CHILD.
OF THEIR OWN. FIVE ONE FIVE OH
FIVE FOR SOMEONE IN PROGRESS I'M
PETER BUT ONLY ON THE HOW ONE
NEPHEW. ONE FIVE FIVE FIVE ONE
FIVE ONE FIVE FOUR FIVE HI MY
NAME IS DAN ASSEMBLY OUT CAN I
HAVE. THREE KIDS AND I DO OPPOSE
THE BILL FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LEERY WIVES AND I
OPPOSE FOR A BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS A
ROMANCE OF CA.
I OPPOSE FOR FIFTEEN OR FIVE
HELLO MY NAME IS IRENE US
MICHAEL AND I OPPOSE ON FIFTEEN
OH FIVE HELLO.
MY NAME IS ME TO CONTINUE.
OKAY -- FOR CHILDREN.
I OPPOSE FIFTEENTH.
ZERO FIVE I'M QUOTING ABOUT
TODAY [inaudible]
ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO FIVE THIS
[inaudible]
BILL.
HI.
MY NAME IS ALL BIRTH.
I HAVE SIX CHILDREN.
I'M AGAINST.
DO YOU. FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LOU WITH THE CLOVER.
I COULD HAVE SIX CHILDREN.
I COULD HAVE GRANDCHILDREN.
I OPPOSE.
THIS BILL.
MY NAME BRING TO NOT UNDER YOUR
SKIN.
I OPPOSE.
A FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE BE ABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME -- MIKHAIL EVERYTHING ON
THE U. S. K..
I HAVE THREE CHILDREN AND SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN.
I AM A POST -- FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE
BILLS.
MY NAME IS DAVID TURNOUT -- I
HAVE -- ONE NEPHEW AND TWO
NIECES AND I OPPOSE OF FIFTEEN
OH FIVE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ON THE TOILET.
I OPPOSE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELA GOOD CHAIN GO
AND I DO OPPOSE EIGHTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU.
I MEAN FIFTEEN OH FIVE THINKS.
MY NAME IS GLOBAL OF REASONING
CHEN GOT I AM OPPOSED.
TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
REJECTED THE RECESSION AYE
OPPOSED.
TO FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
WHAT THE MILLION.
I OPPOSE FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE THANK
YOU.
MAY I MET MY NAME IS GIVEN.
TO THE I OF THE FIFTY TWO ZERO
FIVE MY NAME IS ALL THE COURTS
YOU VOICE WHO HAVE -- FOR KIDS
YOU KNOW HOME SCHOOL TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND TWELVE KIDS AN
EXTENDED FAMILY YOU WILL POSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ELLA QUITE CHOI AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS
INDIANA CORRECT AVOID AND I
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OF FIVE HELLO MY
NAME IS JULIA QUARTS OF OIL AND
AYE OPPOSED FIFTEEN OH FIVE I'M
A MOM OF HOME SCHOOLING KIDS.
MY NAME IS YOU KNOW THE DECISION
AND AYE OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS TIM
PETITION NYPOST A FIFTEEN OF IF.
SO MY YOUNG DAD WITH TWO KIDS
AND I OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH FIVE
THANK YOU.
WE JUST LOVE STEVEN HI OPPOSE.
FIFTY FIVE CHARTER SCHOOL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE KIANA.
IF YOU KNOW.
FIVE MY NAME IS BY -- CO WROTE
THE SOPRANOS THE BILL.
IF YOU ALL.
FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS THE TOWN
OF THAT SHOW SKINNER AYE AYE
OPPOSED.
THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER IS A THEIR SHIPS GOT
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME
SHE LIMóN.
AYE APPLES IS A BILL.
I A. B..
IF YOU JUNE.
FIFTEENTH WILL. FIVE HI MY NAME
IS A WAR.
A AYE OPPOSED THE VEAL AB --
FIFTEEN FIVE HELLO MAN MY NAME
ELIMINATE THE SOUND OFF AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL IS.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE HELLO I AM GONNA
DO THE BIG.
I'M FOR SERVER FOR KIDS.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTEEN OFF
OF OH FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
ANDRE PEUGEOT I'M A FATHER OF
FIVE AND AYE OPPOSED THE DEAL A
D. O..
N. TONO. FIVE FIFTEEN OH FIVE
HOW MANY USERS ARE HOWEVER I'M A
I'M A US ARMY VETERAN.
AND I BELIEVE IN FREEDOM AND AYE
OPPOSED BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS DANIEL CHEN GOT.
ALL VOTE.
I I AM FROM WAS SERVED THE
CHARTER SCHOOL OF LAW AND I IT.
A BULLS A FIFTEEN EIGHT BEERS
FIFTY NO.
FIVE SENATE PEAK CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE FIFTY A. B..
FIFTEEN OH FIVE OKAY FOR WITH
PACIFIC CHARTER INSTITUTE AND
BOARD MEMBERS OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION OPPOSING
.
FIFTEEN ZERO FIVE ALL RIGHT
THERE WE GO GOOD JOB -- BRING IT
BACK HERE -- OKAY THANK YOU AND
I THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS FOR BEING QUICK
EFFICIENT AND ALSO -- ALLOWING
OTHERS TO GET THEIR THEIR THEIR
POINT OF VIEW ACROSS AGAIN THANK
YOU -- WITH THAT WERE TO TURN
OVER BACK BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I'LL JUST MAKE A MAYBE
A COMMONER QUESTION.
OFFER I DIDN'T CATCH YOUR NAME
ON THE END OF THE TABLE AND I
DIDN'T.
KNOW MY NAME IS HASTEN THOMAS
FROM -- EDUCATION FOR CHANGE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA OKAY IT IS A
ONE POINT YOU MADE ACT.
I TWENTY SURE YOU YOU HAD A
CONCERN ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT
THAT WOULD ONLY BE GOING FORWARD.
WE SEEK TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS AT CLARIFY THAT I SPOKE
TO THAT WHEN I OPENED UP TODAY.
WITH REGARD TO THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF CHARGES THAT WOULD ONLY BE A
NEW CHARGE GOING FOR SO I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
OKAY AND THOSE WHO YOU SPOKE
ABOUT.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR CAN I ASK.
ALRIGHT LET ME JUST.
NINETY BUT WHEN YOU ASK IS A
PERK PERTAINS WHAT I JUST
BROUGHT UP OKAY GOT.
BOB SO ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT
THE BILL IMPRINT TODAY -- IS NOT --
EIGHT THE BILL IN PRINT TODAY IS
WHAT WE'RE REFERRING TO THE
CROSS REFERENCE WHICH WOULD
APPLY TO RENEWAL STANDARDS AND
WOULD APPLY TO EXISTING SCHOOL
SO ARE YOU SUGGESTING THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THIS.
YEAH YEAH SO MEMBERS WE PLAN TO
TAKE.
NOT THE CURRENT FORM.
OKAY BILL FOR THEIR NOT REFLECT
IN THE BILL.
OKAY THAT'S WHAT I'M STATING YES
I'M SORRY I THOUGHT OF YOU THE
CLIP.
OKAY THEN AGAIN -- I I JUST HAD
A QUESTION TALK ABOUT FISCAL
IMPACT YOU TALK ABOUT DISTRICTS.
MAYBE THE WAY SOUND MAY WORK THE
COMMENTATOR TAKE TEACHERS TOO
MUCH.
YOU TALKED ABOUT PENSIONS AND
YOU TALK ABOUT BENEFITS AND PAY
WAS IS IT YOUR POSITION THAT
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA PAY TOO
MUCH.
NO MY POSITION WOULD BE THE
OPPOSITE AND WE COME FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WERE
SKYROCKETING COST OF LIVING IS
MAKING IT SUCH THAT WHETHER
YOU'RE IN A DISTRICT A CHARTER
PUBLIC SCHOOL OUR ABILITY TO PAY
TEACHERS TO EVEN PAY RENT -- AND
SURVIVE IS INADEQUATE SO I THINK
I WAS REFERRING TO THE FACT THAT --
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS ARE THE
ART.
SCHOOL OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO CONTRIBUTE
INCREASING AMOUNTS TO THE
PENSION FUNDS WHICH HAVE MADE IT
SO THAT WHILE L. L. C. AT THAT
HAS GONE UP OUR EXPENSES OF ALSO
GOING UP DRAMATICALLY IN AT THIS
POINT.
THE INCREASES IN LCF ARE NOT
KEEPING PACE WITH THE INCREASES
IN PENSIONS AND BENEFITS
INCREASES OKAY AND I AGREE WITH
AND THAT'S NOT A THAT'S NOT A
CHARTER SCHOOL OR TRADITIONAL.
SCRAP PROBLEM THAT'S A
CALIFORNIA PROBLEM THAT WE NEED
TO DRESS FOR ALL STICKER ACT IN
EVERY SCHOOL SO I APPRECIATE
THAT POINT OF VIEW.
AND I AGAIN I JUST I EITHER A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO CAME UP WITH
THINK FROM THE HOME SCHOOL
COMMUNITY I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
FEEL MORE TARGETED THAN ANY
OTHER IN THIS EFFORT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE
EFFORT HERE.
AND I I JUST WANT UNDERLYING
THAT IF YOU'RE CHARTER SCHOOL AS
WELL OPERATED TODAY.
THIS BILL DOES NOT SPEAK YOUR
SCHOOL.
THIS BILL SPEAKS TO THOSE
SCHOOLS WHO ARE NOT OPERATED
WELL THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE
BILL OKAY SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND ALL MR MCCARTY YOU SEE SHE
IN HER DO WISH [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU -- MAYBE I CAN JUST
ASK YOU MISTER BONTA OR THAT THE
CHAIR IS A JOINT AUTHORED JUST
TO CLARIFY ONE MORE TIME.
BECAUSE I THINK IF YOU ASK THE
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE HERE TODAY
WHATEVER THE WHATEVER NUMBER
THERE ARE THIS BOOK CAN
OPPOSITION.
THEY WOULD SAY TWO THINGS.
THEY LOVE THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS
THEY EITHER HALFORD HAD A GREAT
EXPERIENCE.
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO SHUT DOWN.
HEY THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION.
AND FRANKLY DISINFORMATION ABOUT.
THIS AND THE AND THE NEXT BILL
WHICH WILL GET TO A LITTLE BIT
SO COULD YOU CLARIFY. FOR THE
RECORD WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
CURRENT.
OPERATORS.
WHETHER THE GRANDFATHER
GRANDMOTHER CLAUSE WHEN THEY
PETITION FOR RENO.
YES IN SHORT THIS THIS BILL IS
NOT DESIGNED OR INTENDED TO
CLOSE ANY CURRENTLY EXISTING
CHARTER SCHOOLS [inaudible]
THE IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE
HAVE A DRAFTING ERROR.
THAT HAS CREATED SOME CONFUSION
IT'S IT IS IN THE CURRENT FORM
OF THE BILL WHAT YOU'RE READING
YOUR READING IT RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IT'S
INTENDED TO DO IT WILL BE A
CHANGE SO THAT.
THE CONSIDERATION OF FINANCIAL
IMPACT THE CONSIDERATION OF
ACADEMIC IMPACT THE
CONSIDERATION OF FACILITIES
IMPACT WILL ONLY APPLY. TO
INITIAL AUTHORIZATION.
NOT.
NOT. TO RENEW OFFICE
[inaudible]
AND YOUR GRANDFATHER NANOGRAM
MOTHER DâN.
I'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE BUT OFF
REPEATED -- IF -- IF YOU'RE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN AUTHORIZING YOU SEE
CAN WE AUTHORIZATION YOU GO BACK
TO THE AUTHORIZED FOR THAT
AUTHORIZE YOU -- WITH ONE
EXCEPTION BUT BUT IF YOU GOT A
AUTHORIZATION FROM A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE YOU GO BACK FOR FOR RE
AUTHORIZATION. FOR WE KNOW IF
YOU GOT AUTHORIZED BY COUNTY.
HE GO BACK TO THE COUNTY.
BUT IF YOU'RE AUTHORIZED BY THE
STATE WE ASK NOW WITH THIS BILL
THAT YOU GO.
BACK TO THE LOCAL DISTRICT
THAT'S THE ONE EXCEPTION.
SOMEONE JUST BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT --
SO THAT WE MY IMPRESSION WAS
MUCH THE SAME AS YOURS MISTER
MCCARTY -- AND I FIRST WANT TO
THANK INCREDIBLE LEVELS OF
ENGAGEMENT FROM -- FOLKS MALL
OVER THE STATE MANY -- I NOTICED
A FROM MY DISTRICT THANK YOU ALL
FOR COMING IF YOU CAME FROM MY
DISTRICT -- THE YOUNG PEOPLE
PARTICULAR WANNA GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO FOR BEING HERE FOR
EXPRESSING YOUR VIEW FOR
ENGAGING.
AND OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS --
BUT MY SENSE WAS.
THAT FOLKS LOVE THEIR CURRENT
CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND THOUGHT IT WOULD BE CLOSE BY
THIS BILL.
AND I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THAT
IS NOT THE INTENTION NOR DO WE
THINK IT WILL BE THE IMPACT AT
ALL.
OF OF THIS BILL THIS IS ABOUT
NEW APPLICATIONS --
AUTHORIZATIONS GUY GOING FORWARD
WHERE I CHARGE BUT NEVER BEEN
AUTHORIZED BEFORE SO THERE'S NO.
KIDS ARE STUDENTS GOING TO IT
YET IT DOESN'T EXIST.
AND THEY'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA BE
ASKING.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
TO CONSIDER WHAT THEY CONSIDER
FOR OTHER ISSUES.
LIKE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
PENSIONS THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
HEALTH CARE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES WERE GONNA ASK
THAT THEY ALSO BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER AS ONE FACTOR AMONG
MANY.
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF ON A
DISTRICT OF A CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT'S BEING ASKED WE AUTHORIZE
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
SO I HOPE THAT CLARIFIES THINGS
FOR SOME OF THE FOLKS HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE -- AND MAKES THEM
FEEL A BIT MORE COMFORTABLE
ABOUT THEIR EXISTING CHARTER
SCHOOL AND MISTER MCCARTY IF I
COULD THERE'S ALREADY PROCESS
FOR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AB TWELVE HUNDRED I BELIEVE IT
IS THERE'S A PROCESS WHERE AND
THEY FILED THE COUNTY AND THERE
FISCAL SITUATION LOOKED AT THREE
YEARS OUT AND ALSO SEE NEW
SIMPLY.
IS DEPRIVE BASICALLY THE SAME
STANDARD TO CHARTER SO THAT WE
CAN IDENTIFY WHEN THERE ARE
FISCAL PROBLEMS MUCH EARLIER.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYONE CAN
FAULT US FOR DOING THAT THAT'S
JUST WISE POLICY SO THAT IF
THERE ARE PROBLEMS WE CAN GET
INTO THE CHART OF THE COUNTY
MEMBER THEY NEED HELP FROM.
CAN GET IN THERE I AND HELP
ADDRESS THE FISCAL PROBLEMS ON
IT -- IT EARLY ON SO THEY DON'T
RESULT IN A DAY OF APPARENTLY
THE DAY HAVE A SCHOOLS CLOSING
THAT THEY HAVE TO GO THEN FIND A
SPOT FOR THEIR STUDENT IN IN IN.
IN ANOTHER SCHOOL IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL LOCAL TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL HAS TO PICK THAT STUDENT
UP IN A VERY IMMEDIATE BASIS AND
THAT CAUSES ALL KINDS OF
LOGISTICAL ISSUES.
SO AGAIN THIS IS IT WE SEEK
EARLY WARNING. TO HELP NOT TO
HURT YEAH.
THANK YOU AND AND MY NEXT
QUESTION CAN I ASK MY LOCAL
COUNTY SUPERLATIVE SCHOOLS
MISTER GARDEN -- TO TO TO COME
BACK IF YOU MAY FOR SECOND.
YEAH AND WHILE HE'S HE'S ON HIS
WAY OUT -- MISTER BONTA I WILL
SAY JUST LIKE YOU THAT YOU KNOW
WE KNOW GOOD CHARTER OPERATORS
AREN'T IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
HEARD.
HERE FROM TODAY AND A BUNCH OF
MY AREA THAT THE HIGHLANDS
CHARTER PROGRAM WHICH IS THE
FOCUS IS PROBABLY AN ADULT ADULT
EDUCATION.
ADULT LEARNERS ARE FORTUNE
SCHOOL OF COURSE ARE HEARD FOR
THE LANGUAGE TO CARRY A SACK
SACRAMENTO SO.
I KNOW INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
TO PARTICIPATE SO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE.
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING AWAY.
I WILL I WANT TO I WANT TO ASK
YOU MISTER GORE YOU FOR THOSE OF
YOU DON'T KNOW YOU ARE ARE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
AND YOU'RE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION -- TO THIS BILL --
ON BEHALF OF YOUR BOARD YOU SAID
RIGHT SO SO YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
HERE AS AN INDIVIDUAL AS A SUPER
TEN YOU'RE HERE ON BEHALF OF
YOUR BOARD.
CORRECT.
YEAH I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
BOARD TRYING TO REFLECT THE
EXPERIENCE.
THAT I AND MY BOARD HAVE HAD
OVER THE YEARS.
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THERE ARE.
OF THE ED COALITION.
WE HEARD FROM -- THREE GROUPS OF
MY SENDING EARLIER THAT ARE TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
AND THERE'S THREE OTHERS FROM
THE MANAGEMENT SIDE THE SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION CSPA
BACKS -- WHO UP SOMEWHAT
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION SUCCESS AT?
WHICH IS COMMUNICATED TO OUR
STAFF THAT THEY ARE ALSO.
SUPPORT FOR MINUTES SO IT SENDS
A LITTLE BIT OF CONFUSION THAT
YOU'RE HERE.
OPPOSING THE BILL.
WHEN YOUR ORGANIZATION WHICH
YOU'RE A PROUD MEMBER OF IS
WALKING AROUND THE SAME ALL
SAYING THAT THEY WOULD SUPPORT
WITH THAT TECHNICAL AMENDMENT?
THAT CREATES A PROBLEM MISTER
GORE'S LE LET ME TRY TO SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT ON THAT BECAUSE
AS I SAID I THINK YOU KNOW ME
WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW.
THAT WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS IS
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE RECORD OF OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH MY COUNTY BOARD.
AND THE MANAGEMENT OF OF
CHARTERS.
AND I THINK OUR OUR BOARD OVER
THE YEARS HAS BEEN VERY PRUDENT.
IN LOOKING AT CHARTERS THEY HAVE
NOT -- APPROVED WEEK CHARTERS
THIS AS I MENTION THE ONLY
COUNTY WIDE CHARTER THAT.
THE BOARD HAS APPROVED AS THE
FORTUNE CHARTER WHICH WHICH I
THINK IS IS KNOWN PRETTY WELL.
AS A HIGH PERFORMING CHARTERS SO
THAT'S OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
CHARTERS AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANTED TO REFLECT TO TO THE
COMMITTEE AS YOU DELIBERATE.
ON WHERE THE SKULLS.
OKAY I WOULD JUST ASK THAT THE
DID YOU KNOW YOU WORK WITH ALSO
WITH THE ASSOCIATION.
THEY'RE BRINGING US INFORMATION
ABOUT -- SUPPORTING THE BILL
WITH A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT AND
SO I THINK THAT GOD AND ASK YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU COMMUNICATE THAT WITH US AS
WELL YEAH YOUR EYES SHALL AND
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE A
MEMBER ON THE GOVERNOR'S --
APPOINTED COMMITTEE -- UP.
THE HEAD OF OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT ASSOCIATION --
ADVANCE.
AND AND WE'RE LOOKING TO TO HIM
TO HAVE -- INPUT AN INFLUENCE ON
THAT PROCESS SO THANK YOU.
YES AND AND AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A FEW BILLS I WON'T GET AHEAD OF
OURSELVES BUT IT'S BUT I KNOW
SACRAMENTO IS IS ROUGHLY 1012%
CHARTER POPULATION SIMILAR TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE HAD.
THIS LAW ON THE BOOKS SINCE THE
EARLY NINETIES FARCE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE.
LABORATORIES FOR LEARNING WHEN
THEY FIRST CAME ABOUT TEN IT'S
EVOLVED AND IT IS WHAT IT IS AND
SO I THINK.
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE FISCAL
REALITIES OF OUR SCHOOLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND NEEDED AND THAT'S
WHY SUPPORT THIS MISSION THANK
YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY HOPE.
MISS SMITH.
I LIKE TO THINK MY CO AUTHOR ON
THIS MISTER BONTA AND I
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATED YOUR
COMMENT.
ABOUT PARTNERS IN INNOVATION AND
FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY AND I'VE HAD
SOME ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
ONE OF MY MAIN CONCERNS HAVING
SPENT.
TIME AT THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND NINE YEARS AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER IS THAT WE
HAVE LOST SIGHT.
OF THE INNOVATION FEEDBACK LOOP
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY INTENDED IN
OUR NATION AND OUR STATE'S
CHARTER MOVEMENT.
AND SO IF YOU COULD THOSE OF YOU
IN OPPOSITION SPEAK TO KIND OF
WHAT THAT INNOVATION FEEDBACK
LOOP LOOKS LIKE IN THE DISTRICT
THAT YOU CURRENTLY SERVE.
AND IF YOU'RE PLANNING ON ANY
CHANGES GOING FORWARD TO HELP
ENHANCE THAT PROCESS.
I'M SORRY JUST TO CLARIFY SO THE
CHARTER SECTOR IN OAKLAND IS
ACTUALLY IN PRETTY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH DISTRICT
LEADERSHIP -- WE MEET REGULARLY
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT HER
STAFF TO THINK ABOUT THE LARGER
PORTFOLIO OF SCHOOLS I AM THE
FOUNDER AND A PARENT URBAN
MONTESSORI CHARTER SCHOOL THE
ONLY PUBLIC MONTESSORI OPTION IN
OAKLAND.
WORKING ACTUALLY WE RAISE MONEY
TO HAVE A STAFF PERSONWHO IS
ACTUALLY WORKING ACROSS DISTRICT
IN CHARTER SCHOOL TO HELP FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CREATE MONTESSORI
PRESCHOOL AND KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMMING AND U. S. D..
I I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
ACTUALLY WE'RE PART OF WE
PARTNER WITH -- SIX ACTUALLY --
THIRTEEN LOWER ELEMENTARY
PROGRAMS OPEN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS PART OF AN EARLY
LITERACY INITIATIVE FUNDED BY
THE KENNETH RENDON FOUNDATION
CHARTER DISTRICT ALIKE WE
EDUCATION FOR CHANGER IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH -- UST AROUND
CREATING A SPECIAL EDUCATION
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AND ACTUALLY
GOT STATE FUNDING TOWARDS THAT
THIS THIS SCHOOL YEAR.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS IN WHICH THE
DISTRICT CHARTER DIVIDE THAT IS
SORT OF PERPETUATED IS ACTUALLY
NOT TRUE IN OAKLAND THERE'S
RHETORIC AND THERE'S REALITY.
AND I THINK THERE IS MUCH
INTEREST IN WORKING ACROSS -- I
OPENED AT THE CONTROVERSIAL
LATITUDE HIGH SCHOOL THAT WENT
TO STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IT
IS ONE OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS IMAGINABLE WHICH IS WHY
I PUT SO MUCH ENERGY AND OPENING
IT.
WE'RE THEIR CREDIT A COMPETENCY
BASED HIGH SCHOOL MODEL VERY
INVEST IN WORKING WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
OAKLAND SO WE CAN GET RID OF
THINGS LIKE CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOLS AND ALTERNATIVE HIGH
SCHOOLS AND MOVE TOWARDS.
IF YOU HAVE A COMPETENCY BASED
SYSTEM ALL KIDS REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY'RE UNDER CREDITED
SIXTEEN CAN ACTUALLY ATTEND HIGH
SCHOOL AND WORKED QUICKLY OR OR
THROUGH SUMMERS ARE EVENINGS TO
ACQUIRE THE COMPANY SEES TO GET
A FOUR YEAR DEGREE THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF INNOVATIONS WERE
LOOKING.
FOR AND SPEAKING OF INNOVATION I
THINK WHAT'S TRICKY FOR ME ABOUT
THE WORD INNOVATION BECAUSE MY
CHARTER NO HE'S NOT PARTICULARLY
INNOVATIVE.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS IN FACT ART
MY TURN OVER HE'S ACTUALLY
COMPRISED ALMOST ENTIRELY A
FORMER -- UST SCHOOLS THAT
CONVERTED TO CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR
VARIOUS SINCE OVER THE YEARS.
AND I WILL SAY THIS I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT OAKLAND NEEDS
FOR INNOVATION IS.
BETTER PERFORMANCE FOR BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS IF THAT'S NOT
INNOVATIVE IT'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING INTO IT
FIFTY SIXTY YEARS OF UNDER
PERFORMANCE. FOR BLACK AND BROWN
KIDS IN THE DEFAULT PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT'S THE STATUS
QUO AND SO IT IS DISRUPTIVE TO
ACTUALLY HAVE HIGH PERFORMING
BLACK AND BROWN KIDS IN OAKLAND
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND I UNDERSTAND HERS AREN'T
ALWAYS THE ANSWER IN FACT THERE
ARE BAD PLAYERS AND WE ARE VERY
OPEN TO GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG AUTHORIZED
AN OPEN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THEY ARE TOUGH AUTHORIZED -- ARE
COUNTIES A TOUGH AUTHORIZED --
AUTHORIZING PLAYS A BIG ROLE IN
ACCOUNTABILITY -- IT'S A TOUGH
PLACE TO RUN A CHARTER SCHOOL IF
YOU'RE NOT A GOOD PLAYER.
AND I WILL SAY THIS I THINK THE
CLOSING DOORS TO POTENTIALLY
INCREASING OUTCOMES FOR KIDS
WE'VE NOT SEEN OUTCOMES FOR
DECADES WORRIES ME IT MIGHT NOT
BE INNOVATIVE IN IN TERMS OF
LIKE ENGINEERING OR STEM.
BUT IT'S AND IT'S TRULY INNOVATE
IN TERMS OF LIKE KIDS AND AND
COMMUNITIES IN OAKLYN ARE
EXPERIENCING.
I WOULD ONLY THANK YOU NO NO NO
NO NO NO NO.
I WOULD ONLY GOT A GAME -- DO WE
HAVE ANOTHER SPEAKER.
IN OTHER NO AND CONNECT YOU
REMEMBER WHICH IS [inaudible]
NUMBER OKAY.
NO ONE DOWN THERE MISS SMITH.
IS A FOLLOW UP TO THAT SO I
pREMARKS.
AND HERE'S MY THOUGHT WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE I LIKE AS I JUST
SAID I CAME OF NINE YEARS AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
I ALSO KNOW THAT IN THE
DISTRICTS THE COMMUNITIES THAT I
SERVE WE HAVE SOME HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE CHARTERS I'M THE HOME
TO THE GRANADA HILLS CHARTER
HIGH SCHOOL MULTIPLE TIME WINNER
OF THE STATE'S ACADEMIC
DECATHLON.
I REPRESENT AND I LEAD AS HE AYE
AYE LEAD SCHOOLS SELF DIRECTED
LEARNING FOR STUDENTS -- A
NUMBER THAT ARE CHARTER THROUGH
OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAVE BEEN HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL IN
SERVING STUDENTS WITH VERY
DIVERSIFIED BUT SPECIFIC NEEDS.
AND SO MY HOPE AS SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN A GOVERNING BOARD MEMBER
AND WHO KNOWS THE SIGNIFICANCE
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT KIND
OF RELATIONSHIP IN ESTABLISHING
WHAT THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT
INTENDED.
WHICH WAS DRIVING INNOVATION.
ELIMINATING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AND FOCUSING ON STUDENT SUCCESS
THAT THE CLOSER THAT
RELATIONSHIP IS AND THE MORE
THAT WE TAKE OUT THE HIGHER
INSTITUTIONS OF APPROVAL LIKE
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
THAT REALLY HAS NO RELATIONSHIP
TO THAT LOCAL DYNAMIC.
THE BETTER OFF STUDENT SUCCESS
IS GOING TO BE ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO I DO PLAN TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE WORK THAT WE MAY DO AFTER
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE IS
DONE AND WRAPS UP AND GIVES US A
REPORT ON WHAT THEY THINK MIGHT
FURTHER IMPROVE THIS
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT I THINK I'VE BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR WITH EVERYBODY ALL ALONG
FROM MY OWNCOMMUNITY TO THE
FOLKS ON THIS COMMITTEE THAT
WHAT I CARE ABOUT IS GETTING
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL MOVEMENT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND I
WANT EVERYBODY OUT OF THEIR
SILOS AND TO STOP THROWING BOMBS
FROM OTHER SIDES OF THE AISLE
AND FOCUS ON WHAT THAT
MEANINGFUL WORK IS ABOUT.
REGARDLESS OF THE KIND OF
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL AND THE KIND
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT THEY ARE
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
WAS TO SPEAK DOCTOR WEBER GOING.
YES OF I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
THANK -- MY COLLEAGUES WHO.
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD I REALIZE
IT.
IS THAT YOUR HEART IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AND SO I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A PART OF IT ANY
MALICIOUS OR PLATEN PLAN AGAINST
I HOPE NOT AGAINST CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW I I JUDGE
EVERYTHING THAT COMES IN -- ON
ITS MERIT IN WHERE THE NOT IT'S
BENEFICIAL TO CHILDREN.
AND CLEARLY IT BRINGS ME GREAT
CONCERN TO SEE THE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
HERE TALKING ABOUT WANTING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND FOR
THEIR CHILDREN -- ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE KNOW.
GENERALLY HAPPENS IN MANY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WITH REGARDS TO BLACK
AND BROWN KIDS WILL POUR -- HAVE
BEEN UNDERSERVED ANDAND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE CRITICAL
QUESTION IS NOT BEING ASKING IS
WHAT IS BEST FOR CHILDREN.
I THINK WE CAN IDENTIFY THE
ECONOMIC ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
CREATED FOR OURSELVES -- THE MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE SOME VALIDITY --
I AM CONCERNED AND I EXPRESSED
TO SOME OF THE AUTHORS OF THAT --
I'M THAT PRETTY MUCH THIS THIS
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY IS A DONE
DEAL BECAUSE FOUR OF THE SIX
MEMBERS ON THIS.
ON THE DAY AS OUR CO AUTHORS OF
OF THIS BILL SELF OF THIS BILL
AND ALL THE OTHER CHARTER BILL
SELF.
BUT IT'S GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU
ANYWAY SO I DON'T FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF ROOM FOR
PERSUASION BUT SIMPLY LET ME SAY
THAT -- I AM CONCERNED THAT THE
GOVERNOR.
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT HAVE
FORMED A TASK FORCE.
WHOSE TASK IS TO ANSWER SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT
AUTHORIZATION.
YOU WHERE SHOULD BE HOPEFULLY
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT SHOULD BE IN
THERE AND EVEN NOW MORE RECENTLY
THE IMPACT ECONOMICS HAS ON THE
CHART OF SYSTEM -- I JUST LOOKED
AT AND OF A LETTER FROM THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT ABOUT THE
MEETINGS A PAD AND THE GOAL THAT
THEY HAVE TO RELEASE THE REPORT
BY JULY.
ONE SO I'M CONCERNED THAT I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION.
NOT UNBIASED INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ACTUALLY DO
AND THE IMPACT THEY HAVE ON OUR
SCHOOLS.
NOW IS NO QUESTION THAT AFTER
TWENTY SIX YEARS -- THERE'S A
NEED FOR A SERIOUS DISCUSSION
ABOUT CHARTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OVERSIGHT OF CHARTERS -- AND
WHAT IS REASONABLE FOR A
DISTRICT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
CHARTERS IS REASONABLE FOR
DISTRICT THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
MANAGE AND SUPERVISE.
THE WHAT WE'RE GETTING READY TO
DO WITH THAT AND SOME OTHER
BILLS WOULD WITH TAX AND THIS
AND THIS DOESN'T REALLY ADDRESS
THAT.
BECAUSE OF OAKLAND IS ONE THIRD
CHARTER IS THAT A REASONABLE
PERCENTAGE FOR THE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THAT DISTRICT
ACTUALLY SUPERVISE THAT NUMBER
SINCE YOU'RE CAPPING IT AT THAT
THOUGH STILL BE A 30%.
AND SO THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES
IS THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
THAT WE HAVE FOR CHART IS NOT
ONLY TO BE OPERATED BY A BOARD
THAT HAS GOOD OVERSIGHT IS THAT
ENOUGH.
AND WHAT IMPACT DOES THAT HAVE
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
OVERSIGHT AND WE SEEN THAT IN
OTHER PLACES WHAT HAPPENS TO
BOARDS THAT ARE BAD ACTORS.
WHO ACTUALLY MAKE LOTS OF
CHARTERS AND DO NO OVERSIGHT YOU
KNOW DO WE TAKE AWAY THEIR RIGHT
TO CHART I MEAN I THINK THERE'S
SOME REALLY SERIOUS QUESTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO ASK THIS NOT?
BEING ASKED AND SERVE OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT WE SEE THIS
COMING FOR I'VE HEARD THE RUMORS
I KNOW WHAT PEOPLE SAY I'VE
LOOKED AT IT.
AND THEN I KNOW THE TRANSPARENCY
POLICE IS GOOD AND WE WE BOTH
GREASE FOLKS GREAT TO THAT.
BUT I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT THAT
THE REAL ISSUES AFFECTING
CHARTERS AND THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
IN THE STATE ARE NOT REALLY
BEING ANSWER.
NOW MY YOU KNOW MY INVOLVEMENT
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS WAY BACK
PROBABLY MORE THAN ANYBODY IN
THIS ROLE.
BECAUSE I WAS CHAIR OF THE NO
ONE ONE SEVENTY FOUR CAMPAIGN IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE I WAS
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND I'VE FOUGHT AGAINST VOUCHERS.
AND I KNOW THAT A PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION OUT OF THAT CAME
CHARTER.
WHICH IS FINE AND AND THE WHOLE
IDEA OF SHARING INFORMATION AND
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF AND WE'VE
GONE COMPLETELY IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION IT SEEMS AS IF THE YOU
KNOW THAT MOST OF THE
CONVERSATION HAS NOT BEEN.
FRIENDLY SUPPORTIVE
CONVERSATIONS EVEN THOUGH I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME SCHOOL BOARDS AND
A SAN DIEGO SOMEONE THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS WITH CHARTERS.
AND HAS DONE SOME GOOD WORK WITH
CHARTERS AND AND AUTHORIZES
REASONABLE CHARTERS BUT I KNOW
THAT RUMORS AND ALL KINDS OF
THINGS AND YET I DON'T REALLY
NECESSARILY SEE THIS BEING
ADDRESSED HERE.
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
IT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT HOW AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO IT --
AND WHETHER NOT WAS THE ECONOMIC
ISSUES REGARDING CHART IS WHAT
THIS WAS THE REAL ECONOMIC ISSUE
WHAT'S A REASONABLE NUMBER OF
CHARTERS THAT SHOULD EXIST IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE SIZE OF THE
DISTRICT.
I MEAN THESE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT TO ME STILL ARE NOT
ADDRESSED AND AND SO WHEN I SAW
THE THREE BILLS COME FORWARD.
WITH THE WOOD FOR THE AUTHORS
FROM THIS COMMITTEE I BASICALLY
SAID WAS A DONE DEAL.
YOU KNOW IT'S A DONE DEAL THAT
THIS IS THE DECISION THEY MADE
AND THAT MY COLLEAGUES IN MAY TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH I THINK GREAT
INTENTIONS BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF DISCUSSION.
AROUND CHARTERS AND MANY OF YOU
AS PARENTS HAVE -- YOU DON'T
HAVE EXPRESSED THAT INTEREST BUT
I'D STILL ASK THE QUESTION AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO ASK A QUESTION
WHAT'S BEST FOR KIDS.
AND WHY DO SO MANY PARENTS FEEL
SOUL DESPERATE. FOR A CHARTER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I FIND THIS TO BE
TRUE THAT THEY SEE THIS IS THE
ONLY HOPE THEY HAVE THE ONLY
ANSWER THEY HAVE A MEET AND I
HEAR THIS REGULARLY FROM PARENTS.
AND WHAT I SHARED A DON'T SHARE
THEIR THEIR VIEW OF THAT THE
REALITY IS WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES THE QUESTION.
WHY IS IT THAT THERE'S SUCH A
TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN CIARA'S
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
PIECE AND THERE'S SOME BAD
ACTORS OUT THERE THAT ARE MAKING
A BUNDLE ON CHARTERS AND THEN
GETTING UP THE BUSINESS OF
WHATEVER THEY'RE DOING?
BUT WE STILL HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION WHY ARE FOLKS SO
WILLING TO DO CHARTERS WE LIVE
RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL ALL RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
FROM A PUBLIC SCHOOL AND THEY
WANT TO GO TO A CHARTER.
YOU KNOW AND SO I I THINK
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE TO BE ASK I'M NOT
GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL I'M
GOING TO STAY OFF OF IT.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A
RIGHT THAT YOU ALL THE
INFORMATION YET AND LIKE I SAID
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WAS FORMED.
BY THE GOVERNOR AND THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TO BASICALLY
PROGRAMS A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
AND HELP US COME TO A CONCLUSION
ABOUT WHAT IS BEST -- WITH
REGARDS TO CHARTERS AND I I
STILL LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
INFORMATION I'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN IT COMES IN IS HOW
IT AFFECTS THESE THREE BILLS
THAT ARE HERE.
BUT I CAN'T IN GOOD CONSCIENCE
VOTE FOR THE BILL'S KNOWING THAT
THAT WE THAT THAT MANY OF US ASK
FOR TASK FORCE.
AND NOW WE HAVE ONE AND IT'S
JUST GOT STARTED AND WE'RE GOING
TO DO SOME MAJOR RESTRUCTURING
OF CHARTERS BEFORE WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION BUT I WOULD THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THINKING ABOUT IT
IT IS A CRITICAL ISSUE.
I CAN'T SUPPORT IT UNTIL I GET
MORE INFORMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THINGS YOU SAID MISTER CHAIR SO --
I'M SORRY I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT -- REMARKS YOU
MADE IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS I
THINK IT'LL LEAD AUTHOR THIS
BILL.
KATE WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE
PERRY MASON THANK YOU KNOW I'M
THE AUTHOR THE BILL RIGHT.
SO YOU WANT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM UP HERE GET ON THERE I'M
SORRY YOU WANT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS FOR APPEAR GO TO OUR
LIVES WE'VE GOT A JOINT AUTHORED
THERE I THINK.
YOU CAN ASK THE QUESTION ONE
ASKED IT'S ON THE FRONT.
MR KILEY LIKE TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS I'M HERE OKAY SO
PLEASE.
IT'S OKAY TO BE NICE ASKED THE
QUESTION WE USUALLY HAVE THE
AUTHOR DOWN THERE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE TRADITIONALLY
WE HAVE AND ONE OF THE OTHER SO
MAYBE MISTER BONTA WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS AND I MAY
ASK HIM TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
FOR ME SURCHARGE WHEN.
I MAY HAVE QUESTIONS REST WE
HAVE OTHER.
AS WELL SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU SO.
I'LL START WITH YOUR COMMENT
THAT YOU MADE.
IN YOUR REMARKS.
IF YOU'RE A GOOD CHARTER
OPERATOR YOU HAVE NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT NOW I TAKE IT THIS
IS A REFERENCE TO THE AMENDMENT
YOU HAVE AGREED TO TAKE.
SAYING THAT -- NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE DISTRICT
WILL NOT BE A CONSIDERATION
RENEWALS IS THAT RIGHT.
IN GENERAL SPEAKS TO THE THE RE
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS RIGHT SO.
YOU CAN'T BE DENIED RE
AUTHORIZATION -- ON THE BASIS
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE A NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE
AUTHORIZES SCHOOL DISTRICT
PURSUANT YOUR ANSWER REPHRASE
THE QUESTION [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO.
THE AMENDED THE YOU SAID YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE WILL MAKE IT SO I
CHARTER THAT IS SEEKING TO GET
RENEWED.
CANNOT HAVE ITS RENEWAL DENIED.
ON THE BASIS OF ANY NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT.
ON THE AUTHORIZING DOES THAT
THAT ISN'T THAT IS THE AMOUNT WE
SEEK TO TAKE OKAY.
AND SO IT'S I WANT THERE IS SOME
COMMON THERE IS DISINFORMATION
OUT THERE NO IT'S NOT THAT'S
THIS IS THE BILL AS IT DESPITE.
I'M RIGHT HERE I CAN HEAR YOU SO
JUST YEAH GET OUT OF IT AFTER.
WE CAN CONVERSE.
THAT'S THE BILL AS WRITTEN AND I
WAS EVEN CALLED A DRAFTING EVER
MISTER BOND AS THERE'S BEEN NO
DISINFORMATION BUT I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHO'S EVEN TOO MUCH
DRIVING YOUR IS IT IS SOMETHING
WE ARE GOING TO INCLUDE IN A
MOMENT AND AND WE KNOW.
OFTENTIMES IN THIS BUILDING
BILLS COME THROUGH AND WE NEED
TO CHANGE THEM MR THAT'S WHAT WE
SEEK TO DO MISTER CHAIR AND CAN
I CAN I SAY SOMETHING FOR THE
PUBLIC RECORD BECAUSE I IT IT'S
IMPORTANT IF WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
LIVE WHERE ALREADY DID TALK
ABOUT THIS.
A MOMENT SO I THOUGHT WHY DON'T
I I APPRECIATE IT NO I NIGHT WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT MISTER
CHAIR I I THINK WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BEFORE THE PUBLIC RECORDS WE'RE
GONNA WORK IN LISTEN WE'RE GOING
TO WORK WITH YOU IN A MINUTE SO
OF COURSE MR MCCARTY.
THAT DID STATED THAT THAT DATE
OR ALLEGED THAT THERE WAS
DISINFORMATION AND LET'S BE
CLEAR THE BILL IN PRINT RIGHT.
BUT THERE'S NO MISINFORMATION
AND PLAY YEAH WELL WE CAN ONLY
RESPOND TO WHAT'S IN PRINT BUT
I'M I'M QUITE CONFIDENT THERE'S
BEEN CUT COMMUNICATION WITH YOU.
AND THE MEMBERS OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION THAT WE WOULD AMEND
THAT SO.
IT IS WHAT IT IS NOW OKAY PLAN
NO MA'AM IT LIST.
GANG I SAID IT IT'S HERE IT'S ON
THE RECORD.
THERE IT IS THANK YOU SO IF YOU
ARE A CHARTER OPERATOR THAT --
YOU KNOW WAS LOOKING TO OPEN
ANOTHER SCHOOL BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH DEMAND MORE DEMAND THAN
THERE ARE SPOTS THAT'S HAPPENED
FOR SOME OF THE CHARTERS IN MY
DISTRICT IS.
YOU KNOW THERE IS THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO THERE --
THERE'S A LOT OF SPOTS SO
EVENTUALLY OPEN OTHER SCHOOLS --
SO IN THAT SITUATION -- WOULD
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT BE A VALID
FACTOR TO CONSIDER IN
AUTHORIZING THE CHARTER.
THE ES.
IT'S A NEW CHARTER.
AND UNDERSTANDING UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE DOING THIS -- BECAUSE
THERE ARE NOW MORE CHARTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEN
THERE ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND WE HAVE A VARIETY UNDER --
FINANCIAL DURESS AND I THINK IT
IS A VALID QUESTION SHOULD NOT
AT ALL.
THE THE ONLY QUESTION IS ASKED
UPON APPROVAL BUT IT IS A VALID
QUESTION TO ASK.
IF THAT IS -- FINANCIALLY
IMPACTFUL AND IN FACT CAN THE
CHARTER.
BE SUSTAIN FINANCIALLY.
TO OKAY I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
YOU SAID THAT IF YOU'RE A GOOD
CHARTER OPERATOR YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMEONE OR OFTEN
THIS BILL BECAUSE YOU WANT OPEN
ANOTHER SCHOOL DOING PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY TO MORE KIDS.
YOU WOULD HAVE A FACTOR OTHER
THAN THE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
AND THE PERFORMANCE OF THAT
SCHOOL BE ROB IS THAT RIGHT.
WELL YOU WOULD.
IT'S A FIGHT AT THE FINANCIAL
QUESTION WOULD BE ON PAR WITH
THE OTHERS WHICH I THINK IT'S
IT'S A VALID QUESTION ACT ASK.
IT IS VALID TO ASK WHAT
FINANCIAL IMPACT A NEW SCHOOL
WOULD HAVE.
AS FAR AS THAT STREET SCHOOL
BEING ABLE TO BE SUSTAINED OR
ITS IMPACT ON OTHER SCHOOLS.
WHAT -- I MEAN HOW WOULD.
HOW WOULD YOU ESTABLISH THIS --
YOU KNOW THE NEW FACTOR IS.
NEGATIVE FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE
DISTRICT -- WHAT EVIDENCE WOULD
YOU HAVE TO SHOW TO SUBSTANTIATE
THAT THERE BE A NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE DISTRICT
UNDER THIS BILL?
WELL I'M SURE THERE WOULD BE AN
APPLICATION PROCESS WHERE THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE ASCERTAINED
SO EVEN IF IT'S A VERY MINOR
NEGATIVE FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE
DISTRICT WOULD IT COULD A
CHARTER BE DENIED ON THAT BASIS.
I WOULD THINK -- BOARD WOULD
TAKE THE SITUATION IN TOTALITY
AND MAKE AN ACTION BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THEY'VE BEEN
PROVIDED BUT IT WOULD BE LAWFUL
FOR A BOARD TO DENY CHARTER ON
THE BASIS OF A NEGATIVE.
EVEN A MINOR NEGATIVE FINANCIAL
IMPACT ON THE DOESN'T THAT RIGHT
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE
[inaudible]
AND AGAIN.
I'M NOT ON THE LOCAL BOARD.
OKAY BUT I FOR ASK ABOUT THE LAW
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING TO MAKE THE
GOVERNOR'S THESE THINGS AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS. THREE
CHART RETURN THOSE DECISIONS THE
LOCAL LEVEL BASED ON A VARIETY
OF FACTORS.
WELL LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT SO
YOU YOU SAID YOU WANT TO RETURN
DECISIONS TO THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
I THINK YOU TALKED ABOUT.
WHAT AUTHORIZES SHOPPING WAS AT
THE TERM?
AND YOU MADE THE ARGUMENT THAT
THERE IS.
GREATER DEMOCRATIC
ACCOUNTABILITY -- WITHIN THE
AUTHORIZED -- WHEN THAT WHEN
THAT CHARTER IS WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE AUTHORIZES
SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS A ARGUMENT?
YES YEAH WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS A
SITUATION WHERE.
CHARTERS ARE BEING AUTHORIZED
FAR AWAY FROM THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THEY MAY SIT IN.
AND THERE IS LITTLE TO NO
OVERSIGHT OF THESE CHAR'S WHAT
WE FOUND AYE AYE TO I TALKED
ABOUT THE ARTICLES WE HAVE
PEOPLE MAKING LOTS OF MONEY OFF
THESE CHARTERS.
KIDS NOT BEING SERVED WELL AND
IT TURNS OUT TO BE A RATHER
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION FOR THE
STUDENTS.
AND AND AND AND THE THE THE
AUTHORIZED.
FOR SO WHAT ABOUT COUNTS THAT
COUNTIES HAVE DEMOCRATIC
DEMOCRATIC ACCOUNTABILITY --
THEY'RE MORE MEMBERS ARE
POPULARLY ELECTED -- YET THIS
BILL SEEKS TO FOR ALL INTENTS
AND PURPOSES ELIMINATE THE ROLE --
WHY IS DEMOCRATIC ACCOUNTABILITY
NOT GOOD ENOUGH WHEN IT COMES TO
THE COUNTY?
BUT WELL FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT
TOTALLY ELIMINATING THE ROLE BUT
WE'RE SAYING IS IT SHOULD BE A
LOCAL DECISION WERE CHAIRED AND
WERE RETURNING DECISIONS TO
LOCAL BASIS.
OKAY SO WHY IS I I'M NOT I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I'M A FIRM
SUPPORTER OF LOCAL CONTROL AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IT FALL IT FALLS BACK ON THE
LOCALS.
OUR COUNTY IS NOT LOCAL DECISION
MAKERS.
THE REGIONAL DECISION MAKERS I
WOULD SAY THEY'RE VERY MUCH
LOCAL DECISION OKAY SO WHY IS IT
THAT.
I MEAN WHY IS THAT A DISTINCTION
THAT MATTERS IN THIS CONTEXT.
YOU TELL ME.
WELL NOW YOU'RE THE ONE WHO'S
ACTUALLY PUTTING THAT
DISTINCTION THE LAW SO I THINK
YOU WANT TO TELL ME WELL IT'S
IT'S IT'S A GENERALLY UNDERSTOOD
CONCEPT THAT COUNTIES MAKE
DECISIONS ON A REGIONAL BASIS.
AND FOR INSTANCE A SCOLD SCHOOL
DISTRICT MAKES DECISIONS ON A
VERY LOCAL -- BASIS ONLY WITHIN
THE CONFINES.
OF THAT DISTRICT SO WE'RE
SEEKING TO DO IS ALLOW THAT
DISTRICT WHICH MANAGES THAT.
THAT.
WITHIN THE CONFINES THAT
BOUNDARY TO MAKE THE DECISIONS
NOT TO PASS IT ON TO SOMEONE WHO
WOULD NOT.
A REALLY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT ON ON I SEE
COOPERATION AND A VERY LOCAL
BASIS UNDERSTAND SOME THESE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY.
FROM WHERE THE SCHOOL SIT SO
HE'S AUTHORIZE OR SITS FAR FAR
AWAY STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
TALK HOW FAR AWAY FROM SOME OF
THESE ARE THAT IS AN ANSWER.
SEVENTIES SO THESE CHARTER
SCHOOLS SIT FAR FAR AWAY FROM
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND THEY'RE JUST IS NOT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT I THINK YOU'VE SEEN
PEOPLE GOING TO JAIL.
YOU SEEN CHARTERS CLOSING
OVERNIGHT YOU SEEN FINANCIAL
DISASTERS AND I THINK TODAY WE
NEED TO FIX THAT OKAY I WAS
TALKING ABOUT COUNTIES SO SOME
COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY SMALLER
THAN SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- I
THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE CAN TELL
YOU WHAT COUNTY THEY LIVE IN A
LOT OF YOU MIGHT EVEN KNOW WHAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY HAPPEN TO
BE AND SO WHY IT.
IS THAT NOT CONSIDERED A FORM OF
LOCAL CONTROL BUT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR CHARTER AUTHORIZED.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE'RE DOING WHAT
WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS RETURN
THE DECISION OF LOCAL CONTROL A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HAS CONTROL OVER ITS OWN
BOUNDARIES AND AND AND I SUPPORT
THAT YOU MAY NOT I DO.
AT A COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE
CONTROL OVER ITS OWN BOUNDARIES
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
BUT WHATEVER I COUNTY DOES NOT
HAVE CONTROL OVER ITS OWN
BOUNDARIES THAT WE'RE SAYING
[inaudible]
SURE DOES [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S GO ON TO A THE PORTION OF
THIS BILL.
THAT WOULD ELIMINATE GROWTH IN
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN CHARTER REAL
WHAT'S THE REASON FOR THAT.
I'M SORRY ONE MORE TIME WHY DOES
THE BELL THE MINUTE GROWTH IN
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN CHARTER
RENEWAL -- DOESN'T IT IT DOES
NOT.
IT IS STILL A FACTOR IT IS STILL
A FACTOR BUT IT'S NO LONGER THE
PRIMARY FACTOR WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT SHOULD
NOT BE THE PRIMARY FACTOR.
WELL IT PUTS IT ON PAR WITH
OTHER FACTORS BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
SOME CHARTER THAT ARE VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT OUR FINANCIAL
DISASTERS WE HAVE TO THE TRI
VALLEY EXAMPLE.
WHERE IN A CHARTER -- CHARTER
WENT BANKRUPT WHEN OUT OF
BUSINESS YET THE THE BUILDING
THEY BOUGHT WITH PUBLIC MONEY
ENDED UP IN PRIVATE HANDS.
THE BUILDING WAS WORTH A LOT OF
MONEY THE STUDENTS MIGHT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL WITH THE SCHOOLS
GOING DOWN THE TUBES FINANCIALLY.
SO THERE'S A BALANCE TO BE FOUND --
BUT LISTEN I'M AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER I WANT STUDENT SUCCESS I
WANT OUR STUDENTS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH US IF IF CHARTER IS -- IS
IS IS IS FINANCIALLY CHALLENGED
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE DO
NEED TO LOOK I THINK WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY ATTENTION
THE PHYSICAL ASPECT OF ANY
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATION.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
MAY NOT YOU MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH
THAT BUT THAT'S MY PERCEPTION MY
POSITION.
THAT'S OFTEN UP.
THANK YOU -- THAT -- MISTER
KALRA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT I REALLY
PERSON DIALOG.
PUSH THE DOWN ESPECIALLY AS OF
LATE SO THE CONVERSATION FROM
THE CHARTER EXPLICA THERE'S ROOM
FOR A LOT OF COMMON GROUND AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
OPTICALLY WITH THE AMENDMENT AND
THE CLARITY THERE I THINK THAT --
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT -- IS
A TAKE AWAY FROM ALL OF US IS
THAT -- NO ONE WANTS ANYONE
WHETHER IT'S A TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR A CHARTER
SCHOOL TO BEA POOR PERFORMER I
I THINK THAT WE WANT TO DO OUR
BEST UP THAT ALL CHILDREN ALL
SCHOOLS.
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WITH THE
THE CLARIFICATION -- THAT'LL BE
FORTHCOMING THAT THAT HELPS
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AT LEAST FROM THE SCHOOLSTHAT
ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING IN
OPERATING WELL -- AND IF THERE'S
FURTHER NEEDS FOR CONVERSATION
AMENDMENTS WHAT HAVE YOU THE
DIALOGUE CONTINUES IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING.
I'VE NEVER YEAH I WOULD I WON
THIS ONE OF MY THIRD YEAR I'VE
NEVER SEEN A BILL THAT'S
INTRODUCED THAT ISN'T AMENDED --
NUMEROUS TIMES AS IT MAKES ITS
WAY THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND SO -- IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET FEEDBACK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND APPRECIATED EVERYONE THAT
CAME ON BOTH SIDES TO PROVIDE
THAT BE BACK -- BECAUSE THAT
THAT IN ADDITION.
TO CLEARLY UP SOME OF THE THE
THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE GREATER
EXPERTISE -- CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE HELPS. NINE TIMES OUT
OF TEN TO MAKE IT BETTER BILL.
AND TO IMPROVE ON THE BILL AND
CREATE CLARITY WHERE IT'S
NECESSARY AS HAS BEEN SICK --
DEMONSTRATED BY THE CHAIR.
AND SO -- I ALSO -- SHE DOCTOR
WEBER'S COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE SUPPORT OF CONVERSATIONS.
THAT THE AND THAT'S AND THAT'S A
A TWO WAY STREET BOTH IN TERMS
OF COLLEAGUES DOING ONE OTHER
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS.
IS GONNA BE IT OF OF A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WERE AT
LEAST THERE'S UNDERSTANDING THAT --
THAT.
THE GOOD THE ULTIMATE GOALS AS
STATED BY DOCTOR WEBER NEED TO
BE SIMILAR OR THE SAME HOLE FOR
THE SAME OR SOMETIMES IT CAN BE
THE SAME ONLY SIMILAR.
IN THE SENSE OF ENSURING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AND
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THESE A PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
REQUIRED THE SAME KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAN ANYTHING
ELSE THAT IS FUNDED BY TAXPAYERS
REQUIRES.
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE IS A
COMMON GROUND THAT CAN BE HAD
HERE.
WE ALSO RARELY SEE BILLS THAT
HAVE A 100% UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ON
EVERY ITEM BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
THAT I KNOW THE CHAIR OF HIM
HAVING SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND SEEN HUNDREDS OF THE HOUSE
COMPASS ME THE CHAIR ALWAYS.
TRIES TO STRIVE FOR AN AND BEING
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A PRIMARY
AUTHORED THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO AND I AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE MAYES WAS A MENTION OF AND
I AND I TOLD I NEED TO BECAUSE I
WAS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY MENTION
REGARDS TO IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
ALUM ROCK AND JUST TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR I THINK THAT ANYONE
HAS PAID ATTENTION DOWN OCT
KNOWS THAT.
I CALLED FOR THE AUDIT OF THE
ALAMO SCHOOL DISTRICT I
SUPPORTED THE GRAND JURY
RECOMMENDATION TO THAT THREE OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS SHOULD RESIGN --
SINCE THEN TWO OF THE MEMBER OUR
PLACE TO DEMOCRATIC ELECTIONS --
THE SUPERINTENDENT WAS UNFAIRLY
TARGETED BY THE PREVIOUS BOARD
MAJORITY.
HAD BEEN -- TRYING HER BEST TO
WORK WITH THE STATE AND THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
AND SUBSEQUENTLY HAS SUPPORTED
ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
SUPPORTER IN THAT WORK.
AND WITH THE NEW BORDER MAJORITY
I HOPE -- EFFECTIVE FORMS BE PUT
IN PLACE BECAUSE I BOARD.
THE BOYS ACTUAL HARM PUT ALL
SCHOOLS CHARTER AND OTHERWISE
AND IF THERE'S SOME AGREEMENT
THAT WE HAVE -- I HOPE -- BUT
ANYONE THAT'S BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION ALUM ROCK THAT IT'S IN
A BETTER PLACE NOW IN TERMS OF
CHANGES IN THE LEADERSHIP.
IS A LOT AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO BE VOLATILE
BLACKED OUT THE NEED TO AT LEAST
MENTION THAT.
IS WAS VERY SPECIFICALLY
MENTIONED AND AND I THINK THAT
WITH THE I. I HOPE THERE'S
AGREEMENT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
SIDE YOU'RE ON ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
THAT OUR BROUGHT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO CHANGE AND MOVE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
HOPEFULLY ALL CAN WORK TO
CERTAINLY MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
SO.
WITH THAT -- I I I I WANT TO
EXPRESS GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE
THAT CAME TODAY EVERYONE ON BOTH
SIDES PROVIDING EXPERTISE.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT AGAIN THAT
EXPERTISE IS GOING TO BE NEEDED.
GOING FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOOD WORK OF MY COLLEAGUES I AND
AGAIN AS DR WEBER SAID AND I
AGREE A 100% -- WILL CERTAINLY
IS A PRINCE ACOSTA I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT THEIR INTENTIONS ARE
GOOD I WOULDN'T HAVE SIGNED ON
IF I DIDN'T BELIEVE THE
INTENTIONS WERE GOOD.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE GOOD IN
GOING FORWARD AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED -- DEBATE
AND AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND AS A DOES MOVE FORWARD IF
THERE ARE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
COME FORTH OUT FROM THE GOVERNOR
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTIONS.
AS INDICATED BY THE CHAIR --
THAT THAT CERTAINLY CAN BE
ACCOUNTED FOR GOING FORWARD AS
WELL -- SO WITH SO AGAIN THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE THAT CAME FOR
TODAY [inaudible]
UP.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND I'M SORRY I
JOIN AUTHOR I DID NOT LIKE YOU
TO RESPOND TO MR KYLIE'S
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO ADD TO THOSE.
PLEASE ADDED AN OTHERWISE YOU
MAY HANDLE THE CLOTHES THANK YOU
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED SUBSTANTIVELY AND ALSO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT TODAY.
I JUST WANNA MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED -- BRIEFLY OUT
ONE IS THERE'S BEEN REPEATED
REFERENCE TO THIS THIS BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
IT'S A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
WHO.
ARE WILL BE DIGGING DEEP INTO A
POLICY AREA THAT THAT NEEDS TO
DEEP DIVE THAT WE EAGERLY AWAIT.
THE REPORT FROM IN THERE AND
INPUT FROM -- AND THEY ARE ALSO
NOT THE LEGISLATURE [inaudible]
THAT.
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT WAS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR. TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS AGO.
IT'S OUR ROLE TO TO LOOK IF IT'S
AT THAT SET OF LAWS AND IDENTIFY
WHETHER WHICH ACHIEVING ITS
GOALS.
IF THERE'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF IT CAN BE
STRENGTHENED IMPROVED IF THIS
PLACE TO FIX IT MAKE IT BETTER
MAKE IT STRONGER MAKE IT BETTER
FOR KIDS PARENTS.
TEACHERS SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO
WHILE THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
HAS THE ESSENTIAL ROLE.
AND AND I I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
I APPLIED A SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ROLE -- WE WE WILL
AND WE'LL BE LISTENING TO IT AND
INCORPORATING -- ITS IDEAS --
THERE REALLY IS A ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HERE AND TERMS OF
BEING ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SENT HERE TO ADDRESS
BIG POLICY ISSUES LIKE LIKE THIS
ONE SO -- I I I I I M. I KNOW
IT'LL ADD VALUE TO LOOK FOR TO
IT I JUST WANT TO SORT OF TRY
OUT AND HE'S OUT THAT
DISTINCTION A LITTLE BIT.
ALSO WANT TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
YOU KNOW.
MUCH OF THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROVIDING.
MORE LOCAL CONTROL IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE TALK ABOUT SO
MANY TIMES IN THIS BUILDING --
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE FOLKS
TOUT THE IDEA OF LOCAL CONTROL
THAT THOSE NEAREST TO THE
PROBLEM OUR BEST LOCATED TO
PROVIDE THE SOLUTIONS.
AND AFTER THIS BILL DOES AND IN
POWERS OUR OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD LEADERS WHO ARE.
ELECTED TO STAND UP FOR KIDS AND
PROVIDE -- RACIAL EQUITY AN
OPPORTUNITY AND TO STAND UP FOR
TEACHERS AND PARENTS TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEST FOR THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND THE CONSIDER DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT ARE RELEVANT.
AND NOT TO BE WILLFULLY BLINDED
TO CERTAIN FACTS THAT COULD BE
RELEVANT TO AN ANALYSIS NOT TO
BE WILLFULLY BLIND AT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OR TWO IMPACT
ON FACILITIES BUT TO CONSIDER
THEM -- MANY OF THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS WILL UP LEFT THE IDEA OF
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AS THE TOP
ISSUE WILL UP LEFT THE IDEA OF
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AS THEIR TOP
ISSUE.
THAT'S THEIR RIGHT -- BUT THEY
SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO AT LEAST
CONSIDER.
OTHER FACTORS LIKE FINANCIAL
IMPACT -- IMPACT ON FACILITIES
THAT TO THIS BILL -- ASKS SO AND
I I WANT TO JUST -- UPLIFT AS A
MEMBER SERVICE MATHS.
CONCEPT I I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS A LOT AS I'VE GIVEN A LOT
OF THOUGHT TO OUR CURRENT
CHARTER SCHOOL LAW ON THE IDEA
OF OF OF WHAT THE INNOVATIONS
AND GOAL THIS. TO ME THE END
GOAL IS IS.
TO RECAPTURE.
EFFECTIVE IMPACTFUL INNOVATION
APPROACHES SO THAT MORE STUDENTS
CAN BENEFIT FROM AND TO SCALE.
AND IF SOMEONE HAS UNLOCKED -- A
PROCESS FOR HOW -- TO THEN THE
NEEDLE OR ARE THAT.
BEND THE CURVE.
FOR BLACK AND BROWN KIDS AND
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
WHY SHOULD THAT BE LIMITED TO
ONE CORNER OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN ONE SCHOOL? FOR
COUPLES WHY CAN'T IT BE SOME OF
THAT COULD BENEFIT ALL -- BLACK
AND BROWN STUDENTS IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND BEYOND -- SO I JUST
ASK THAT QUESTION NOT TO
ATTRIBUTE ANY -- BLAME BUT JUST
TO SAY THAT THE KIND OF THING I
THINK WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT GETTING BACK TO BASICS ON
AND I ALSO JUST WANT A DOCTOR
WEBER FOR ALWAYS LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING. THREE JUSTICE LANDS
FOR AN EQUITY THROUGH AN EQUITY
LANDS -- WE MUST AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SHOULD THIS BILL GET OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE -- KEEP THE S.
S. DO NINETY MINUT OUTCOMES FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS -- FOREMOST
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE OF
OUR CHILDREN CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THE FULL
POTENTIAL REALIZE THEIR DREAMS --
WITHOUT RESPECT ASK THE I'VE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMEDMENTS
TO BE TAKING AND APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY NO KILEY
KNOWN KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
FOR BILL HAS FOR VOTED IS OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. THIRTY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTY AB FIFTEEN OH SIX AB
.
FIFTEEN OH SIX OKAY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
WHICH IS AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MISS MCCARTY'S
GOING TO PRESENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'D FIRST LIKE -- TO THANK YOU
AND THAT COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE PROPOSAL
AND WILL BE ACCEPTING THE THAT
COMMITTEE.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
ESSENTIALLY THIS MEASURE.
I THINK IT IS JUST AS PROBABLY
HEATED FROM THE POLITICS AS A
PRIOR MEASURE BUT I THINK A BIT
MORE SIMPLE.
IN ITS NOT THAT YOU'RE MEASURE
WAS NOT AN IMPORTANT ONE USED TO
SHARE BUT WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
IS A BIT MORE OF A SIMPLE --
EQUATION I THINK PEOPLE WITH
WOULD UNDERSTAND.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ESTABLISH A
CAP ON THE NUMBER OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS OPERATING AT BOTH THE
STATEWIDE.
AND LOCAL LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
OF COURSE THE LAN THE LANDS
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AS MR BONTA
ALLUDED.
TO THEY WERE CREATED TO BE --
LABORATORIES OF LEARNING AND
HAVE SERVED A VITAL ROLE.
HOWEVER THIS CHARTER SCHOOL
GROWTH HAS PLAYED A ROLE.
NOT THE ROLE A ROLE IN THE
FINANCIAL INSTABILITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CHARTER SCHOOL GROWTH HAS
REMAINED STEADY IN THE STATE
OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS.
LEADING TO MORE AND MORE AND
STABILITY WE ALL KNOW THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FUNDED
BASED UPON ATA AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE.
AT IS DECLINING STATEWIDE.
THAT MEANS FEWER FUNDING AND
FEWER THAT MEANS LESS FUNDING
AND FEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF
COURSE ETA'S DECLINE BECAUSE OF
THE POPULATION OUR STATE.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE GROWTH
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
COMPETITION FOR THESE SCARCE
EIGHTY EIGHT DOLLARS BETWEEN
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOL.
BREED STRESS AND TENSION THAT'S
LEADING TO A SCHOOLS WEARING IS.
TO OPEN ADDITIONAL CHARTERS OF
COURSE.
MANY TITLE ONE SCHOOLS FACE
GREAT CHALLENGES WITH EDUCATING
OUR LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
A SPREADING FINITE RESOURCES
AMONG BOTH CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS EQUITY IN
SKIN A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
EVEN IF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT DID
NOT APPROVE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL.
ESSENTIAL WE HAVE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
IS WERE FUNDING TO SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
LIKE A FAMILY.
WITH THAT.
WITH THAT THE I. CAPPED INCOME.
FUNDING TO HOUSEHOLDS.
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE.
THIS BILL WILL GRANT SCHOOL
DISTRICT WITH SOME FINANCIAL
RELIEF BY CURBING CHARTER SCHOOL
SCHOOL GROWTH.
IT'S NOT A BAND IT'S NOT A
MORATORIUM HAVE SOME VAST I
THINK THIS IS A FAIR SOLUTION.
IT WON'T CLOSE SCHOOLS AGAIN
THIS WILL NOT CLOSE SCHOOLS.
DESPITE WHICH MANY -- THINK WITH
THE OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL WOULD INSTITUTE A
ROLLING CAP.
MEANING THAT WHEN A CHARTER
SCHOOL CLOSES.
ANOTHER CHARTER SCHOOL MAY TAKE
THAT SLOT
AND WE'RE AND WE'RE WE'RE
ADJUSTING AND AMENDING THE
PROPOSAL NOT ON THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS BUT UPON THE
ATA.
SO IN OTHER WORDS KIND OF THINK
ABOUT CAP AND TRADE HERE.
SO IF A FAILING SCHOOL NOT A
GOOD ANALYSIS CAP AND TRADE NOT
A POPULAR PROGRAM.
BUT THE MATHEMATICAL PART ABOUT
CAP AND TRADE.
IS SOMETHING WE WE WE CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND.
SO IF ONE OF THAT.
POOR PERFORMING CHARTER SCHOOL
CLOSES AND WE HAVE A THRIVING
CHARTER SCHOOL LIKE WE HEARD
FROM EARLIER TODAY DRIVING
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THEY CAN OPEN THIS PLACE.
A ROLLING CAT.
AGAIN THIS RECOGNIZES THAT THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE ON THE DISTRICT'S.
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM AND FINANCES.
AT THAT TWO THINGS ABOUT THEIR
FINANCES YOU KNOW WE HAVE
DISTRICTS IN FINANCIAL STRESS.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT LOS ANGELES
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT OAKLAND.
RIGHT HERE IN MY HOMETOWN OF
SACRAMENTO OUR DISTRICT IS
LITERALLY ON THE BRINK.
MAY RUN OUT OF CASH IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
IS IT BECAUSE OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
PROBABLY NOT PROBABLY WASN'T THE
ISSUE IS IT A FACTOR IT'S GOING
ON AS FAR AS THEIR THEIR
ATTENDANCE.
POTENTIALLY THERE ARE CHARTER
SCHOOL POPULATION TO ABOUT 12%.
ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS HOWEVER.
IF THAT GREW BY 10% NEXT YEAR TO
THE THEIR FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY AND THE
YEAR AFTER THAT -- THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT GROWTH WOULD PUT
THIS DISTRICT ON THE BRINK.
AND THAT'S WERE FACING UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT'S THE ISSUE WE'RE
LOOKING TO ADDRESS I ALSO WANT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
REPORT COMING BY OUR GOVERNOR.
AND OUR SUPERINTENDENT.
OUR COLLEAGUE MR BONTA SAID IT
WELL THAT'S THE THOSE ARE TWO
STATEWIDE ELECTED OFFICIALS WERE
THE LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
THIS AS WELL.
BUT SHOULD THIS REPORT COME OUT
WITH SOME GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS --
REST ASSURED THAT THIS BILL WILL
NOT BECOME LAW.
WHEN THAT REPORT COMES OUT WE'LL
BE GOING AT IT AS WE KNOW UNTIL
THE END OF SUMMER END OF AUGUST
EARLY SEPTEMBER?
THE REPORT THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
THE S. P. ARE WORKING ON WILL BE
OUT WITHIN A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AND ALLOW US TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND POTENTIALLY --
BRIDGE THAT MEANT THE PROPOSAL
WE HAVE HERE -- SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MIKE MY
TWO WITNESSES -- CLEAR CRAWFORD
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST WITH IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST MISTER
JEFFREY BEAR SUPERINTENDENT OF A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT THE LOS
ALTOS SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE BAY
AREA.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M CLEAR PRO FOR THE SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER IS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE FINDINGS
FROM TWO OF OUR REPORTS THAT
DOCUMENT SOME OF THE FISCAL AND
RESULTING.
EDUCATIONAL IMPACT OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNRESTRICTED
CHARTER SECTOR GROWTH ON
DISTRICT PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I'M AB FIFTEEN OH SIX ALONG WITH
A COMING BILLS BEFORE YOU TODAY
WILL GO ALONG WAY IN ADDRESSING
THESE IMPACTS.
ARE TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT
SPENDING BLIND EXAMINED
CALIFORNIA'S ON TARGETED IN
HAPHAZARD SYSTEM FOR FACILITIES
FINANCING OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE FOUND THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAD RECEIVED
MORE THAN TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
TAXPAYERS SUBSIDIZE FUNDS TO
LEASE BUILDER BY SCHOOL
BUILDINGS.
MUCH OF THIS FUNDING WENT TO
SCHOOL THAT OPENED WHERE THERE
ARE ALREADY ENOUGH CLASSROOM
SPACES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AND TO SCHOOL THAT DID NOT
PROVIDE A BETTER ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES THE NEARBY TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
DEMOGRAPHICALLY SIMILAR STUDENTS.
WE FOUND THE PUBLIC FACILITIES
FUNDING HAD BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY CONCENTRATED
AMONG THE LESS THAN ONE THIRD OF
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OWNED AND
OPERATED BY CHARTER MANAGEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
OPERATING CHAINS OF BETWEEN
THREE AND THIRTY SCHOOLS.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF PUBLIC
TAX DOLLARS HAD ALSO BEEN USED
BY CMO IS TO BUY PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
OUR SECOND REPORT RELEASED IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DOCUMENTS -- THE
IMPACT ON LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SO WHEN A STUDENT LEAVE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL FOR CHARTER
SCHOOL ALL THE FUNDING FOR THAT
STUDENT LEAVES WITH THEM HOWEVER
NOT ALL THE COSTS.
TO OUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT
BREAKING POINT DOCUMENTED THESE
NOT COSTS OF CALIFORNIA'S AND
RESTRAINED CHARTER GROWTH WHICH
LEADS TO CUTTING CORE SERVICES
LIKE COUNSELING IN LIBRARIES AND
NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
USING OUR MOST CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATES WE FOUND THAT OAKLAND
UNIFIED LOST FIFTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION PER YEAR.
THAT'S ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
LESS PER STUDENT ATTENDING A
NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOL THE ANNUAL
COST OF SAN DIEGO UNIFIED WAS
SIXTY FIVE POINT NINE MILLION.
AND HE SAID UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THE NET IMPACT OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS WAS NINETEEN POINT THREE
MILLION PER YEAR.
AB FIFTY NO SIX WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT STRONG EXISTING CHARTER
SCHOOLS COULD FLOURISH WITHOUT
FURTHER HARMING THE EDUCATION OF
THE 90% OF STUDENTS THAT ATTEND
DISTRICT MANAGED SCHOOLS.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JEFFREY
BEAR I'M SUPERINTENDENT LOS
ALTOS SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY NO
SEX YET WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
MODIFICATION.
I SUPPORT A AP ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS YET A LIMITATION ON
CHARTER SCHOOL ENROLLMENT ALONE
IS OUR ON ENROLLMENT IS ALSO
ESSENTIAL TO MITIGATE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE.
ARE ALREADY OPERATING IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ROMAN RESTRICTIONS
SUCH AS AN AGGREGATE TOTAL
PERCENTAGE CAP ON STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
WITHIN THE DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE IMPRECISE
MEANS OF ADDRESSING THAT HAS
GONE DEMOGRAPHIC IMPACTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS CREATE.
A PERCENTAGE ENROLLMENT CAP IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE DISTRICT OF
CHOICE LEGISLATION ALREADY IN
PLACE.
WHICH SAFEGUARD TO LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FISCAL HEALTH BY
CAPPING THE NUMBER OF OUTBOUND
STUDENT TRANSFERS.
STUDIES SHOW THE CHARTER SCHOOL
GROWTH DRAINS MONEY AWAY FROM
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND THOSE STUDENTS BEAR THE COST
OF ON CHECK CARD CHARTER
EXPANSION UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN
DISTRICTS LOSE ENROLLMENT TO
CHARTERS THE ONLY RECOURSE IS TO
LAY OFF STAFF AN INCREASE CLASS
SIZE WHAT'S WORSE.
MANY CHARTERS LEAVE BEHIND THE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS TO COST
THE MOST EDUCATE.
SIMPLY PUT AS A OPERATE TODAY
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE INCREASINGLY
INEQUALITY IN EDUCATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION RELEASED DATA.
JUST THIS PAST MARCH.
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE A SMALLER
PERCENTAGE OF DISADVANTAGED SUB
GROUPS SUCH AS ENGLISH LEARNERS
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESS MIGRANT
STUDENTS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS.
WHAT?
WELL IT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN THE
ORIGINAL INTENSE.
WE CREATED A TWO TIERED
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHERE MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE ALLOWED TO
SERVE THE NARROW INTERESTS OF A
SELECTED GROUP OF STUDENTS TO
THE DETRIMENT OF DISTRICT
STUDENTS WHETHER HIGH OR LOW
ACHIEVING WHICH ARE LEFT WITH
FEWER RESOURCES.
THE UNREGULATED ABILITY OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO ENROLL
UNLIMITED STUDENTS WITHOUT ANY
CONSIDERATION TO THE IMPACTS
UPON THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
UNDERMINES OUR COMMITMENT TO A
PUBLIC EDUCATION THE DENTURES WE
MEET THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL
STUDENTS.
PLEASE ENACTED BE FIFTEEN NO SEX.
PLEASE ALSO STRONGLY CONSIDER AN
AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE ENROLLMENT
LIMITATIONS TO PROTECT
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND FISCAL
HEALTH OF ALL STUDENTS -- OTHERS
IN SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR SEVEN
RAMBLE HERE ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WEREN'T
SUPPORT I'M HERE.
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE OPPOSITION.
OR OTHERS IF YOU'RE.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO
WALK UP TO THE MIKE IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU WANNA DO OF THAT THAT'S
WHAT THAT MEANS.
I ALMOST GOT AWAY WITH IT SORRY
SORRY CHAIR.
WITH DEMOCRACY TAKES TIME.
SO -- AND PATIENCE -- BUT I
CAN'T SEE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
A POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR JEFF RADIUS
PRESIDENT ELECT OF CFT A UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SANDERS MORRIS I'M A
SECOND GRADE CLASSROOM TEACHER
IN RALEIGH AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M JILL YES A TALKIE I'M A
TEACHER AND I REPRESENT ABC
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MY RIGHT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M SURE HE'D A MAGENTA
AND I'M A CHEMISTRY TEACHER.
AT SALINAS HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SALINAS UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I SUPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M DENNIS **** I'M WITH THE
CITY OF THI AND THE A. B. C.
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS RETIREE
CHAPTER.
THE IBM A STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
I'M CARL WILLIAMS PRESIDENT OF
THE LAWNDALE FEDERATION OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES I'M A THING
SENIOR CUSTODIAN AT AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE
BASSLER I AM A HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER IN SALINAS.
I AM A MEMBER SALINAS VALLEY
FEDERATION OF TEACHER.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEVE MCDOUGAL A
PRESIDENT OF THE SLEAZE BY FIRST
OF TEACHERS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW SOME OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT.
KEVIN CHARMER ON BEHALF THE
COMPTON UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DANA DODGE CITY OF WATSONVILLE
ON FOR THE GRILL COLLEGE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I'M
STRONG -- EXTENDED SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THE HEART OF YELLOW ALSO.
COULD BE A CALL TO FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS I HAVE SUPPORT THIS
BILL WILL BE AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL.
MICHAEL SEND.
CFT -- CAREER COLLEGE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI AM I A TEACHER AND HE LOOKS
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL A
COMPREHENSIVE.
HIGH SCHOOL THAT'S A CONVERSION
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DILLER STRAND FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GO UPSTAIRS NOW.
CASEY CARLSON'S SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER SANTA CRUZ IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ WITH THE
BOTTLE VALLEY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND THE PARENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DAVID -- SAW CLASSIFIED STAFF
WITHOUT CAMINO COLLEGE DISTRICT
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CONNIE MARTIN PRESIDENT OF CLOSE
FEDERATION OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES OF ORANGE COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DEIRDRE ELEMENTS SUMI PARENT AND
LIBRARIAN IN SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WEKISS SMITH ACCOUNTING
TECHNICIAN EL CAMINO CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND SECRETARY LOOK FOR
SEA OF TEA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CAROLINE SMALLER VICE PRESIDENT
FOR PERRY EDUCATORS FOR SAN
FRANCISCO AND ESPECIALLY BAY
AREA DECATUR AND ALSO
GRANDMOTHER I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JAMIE CROWDER BECAUSE FEDERATION
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES HUNTINGTON
BEACH I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WE GO TO MY OWN PRESIDENT OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD T. K. TWELVE
COUNSEL FOR CFT AND I RISE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NANCY JACKSON MEMBER THE POTTO
VALLEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS --
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RIGHT A COOKER MAN MEMBER OF THE
BAR -- VALLEY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS TEACHER IN WATSONVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- SEVEN CUBIC A PARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN WEST CONTRA COSTA
UNIFIED AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OR IS TO CURRENT MEMBER OF THE
POP HER ABOUT A FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
SPECIAL ED TEACHER IN THE AIR OF
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY IN THE
WATSON BILL THE APOCRYPHA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND HOME
SCHOOLING PARENT.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M STEPHANIE POETS CAM
ESPECIALLY TEACHER IN ABC I
REMEMBER OF AB CFT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ELENA ISLAND I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
MATH TEACHER IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LAWLER CARRY ON A HISTORY
TEACHER IN PICO RIVERA PRESIDENT
A BRANCH OF FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND A BELLY BY YES POLITICAL
DIRECTOR WITH UNITED EDUCATORS
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND A PARENT AT
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LARA SORROW FROM THE UPON HER --
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT PDF T..
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I I THINK YOU LEGISLATURE
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION.
TANYA GOLDEN TEACHER
REPRESENTING ABC FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
HELLO HE MENACE WITH HOUSE ON
FEDERATION OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
YOU CAN'T THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD
TEACHER WITH ABC UST AND I STAND
SUPPORT.
MELINDA DART PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER RETIRED JEFFERSON
ELEMENTARY DISTRICT AND
FEDERATION.
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT.
DAVID HI IN HIGH SCHOOL ENGLISH
TEACHER AND BUILDING UP WITH A.
B. C. F. T. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RACHEL SMITH FOURTH GRADE
TEACHER AT ABC UNIFIED AND
MEMBER OF ABC FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CATHERINE HAS QUAL HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER ABC FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHERI LEWIS I'M RETIRED FORTUNE
ONE HUNDRED I HOME SCHOOL CHILD
HER CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE SUPPORT IS NOW COMPLETE NOW
WILL GO TO THE OPPOSITION THE
OPPOSITE IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL COME FORWARD
.
YOU MAY PROCEED [inaudible]
THE FIRST.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARGARET
FORTUNE ON THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
FORTUNE SCHOOL AND THE CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION.
AND I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL -- MY CONCERN IS THAT
A CAP ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
REPRESENTS A CAP ON
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS -- IN
THE CASE OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT I RUN THE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION MADE A
FINDING OF FACT BASED.
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT THERE
IS A SEVERE AND PERSISTENT
AFRICAN AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT GAP
IN ALL OF THE TH THE COUNTIES
THIRTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SUCH A THERE IS NO PLACE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILY COULD GO
AND NOT CONFRONT THIS GAP.
AND SO THEY CHIU CHOSE TO
EXERCISE THEIR AUTHORITY. TO
APPROVE OUR NETWORK OF SCHOOLS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CLOSING THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT GAP
IN OF COURSE WERE OPEN TO ALL
STUDENTS.
WE ARE THE ONLY CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT THAT THE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION APPROVES SO IN THE
CASE OF THE APPLICATION OF THIS
BILL.
WHAT IT WOULD MEAN IS THAT IN
ORDER FOR A NEW?
CHARTER SCHOOL FROM FORTUNE
SCHOOL TO BE OPEN AN EXISTING
CHARTER SCHOOL AND AND FORTUNE
SCHOOL WOULD HAVE TO BE CLOSED --
IT WOULD CANNIBALIZE OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
THIS IS A TIGHT RESTRICTION ON
THE PROGRESS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT.
THERE ARE STUDENTS.
AND YOU SAW MANY OF THEIR
PARENTS TODAY.
AND THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
THAT ARE DESPERATELY SEEKING
ANOTHER OPTION WITHIN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM -- THAT -- THAT
DESIRE IS REAL -- YOU CAN'T FAKE
THAT.
AND IN THE CASE OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY IT'S VERY WILL
ESTABLISH THE BLACK STUDENTS ARE
THE LOWEST PERFORMING SUBGROUP
OTHER OUTSIDE OF STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
THE DISTRICT THAT MR MCCARTY
MAKES REFERENCE TO SACK CITY
ONLY 13% OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS MEET STEP MET STANDARDS
ON THE LAST STATE ASSESSMENT OF
MATHEMATICS.
A CAP ON SCHOOLS.
BETTER DESIGNED TO CLOSE THOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
ARE IS A REAL INJUSTICE TO THE
FAMILIES THAT NEED OPPORTUNITIES.
THE OTHER PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL.
IS THAT IT SUGGESTS THAT NGUYEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A NEW
SCHOOL I WOULD WOULD BE CREATED
THAT.
AN EXPERIENCED OPERATOR COULDN'T
DO THAT WORK -- AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS -- WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARLOS ARE CARED
CABS HERE REPRESENTING THAT
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. TO AB --
FIFTEEN OH SIX AS MISFORTUNE
HIGHLIGHTED BRIEFLY A. B.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MAKES AN
ARBITRARY JUDGMENT THAT SOMEHOW
NEW SINGLE SITE CHARTERS ARE
BETTER PREPARED TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS.
OVER OPERATORS WITH A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF SUCCESS
OPERATING EXISTING SCHOOLS.
THIS POLICY RUNS COUNTER TO
STRONG EVIDENCE BY THE CENTER
FOR RESEARCH ON EDUCATED ON
EDUCATION OUTCOMES AT STANFORD.
THAT IN CALIFORNI IN BOTH THE
READING AND MATH STUDENTS IN CMO
TO HAVE LARGER LEARNING GAINES
PER YEAR.
THEN THERE DISTRICT COUNTERPARTS
AND THEN THERE INDEPENDENT
SINGLE SITE CHARTER SCHOOL PEERS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS EQUIVALENT TO
A STUDENT ATTENDING SEVENTEEN
ADDITIONAL DAYS OF SCHOOL PER
LEARNING IN BOTH SUBJECTS.
SO THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF
ATTENDING A CMO IS EVEN LARGER
FOR BLACK IN LATIN NEXT STUDENTS
AND THE GAINES EVEN GREATER
AMONG BLACK IN LATIN NEXT
STUDENTS IN POVERTY.
AND THESE ARE THE SAME STUDENTS
OF GROUPS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE WIDEST LEARNING GAPS IN
DISTRICT SCHOOLS.
AS STANFORD RESEARCH FINDS AND
SO FURTHER WE NEW SCHOOLS ARE
REPLICATED BY SEE A MOST.
CREDO FOUND THAT THOSE SCHOOLS
PRODUCE LEARNING RESULTS IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR THAT ARE MORE
POSITIVE THAN THEIR DISTRICT
PEERS SO THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS
THAT SEE A MOST IN CALIFORNIA.
I UNDERSTAND THIS HOW TO SCALE
AND REPLICATE HIGH QUALITY
OUTCOMES FOR OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS.
SO WHY WOULD WE DISADVANTAGED
THESE TYPES OF CHARTERS FROM
OPENING NEW SCHOOLS.
THE OTHER POINT I WANT TO RAISE
TO RESPOND THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS ON A. B. FIFTEEN OH SIX
IS THE DEEPLY FLAWED MISLEADING
RESEARCH BY IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
I PROVIDED WRITTEN TESTIMONY IN
FULL BY ROBIN LAKE THE DIRECTOR
OF CENTER ON REINVENTING PUBLIC
EDUCATION TO ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BUT JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
OBSERVATIONS LAVERS ANALYSIS
FAILS TO FOLLOW EVEN THE MOST
BASIC REQUIREMENTS -- AROUND --
PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH AND WE
WOULD JUST -- RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
OBJECTED PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
IN ITS ANALYSIS MOVING FORWARD
WE URGE YOUR KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION -- IT'S TIMELINE
OF THE MICROPHONE.
AGAIN YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
SIMEON GANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CAPITOL HEIGHTS ACADEMY AND MY
GRANDSON WHO GOES TO SCHOOL
THERE.
AND FORTUNE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
LARA FERAL TEACHER OF
EXCEPTIONAL LEARNERS AND UNION
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CAMINO TO
WAVE -- TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
THE MACARTHUR PARK NEIGHBORHOOD
OF LOS ANGELES I OPPOSE THIS
MOTION THIS BILL.
JOANNE A WHOLE LOT VICE CHAIR OF
SECULAR COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND PARENTS OF
TRADITIONAL AND CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN ST ONE UNIFIED AND
ACCOUNTABILITY CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I'M DON PLAN FROM CORE CHARTER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M ROBIN PASCOE.
AND I HAVE TO STUDENTS AND A
GRADUATE FROM MARYSVILLE CORE
CHARTER.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL I AM A FORMER
TEACHER AND CLASSIFIED STAFF.
ANY RAMIREZ I'M FROM CAMINO
CHARTER CAN I MEAN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S BEEN PASCHIM A STUDENT
AT COURT CHARTER IN MARYSVILLE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHN NORTON A SUPPORTER FULLER
CHARTER SCHOOL OF GO AHEAD.
AND HAS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M MORE PASCH A STUDENT
FROM FOR CHARTER SCHOOL
MARYSVILLE NICE STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALSO THERE MIGHT DENNIS A
STUDENT ALUMNI PARENTS AND A
CURRENT EMPLOYEE OF CAMINO NOBLE
CHARTER ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ERICA GONZALEZ FROM CAMINO NUEVO
CHARTER ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
TAMMY STANTON PARENT AT OCEAN
CHARTER SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES
AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
CAMINO NO WAY BUT CHARTER
ACADEMY A CMO OPERATING IN LOS
ANGELES.
I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHNSON NINETY AND I AM THE
STUDENT AND FAMILY SERVICES
SYSTEM LIKE I MEAN I KNOW WHAT
CHARTER ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JOINT SPENCER CAMPBELL SAN
BERNADINO CALIFORNIA CONCERN
AFRICAN AMERICAN PARENTS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LET THE GOMEZ ROCKET SHIP FOR
TOP PAIR FOUNDING PARENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TROY BUYER LEADS LIKE LEAD
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FROM LITERACY
FIRST CHARTER SCHOOL IN SAN
DIEGO.
AND WE STAND IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
OUR GOVERNMENT DOUBLES I'M UPPER --
VERY PROUD.
BUT A LEADER OF A ROCKET YOU FOR
SARAH AND KEEP HIGH.
IMAMS STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
DR VALERIE A BAD FIFTY YEARS IN
EDUCATION -- CONSERVATORY OF
VOCAL AND INSTRUMENTAL ARTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
THIS [inaudible]
POSITION.
HELLO MY NAME'S CELEBRATE
CYNTHIA AND I'M A STUDENT AT
ALPHA PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
CHARTER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MEYER WITH KIDDIES PREVIOUS
DISTRICT LEADER WITH OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT CEO
SUPERINTENDED OF AMERICAN INDIAN
MODEL SCHOOLS THE ONLY SCHOOL IN
OUR AREA THAT WAS RECOGNIZED FOR
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS.
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU IN THE
NAME OF STUDENTS THAT NEED A
CHANCE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL AND I'M
HERE FROM I MEAN I'M FROM MY
OFFICE IN THE RETAIL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BONNIE MILLIGAN A PARENT OF A
GRADUATE OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
AND A GRADUATE OF A PUBLIC
SCHOOL REGULAR PUBLIC SCHOOL I
OPPOSE THE BILL.
HI MY NAME'S ABOUT ALI AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I ADDED YOU
TO DO PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS RANDY MILLION I'M
A PARENT OF A STUDENT AT COR AT
MARYSVILLE.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JAMIE ROBINSON I'M
A PARENT AND A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AT LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AARON AND I'M A
STUDENT OF COURSE CHARTER SCHOOL
THEN I DEEPLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE BUYER I AM
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOLS K..
TWELVE ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR STAFF AND OUR BOARD I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE SHARP I'M
A PARENT FOR EACH COURT CHARTER
SCHOOL IN A DEEPLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
LISA WILLIAMS I'M A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR WITH LITERACY
FIRST CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN
DIEGO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ROB GIVES FROM --
CORE CHARTER A PERSONALIZED
LEARNING TEACHER FROM A
PERSONALIZED LEARNING -- CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I DEEPLY POLLICIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHAIR PRESENT
NUMBER FOUR SQUARE FROM ROCKET
SHIP FOR SOME.
AND I PULLS ME.
POST THIS BILL.
HI ELIZABETH SHORT INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY LEAD AT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL OF SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI AM DEARLY TAKE COUNT AND MY
SON IS AND WRECKAGE OF FORT
SATIN HE LOVE HIS SCHOOL SO MUCH
SHE WOULD CRY IF I TOLD ME
CANNOT GO TO SCHOOL.
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I MEAN NUMBER AS WELL OPEN AND
ALSO TO STAY SO BOTHER THERE
MIGHT THAT ROCKET SHIP
NEGOTIATING.
YES THEY ENCUENTRA THIS THE THE
LACKEY IN SAYS IT'LL SAVE.
OUR BINGO FOR YET IS IN SALINAS
CA YES ON YOUR AND HONEST WHEN A
CHARTERED A YEAH.
THAT'S JUST.
HELLO MY NAME IS SOPHIA CACKLE
I'M A STUDENT FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I HIGHLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VERONICA BALDWIN AND
THE SCHOOL COORDINATOR FOR OUR
DAILY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SIT ON THE CUT CONVENIENT TIME
HOME SCHOOL PARENTS ROOM
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL -- SAYS
SERGEANTS SIMON STUDENT -- AWFUL
CHARTER SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
JAMES CHALCO FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
MARTY ACT UP BEYOND I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL WITH --
REPRESENTING ROCKET SHIP AND OUT
OF CHINA SCHOOLS.
DURING THE GENERAL JOHN ADAMS
ACADEMY THAT POSES BILL.
GOOD DEAL.
ROCKCHIP MOSAIC AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GREG WESTER GRAHAM WAY SCHOOLS
IN KERN COUNTY SERVING THE ROLE
COMMUNITIES OF THE COUNTY AND
OUR BOARD OPPOSED -- POSES THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TELLING **** AND I
AM FROM GLACIER HIGH SCHOOL
CHARTER AND I STRONGLY TO STAY
IN THIS BILL.
JOY ANNA KENDRICK SCHOOL LEADER
FOR GRIMLY ACADEMY SHAFTER AND
SHAFTER CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
MY PARENTS.
AND MY FACULTY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHAEL **** EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF WESTERN ZERO CHARTER SCHOOLS
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CALL SAMPSON
PRINCIPAL AND PARENT OF A
STUDENT A GRIMLY ACADEMY IN
RURAL AREAS ARE IN CALIFORNIA
OUTSIDE INTO THE KERN COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI JODY JEFFERS I BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM OF CHOICE THEREFORE
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SIMPSON I AM
A HOME SCHOOLING PARENT AT OUR
HYBRID SCHOOL COR CHARTER.
AND I'D STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THE NUMBER IS MAKE VALIUM ITS
WAY BUT IT THE LESS WELL I I'M
FORCING THE MEDIA.
AND MOVE ON WELL I I REALLY.
KEEN SAYS FEDERAL STATE.
BRENDAN TO EGG ON BEHALF OF
ADVICE IN OPPOSITION.
THE BUT I SIERRA FROM ALPHA
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN JOSE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TERRY NAY BEER MADERA CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS ON OUR WAITLIST WE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HALEY BEAUPRE SCHOOL COORDINATOR
OF GROSS ONE SECONDARY SCHOOL IN
SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GILLIAN AND TOWN -- ON BEHALF OF
ROCK AND ACADEMY TURNSTONE ROCK
ON ACADEMY MYERS ROCK ON ACADEMY
GATEWAY AND QUESTIONS HERE
COLLEGIATE ACADEMY.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JACKIE ROBINSON CHIEF OF STAFF
ALL TO SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
WE OPPOSE THE SPELL.
PETER SAVILLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FORCED HER SCHOOL ON BEHALF OF
OUR SCHOOL WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RACHEL THOMAS CURRICULUM IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
COORDINATOR AND THE PARENT OF
TWO FORMER CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AT ALTERS THE CHARTER SCHOOL SAN
DIEGO AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE MURPHY WITH THREE SIX
SIX SELLER IT EDUCATION PARTNERS
OUT OF FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER MAY COME
RAN A TEACHER WITH THE OUR DAILY
CHARTER SCHOOL TO WIN SAN DIEGO
AND WE OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN NO
SEX.
MY NAME IS STACY PELTS FROM A
PARENT COR CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANNA MARIA ROW HAS TEACHER THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS SAN DIEGO AND I
ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JACK THAT CODE DEREK GRADUATE OF
SPRING CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ME NUMBERS MY EQUITY HAVING LESS
AND LESS AS A MOTHER IF I MAY
HAVE THEM LOOK AT YOU PLUS WHEN
YOU'LL SEE I'LL PARKING SEVEN ON
THIS USING THE IDEA.
THE MAINTHING OF HIM YES AND
COOK ON CULTURE LET THEM IN.
YOU SEE ON THE KNOWN AS WELL
CHARTER SCHOOL YES YES.
JUDY THEIR ADMINISTRATOR FOR
SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE NUMBER IS COUNTY THE ONLINE
YOU'LL BRING ALL THE SAMPLES
THAT CALIFORNIA AND SAY MY
MOTHER THOSE NEURONS THEIR ROCK
ISSUE BE I'M FAR BLANCA.
GRASS YES.
HI I'M DANNY SHAPIRO FROM A
SPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS ON BEHALF
OF OUR THIRTY SIX SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LINDA HARD AND THE
GRANDMOTHER OF THE DAUGHTER WHO
ATTEND SCHOOL OF FORTUNE AND I
HOLES THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TO KIA HUMANS LOPEZ
HAVE A FUNDING GOES TO FORTY
SCHOOL IN THOMAS.
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HOW DOES A LADY OF IT UP ARE IN
ALL OUR?
BROKERS SHE HAD A PHONE CALL I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MICHELLE CODA CORE CHARTER I
ADAM CAKE WHEN A PARENT OF A
STUDENT WAS ON A SIX YEAR
CHARTER WEIGHTLESS MY POSSIBLE.
CHRIS DEVELOP RAIN WITH A ROCKET
SHIP PUBLIC SCHOOLS NETWORK WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ERICA MY BELLY AND ALL BARN OF A
STUDENT AT ROCA CHEERFUL TO
ROUTE AND I ARE BOTH OF THESE BE.
ERIC HAGEN ADMINISTRATOR OF
MOUNTAIN HOME SCHOOL OR TWENTY
FIFTH HERE AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
FAMILIES ON OUR WAITLIST.
NANCY GARCIA ADMINISTRATOR
WESTERN ZERO TURN SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MINDY CLANG ADMINISTRATOR
WESTERN TEAR CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JEFF RICE REPRESENTING THE A
PLUS PERSONALIZED LEARNING
NETWORK ASSOCIATION OF SEVENTY
THOUSAND K. TWELVE STUDENTS AND
MORE THAN.
SEVENTY FIVE PERSONALIZED
LEARNING CHARTER SCHOOLS WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND FURTHER
OPPOSE THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT.
WELL I MEAN I'M AS I'M ADDING
MORE MEANING YOU KNOW THAT AND
RECORD SHIP IN ALMOST ANY
BECAUSE IT IN THIS TO SCORE LET
IDEAS.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIA AND I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN OF
SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANA BUSH CALL
I AM OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A FILE I HAVE TO
GET SOME BASIS AND A PASTA AB.
FIFTY SIX MY NAME IS CYRUS THIS
IS AN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL [inaudible]
I MY NAME IS LINDA MISSUS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW MRS AND I'M
HOME SCHOOL CHARTER PARENT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM ALLIED TO MISSISSIPPI AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JODY MISSUS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EMMA BEATEN VENDOR
WE'VE BEEN WITH SOUTH CENTER
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR ELEVEN YEARS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LIABLE CORA I'M FROM
UP IN SPORTS CHARTER SCHOOL I
OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACOB BEATING MENDER
I'VE BEEN WITH SOUTH SUTTER
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR ELEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A LEASE SO MY THREE
KIDS BASILE A ELEMENTARY BE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMIE MATTER I'VE
BEEN.
WITH CELLS ARE JOE SCHOOL FOR
TEN YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SPELL.
MY NAME IS LEAH GLUES GO I AM US
OF THIS TO HIGH SCHOOL STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JC BEATEN VENDOR.
I'VE BEEN WITH SOUTH SETTERS
CHARTER SCHOOL. FOR FOUR YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM I'VE INCLUDES GO FARTHER
FOR HAS STRONGLY OPPOSES FEEL.
MY NAME'S PARRIS LAUDERDALE I'M
WITH CHAU SAUCERS OUR SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS MILAN MOSTRA NOT AND
I AM GRANDMA AND I'M VERY
STRONGLY OPPOSE DEAL FIFTIES.
ZERO SIX MY NAME IS SHANNON
STUDENTS IT'S ALSO -- CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S LILY HAVING TO
LAW AND I HAVE TO STUDENTS IN
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS IVAN TO SINGLE.
THEM FROM HIS HIS TEACHERS
SCHOOL.
IN THOSE STRONG OPPOSE -- AB
FIFTY NO.
SIX WHEN ASKED THAT IS MY NUMBER
IS MUDDY UP BEING OUT OF BREATH
CENTRAL ISSUE THE SAMPLE SAFE.
I'M A FORMULA AVE INTO SEVERAL
SAY HE'S.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER TO SLING CO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A FIFTEEN
OH SIX MY NAME.
A LISTEN.
I AM.
AROUND.
MáS MY CHILDREN.
MY STUDENT.
I I AM.
OPPOSE AB. FIFTY ZERO SIX MY
NAME IS A LITTLE IT THIS LAN
KERR.
MY FOUR KIDS ATTENDING COULD --
CO A SCHOOL AND A STRONG LEVELS
THE BILL AB FIFTY IN ALL.
SIX HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA MISS.
I AM A BIT UNTIL FOR US TO USE
THAN TO THE ROCKLIN INDEPENDENT
CHARTER SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M NOT JUST THE ONLY FOOD CHECK
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
HIS MERE HI I'M MOM OF FOUR KIDS
AND MIKE ARE WAS VISIONS IN
EDUCATION AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE TOWN I'VE GOT OFF
OF A PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL FIFTY
NO.
SIX MOTHER OF TWO STUDENTS FROM --
HERITAGE PEAK CHARTER SCHOOL.
pAND THROW I'M STRONGER BALLS.
THIS BILL AND ALSO.
ALL FURTHER.
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SET UP A SHOP SCOTT A
MOTHER OF FOR FOR KEYS FROM ON
CA CHARTER SCHOOL AND I'M
STRONGER POSTERS FEEL.
MY NAME IS NATALIA ANY CORA I
HAVE A THREE KIDS A STRONG. FOR
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME IS
LEVERAGING IT CAN.
IF TO AND SUBSTITUTE.
NUMBER LOW ENOUGH TO SEND FOR
THIS FOR A LOT OF PAIN IN
LATERAL COULD CHIP IN THE PHONE
WHILE OUT OF IT CAME TO SETTLE
CITIES.
I AM A MOM OF THREE I AM NOT
ALONE NUMBER QUALITY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA -- IN ALPHA
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTY NO.
SIX HI MY NAME IS THE TEN I HAVE
A FOUR CHILDREN THREE OF THEM A
STUDENTS AND INSPIRE CHARTER
SCHOOL.
WE HAVE BEEN WITH A CHARTER
SCHOOL. FOR FIVE YEARS AND I
OPPOSE STRONGLY BILL FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK YOU.
ME NUMBERS FOR VIDEO LEGAL THE
SAMPLE SANTA PERCENT BUT AS
CONNECTICUT CHIEF.
HISTORIAN CONTROL THE LAB MAKING.
SEVEN SIX I'M THE TELEVISION
CALLED THE FATHER OF THREE KIDS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
OPPOSE ANY FURTHER AMENDMENT.
MY NAME IS A AND I GO TO ALL
FOUR BLOCK THEN I SUPPOSE.
AYE OPPOSED FIFTEENTH.
MY NAME IS NATALIA VERSION KERR
WHO THREE KIDS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WITH OLLIE ARM ON
FATHER OF THREE KIDS.
ARE BELIEVING RULES WILL
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ARMY NUMBER AS WELL I LOOK A
VIOLENCE YEAH YEAH I MEAN FOR
STEINORTH BOB LONG GOT ABOUT
OFFICE I WILL SAY EMAIL PHONE
CALL I'M NOT MAKING SUICIDAL
SAFE.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH.
AGORA ALPHA AND I OPPOSE BILL AB.
ONE ONE FIVE OH SIX ME NUMBER
NOT THAT WOULD BE THEY THEN WILL
NEED ONE AND ALL THAT SHOULD FOR
THE SUN.
IMMOBILIZED GISELE SAYS.
MY NAME IS A NOT TRAIN I HAVE
THREE KIDS AT ALFA CAUGHT A
STONE AYE OPPOSED THE BILL AB.
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX MY NAME IS
LEVEL OF KERR FOR FIVE MOTHER OF
SIX AND FIVE OF THEM ARE IN
CHARTER IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMY PORTER WITHOUT
CENTER CHARTER SCHOOL TEACHER
AND PARENTS OF CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ME OF MCCURRY I'M A
PARENT AT COURT CAMPTON
FILMMAKERS WILL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NATALIE MUHTAR I AM
FROM READING AT NEW DATE --
CHARTER NEED A ACADEMY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BILL.
ONE FIVE OH SIX MY NAME IS
RUNNING MCCURRY AND I GO TO
SCHOOL AT COR CHARTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER HUMBLED MEDIA ACADEMY
AYE OPPOSED FIFTEEN A SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS COMMON MCCURRY I GO
TO COURT CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONG IMPOSES.
MY NAME IS JOHN I AM FROM MEDIA
CAN STILL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MY NAME AND OFF AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GLENDALE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ANTHONY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER YANTAI FROM
NEW DAY ACADEMY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
A ARENA SAM ENOUGH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTY
NO.
SIX YOU MUST BE.
QUICKLY.
OKAY MY NAME IS MICHELLE BAILEY
FRIEND FROM NEW DAY ACADEMY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S IN ACETIC I'M WAS
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SIX I AM A DIFF.
I AM I AM I DO.
AND I'M GO WITH.
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL.
JUNGLEE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GALINA RIGHT TO GO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE DEVON AND
SKI.
AND I GO.
TO INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL.
IN A STRONGLY A POSTER.
BILL.
MY NAME IS EDDIE THE GOOD TO BE
I AM I'M A FIVE I'M STROLLER
OPPOSE THIS BILL THINK.
MY NAME IS A VERITABLE NETSKY I
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN AND TWO OF
THEM ARE WITH INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
FIFTY AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME IS
ALLOWED TO MEET THREE OF I HAVE
SIX KIDS AND FOR THE THEM IN THE
VISION.
HOME SCHOOL I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL OF FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A WORD OF AN ESKY --
FATHER OF FOUR TWO KIDS GO TO
INSPIRE NOW STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH THE
LOCAL C. Là I HAVE SIX CHILDREN
FOUR OF THEM ARE IN VISIONS.
HOME SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS.
BILL EIGHTY FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MILAN IT AND I GO TO
INSPIRED TREASURE SCHOOL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA TELL
ISSUE OF HI MOM OF TWO KIDS I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED OF THIS BILL.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS JULIA
AND I AM A MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN AND THEY GO TO INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BOTH CAMELOT I
HAVE THREE KIDS I STONE GLOBAL
WITH THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MAX BECAUSE SHOOK
IN MY DAUGHTER IDEA WE REPRESENT
IS.
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS LAWYER --
HAVE THREE KIDS AND TWO OF THEM
AND INSPIRE.
CHARTER I STRONGLY OPPOSE
FIFTEEN H
FIFTEEN Hí SIX A. B. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE BELL --
STRONG APPLES -- BILL AB SIX
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME S TO JUST THOSE TWO
A FATHER OF TWO KIDS.
I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALEB MOST ALSO ORDER
CHARTER SCHOOL RIGHT.
OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
EXXON AYE MITCH AND HI MOM OF
TWO HOLDEN SCHOOLERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATIE IN.
I HOLES. FIFTEEN OH SIX HI MY
NAME'S ELIZABETH HAS THAT
INTRICATE AND I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE AND ON BEHALF OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS I STRONGLY OPPOSE --
BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL CAM A LOCK I HAVE ONE
CHILD I UP PULLED AB -- FIFTY
SIX MY NAME IS MADELINE
SANDERSON WE HAVE FOUR CHILDREN
THREE YEAR WITH SOUTH CENTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND AYE OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
EMMA CAM OUTLOOK AND I HAVE ONE
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME IS JAMES
JOHNSON [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THIRTY ON A TARIFF
AYE AYE MOM OF TWO KIDS AND I AM
STRONGER FORCED OF THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OF SICK MY NAME IS IS
ABOUT JOHNSON AND I HAVE BEEN
HOME SCHOOLING FOR FOUR YEARS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JORDAN.
AND I SUPPOSE AB FIFTY NO.
SIX MONDAY MY NAME IS DINO TURN
GOLF ALL OF OUR ARMED FROM
SUTTER BIG SHOT.
CHARTER SCHOOL.
FULLER NILE POSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THE VIAVOICE AND
WE HAVE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR
SIX YEARS WITH CORPS PLASTER
CHARTER SCHOOL AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WELL FIFTY
AB FIFTY NO.
SIX MY NAME IS VERY TEARING
COUGHING AND MY KIDS ARE GOING
TO SORRY PEAK CHARTER SCHOOL AND
AWARE OF CLOSING THE SALE.
CHAIRED AUSTIN CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR COVERS
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND PARENT OF TWO
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE AND ALSO
REGISTERED NURSE AND I'M FATHER
OF SIX SOMETIMES STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL FIFTEEN OF SIX THANK
YOU.
HI PAT BROUGHTON EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR CONGRESS
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M MARC GROSSMAN AND I HAVE
THREE KIDS AND I'M STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL FIFTY NO.
SIX MY NAME IS CHIANA GRECO AND
I WITH INSPIRED INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL IN ASSURING WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL -- LEE'S ARREST MEN
I'M A TEACHER AND A A MOM OF
THREE KIDS AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB FIFTY NOW.
SIX MY NAME IS ELIANA CARPING.
AND I'M FROM.
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE -- I AM SURE YOU
BY THOSE GAY FROM.
FATHER FIVE GIFTS.
AND FROM.
THE SACRAMENTO A PICTURE UP A
SCHOOL AND UP WAS -- DEAL A. B. --
FIFTY NO.
SIX I AM SO BE CARPENTER AND I
AM FROM INSPIRED HER SCHOOLS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM UNITED -- VIC.
I HAVE FOUR KIDS OPPOSES BILL --
FIFTEEN OH SIX I AM STANDING
CARPENTER SENIOR DIRECTOR
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS I HAVE
SEVEN CHILDREN AND AYE AYES
STRONGLY OPPOE THIS BILL -- MY
LAMB ELENA SO OFTEN CALL -- AND
I HAVE FOR FOR KIDS.
AB POULSON IF.
A. B. FIFTIES ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
I'M SARAH GRECO FAMILY LIAISON
INSPIRE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
A HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL ASCHER.
I HAVE A TWO KIDS AND WE GO A
GOVERNMENT SCHOOL.
I AM PLEASED AB ONE ZERO FIFTEEN
SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SELENA MENU LAND CAM
ALMOST THREE CHILDREN AND THE
WORK IN IN JUST TO SEE CHARTER
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
I AM IDEA LESS SHOOK I HAVE TWO
KIDS -- OF FOR ALMOST GOT THE
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOL PUBLIC IN
THE RANCHO CORDOVA.
I AM A POLLS AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HI MY NAME IS
BORIS THE HOA.
I AM A FATHER OF THREE KIDS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SIX HI I AM JUST
MEANS FOR TO AND I'M FROM RIO
VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NICOLE CHRISTEN A
HARDER PULLS -- FIFTEEN OH SIX
MY NAME IS ERIC GAGNE.
FROM RIO VALLEY CHARTER SCHOOL
ENOUGH WITH HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALINA VOCAL FIVE GO
TO JOHN ADAMS ACADEMY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME THIRTY ON
A NEW CORA I HAVE I AGREE IN
MIND HIGH HAVE. NINE GRANTS
HOMES AND GO IN STRUGGLING ALL
CALLS. 906- MY NAME IS TAMERA
BOKO FUND FROM PLASTER COUNTY.
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS YOUR GUINEA JIM OFF
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
FIFTEEN THE SIX MY NAME IS THE
OLDEST REAL SOUL.
I'M.
GRAND.
MOM.
ALL FLOWS SIX GRAY AND KIDS --
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EDWARD WITH ALLIANCE.
I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME IS ALLAH
MARCH CHALK I HAVE CHILDREN THAT
GO TO CHARTER SCHOOL AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SIX MY NAME IS JAMES
CASH AGAIN I GO TO HOME SCHOOL
AND AYE OPPOSES THE STEPHEN CASH.
GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOL.
POSTED THE MY NAME IS MARK.
AND HE OPPOSES THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA JORDAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT PATHWAYS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND PARENTS OF
CHILDREN IN TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHERYL TOWNSEND I'M
THE PRINCIPAL AT PATHWAYS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WE'RE GONNA GO UP TO THE TOP NOW.
HI.
I'M AMY MCCAMLEY A BOMB OF TWO
CHILDREN WHO ARE HOME SCHOOLED
FOR AN INDEPENDENT CHARTER
SCHOOL I STRONGLY BECAUSE EIGHT
P..
FIFTEEN OH SIX I KNOW YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO DO YOU KNOW SEVEN BUT I
HAVE A PLANE TO CATCH SO I
POSTED YOU KNOW SEVEN AS WELL.
HI MY NAME IS TIME MCCAMLY
FATHER TWO DAUGHTERS THAT WE
HOME SCHOOL THROUGH A PRIVATE
CHARTER OR NOT A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL.
I AM ALSO OPPOSED B FIFTEEN OH
SIX AS A STATE I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MCKINNEY I'M
ALMOST APPARENT FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I PROBABLY GRADUATED ONE
STUDENT FROM INSPIRED CHARTERS.
AGAIN SPELL YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ON THE PLACE THAT.
THAT WILL GET.
ME SIEU ME PLACE WE WANT
EVERYBODY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
SURE THEIR OPINION CAKE PLEASE I
WANT EVERYBODY SHARE THEIR
OPINION.
OKAY SO PLEASE YOUR NAME
POSITION ON YOUR AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THAT
WE EVERYBODY GETS AN OPPORTUNITY
QUE.
PLENTY OF PEOPLE HERE BUT
THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME THANK YOU
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT MY NAME
IS KRISTEN SHEPHERD I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I REALLY
THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK INTO
SEEING AND
I AM DR KELLY SIMON
THE DIRECTORY BRIDGES CHARTER
SCHOOL IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE AUTHORIZED THROUGH ENTERA
COUNTY ON APPEAL AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHO ARE
AUTHORIZED TO BE VENTURA COUNTY
AND OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TWENTY ACKLAND
I'VE BEEN HOME SCHOOLING MY
THREE CHILDREN TO PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HI MARC LOPEZ AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MATT -- RAINER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE ALL BILLS THAT
HAVE LIMITATIONS TO THE CHARTER
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL DONE.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE RAINER I'M
FROM ORANGE COUNTY ANIMATRONICS
SCHOOL PARENT AND VENDOR -- ALSO
THERAPISTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL.
CASEY NO FURTHER OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL -- THE WE HAD OUR LAST ONE
HERE.
ARE YOU GOING TO SPEAK.
YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
YES YES OKAY HI MY NAME IS SIX
ANA I PROPOSES THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT -- OVER
YOUR BACK IN THE COMMITTEE BRING
BACK BEHIND THE RAIL ANYBODY
WISH TO COMMENT -- SEEING NONE.
A MISTER KILEY ME.
IT'S YOUR TURN MISTER MCCARTY
HERE YOU GO.
MR FORTY S. LET'S SEE IT'S
SUBSECTION EIGHT TWO OF YOUR
BILL SAYS THAT -- THE PRIORITY
SHOULD BE GIVEN TO A CHARTER
PETITION SUBMITTED UNDER THIS
PART ESTABLISH A CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT WILL NOT BE OPERATED BY AN
ENTITY THAT IS OPERATING AT A
CHARTER SCHOOL.
SO -- FOR EXAMPLE MISFORTUNE
IT'S HER SCHOOLS HAVE A TRACK
RECORD OF CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS AND YOUR BILL WOULD DE
PRIORITIZE FOR POSITION
PRECISELY ON THAT BASIS.
WHY IS THIS GOOD POLICY?
WELL I THERE'S THERE'S TWO
THINGS CLICK TO CLARIFY
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THE FOR EXAMPLE SACRAMENTO HER
AUTHORIZES SAT COUNTY ONE OF FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS WOULD NOT HAVE
TO CLOSE DOWN FEATHER WENT TO
OPEN UP.
BUT THERE IS A THOUGHT THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY EVALUATING AND
AND SHOULD WE MOVE FORWARD WILL
KEY LOOK AT IT.
IS SIMPLY A ALLOW THESE -- YOU
KNOW LACK OF BETTER TERM
CORPORATE STYLE AT T. CHARTER
OPERATORS TO COME INTO COMMUNITY
AND OPEN.
ONE WHEN THEY REALLY ARE GONNA
BE FOCUSED ON THAT COMMUNITY.
LIKE A LOCAL ENTITY WAY.
SO THE NOTION IS TO GIVE
PRIORITIES TO A NEW CHARTER
OPERATOR THAT AS MORE ROOTS IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
RECENTLY.
WAS -- EVALUATED WHEN WE SAT
DOWN WITH THE OPPOSITION AND YOU
WERE OPEN TO LOOKING AT THAT
THAT PIECE GOING.
FOR SO YOU'RE OPEN TO TAKING UP
OR OUT OF IT OR MAYBE MODIFYING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
WORKING AT THAT THE SO I THINK
IT RAISES SOME LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THERE IS CAPACITY HAS SOME WE
ALL AGREE THERE ARE SOME BAD
OPERATORS AND SO IF IF A CHARTER
SCHOOL -- SHUTS DOWN.
OR YOU KNOW PHASES OUT FOR
WHATEVER REASON
AND WE HAVE CAPACITY TO OPEN UP
A NEW SCHOOL SERVING ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS BASED UPON THAT.
EIGHTY EIGHT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
WHAT'S BEST FOR THE COMMUNITY
WHAT'S GOING TO BE A STABLE
ENTITY THERE.
CAN BE A LONG TERM NET POSITIVE
FOR THE COMMUNITY.
THERE'S BEEN THAT SOME REFERENCE
TO A STUDY FROM -- THE STANFORD
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR RESEARCH
ON EDUCATION OUTCOME SO JUST FOR
THE RECORD I WANT -- TO SAY WHAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT STUDY
FOUND HI THIS IS A QUOTE IN
TERMS OF ACADEMIC GROWTH OVER
TIME CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN
DISTRICT SCHOOLS AND URBAN AREAS.
AND PROFESSIONALLY LOWER
PERFORMING STUDENT GROUPS AS
FOLLOWS.
STUDENTS ARE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED ESPECIALLY THOSE
WERE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
IT'S A DEFINITELY GREATER
PROGRESS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
THEIR MATCH PEERS IN TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BLACK STUDENTS IN GENERAL FOUND
HAVE IMPROVED OUTCOMES IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE ACT IN A
PROGRESS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND POVERTY WAS EVEN
MORE POSITIVELY AFFECTED.
CHARTER SCHOOLS PROVIDE GREATER
LEARNING GAMES FOR STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING SPECIAL
EDUCATION SUPPORT. FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ADVANTAGES PARTICULARLY
LARGE AND SIGNIFICANT WHICH IS
NOT TYPICAL IN OTHER STATES.
AND FINALLY CHARTER SCHOOL
SERVING DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION AND SERVE MORE
STUDENTS ARE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN IN THE STATE AS A WHOLE.
SO GIVEN THESE FACTS WHY IS THIS
THE SECTOR OF OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHOSE GROWTH WE
WANT TO LIMIT.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THAT STUDY BUT YOU
CAN CERTAINLY PASS ON TO ME AND
WE'LL WE'LL TAKE A LOOK -- YOU
KNOW THE I THINK THIS IS A
REALITY CHECK FOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OUR TAXPAYERS THE
LEGISLATURE [inaudible]
TODAY.
WE KNOW THE CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE
A ROLE WE KNOW THERE'S SOME HIGH
ACHIEVING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
BUT THEN VITAL GROWTH YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR HAS A NEGATIVE
IMPACT.
ON OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND WE'RE GONNA SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES HEARING YOUR
COMMUNITIES IN MY COMMUNITY AT
THE STATE CAPITOL AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO ALLOW CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO THRIVE THAT ARE
EXISTING TODAY.
AND CONTRARY TO THE LETTERS THAT
I GOT OVER AND OVER FROM ROCKET
SHIP.
WITH THESE MEASURES ARE NOT
GOING TO CLOSE DOWN.
CHARTER SCHOOLS THIS CASE I'M
GONNA PUT A MORATORIUM.
SOME OF ASKED ME TO GO DOWN.
SOME OF SAID WE SHOULD GET RID
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS THIS IS NOT
THAT THIS I THINK IS A FAIR
SOLUTION WHICH ALLOWED CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO THRIVE.
AND ASK POPULATIONS DECREASE
RESISTING CHARTER SCHOOLS WE CAN
OPEN NEW ONES BUT PROVIDING SOME
FINANCIAL BREATHING ROOM.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA.
I JUST WANT TO CLEAR CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE PART OF THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT.
FOLKS THE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
THERE YOU KNOW VOLUNTARY KNOWN
SPORTS GO TO ANY PARTICULAR
SCHOOL SO I'D ASK YOU TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND WHEN YOU MAKE
CLAIMS ABOUT.
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO FURTHER COMING FROM
COMMITTEES A BILL THEN MOVED.
WELL I I I I WILL NOT JUST
REITERATE WHAT I'VE SAID OF
COURSE IN TERMS OF PROCESS.
BUT I DO HOPE AT SOME POINT IN
THIS -- DISCUSSION THAT WE
FIGURE OUT -- WHAT'S THE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO GET OUT OF
ALL OF THIS STUFF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY IN OTHER WORDS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE NO GUARANTEES
OR NO DISCUSSION.
OF HOW EITHER PUTTING A CAP. ONE
CHARTERS OR WHATEVER PROCESS WE
HAVE WILL BENEFIT THOSE STUDENTS
WHO ARE WHO ARE REMAINING IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS OR WHO MAY BE
FORCED TO GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOL.
IF THAT HAPPENS TO BE A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR CHART IS
CLOSE TO WHAT HAPPENED.
THESE PANTS THOUGH SINCE OF
DESPERATION AND I THINK MOST OF
YOU SINCE THAT.
THAT -- AND AND AND I THINK IT'S
IT'S WRONG TO TRY TO CONNECT --
THE PROLIFERATION OF CHARTERS
WITH THE LIMITED -- OUTCOMES IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS BECAUSE IF SO
THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
SAYING THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GUARANTEE THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
GOING TO DO BETTER GET BETTER
FOR KIDS AS A RESULT OF ALL THIS
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
AND AND I DON'T THINK THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT EVEN BEFORE
CHARTERS.
WITH A TO PLACE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THE SYSTEMS CONTINUE
TO FAIL AFRICAN AMERICAN KIDS.
AND AND SO I I I UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE OF THE GROWTH IN
THE LACK MANAGEMENT AND CONTROL
AND I'M NOT A LOT OF OVERSIGHT
THAT.
THAT THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN THAT
HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING AND I
DON'T.%
I DON'T EVEN AYE LESSER TO SEE
THE OVERSIGHT COMING IN THIS AND
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO SEEN
SOMETHING IN ALL OF THIS THAT
REALLY MADE A COMMITMENT.
OF OVERSIGHT AND OUTCOMES FOR
KIDS WHO ARE POOR.
BUT IF WE'RE TAKING THE MONEY
AND PUTTING IT BACK INTO AND
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL PIECE ISN'T CONCERNED
ABOUT THOSE THINGS WHICH WE
SHOULD BE.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THINGS ARE NOT
GOING RIGHT AT THIS POINT FOR A
LOT OF KIDS AND WE'RE YOUR
FORTUNE IN SACRAMENTO TO THE
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS.
BUT THAT THE PERFORMANCE IS UP
AND DOWN THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE DON'T SEEM TO BE.
AGGRESSIVELY DEALING WITH THAT
WE SEEM TO DEAL MORE WITH --
FINANCES AND MANAGEMENT AND ALL
THESE KINDS OF THINGS AND WE
KNOW WHEN SCHOOLS HAVE DONE
EXTREMELY WELL FINANCIALLY.
BLACK AND BROWN HE'S STILL FAIL.
WHEN THEY LOST MONEY BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS STILL FAIL?
SO EVEN AS WE DO THIS WE HAVEN'T
MADE A COMMITMENT TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND ATTACHING IT IN SOME
WAY.
THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE GOING TO
GET BETTER FOR OUR KIDS I THINK
THOSE ON THIS COMMITTEE WE HAVE
TO COMMIT OURSELVES AFTER THESE
THREE BILLS.
AND ALL THE OTHER ONES WE SEE TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MAJORITY
OF KIDS IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
KNOWLEDGE TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BUT WHAT ACT WHERE I KIDS
FLEEING WHAT A PAN STILL SO
DESPERATE.
UP I MEAN IT.
I UNDERSTAND IT THE WORST YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE DECISIONS
PARENTS HAVE TO MAKE ABOUT
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN WITH THEIR
KIDS THESE THESE FOLKS A
DESPERATE.
AND AND SO AND THEN AT THE SAME
TIME WE BUT WE SAT BACK AND KIND
OF ALLOW THE CHARTER TEAM TO GO
UP AND DOWN TO GIVE WEEKLY
WAGGLE YOU.
GET SOME THINGS OF THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THERE THAT WE GET
TO TOSS OUT AND WE'VE HAD TO
DRESS.
BUT I'M HOPING AT SOME POINT
THAT THOSE WERE PUT FORTH THESE
THREE FOUR BILLS.
THAT WOULD DRAMATICALLY CHANGE
CHARTERS ALSO WE'LL TALK ABOUT.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY? FOR PERFORMANCE
INTEREST IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST CLAMP DOWN
THIS AND THINK EVERYTHING'S
GONNA BE OKAY BECAUSE IT WILL
NOT.
AND SO I HOPE THAT BECOMES A
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE
REALLY START TALKING ABOUT.
PERFORMANCE AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO FOR OUR KIDS FOR EVERY KID IN
CALIFORNIA TO GROW AND TO THRIVE.
AND IF NOT WE'RE GOING TO
BASICALLY PUSH OUR FOLKS OUT
AGAIN.
OUT OF FRUSTRATION.
AND MY FEAR IS THAT THEY WILL GO
INTO THE VOUCHER SITUATION THAT
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT SOME
TWENTY SIX YEARS AGO.
AND I CHAIRED THE VOUCHER NO ONE
AS I TOLD YOU THE NO ONE THOUGHT
TO COMMITTEE AND I STILL WANTED
TO THIS DAY IF I DID THE RIGHT
THING.
BECAUSE THERE WAS SOME
ASSURANCES MADE AS TO WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN OUR SCHOOLS.
IF WE DEFEATED VOUCHERS AND THAT
INSURANCE WAS NOT LIVED UP TO
FOR ME IN TERMS WITH PEOPLE
SHORT ME WHEN I TOOK THAT CHARGE
TO DO THAT IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
SO I'M HOPEFUL THAT THAT
CONVERSATION WILL RISE TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
PERFORMANCE.
IN ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS SO THAT WE
CAN BE PROUD OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS AND AND AND BOTH RUNNING
TO CHART IS IS JUST A SYMPTOM.
OF OUTCOME OF OF WHAT WE SEE AND
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE REAL
ISSUE WHICH IS EVERY SCHOOL IN
THIS STATE SHOULD BE AN
EXCELLENT SCHOOL SO THE PARENT
CAN WALK DOWN THE STREET AND PUT
THEIR KID IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND FEEL THAT'S A GOOD THING AND
AS A GRANDMOTHER YOU KNOW I MY
DAUGHTER PAYS ALMOST FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR HER
TWO KIDS GO TO SCHOOL.
THAT IS CRIMINAL YOU KNOW THAT
IS CRIMINAL AND SHE LIVES IN A
DECENT NEIGHBORHOOD BUT THE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT PERFORMING AT
THE LEVEL THAT SHE THINKS IS
IMPORTANT.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE TO DO
THAT IS A STATEMENT ABOUT.
PEOPLE CRYING OUT FOR HELP AND
I'M HOPING THAT ONCE WE DO ALL
THIS MISCEGENATION EVERYONE DO
WITH THESE THREE BILLS.
THAT WE AS A COMMITTEE BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE CRYING OUT FOR A
QUALITY SCHOOL IN EVERY
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE MUST COMMIT
OURSELVES TO THAT.
OTHERWISE THEY WILL FEEL THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DUPED AGAIN.
GREAT -- SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT --
MISTER MCCARTY.
YOU MAY -- CLOSE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO PROVISIONS OF EMOTION.
THE BILL WILL AS THE CALLER
SECOND MIGHT MISS SMITH.
UP YOU MAY CLOSE.
YEAH I THINK THANK YOU I I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
YOU KNOW I KNOW PEOPLE THINK IT
THIS IS A A BLACK AND WHITE
ISSUE.
IT'S A LOT OF GRAY BETWEEN AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE AS YOU
SAID IN YOUR MEASURE AND ARE
MEASURE TO WORK WITH THAT.
WITH THOSE SITES YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE REALITY WE'VE BEEN HERE
FOR FOUR HOURS YOU KNOW I
HAVEN'T HEARD ONE TO FOUR HOURS.
HOWEVER WOEFULLY UNDER FUNDING
OUR SCHOOLS.
RIGHT. FORTY FIRST THE NATION IN
PER PEOPLE FUNDING THAT'S A
DISGRACE WE PROBABLY WOULD NOT
BE HERE RIGHT NOW.
IF WE WERE TWENTY FIFTH IN THE
NATION -- FIT IN THE NATION ARE
TENTH IN FUNDING OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION INCLUDING OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE X. ON
UNBELIEVABLE PRESSURE ON OUR
FINANCIAL -- WHERE WITH ALL OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THAT MEANS EIGHT
IN SCHOOLS INCREASE CLASS SIZES
DON'T HAVE THE IN RICHMOND THAT
THE SPORTS THE MATH?
AND ON THE MAP THE SPORTS THE
MUSIC THE DR SO THAT TOO
SOMETIMES A MATHIS DOCTOR WHERE
I WAS JUST POINTING OUT.
AND YOU KNOW MONEY IS NOT THE
ANSWER TO ALL OF OUR WILLOWS BUT
I THINK THAT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE
THAT WE NEED.
pTRACK ON BUT THIS ISN'T IS THAT
NECESSARY PIECE.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR PERSPECTIVE.
HEARING WHAT THE ALTERNATIVES
ARE.
AND WITH THAT HAS BEGUN.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY THINK
YOU'RE POINTING OUT THE FUNNY
ISSUE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY ACCURATE
WITH REGARD TO THAT AND IN SOME
COMMUNITIES OF ACTUALLY INCREASE
THEIR LOCAL TAXES TO SUPPORT
THEIR SCHOOLS.
NOT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE THAT
OPTION OR HAVE BEEN ABLE TO YOU
KNOW GET THAT PASSED BUT THAT
SHOWS YOU THE DESPAIR NESS OF
OUR FUNDING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED SO THANK YOU --
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE REAL QUICK
MISTER MCCARTY YOU DO IT ON A
MICROPHONE YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
YES I SAID AT THE BEGINNING ALSO.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN AND APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
I SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES ITIS
OUT AND I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT -- EIGHTY
SEVEN ELEVEN HAS BEEN PULLED AS
HAS AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE THOSE OF
BOTH AND PULL FROM TWO NIGHTS
AGENDA.
IT WAS TODAY NOW IT'S TIME.
I'M SORRY NEXT NEXT TO FILE
ITEMS THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE AND THIS IS. FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN BY MISS SMITH -- YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY WITH AB
FIFTEEN OR SEVEN MISS SMITH
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO OPEN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH CLARIFY
PREVIOUS AMENDMENTS AND INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY FOR SCHOOLS.
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN CONTINUES
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK IN INCREASING
CHARTER TRANSPARENCY.
THIS BILL INCREASES LOCAL
CONTROL BY ELIMINATING LOOPHOLES
IN CURRENT CHARTER LAW WHICH
ALLOW CHARTER SCHOOLS TO OPERATE
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL RESTORES THE RIGHT OF
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SCHOOLS
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES AND CLARIFIES THE
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY OF
THE DULY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS
AND THEIR ROLES IN PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT.
MY STAFF AND I PROVIDED RECENT
LA TIMES AND CAL MATTERS
ARTICLES TO YOU FRAMING OUT OF
DISTRICT CHARTER AUTHORIZATION
ABUSES.
THE ISSUE THAT AB FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN SEEKS TO ADDRESS AND IS
NOW BEEN A CONSISTENT AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE LEAVING IMPACTED ELLIE
IS NO RECOURSE OTHER THAN COSTLY
LITIGATION.
ELEAZAR HAVE BEEN TASKED WITH
ENSURING STUDENT SUCCESS BUT
THAT SUCCESS IS BUILT OFF TRUST
FROM THE COMMUNITY WITHIN THE
ALLEY A AND THE COMMUNITY
IMPACTED BY IT.
REST IS BUILT OFF MEASURES OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
WHICH IS NOT PRACTICABLE IF
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
AUTHORITY OVER THE SCHOOL IN
YOUR BACKYARD.
THIS WAS THE CASE DURING MY
TENURE ON THE NEW HALL SCHOOL
BOARD.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE TOOLS NORTH
ALREADY TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT.
ON A SCHOOL.
THERE WAS AUTHORIZED BY ANOTHER
DISTRICT BUT PHYSICALLY LOCATED
WITHIN OUR SCHOOLS BOUNDARIES IN
FACT ACROSS THE STREET FROM OUR
DISTRICT HEADQUARTERS.
WE COULD NOT DO ARE DULY ELECTED
JOB TO LOOK OUT FOR AN ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF THOSE STUDENTS.
IN THE SCHOOL NOR COULD WE
ADVOCATE TO MITIGATE ANY FACTORS
TO DECREASE THE IMPACT TO THE
SCHOOL AND ITS SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AS A CAL MATTERS ARTICLE
INDICATES THE CHARTER IN MY
DISTRICTS CASE CLOSED IN A FEW
SHORT YEARS DUE TO WOEFULLY
MISMANAGED FINANCES THROUGH
THEIR CMO.
AS HAD BEEN PREDICTED BY THE
MULTIPLE ELLIE ETS WHO WOULD
CAREFULLY VETTED AND DENIED
THEIR ORIGINAL PETITION.
THE AUTHORIZED OR IN THIS CASE
WAS A SMALL RURAL DISTRICT IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS DUE TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
AND THIS IS OCCURRING IN
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE LOOPHOLE IN THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACTION LITERALLY SETS UP
A PERVERSE SET A FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR STRUGGLING ELLIE
ETS IN A MANNER INCONSISTENT NOT
ONLY WITH THE INTENT OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ACT BUT WITH OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADEQUATELY
FUND ALL DISTRICTS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AS THE COST OF
OPERATION OFTEN DON'T DIMINISH
IN DIRECT PROPORTION TO
DIMINISHMENT OF ADA.
HOWEVER AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
ULTIMATELY IS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL AND MAKING SURE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE TOOLS AND
POWER TO BEST USE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN
CHILDREN.
AND FOR THOSE LOCAL ENTITIES TO
DO WHAT THEY WERE ELECTED TO DO.
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TO ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WITHIN THEIR STATUTORY
JURISDICTION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OUR
GUILD GARBARINO MOJICA
SUPERINTENDENT OF PLASTER
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND MARK
WINGER MY FORMER SUPERINTENDENT
IN THE FORMER SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE NEW LAW SCHOOL DISTRICT.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS GAIL
GARBARINO MOJICA AND I'M THE
PLASTER COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS WE HAVE HAD A NEW NUMEROUS
AMOUNTS.
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT WERE
LOCATING IN OTHER DISTRICTS THAT
WERE NOT AUTHORIZED BY THEM.
WE ARE AS A COUNTY OF ABOUT
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND KIDS
SIXTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
TWENTY ONE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AT ONE POINT WE HAD SIX CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT WERE OPERATING
OUTSIDE OF THEIR AUTHORIZES
BOUNDARIES.
BASED UPON MY EXPERIENCE THESE
LAST TEN YEARS I'VE COME ACROSS
TO TRANSIT I FIND TROUBLING WHEN
WE HAVE A CHARTER SCHOOL THAT
RELOCATES OUTSIDE AN AUTHOR
RISERS BORDERS.
THE FIRST ONE HAPPENS IS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM A LOCAL CONTROL SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE CHARTER
SCHOOL THAT'S LOCATED IN
ROSEVILLE.
AND THERE WERE SOME INGRESS
EGRESS ISSUES THAT HAVE IMPACTED
THE BUSINESS AND THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
THE BUSINESS IN THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
TAKING THEIR CONCERNS TO THEIR
LOCALLY ELECTED OFFICIALS THEIR
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
YOUR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS THERE
CITY GOVERNMENT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT WASN'T
THE CASE THEY WERE AUTHORIZED BY
A TOWN THAT WAS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AWAY.
FROM THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE A
TOWN THAT HAD A SCHOOL BOARD
THAT DID NOT HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE THE
SCHOOL BOARD OR THE CAST CITY
GOVERNMENT.
IT RESULTED IN MANY CONSTITUENTS
BEING VERY CONFUSED AS TO HOW
THEY CAN CONFIRM CONVEY THEIR
CONCERNS REGARDING THE INGRESS
AND EGRESS ISSUES.
THE SECOND ISSUES THAT I'VE COME
ACROSS IN THE LAST TEN YEARS IS
THE I DO THE THE PARTICIPATION
OF MANY CHARTER SCHOOLS SEEKING
A SMALL AUTHORIZED -- SUCH AS
ONE OF MY SMALLEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY LOCATED
IN THE FOOTHILLS.
THEY ARE SMALL.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEIR
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS AND THEY
DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF STAFF TO
CONDUCT A IN DEPTH HIGH QUALITY
REVIEW.
AS SOON AS SUCH THEY HAVE
AUTHORIZED MANY LARGE CHARTER
SCHOOLS SOME OF WHICH THREE OF
THEM ARE LOCATED IN TAHOE SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AWAY FROM THEIR
CURRENT AUTHORIZED -- SO IF YOU
DRIVE UP HIGHWAY EIGHTY YOU HAVE
TO DRIVE THROUGH SIX OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEFORE YOU GET
TO THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WHAT IS THE SERBS WHAT HAS
RESULTED IS THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT THAT THE SMALL RULE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HOUSE FOR THESE
CHARTERS I HAVE WITH WITNESSED
IT MYSELF?
THE FACT THAT THIS CHARTERS THIS
DISTRICT DOESN'T EVEN MEET THE
BASIC REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH IN
LONG WHEN IT COMES TO OVERSIGHT.
SO I HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS THOSE IN
DEPTH IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
LATER.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON MARK
WHERE FORMER SUPERINTENDENT NEW
HALL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
I'M GONNA TELL YOU ARE DISTRICTS
STORY SO TO A LITTLE MICROCOSM
OF WHAT YOU JUST HEARD -- WE
REJECTED A PETITION FROM THE
ALBERT EINSTEIN A KIA CAN ME IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN DUE TO FISCAL
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THEY WERE
MAKING THAT WE KNEW WERE WRONG
AND THEIR ABILITY TO OR THEIR
LACK OF ABILITY.
TO NOT DELIVER PROGRAM FOR OUR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS IN THE
DISTRICT.
THEIR PETITION WAS ALSO REJECTED
BY OUR NEIGHBORING DISTRICTS
SAUGUS SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND REJECTED BY THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OF EDUCATION ON APPEAL
FROM THE SAUGUS DISTRICT AND
REJECTED.
BY FOUR OTHER LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE LOS ANGELES AND
VENTURA COUNTIES.
AT AROUND A PARALLEL TRACK IN ON
TWO THOUSAND IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ACTON I WOULD ALSO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS --
IS FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENT
DISTRICT AT THAT TIME ABOUT
TWENTY MILES AWAY FROM US.
AND THEY WERE NEGATIVELY
CERTIFIED BY LA COUNTY THEY
COULDN'T MEET THEIR OBLIGATIONS
IN THE COMING YEARS -- THEIR
BOARD DECIDED THAT THE WAY THEY
WERE GOING TO PROVE THIS WAS BY
APPROVING MULTIPLE CHARTERS AND
I HAVE THE SLIDE PRESENTATION
FROM THE BOARD -- MEETING AT
THAT TIME MULTIPLE CHARTERS AND
THEY WOULD GENERATE ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND SOLVE
THEIR FISCAL PROBLEMS -- SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE THAT.
ACT AND I WOULD ALSO BE AND THE
EINSTEIN CHARTER FOUND EACH
OTHER AND ACT AND THEY'LL SEE
APPROVED THERE -- PETITION AND
THE PETITION TALK ABOUT SERVING
THE STUDENTS OF THE ACT AND I
WOULD ALSO A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT THE IMMEDIATELY DECLARED
THERE WAS NO ROOM IN THE
DISTRICT AND THEY HAVE TO MOVE
ELSEWHERE -- AND AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO SAW ON
THE SMALL DISTRICTS WAS THEY
MANUFACTURE THE ARGUMENT TO FIT
THE LOOPHOLE THAT THERE'S NO
ROOM IN THE DISTRICTS ARE SMALL
DISTRICT -- SO THE THEY WANT TO
MOVE TO SANTA CLARITA AND THEY
TRIEDAND THEY FAILED TO OPEN.
BUT THEY DID OPEN THAT FIRST
YEAR THEY OPENED AN ABANDONED
SCHOOL IN ACT AND I WOULD ALSO.
GOING TO DEFINE THEIR OWN CLAIM
OF NOT HAVING SPACE A YEAR LATER --
PRIVATE SCHOOL CAME ON THE
MARKET IN SANTA CLARITA IN THE
NEW HOUSE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THEY MOVED INTO THAT PRIVATE
SCHOOL AND OPENED NOT TO SERVE
THE STUDENTS OF BACKING OUT OF
THE I WOULD ALSO BUT TO SERVE.
THE SCHOOLS IN SANTA CLARITA.
WE HAD ONE PETITION.
IN THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR HISTORY
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL LAW ONE
PETITION WE DENIED IT.
WE FOLLOW THE LAW WE DID NOT IT
ON SIGNIFICANT FOR SIGNIFICANT
REASONS AND IF THAT SCHOOL WAS
OPERATING IN OUR DISTRICT.
AND HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE
LACK OF OVERSIGHT THAT WE ARE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE COULD NOT
APPLY A FEW YEARS INTO THEIR RUN --
FIFTH MAC CONDUCTED AN EXTRA
EXTRAORDINARY HOT IT.
AND FOUND ALL KINDS OF FISCAL
MISMANAGEMENT A COMPLETE LACK OF
PAPERWORK IN A LOT OF CASES THEY
COULDN'T PROVE THAT THERE WAS
ANYTHING CRIMINAL GOING ON
BECAUSE A CONFINED ENOUGH
RECORDS TO DO THAT.
AND NEW -- SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS
COMPLETELY UNABLE. TO OVERSEE
THAT CHARTER OPERATING OUR
DISTRICT I THINK MATT HAD
SEVERELY CRITICIZED AND AFTER
NOT WITH ALL STATE I COMPETING
INTERESTS HERE DIDN'T THEY DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT THICK MAT.
AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
SAID THEY DROVE THEMSELVES INTO
THE GROUND EVENTUALLY AND CLOSE --
ANY AS YOU KNOW THIS WAS NOT AN
ISOLATED CASE A DOCTOR WEBER YOU
KNOW TWELFTH BECAUSE IT HAPPENED
IN SAN DIEGO UNIFIED WITH THE
SAME GROUP -- IT'S HAPPENED
ACROSS THE STATE THE COMMON
THEME IS SMALL FISCALLY
DISTRESSED UNITS MANUFACTURING
THIS NO SPACE SOLUTION. TO
EXPLOIT THIS LOOPHOLE IN THE
WHAT.
AND HOW I FEEL STRONGLY A LOCAL
LOCALLY ELECTED BOARDS OF WE'VE
HEARD ALL DAY TODAY.
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CHARTERS WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRICTS.
THE CURRENT LAW ALLOWS OTHER
DISTRICTS TO VIOLATE THAT WHOLE
CONCEPT AND AND THE SOVEREIGNTY
OF OTHER DISTRICTS.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED AND I
DON'T SEE THIS CONVERSELY IF
THAT LOOPHOLE ISN'T CLOSED
THAT'S SENDING A SIGNAL THAT
THIS UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR IS
ACCEPTABLE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE ALLOWING IT
TO GO ON SO COURSE I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IF YOU KNOW SO.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
RESEARCHERS AT BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
HELLO WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION SPORT.
MORE PRESENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT. TO OUR STRAND
FLORES CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IT'S PART.
A GROWING WE HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE SANTA BARBARA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASKING ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
CLEAR CRAWFORD WITH IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN SUPPORT.
HE ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
LEILANI I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND AND FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT --
WILL GO UP STAIRS NOW THERE'S IS
THERE SUPPORTERS UPSTAIRS SHE
MADE YES THANK YOU -- JEFF RATE
IS -- PRESIDENT ELECT OF CFT THE
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING
PRACTITIONERS IN PUBLIC CHARTER
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
VALLEY BACHELOR WITH C. F. T.
FROM ALAMEDA AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'M ERIN CALMLY I AM WITH YOU
HAVE T. I LIVE IN PASADENA AND I
WORK IN LA AND ORANGE COUNTY'S
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THEN A LARGE REAL COLLEGE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NO HARM YELLOW POST THIS IS THE
CAREER BECAUSE FRAZIE
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
ON THIS BILL.
MATTHEW HARDY CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND A
BERKELEY PUBLIC SCHOOL PARENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
TOM HERMAN.
UNITED TEACHERS TO SAN FRANCISCO --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MICHAEL SANTEE CFT -- CAREER
COLLEGE IN STORE SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THE THE MOUSA CLASSIFIED STAFF
FOR THE EL CAMINO COLLEGE
DISTRICT I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JESSICA ALSO SAID I'M WITH CFT
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN CASEY CARLSON
GRANDMOTHERS SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS SANTA CRUZ AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ONLY NOW IN HIGH SCHOOL MATH
TEACHER IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEPT VACATE PARENT OF TWO KIDS
IN WEST CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED AND
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
LINDA DARK TEACHER JEFFERSON
ELEMENTARY DISTRICT AND
FEDERATION AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
STEVE MCDOUGAL PRESIDENT SLEAZE
BY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATIE BASSLER SALINAS VALLEY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS HIGH
SCHOOL ENGLISH TEACHER AND I
STAND IN SUPPORT.
DILLON HARO IT'S I'M HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION TEACHERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CAROLINE SAMOA VICE PRESIDENT
FOR PARITY CATERS AND SAN
FRANCISCO SPECIAL APPEAR
EDUCATOR AND A GRANDPARENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HIS BILL.
FRANCISCO TODAY AS PRESIDENT
WITH THE BOTTLE VALLEY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
PARENTS I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
YOU MAY CARRY ON HISTORY TEACHER
DEGREE VERA PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN
BETWEEN BIRTH AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
PRODUCT KIRKMAN MEMBER OF THE PA
HER VALLEY FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN THE C. F. T. A
TEACHER IN WATSONVILLE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AMONTE FRANCIS I MAKE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOL ALUMNI FROM BY
CELL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MARZUK -- BUT HER OF ANY
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPECIAL
ED TEACHER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ANOTHER I YES UNITED EDUCATORS
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND A PARENT AT
TEMPS IS CLEAN BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I STAND AS A PART
OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LAYLA MOLINO I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LARA'S RO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER FROM WATSONVILLE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NANCY JACKSON PONDER ABOUT A
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS FOURTH
GRADE TEACHER IN WATSONVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STAND SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JOANNA VALENTINE CFT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
CAN REALLY ROSE BURGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SAYING NO MORE SUPPORT
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION.
DOES NOT APPEAR THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION.
GET UP HERE.
WELL THEY DON'T LINE UP TO THE
MICROPHONE YET.
WE HAVE A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
FOR ALMOST
.
WHEN WE IN THE?
THANK YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
HI MY NAME IS THE RANDY GUESS
AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING IN
EDUCATION AS A TEACHER AND NOW
AS A COUNSELOR. FOR THE PAST
TWENTY THREE YEARS.
I MADE THE SWITCH FROM WORKING
IN A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL ELEVEN
YEARS AGO WHEN I BEGAN WORKING
AT A SITE BASED CHARTER SCHOOL.
BECAUSE I WAS INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH A POPULATION OF
STUDENTS IN WHICH I CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
I HAVE DECIDED TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE THREAT THAT
AB FIFTY NO SEVEN PRESENTS TO
THE POPULATION OF STUDENTS.
THAT ATTEND OUR SITE.
STUDENTS THAT HAVE COME TO OUR
SITE.
ARE THE STUDENTS.
THAT COME TO US FOR VARIOUS
REASONS [inaudible] FOR EXAMPLE.
STUDENTS WITH DEPRESSION.
ANXIETY.
VICTIMS OF BULLYING.
STUDENTS THAT PERHAPS ARE
LOOKING TO START THEIR CAREER.
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL EARLY.
WHO CAN BENEFIT FROM A FLEXIBLE
SCHEDULE?
AND A SMALL CLASS INSTRUCTION.
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BIBLE FORCE OR
I. E. P.'S WHO ARE STRUGGLING
ACADEMICALLY.
AT OUR SITE STUDENTS CAN ENROLL
IN SMALL CLASSES.
THAT ARE NO BIGGER THAN.
FIVE AND HAVE THE BENEFITS OF
TRUE DIFFERENTIATED INSTRUCTION.
I CAN BE TRULY ENGAGED.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW DETRIMENTAL
IT WOULD BE TO THESE STUDENTS.
LIVES IF THAT WAS TAKEN AWAY.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IF AB FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN PASSES.
IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THE
STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE FOUND SUCCESS IN OUR
BACK OF BILL SITE BASED PROGRAM?
WILL THEY BE FORCED TO GO BACK
TO THE PROGRAM.
AT THEIR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL SITE.
THAT OBVIOUSLY DID NOT MEET
THEIR NEEDS.
WILL THEIR I EP GOALS.
BE MAD AT THE RICH AT THE
TRADITIONAL SITE.
OR WHERE OR WILL THEY JUST
SIMPLY DROP OUT.
KNOWING THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM FAILED THEM.
AND I LEAVE THAT QUESTION FOR
YOU TO PONDER.
I KNOW.
THAT OUR SITE PROGRAM MAKES A
DIFFERENCE EVERY DAY.
PERHAPS YOU KNOW FOR THE PAST
ELEVEN YEARS WITH THE STUDENTS
THAT I WORK WITH.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT
OUR ORGANIZATION.
ATTEMPTED TO GET CHARTER
APPROVED BY OUR LOCAL DISTRICT.
AND WE WERE DENIED TWICE.
DESPITE THE CLEAR STUDENT NEED.
A COMMUNITY DESIRE IN THAT
DISTRICT FOR OUR PROGRAM.
I KNOW IT MUST HAVE BEEN BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT HAVE CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO EVERY DAY.
HOW CAN ANY EDUCATOR OR LEADER
DENY A STUDENT A SCHOOL LARA
PROGRAM OF CHOICE?
IF THEIR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL DID
NOT WORK FOR THEM.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
AND AT THE END OF MY SPEECH HERE.
I WANT TO JUST CONVEY THAT I
WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
HELLO AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS DRIVING SPORTS AND
I'M SIXTEEN AND I'M A JUNIOR AT
US AND I'M A STUDENT AT RIO
VALLEY.
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW.
GOING TO CHARTER SCHOOL CHANGING
FOR THE BETTER AND HOME
EDUCATIONAL ON WHAT EVERYONE
ELSE IS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
SO FIRST OFF I WASN'T ALWAYS IN
A CHARTER SCHOOL I WAS ALWAYS
INTRODUCTION ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND THE PUBLIC SYSTEM.
I WENT TO TRADITIONAL HIGH
SCHOOLS I WILL FOLLOW FOR PLAN
AND I FELT LIKE EVERY SCHOOL
THAT I WENT TO DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I NEEDED
THAT EXTRA AN INDIVIDUAL HELP.
FROM TEACHERS I NEVER GOT THAT
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS FEELING
MOSTLY ALL MY CLASSES AND I'M
GETTING ANYTHING DONE.
AND I WAS FALLING BEHIND IN A
LOT AND EVERYTHING AND SO I WENT
TO THE CHARTER SYSTEM AND IT WAS
THE BEST THING I EVER DID.
I WENT IN AND I FEEL LIKE I
REALLY GOT A SECOND CHANCE AT
SCHOOLING.
MY FIVE OH FOR PRIME WAS
RESPECTED AND I GOT THE
INDIVIDUAL HELP I NEEDED AND I
FELT SO MUCH BETTER AND MORE
CONFIDENT IN MY FUTURE AND THAT
I WAS GOING TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
AND IT IS GOOD SHOT DOWN
EVERYONE INCLUDING ME WILL BE
PUSHED BACK INTO THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM AND EVERYTHING WILL NOT
WILL BE THE SAME AS IT WAS
BEFORE.
AND I HONESTLY THOUGHT THAT'S
NOT THE BEST THING FOR ME.
BECAUSE THEN THERE GOES MY HOPE
FOR PLAN AND MY GRADES ARE GONNA
SLIP AND WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY
IS THAT WE AS KIDS AND
ASSISTANCE ON DESERVED COVER
SCHOOL SHUT DOWN WE DESERVE A
GREAT EDUCATION AS WELL AS
EVERYONE ELSE.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ERIC PREMATURE SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER WHAT ON BEHALF OF THAT
VOICE IN OPPOSITION.
MAX SHOOK INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN JOANNA HOLLOW
VICE CHAIR OF TECHNO COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND PARENTS
OF CHILDREN IN BOTH TRADITIONAL
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
OPPOSITION.
TO FIFTEEN OH SEVEN LARA FERAL
TEACHER OF EXCEPTIONAL LEARNERS
AND UNION REPRESENTATIVE CAMINO
NUEVO TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
THEM I HAVE.
LOS ANGELES AREA IN OPPOSITION
OF FIFTEEN OH SEVEN SHANNON
LAUDERDALE PARENT OF STUDENTS IS
ALSO -- CHARTER SCHOOL IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
EDDIE RAMIREZ WITH CAMINO
CHARTER ACADEMY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S PARIS L'OREAL AND I'M
WITH CELL SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALSO THE MARTINEZ STUDENT ALUMNI
PERRIN AN EMPLOYEE OF CAMINO
NUMBER CHARTER ACADEMY AND AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
ERICA GONZALEZ CAMINO NUMBER
CHARTER ACADEMY IN A OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
DR ALLORI A BAD THE CONSERVATORY
OF OAKLAND MISSION IN MINT VOCAL
AND INSTRUMENTAL ARCH BEEN HERE
LONG TIME TODAY -- IN OAKLAND --
IN OPPOSITION.
JOHNSON ARIANNA STUDENT AND
FAMILY SERVICES A SYSTEM THAT
CAMINO WHAT CHARTER ACADEMY AND
I PULL SYSTEM.
TAMMY STANTON PARENT OF TWO
STUDENTS AT OCEAN CHARTER SCHOOL
IN LOS ANGELES AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF CAMINO NO
WAY BUT CHARTER ACADEMY IN LOS
ANGELES.
I OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS LONDON MISSUS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TRY BUYER DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION LITERACY FIRST CHARTER
SCHOOL SAN DIEGO OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS A LIE JIM ASSISTANT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LISA WILLIAMS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SAYS MRS
INTERNATIONALLY PRESSES BILL.
ELIZABETH SHORT CHARTERS.
DIEGO.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TO MY NAME IS CHERYL TOWNS AND
I'M THE PRINCIPAL AT PATHWAYS
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW MRS CINEMA
HOME SCHOOL CHARTER.
SCHOOL PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN RENAMING PRIDE
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLE HARMONY
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JERRY MISSES IN WITH HORIZONS
CHARTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
SERRA JORDAN PATHWAYS CHARTER
SCHOOL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JUDY THERE WAS SPRINGS CHARTER
SCHOOLS ADMINISTRATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ME IF MCCURRY PARENTS AT CORE
CHARTER SCHOOL I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JACQUELINE RECOLLECT AIR
GRADUATED SPRINGS CHARTER SCHOOL
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BROWN MCCURRY FROM CORE CHARTER
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AMY ROBINSON PARENT IN SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR LITERACY FIRST
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KHAN MIKE MCCURRY I
GO TO COURT CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I'D STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DEBBIE BYER FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR LITERACY
FIRST CHARTER SCHOOLS K. TWELVE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HALEY BEAUPRE SCHOOL COORDINATOR
CHRIS MONTH SECONDARY SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SOPHIA CACKLE
ON THE STUDENT FROM INSPIRED
CHARTER SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
VERONICA BALMAIN SCHOOL
COORDINATOR FRIDAY -- CHARTER
SCHOOL I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JAMES CACO FROM INSPIRED CHARTER
SCHOOL IN A STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
JACKIE ROBINSON ALL TO SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SAID MONOCOT KINDS PART
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN RACHEL THOMAS
FOR ALL TO SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DURING A GENERAL OF JOHN ADAMS
ACADEMY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JODY JEFFERSON WESTERN TEAR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MOVING TO ALARM I HAVE --
CHILDREN IN CHARTER SCHOOL SO I
AYE OPPOSED TO SPILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TELLING **** AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DEAL.
PETER SAVILLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FORCED HER SCHOOL ON BEHALF OUR
WHOLE ORGANIZATION I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MICHAEL **** EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WESTERN SIERRA CHARTER SCHOOLS
PARENT CHOICE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SOUTH SIMPSON HOME SCHOOLING
PARENT OF ELEVEN YEARS WITH CORE
CHARTER WHICH WAS ALSO FORMALLY
KNOWN AS KEMPTVILLE ACADEMY.
ALSO AN EXTENSION OF CAN DEVELOP
CAT ME OUT OF THIS CITY OF
CANTON BILL.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNIFER MONTGOMERY TEACHER WITH
THE IDEA CHARTER SCHOOL TOO AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
ADMINISTRATOR WITH WESTERNS HERE
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MEYER WOOD SKIS AMERICAN INDIAN
MODEL SCHOOL CEO AND
SUPERINTENDENT AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
NANCY GARCIA ADMINISTER WESTERN
SIERRA TURNER'S SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANNEMARIE A ROW HAS TEACHER AT
THE CHARTER SCHOOL SAN DIEGO NO
POST THIS BILL.
MINDY CRYING ADMINISTRATOR
WESTERN TEARS CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM MEMBER DEVON AT SKI AND I
GO.
TO INSPIRED.
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RED MILLINERS RUN AND
THEN MY GRANDMA.
AND I'M VERY STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL AB. FIFTEEN ZERO SEVEN MY
NAME IS STEPHAN DEVON ASKING.
I GO TO INSPIRE CHARTER SCHOOL
[inaudible]
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
IT LOOKS GO FROM BOTH OF US DIE
SCHOOL STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY NAME IS THE WORD OF AN ESKY I
HAVE TWO KIDS THAT GOES INSPIRE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL.
I HAVE ENGLISH CO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS THE KEY TO SUMMON
OFTEN A STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
JEFF RICE WITH THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JACOB BEATING MENDER I'M A SELF
STARTER STUDENT OF ELEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AM I BEATING VENDOR A SOUTH THAT
OUR PARENT FOR ELEVEN YEARS AND
ALSO -- I RUN A CITRUS HEIGHTS
HOME SCHOOL GROUP AND WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED CHARTER
MEMBERS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MANY.
I NAMES J. C. B. MANDER.
I'VE BEEN IN THE CHARGES.
SCHOOL FOR FOUR YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TIMES JANE B. MENTOR AS I'M IN
THE HOST CULTURE.
IT'S ALSO THEIR CHURCH SCHOOL
AND I'VE BEEN IN IT.
FOR TEN YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARK AND I'M STUDENT
INSPIRED HER TO SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
TERROR ANY BEER MADERA COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME THIRTY ON A NEW CORA I
HAVE NINE THOUGH GOOD AND SOUNDS.
AND EYES I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NINETEEN OH SEVEN MICHELLE
MURPHY WITH THREE SIXTY
ACCELERATOR EDUCATION PARTNERS
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M A LITTLE MCCARTY -- MOM OF
THREE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM NOT TELLING THE KORAN I
HAVE A THREE KIDS.
HI A STRONG WAY A PAUSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MAX -- I'M SOON
ENOUGH CHARTER SCHOOL NEXT FROM
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M FROM MEETING ACADEMY CHARTER
SCHOOL MY NAME IS JOHN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EUNICE BEEN OVER --
MY NAME IS JENNIFER YOUNG FROM
NEW DAY ACADEMY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE AT THIS LINK -- MY
FOUR KIDS ATTENDING.
COULD MEAN TELL TO CHICKEN
DEMAND AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSING
GAY BI FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK
YOU.
I NAY KILEY.
IS PRETTY EXCITED TO BE HERE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE -- I'M FROM
NEW DAY ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX AND I AM FROM.
COMMUNITY OUT REACH ACADEMY
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ANTHONY I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS SIMON TO SEND GOING
FROM I'M GCC CHARTERS.
AND THE SHOWING OPPOSE.
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A RENO SEVEN NOW
AND WE ARE WITH -- INSPIRED
CHOATE CHARTER SCHOOL AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DOUBLE KARPOV I AM A
MOM OF SIX AND FIVE CONCERNED
CHARTER SCHOOL -- STROLLER
OPPOSING THIS BILL.
ROSALINA DERRY CHECK I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B..
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME'S IN
ACETIC I HAVE THRIVING KIDS WITH
INSPIRED TO STE -- CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND I REALLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS VERA TO THE NET SKI
AND I HAVE TWO CHILDREN FOR AN
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL THAT ARE
DRIVING AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH IS A
QUASI Là AND MY CHILDREN ARE
WITH REGION'S.
AN INDICATION HOME SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS NATURAL ABOUT MY
CHILDREN THE VISIONS EDUCATION
CHARTER SCHOOL IN STRONG APPLES
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS IT IN THE GOOD SHOULD
BE.
I AM ON OH FIVE MY KIDS -- BUT
THEN THE VISION INDICATION
SCHOOL AND A STRONG APPLE PULLS
HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DOUBLE COULD AMALA
I HAVE THREE KIDS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALLOWED TO MEET THREE
IF I'M STILL LEVELS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTORIA AND
I'M STRONG ABODE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GALINA AND I'M
STONE GATE OPPOSE THIS BILL AB
FIFTEEN ALL SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELAINE NINETY CUT
MY KIDS GRADUATED FROM THE
CHARTER SCHOOL CAN I DEFINITELY
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MY THE CAMELOT I
OPPOSE.
AB -- FIFTY SEVEN JENNIFER
HUMBLE WITH LEADING ACADEMY AYE
OPPOSED FIFTEEN A SEVEN MY NAME
IS EMMA CARE MELIK SACRAMENTO
STATE AND I'M AND I AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMY PORTER CHARTER
SCHOOL PARENT AND TEACHER WITH
SOUTH SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS YOU COULD DO NOT SURE
IF I MAMA OF TWO KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
A. B..
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
JORDAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SPILL.
HELLO EVERYONE HI MOM OF TWO
KIDS WHO HAVE ONLY CRYING ASKING
ME ASK ME TO SWITCH FROM PUBLIC
SCHOOL TO HOME SCHOOL.
AND I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VIANNA VOICE I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE BOYS AND WE HAVE
BEEN HOMESCHOOLING FOR SIX YEARS
AND IT'S BEEN A DELIGHT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND WE BELONG TO CORPS PLASTER
THAT JUST GOT DENIED BY THE WAY.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE LEAST OF IT
HAS AT INSURE CAM NAMA MOTHER OF
THREE AND ON BEHALF OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALEB AND AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NATALIE MADE HARD MY
CHILDREN ATTENDED A ACADEMY IN
REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
BRIAN IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S THESE ARRESTS MAN AND
I'M A PARENT AND A TEACHER AT
EPIC CHARTER SCHOOL IN LESS
SACRAMENTO AND THAT I'VE AYE
OPPOSED.
FIFTEEN AB FIFTY NOW SEVEN THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MADELINE SANDERSON
AND I AM A PARENT WITH CELLS ARE
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR SEVEN YEARS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN I'M MARC
GROSSMAN -- STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS
BILL AB FIFTY NO.
SEVEN MY NAME IS KATIE AND I
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THIS BILL. FIFTEEN CENTER.
I AM SURGERY THOSE GIVE HOLES
FIVE KEYS GO TO A PICTURE UP A
SCHOOL IN WEST SACRAMENTO ARE
STRUGGLING OPPOSE.
AB FIFTEEN ALSO.
MY NAME IS JASON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS BORIS -- FATHER
OF THREE KIDS AND ARE STRONGER
POLLS BILL. FIFTEEN OR SEVEN MY
NAME IS IS ABOUT JOHNSON WE HAVE
BEEN IT'S WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOL FOR FOUR YEARS NOW AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SELENA VOCAL FINISH
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
SELENA MONUMENTUM WORKING AND
YOU SEE SEE CHARTER AND MOTHER
OF THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRA BALK OF MY KIDS
GO TO CHARTER SCHOOL HAVE FOUR
KIDS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
A. B. FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GALINA TELEPHONE
AND I'M ALMOST -- TO THEY'RE
GOING HOME SCHOOL OUR CHAU KIDS
AND I'M OPPOSED THE BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS THE FINAL FIVE MOM
FOUR KIDS FIVE TRONG.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGELINA SLOBODAN YOU
AND I HAVE NIECES AND NEPHEWS
AND AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL FOR MY
FUTURE KIDS.
MY NAME IS CREDIT CARD CHECK AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME IS
WENDY MUSCLE BUT A NEW ITEM
ISN'T MY KIDS AND GRANDKIDS.
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALOMAR CHUCK AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN MY KIDS GO TO CHARTER
SCHOOL AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
PLEASE ACCEPT OUR OPPOSE ASIAN
THANK YOU.
I AM LIKE THE IS THE MOTHER OF
NINE SCHOOL INSPIRED AND I USE
THROWN THE OPALS.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OLGA SO IT I HAVE
FIVE BOYS AND I AM OPPOSED THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS DENNIS OLIVER CHECK
AND I HAVE TWO CHILDREN I WAS
HOME SCHOOLED AND I'M LOOKING
FOR A FUTURE.
TO HOME SCHOOL MY CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HELLO MY NAME
IS ALEXANDER IS A TO SHIP SCOTT
AND OPPOSED THE BILL AB FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MELA AND I AM HAVE
TWO CHILDREN WAS PLAYING TO HOME
SCHOOL IN THEM.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANASTASIA BEFORE
NEVER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DONNA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
FIFTEEN NURSING.
HELLO.
I NINE XIN ON **** SONOMA WHICH
HI APPLES IS A BILL [inaudible]
AB [inaudible] EIGHTEEN ALL
[inaudible]
SHEILA [inaudible]
YEAH.
MY NAME IS ALISON I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME ALLEN A PROFOUND
OFF AND APPLES THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANASTASIA BASIC
AND I AM MOM OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI.
MY NAME IS LEVEL SHERMAN LARGE
THE IDEA OF COURSE ISN'T.
REAL AB FIFTY IN.
A ZERO SEVEN HI MY NAME IS ON
NOT ONLY BASIC.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VERY CYBER AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL.
OF FIFTEEN ZERO SEVEN MY NAME IS
NATHAN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THE TALES OF THE
SHOW'S COUPLES HIS BILL A. B. IF
FIFTEEN THERE ARE SOME.
HI MY NAME IS MEL I'M ALMOST
THREE BOYS AND UP THROUGH
APPLE'S THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS YOUR LIFE I'M A
FATHER OF TWO KIDS AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA BISCAYNE
Mà FATHER OF THREE BOYS THIS
FROM THE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE TOWN I'VE
GOT OFF OF A AM PRESCHOOL
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JAMES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS SVETLANA A MOTHER OF
THREE KIDS -- AND INSPIRE
CHARTER SCHOOL I PULLED THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STEVEN AND I HAVE.
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA I'M A MOM OF
THREE CHILDREN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREA AND I AM
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE AND ALL SAM
FATHER OF SIX KIDS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GOOD.
NINETY I OPPOSE THIS BILL
FIFTEEN AB FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DELAYED A NURSE
ALIVE I'M A MOM OF THREE KIDS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLINE IS
TO BRING YOU A MOTHER OF TWO
KIDS I AM OPPOSE OF A BILL.
FIFTEEN ZERO SEVEN HELLO MY NAME
IS IGOR KNOWS LIFE I AM FATHER
OF THREE KIDS -- FROM WHERE
SACRAMENTO -- CHRISTIAN ACADEMY
AND I PULL UP POLLS THIS BILL
THINK.
HI MY NAME IS THE TEMAS ARE MY
MY MOM OF THREE BOYS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AB
FIFTY IN ALL.
SEVEN HI MY NAME IS NICK WATCH
I'M A FATHER OF FOUR KIDS.
ALL IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND AS ME AND MY FAMILY WILL
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TATIANA I AM A
MOTHER FOR KIDS TO OVERTURN A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AS BE.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HELLO MY NAME
IS YOU GET TO DO THIS AT SCHOOL
I AM A MOTHER OF TWO KIDS AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL A.
B..
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
BOB AND I'M A FATHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
TINA FEY ON FATHER'S TWO KEYS
AND POSE THESE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA SANDERS CAN
I AM A TEACHER'S AIDE AT CCC YES
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TOUCH ANALYST OF A
PUBLIC.
HEALTH NURSE I'M A MOTHER OF
FIVE KIDS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL FIFTEEN OH SEVEN THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VERONICA AND I
MOTHER OF TWO KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
MELA I AM A MOM OF TWO KIDS AND
I AM ANNUAL SO I'M STRONG LEVELS
BILL AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
ANNA VONDLE CAM MOM OF FIVE KIDS.
AND THREE GRANDKIDS I USED TO
WORK FOR A SCHOOL -- I A STRONG
WORKFORCE FIFTY IN THE ZERO
SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE SAUNA AND I'M
A NURSE AND A MOTHER OF FIVE
KIDS IN OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IT.
IN ORDER THE ELECTOR WHAT. ONE
GIVES AND I AM HOPE WAS A TO
THIS BILLS.
HELLO MY NAME IS AND THAT'S YOUR
CAR I HAVE FOUR KIDS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A LARSON I'M A
PARENT OF THREE INTO CHARTER
STUDENTS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA CHECK OUT
AND I'M ALMOST THREE CHILDREN
AND I AM POST.
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANGEL GARCIA I'M A
PARENT OF FOR CHEAP CHILDREN
INCLUDING ONE WITH A DISABILITY
ONE OF MY KIDS GOES TO SAVA.
IN SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LANA -- I'M ALSO.
I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL AT FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN YES ARE A THREE TWO I'M
SARAH CHRISTIAN.
THE MAYOR THREE MOVES TO DUTY I
HAVE THIRTEEN CHILDREN.
HE WOULD KNOW. SIXTEEN GRAND
CHILDREN WHICH IS SO FROM WITHIN.
PLEASE STAY ON SPEECH CORNELIA
PROCEED WITH THE RULES OF COURT.
AND MY GRAND KIDS ARE IN THE
CHRISTIAN PRIVATE SCHOOL AND I'M
AGAINST THIS BILL.
HI MY RING THAT -- HI MY NAME IS
SANDRA MELNICK -- I'M FATHER OF
TWO IS PIZZA I'M SO OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
HI MY REMOTE CHRISTIAN I'M A
NURSE AT KAISER I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN IN THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA BUNDLING
ONE OF I'M AN ON'T OF TWELVE
WONDERFUL CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS VERONICA RODAS
AND I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NELLIE I'M AN AUNT
OF THREE NAY FACE IN AYE OPPOSES
BUT HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE
CHOCOLATE I HAVE. TWO KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LANA CONTRA I HAVE
THREE KIDS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
SWITCHED AND HAVE TWO KIDS AND
THE POST THIS BILL.
HI THERE MY NAME IS ANA GREASY
I'M A NURSE I AM A MOTHER OF
FOUR KIDS I HOME SCHOOL I ALSO
HAVE A CHILD IN PRIVATE SCHOOL.
AND I POSE FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S MERRIAM OKAY AND
I HAVE FOUR CHILDREN AND I
PULLED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME UNITED A BIG -- I AM
POSITIVE FOR CHILDREN AYE
OPPOSED TO HIS BILL FIFTEEN ALL.
SEVEN HELLO MY NAME IS MADE TO
CONTINUE.
THANK SO I WHO OF FOUR CHILDREN.
A OPPOSE FIFTEEN JEFFERSON.
HELLO MY NAME'S ANALYST WHICH I
HAVE THREE CHILDREN ONE OF THEM
GOES TO EPIC CHARTER SCHOOL WEST
SACRAMENTO.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIJAH.
I'M A FATHER AND REPRESENTING A
LOT OF IMMIGRANTS WHO DON'T.
SPEAK ENGLISH BUT THEY ARE.
SPREADING YOU HEAR EVERYBODY
THERE SPREADING THE VOICE THEY'D
LIKE TO HAVE A CHOICE.
AND THEY'D LIKE CONCERNS ARE YOU
OPPOSED.
SEVEN YES YES -- POST.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA SO MUCH UP
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WILL GO UPSTAIRS.
I AND KRISTIN SHEPHERD I OPPOSE
THIS BILL LOCATION SHOULDN'T BE
LIMITATION.
HI I'M WENDY ACKLAND HOMESCHOOL
MOM OF THREE CHILDREN WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN VOLUNTEER AT HOME
SCHOOL CONSIDER SUPPORTING OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND CHARTER SCHOOL
HOME SCHOOLERS.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE LAST ONE IS IN LINE.
I'M CHRISTINE RAINER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE THERAPIST AND THE
HOME SCHOOL PARENT CHARTER
SCHOOL PARENT -- OF FIVE YEARS
AND I DEEPLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
POKEY FOR PACIFIC CHARTER
INSTITUTE BOARD MEMBER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD IN A
POSITION.
TO FIFTEEN ZERO SEVEN REX
FORTUNE FOUNDER FOURTEEN SCHOOL
OF EDUCATION AND BOARD MEMBER
PACIFIC CHARTER INSTITUTED
OPPOSED TO THE LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
HELLO I'M BACK DOWN GOD BLESS.
ONE HELLO MY NAME IS ANA I AM AN
ARTIST.
AND I AM A MOM AND POP AND AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK
BEHIND THE RAIL -- FOR QUESTIONS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
JUST WANTED.
I THINK.
MAYBE THE AUTHOR SHOULD CLARIFY
I DON'T THINK THIS BILLS AIMED
AT H
ANY FASHION AS IF WE'RE NOT
YOU'RE NOT SEEKING. TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM HOME SCHOOLING ARE
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER TERRY
PRETTY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLARIFY THAT SO -- WE ACTUALLY
ARE PLANNING ON WORKING ON ONE
ADDITIONAL SET OF AMENDMENTS
WHICH WOULD GRANDFATHER IN
EXISTING CHARTERS AND THAT MAY
BE WHAT SOME OF THIS OPPOSITION
IS SPEAKING TO OF THEIR CHOOSING
A HOMESCHOOL OPTION NOW THAT.
THAT MAY HAVE PRIOR BEEN LOCATED
OUTSIDE OF A DISTRICT WE ARE
GOING -- TO SEEK TO GO AHEAD AND
GRANDFATHER THOSE SO THAT WILL
BE ACCOMMODATED I'M AND WE ALSO
PLAN ON ADDING FLEXIBILITY RICK
REGARDING -- OPERATIONS AND
CITING AFTER NATURAL DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES AS WE RECENTLY
SIGNED PARADISE SOMETIMES
NECESSARY FOR CHARTER TO GO
AHEAD AND AND LOCATE OUTSIDE OF
ITS BOUNDARY -- IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION SO WE ARE GONNA BE
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT YOU
KNOW TO FURTHER CLARIFY AND AND
IN SEPARATION FROM THE PRIOR.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SERIES OF BILLS
IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED THIS HAS
BEEN A VEXING PROBLEM FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AN INITIAL
VERSION OF THIS BILL WAS
AUTHORED BY SENATOR PRACTICE FAN
FRIEND POWERFULLY IT WAS -- SB
TWELVE SIXTY THREE IT CLEARED
BOTH HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
UNFORTUNATELY WAS NOT SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN BECAUSE HAD IT
BEEN WE COULD HAVE STOP TO THOSE
ABUSES.
YEARS AGO AND WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY BUT THE ONGOING
CHALLENGE REMAINS AND YOU KNOW I
SAY ON BEHALF OF THE THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
THAT WENT THROUGH THIS ONE
CHALLENGE WITH THIS.
ONE AUTHORIZED -- AND AND ONE
BAD ACTOR IN THE CHARTER SPACE
WE SPENT WELL IN EXCESS OF A
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN NOT ONLY VETTING THIS CHARTER
PETITION BY HIRING ACCOUNTANTS
AND BY HIRING CONSULTANTS TO
REVIEW THEIR ACADEMIC PLAN BUT
ALSO IN WHAT WE SPENT IN LEGAL
COSTS.
IT STRAINED OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY
THE CHARTER AS A LOCATED WITHIN
OUR BOUNDARIES WERE NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS GOOD
NEIGHBORS THERE WERE TRAFFIC
ISSUES.
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE WERE
CONCERNS WHEN THE SCHOOL DID
CLOSE DUE TO THAT FINANCIAL
MISMANAGEMENT SO.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS THIS IS A
GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL THAT IS
LONG -- OVER DOOM AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I AGREE THAT IT IS LONG OVERDUE
AND I JUST.
I'LL SAY IT FOR YOU BUT YOU SAID
IT YOU'RE NOT SEEKING TO STOP
THEM FROM HOME SCHOOLING YOUR
CHILDREN.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT CAME
FROM BUT IT IS NOT TRUE.
IT IS NOT TRUE IF YOU HAVE BEEN
LED TO BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN LED DOWN THE WRONG PATH SO
WITH THAT -- THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND ARE THERE ANY TINO COMMENTS
MR KILEY THANK YOU.
OUR FIRST ONE THANK EVERYONE WHO
CAME TO TESTIFY TODAY -- I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY -- AND BUT
IT'S SO SO IMPORTANT THAT THE
AUTHORS THESE BILLS CONCEALED
UNDER PACKED UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT IT'LL HAVE ON YOU SO I
THINK SEVERAL IT CAME OUT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WHAT I DO JUST
HAVE A FEW PAN AYE AYE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND GOOD EVENING I
THINK FOR AN EVENING NOW -- BUT
YOU JUST SAID YOU WERE TAKEN AND
LOOKING AMENDMENT YOU TAKE --
THAT WOULD.
GRANDFATHER IN RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT ARE -- CURRENTLY OUTSIDE
THE BOUNDARIES OF THEIR
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT -- SO IT
ALSO GRANT YOU GRANDFATHER IN.
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE BOUNDARIES OF THEIR
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT WHETHER
THOSE ARE IN A DIFFERENT COUNTY
AND THE DISTRICT OP RESIN OR
WITHIN THE SAME COUNTY IS THAT
RIGHT.
THE FOR THOSE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
EXISTING WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THOSE DEFINITIONS LOOK LIKE
WE WE PLAN ON WORKING ON WITH
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL AS OUR
ALLIES IN MAKING SURE WE'VE GOT
SOME CLARITY ON THAT.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR THANK
YOU ON AND SO I I THINK I I FOR
YOUR ARGUMENT AS FAR AS WHY YOU
DON'T WANT -- RESOURCE CENTERS
OPERATING OUTSIDE THE DISTRICT
THEIR AUTHORIZED MISTER NORM BUT
WHAT IF THERE'S EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE THERE ARE
FACILITIES IN VAIL AVAILABLE
WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
AUTHORIZED INDUSTRY WITH THE
BILL ALSO PROHIBIT THAT.
WELL YEAH I MEAN UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
GREATEST ABUSES BEEN RIGHT IS
THAT IS THAT LITERALLY THAT
ASPECT OF THIS LOOPHOLE WAS
WHAT'S BEEN EXPLOITED -- AND YOU
KNOW THEY DID FOR TO GO INTO A
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT IN
NEIGHBORING COUNTY AND SAY WELL
THERE ARE FACILITIES AVAILABLE --
AND SO YEAH UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH
ABUSE IT WILL I THINK WE'RE AT
KNOW NOW I'M AND NUMBER OF THESE
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE REPRESENTING --
PLACES YOU KNOW VERY OFTEN IF
IT'S A RESOURCE CENTER NOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE ABLE TO FIND A
LOCATION IN A STRIP MALL
LOCATION AND BUSINESS CENTER
THAT KIND OF THING SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY
AROUND THE KIND OF SPACES ON
THAT THEY'D BE.
ABLE TO BE ACCOMMODATED IN DO
YOU THINK YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
WORK -- TO MAYBE -- MORE
STRICTLY RAIN IN WHAT YOU
PERCEIVE TO BE THE ABUSES
WITHOUT AT WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR SOME -- OPTION OF LOCATING
OUT OF DISTRICT EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES WELL I MEAN I
WOULD HOPE SO BUT AGAIN THIS IS
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING ON WITH AND PRIOR TO
HIS TENURE -- WITH THAT YOU KNOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS FOLKS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS I MEAN WE'VE
ASKED AND AND LITERALLY THE ONLY
RECOURSE MY DISTRICT WAS LEFT
WITH WAS LITIGATION.
WE ASKED WE DID WE WENT TO THE
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT AND ASK
THEM NOT TO AUTHORIZE WE ASK HIM
TO RECONSIDER -- AND IN MANY
CASES THERE THERE IS A LAB LEVEL
OF KIND OF ABSTINENCE AROUND
THIS MATTER AND THAT THAT HASN'T
REALLY GOTTEN US TO A GOOD PLACE
AND AND IS IS SIMPLY IS A MATTER
OF GOOD GOVERNANCE I MEAN IF YOU
THINK IF YOU WILL.
YOU KNOW IT THE SCHOOL BOARD IS
A MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT AND A
CITY IS A MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS
OF THE CITY ABOUT GROW SAID TO
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO WELL WE
NEED MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT WE
DON'T KNOW PLACE TO LOCATED
WITHIN OUR CITY SO WE'RE
BUILDING A NEW POLICE DEPARTMENT.
IN YOUR CITY.
BUT YOU HAVE NO OVERSIGHT OVER
IT YOU CAN'T CONTROL WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE COMINGS OR
GOINGS OF LOGISTICS OR THE
TRAFFIC AROUND IT I DON'T THINK
VERY MANY OF US WHO CARE ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD.
SUPPORT THAT RIGHT AND SO WE
NEED TO RESTORE THIS IDEA OF THE
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY OF A
SCHOOL BOARD AND THAT'S WHAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CRAFTED THIS IN A
WAY.
AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WAS ON BOARD BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BEEN ELECTED
TO DO THIS WORK. TO TRY TO HELP
THE STATE MANAGE THESE REALLY
PRECIOUS RESOURCES ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF THE SCHOOLS THAT
THEY AUTHORIZE AND REPRESENT SO
I FEEL LIKE THE TIME IS NOW TO
FOR ITS TO A LEASE CLOSE THE
CHAPTER ON THIS MATTER THAT WE
KNOW WE CAN GET TO NOW.
IN AND I I I JUST WANTED TO
THINK THAT -- THE AUTHOR AS WELL
FOR GREEN TO TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS AND MISTER COLLEY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS I
WILL SAY -- JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT.
THERE IS A GREAT NEED FOR
OVERSIGHT OF AUTHORIZES
PARTICULARLY.
SMALL AUTHORIZES AUTHORIZES THAT
MIGHT AUTHORIZED CHARTERS THAT
WITH A WITH AN ENROLLMENT THAT'S
LARGER THAN THEIR OWN -- WHICH
SHOULD INVITE SOME STREET
SCRUTINY BY SOME.
HIGHER AUTHORITY RIGHT I'M GONNA
REMEMBER YOU JUST SAID THAT WELL
LET'S LET'S I DON'T HEAR THAT
REALLY.
GOT IT DONE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU WERE SAYING I KNOW I
HONESTLY I DO APPRECIATE YEAH.
WELL INTO THE POINT WE HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL AND SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THAT
NEED AS WELL WE HAVE STRUGGLING
RURAL DISTRICTS IN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WHOSE COSTS OF
OPERATION DON'T CHANGE
NECESSARILY IN RELATION TO
EIGHTY A DIMINISHMENT RIGHT.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
THEY HAVE TO KEEP A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF STAFF BASED ON
STUDENTS THAT THEY HAVE WE'VE
GOT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AS A
FUNDING CHALLENGE ON OUR IN TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING THAT
IS A PIECE OF THIS OVERALL
CONVERSATION AS WELL.
YEAH AND THE LAST THING IS THAT
THERE'S A SEPARATE VERSION OF
THE BILL THAT SAYS THAT EVEN IF
YOU'RE RESOURCE CENTERS WITHIN
THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT YOU CAN
ONLY HAVE ONE OF THEM.
YEAH WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR THAT.
WELL WE'RE HOPING THAT ONE
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT RIGHT I
MEAN WHAT WE KIND OF WANT TO NOT
HAVE TO DO IS BE PLAYING THE GO
FOR GAME AS RESOURCE CENTERS POP
UP ALL OVER THE PLACE IT'S
EASIER FOR AN AUTHORIZED OR TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT ON AND MAINTAIN
YOU NO.
ISSUES WITH QUALITY AND SAFETY
AT THAT ONE RESOURCE CENTER SAYS
IT'S A MATTER AGAIN OF A LINE OF
SIGHT AND EFFECTIVE
AUTHORIZATION I CAN SEE HOW
MAYBEIT THAT YOU KNOW.
MIGHT MAKE SOME SENSE FOR REALLY
COMPACT DISTRICT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT RURAL AREAS THAT THAT WE'RE
TALKING LARGE AMOUNTS OF
TERRITORY POTENTIALLY FOR ONE
DISTRICT AND SO YOU FEEL CAN
ONLY HAVE ONE THAT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A LOT OF KIDS WHO.
GOT TO DRIVE A LONG WAY JUST TO
GET THERE SO LET ME ONE WELL
WHICH IS ALSO A CHALLENGE FOR
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD PUBLIC SCHOOLS
RIGHT IN IN AREAS LIKE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT CERTAINLY SOME A PLACE WE
CAN GO.
IN THE FUTURE.
SO YOU'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT
POTENTIALLY -- MODIFYING THAT
PROVISION TO ALLOW FOR MORE THAN
ONE RESOURCE CENTER WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE NOT AT THIS
TIME BECAUSE I THINK THIS LEVEL
OF CLARITY AND SPECIFICITY IS
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE AND HOW
PEOPLE ACTING IN GOOD FAITH.
BUT GOING FORWARD WITH BOTH.
TRADITIONAL NEIGHBORHOOD SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOLS OF CHOICE I THINK WE
WANT TO BE LOOKING AT ACCESS AND
DISTANCE RELATIVE TO WHERE FOLKS
LIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS -- YOU MAY.
CLOSE THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
MISTER KALRA MOVES MISTER
MCCARTY SECONDS -- YOU MAY CLOSE.
I'M AYE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THREE TIMES AFTERNOON AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE MY VOTE --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
GOES TO PASS AS AMENDED.
THE MISSION IS TO PASS AS A
MINUTE TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
O'DONNELL HI BUT ON ALL I KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE SO IT IS
OUT IT PASSED.
REMOVES THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
JUST TO RECALL AFTER THE MOTION
TO DO WANT ME TO ROOM
[inaudible]
SHE CAN.
DO WE NEED THE REASON.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE SECRETARY RIPLEY'S -- THIS
SECTION WILL READ THE MOTION AND
CALL THE ROLL.
WE NEED A MOTION MISS SMITH
MOVES -- MISTER KALRA SECONDS
THAT'S THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. THIRTY DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE
ITEM FIVE AB TWO SEVEN TWO
SEVENTY TWO TWO FASTER
PREPARATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
BE TAKEN AND APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM SIX AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN OH
NINE DO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN TO
PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB TWELVE
FORTY TWO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETEEN YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKING AN APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN AB. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE DO PASSED TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY I'D KALRA.
ALL RIGHT I AM A PARTY.
MCCARTY I'D SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I SIX LOW SIX ARE THE
CONSENT CAN ARE SIX VOTES IT IS
OUT WILL NOW MOVE -- TO YEAH
AGAIN AB -- TWELVE FOURTEEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN THIS ONE IS.
WHO'S BEEN WAITING SOMEWHAT
PATIENTLY ALONG WITH HER -- TEAM
HERE TODAY I'M SORRY IT JUST
TOOK A LONG TIME FOR DEMOCRACY
TO GET TO THIS POINT TODAY.
SO -- THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT WAITING IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- AT
MY WITNESSES HAVE BEEN HERE ALL
DAY AND THEY HAVE A PLANE TO
CATCH SO UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAVE
TO LEAVE AT SIX FORTY FIVE SO
I'M GOING TO JUST ROLL RIGHT
THROUGH THIS IF YOU DON'T MIND
DOING -- I WANT TO BEGIN MY
TESTIMONY FIRST BY ACCEPTING THE
IT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS CURRENT
THINK CHAIR FOR HIS ASSISTANCE
IN CRAFTING THE BILL IN THIS WAY
THIS BILL DOES TOO SIMPLE THINGS.
FIRST IT WILL REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CPR TRAINING AND
SECOND IT REQUIRES CREDENTIALED
EDUCATORS TO PROVIDE A VALID CPR
CERTIFICATE. TO THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING WHEN IT
COMES TIME FOR THEM TO RENEW
THEIR THEIR CREDENTIALS I AM
GOING TO REFER THE REST OF MY
TIME TO MY WITNESS WHO IS HERE
TO SPEAK TODAY I'M.
SABRINA PEERS AND AND HER
HUSBAND RODRIGUEZ PEERS ARE HERE
TO SPEAK -- THEY ARE THE WHOLE
REASON FOR THIS BILL -- AND I
WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
THEM.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS SABRINA
PIERCE AND I AM THE MOTHER OF
ALEX PIERCE.
MY BLONDE HAIR BLUE EYED FRECKLE
FACED SWEET BOYS WOULD BE WITH
HIS FAMILY RIGHT NOW.
FIDGETING IN HIS SEAT SMILING
AND JOKING AROUND WITH US IF
SOMEONE AT THE SCHOOL ANYONE HAD
PERFORMED CPR ON MY SON.
IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ALEX WAS A SEVENTH GRADE STUDENT
SWIMMING AT A SCHOOL SPONSORED
PARTY AT THE HIGH SCHOOL POOL
WITH HIS CLASSMATES WHEN HE
SLIPPED UNDER THE WATER WHILE
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
MARIETTA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT STAFF AND PERSONAL.
IT WASN'T THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
STAFF PERSONNEL.
OR EVEN THE LIFEGUARDS THAT CAME
TO MY SON'S IMMEDIATE RESCUE IT
WAS HIS MIDDLE SCHOOL CLASSMATES
THAT PULLED HIM FROM THE BOTTOM
OF THE POOL.
AND DELIVERED HIM TO LIFEGUARDS
WHO MISSY VALUE WAITED HIS
TREATMENT AND PLACE THEM ON A
FLOATING BACKBOARD IN THE POLL
WITHOUT CHECKING HIS AIRWAY HIS
BREATHING HIS CIRCULATION OR
REMOVING HIM FROM THE POOL TO
ADMINISTER CPR.
MY SON WAS ONLY UNDER WATER FOR
TWO MINUTES.
BUT WAS WITHOUT OXYGEN FOR NINE
MINUTES.
ONLY ONE TEACHER AT THE POOL
PARTY WAS CPR CERTIFIED HE
CLAIMED HE WAS NOT WORKING AT
THIS TIME.
IF SOMEONE ANYONE HAD PERFORM
CPR AND ALEX HE WOULD BE WITH US
TODAY TO SHARE HIS STORY OF
SURVIVAL AND HE WOULD CELEBRATE
HIS SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY IN
AUGUST.
INSTEAD I STAND BEFORE YOU NOW
IS A MOTHER WITH THE SUPPORT OF
MY FAMILY AND AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE MILLIONS OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN LIKE ALEX.
WHOSE PARENTS AND TRUST THE
SAFETY OF THEIR CHILD TO THEIR
SCHOOL.
SHOULDN'T SCHOOL DISTRICT STOCK
AND PERSONAL BE EQUIPPED WITH
ALL THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THAT CHILD
AND EVEN SAVE A CHILD'S LIFE IN
A MEDICAL EMERGENCY.
CHILDREN ARE IN SCHOOL FOR MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND EIGHTY SIX
HOURS EACH SCHOOL YEAR THEY
SPEND MORE TIME IN SCHOOL AND
THEY DO IN THEIR OWN HOME.
CPR IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TOOL.
IN A MEDICAL EMERGENCY BOTH ON
AN OFF CAMPUS WHAT IF YOUR
CHILD HAD AN ASTHMA ATTACK.
ON A SCHOOL FIELD TRIP OR HEART
FAILURE RECESS OR DROWNED AT A
SCHOOL SPONSORED SWIM PARTY LIKE
MY ALEX.
I SERVED SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE
NAVY AND MY HUSBAND SERVE.
NINE BOTH OF US THOUGHT THAT
WHILE WE WERE FIGHTING FOR OUR
COUNTRY OUR CHILDREN WOULD BE
SAFE AND SOUND IN SCHOOL.
NO PARENT SHOULD GET A PHONE
CALL SAYING THAT YOUR SON OR
DAUGHTER IS ON THEIR WAY TO THE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE OF AN ACCIDENT.
AT SCHOOL AND THEY DON'T KNOW IF
HE OR SHE IS GOING TO MAKE IT.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE AND NO ONE
WOULD EVER KNOW HOW BROKEN WE
FEEL UNLESS THEY'VE LOST A CHILD
THEMSELVES.
AS A PARENT YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOUR CHILD THE STEEP AT
SCHOOL AND THE STAFF SUPERVISING
YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER KNOWS WHAT
TO DO WHEN A MEDICAL EMERGENCY.
HOW AND WHEN TO PERFORM CPR IS A
BASIC LIFE SAVING SKILL?
THAT SHOULD BE REQUIRED OF ALL
ADULTS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILD WHILE THE
CHILD IS IN HIM OR HIS OR HER
CARE.
EVERY TIME OUR CHILDREN WERE
DISCHARGED FROM THE NECK YOU WE
HAD TO LEARN CPR AND FIRST AID.
WHY IS THIS NOT A BASIC TEACHING
REQUIREMENTS?
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ENSURE
THE BASIC SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN
DURING A MEDICAL EMERGENCY AT
SCHOOL AND CPR INSTRUCTION
SHOULD BE REQUIRED OF ALL
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF.
MY FAMILY AND I ARE STEADFAST IN
OUR FIGHT TO ENSURE THAT NO
PARENT OR FAMILY SUFFERS.
THE LOSS OF A CHILD LIKE WE HAVE.
WE ARE THANKFUL FOR ASSEMBLY ONE
MELINDA'S IN DRAFTING THIS BILL
AND FOR HER DEDICATION
ADVOCATING FOR FAMILIES TO
ENTRUST SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THE SAFETY OF THEIR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS -- DOES
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO SPEAK I
THINK SHE PRETTY MUCH SAID IT
ALL FOR EVERYONE I BELIEVE SO
WE'RE SORRY EVERY TRAGEDY -- ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
ISABEL GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE FIRST WANT TO EXTEND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES AND
SYMPATHIES TO MR MRS PIERCE.
ON FOR THEIR AND THEIR
PASSIONATE ADVOCACY WHICH WE
SHARE.
AND WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT.
CPR IS AN IMPORTANT LIFE SKILL
FOR EVERYONE.
BUT IN PARTICULARLY FOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND WE'RE ONLY OPPOSING THE
PROVISION IN THE BILL EVEN WITH
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
ON AT THAT PLACE IS AN UNRELATED
ON CERTIFICATED STAFF.
THAT BEFORE THEY RENEW THEIR
CREDENTIALS THEY HAVE TO TAKE A
CPR.
CLASS AND WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE WHETHER THEY'RE
CERTIFICATED OR NON CERTIFICATED.
SHOULD HAVE -- DISTRICT PROVIDED
CPR TRAINING.
AND I CALLED A FEW LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
REQUIRE CPR TRAINING FOR THEIR
SECRETARIES FOR THEIR COACHES
AND THEIR HEALTH TEACHERS.
OTHERS REQUIRED FOR DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND THEY'VE PROVIDED OR
THEY REIMBURSE.
SO WE ARE SAYING THAT FOR THE
BEST INTEREST OF STUDENTS.
DISTRICTS SHOULD BE PROVIDING
CPR FOR ALL THEIR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE DISTRICT.
THAT WERE THIS TRAGEDY HAPPENED
THE POSTPONEMENT THEY ARE WE
PROVIDING CPR FOR ALL OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
WE'RE SAYING THAT'S WHERE THE
BILL SHOULD BE AND WE'RE WE'RE
OPEN TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS.
TO BRING THE BILL TO THAT PLACE
AND NOT.
PUT UP IN AN UNRELATED BEER
YOU'RE IN THE CREDENTIALING
PROCESS WHICH IS ALREADY
COMPLICATED AS TO DO.
AND WE'RE STAYING YOU'RE ONLY
REACHING SOME OF THIS EMPLOYEES
AND NOT ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES --
SO WE'RE SEEING THAT IT SHOULD
BE IT FOR THE NON CERTIFICATED
IN THE CERTIFICATED STAFF AND
THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE BILL GO AND AGAIN WE'RE
HOPING. TO TO WORKING WITH YOU
GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET TO THAT PLACE AND IT'S
FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU --
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN OTHERS IN OPPOSITION BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED -- MISTER KALRA
SECONDS.
NOW MISMAS SECOND SECONDS --
WITH THAT -- MOTIONS TO PASSED
YOU APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY --
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE -- THE OPPOSITION
COMING FOR IN STATING WHAT THEIR
ISSUE IS WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS ISSUE --
WE DISAGREE IN THAT -- THAT CPR
IS JUST A LIFE SAVING SKILL NOT
SOMETHING NECESSARY -- FOR
EDUCATORS TO HAVE WE ON THIS
SIDE OF THE TABLE WE DISAGREE
WITH THAT AS A PARENT I DISAGREE
WITH THAT -- IN THIS BILL
THERE'S NOTHING STOPPING A
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM OFFERING
CPR TO EVERYONE WITHIN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROHIBIT THAT SO -- THE
CONCERN THAT THE OPPOSITION HAD
THAT IT SHOULD BE OPEN TO
EVERYONE THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
CAN OFFER THAT DIFFERENCE WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN AND APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
CALLER I AM MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I SIX OF THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT BILL IT'S AB EIGHT TEN
TWELVE IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN IT'S MISS RAISING
FRAWLEY REMAINING AUTHORS --
MISTER ROSS I THOUGHT THAT WAS
PULLED.
OKAY MISTER RAMOS YOU MAY COME
FOR YOU LOOK SHOCKED OR WHEN HE
SAID THAT WITH.
THOSE. FOUR SEVEN ONE YEAH YEAH
YOU.
THE BILL STILL GOOD FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB.
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY RECOGNIZING THAT I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS -- AB THIRTY FOUR SIX
TO CENTRALIZE THE BULLYING AND
HARASSMENT PREVENTION RESOURCE
THE LEGISLATION LEGISLATURE HAS
WORKED ON THIS MANY YEARS.
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS BODY
HAVE WORKED VERY HARD TO MAKE
SUFFICIENT STRIDES ON BILLION IN
HARASSMENT PREVENTION.
EVEN SO BILLION REMAINS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
RULING IS A WIDESPREAD AND
PERVASIVE APPROXIMATELY 28% OF
STUDENTS IN GRADES SIX THROUGH.
TWELVE HAVE EXPERIENCED BULLYING
AND 70% OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
WITNESSES WITNESS PULLING.
STUDENTS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS ESPECIALLY THE ALGAE
PT Q. STUDENTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY FACE BULLYING
AND CYBERBULLYING AROUND 14%.
OF STUDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED
CYBER BULLYING. 55% OF L. G. B.
T. Q. STUDENTS HAVE REPORTED
BEING [inaudible]
CYBER BULLYING.
BOWLING CAN LEAD TO DEPRESSION
AND IN SOME CASES SELF HARM OR
SUICIDE.
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE AGES FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR IN THE UNITED STATES.
WITH A NATIONWIDE SURVEY FINDING
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT ONE
IS SIX HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
REPORTEDLY SERIOUS REPORTED
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING.
SUICIDE IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR AND
MORE THAN ONE IN TWELVE REPORTED
ATTEMPTING IT.
IN MY DISTRICT THAT CAUSED US TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS BILL TO
LOOK TO A HANDBOOK TO BE OUT
THERE FOR RESOURCES.
THERE ARE SIX INDIVIDUALS THAT
TOOK THEIR OWN LIVES IN THE
ASSEMBLY FORTIETH DISTRICT IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
SCHOOLS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PRODUCE A RANGE OF
RESOURCES ON BULLYING AND
HARASSMENT PREVENTION.
HOWEVER THESE ROY RESOURCES ARE
CURRENTLY SCATTERED BETWEEN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WEBSITES AND
REQUIREMENTS TO INFORM WITHIN A
REQUIREMENTS TO INFORM PARENTS
AND STUDENTS.
AB THIRTY FOUR SIXTY UNIFIED
STATE AND LOCAL RESOURCES INTO A
SINGLE LANDING PAGE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO PARENTS AND
STUDENTS SEEKING OUT HELP.
FROM THEIR SCHOOL AND LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS BILL WILL BUILD ON THE WORK
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN CONTINUE
THE ONGOING PROCESS OF FIGHTING
BULLYING.
BULLY WILL NOT END OVERNIGHT IN
THE PROCESS OF ENDING BULLY WILL
REQUIRE A CONSISTENT AND
CONSTANT PROCESS OF SOCIAL
CHANGE.
I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONTINUE AND CONTINUE WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible] SIX THE ONE
REPRESENTS REPRESENTING RING CAM
IN PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
GIVE ME FRIGGING DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
MR MCCARTY SECONDS SAYING NO --
THE FOR THE COVER THE COMMITTEE --
THE MOTION IS. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK ADMITTED ON THEIR ARMS
WILL BE TAKEN IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SO YES
[inaudible]
THAT'S RIVAL.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS AT WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN AND
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THOSE FOUR VOTES TO IT
IS OUT THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OR MOVE -- TO MISS RANTS AB. TEN
TWELVE FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TODAY PRESENT AB TEN TWELVE A
BILL WHICH WILL MAKE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
BILINGUAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
EARLY CHILDHOOD TO TWELFTH GRADE.
RESEARCH SHOWS FLUENCY IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES BENEFITS
CHILDREN STUDENTS BY BROADENING
THEIR COGNITIVE FLEXIBILITY IN
ENHANCING THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN.
HEALTHY EARLY DEVELOPMENT AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT GIVE
STUDENTS THE GREATEST CHANCES.
FOR SIX FOR LIVE SUCCESS.
GIVING CHILDREN STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME BUYER
MULTI LINGUAL.
CONFERS GREAT BENEFITS ON THEM
AS INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORK FORCE
AS WELL AS IN OUR STATE.
AS A GLOBAL ECONOMIC COMPETITOR.
THE SKILLS FUEL OUR ECONOMY AND
STRENGTHEN OUR SOCIAL COHESION
IN REACHING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF BENEFIT OF
LEARNING MULTIPLE LANGUAGES WHEN
THEY OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION FOR GLOBAL ECONOMY
INITIATIVE.
WITH ME TO DISCUSS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS ISSUE
FURTHER IS KATIE MIDDLEBROOK A
SEAL COACH FACILITATOR IN THE
OAK GROVE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ALONGSIDE HER.
IS ANNA.
YOUR COMMITTEES.
EDGE.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS KATIE
MIDDLEBROOK AND I AM PLEASED TO
BE HERE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I HAVE -- I AM WORKING IN THE
OAK GROVE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
AM SERVING AS A COACH
FACILITATOR SUPPORTING OUR
BILINGUAL PROGRAMS DISTRICT WIDE.
AS WELL AS THIRTEEN TEACHERS AT
MY SCHOOL SITE.
I AM HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN TWELVE AND THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TO ENSURE.
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN CONTINUES TO BE
BROUGHT TO LIFE.
AS THEY SAY IF YOU BUILD IT.
THEY WILL COME AND PEOPLE ARE
COMING.
AS PART OF A TEAM I'VE CHAMPION
THE RIGHTS OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE
WELL ARTICULATED EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM FOR PRESCHOOL TO GRADE
SIX AT LEAST.
THE SCHOOL THAT I SUPPORT WILL
BE EXPANDING BY TWO GRADE LEVELS
IN THE NEXT YEAR. 91% OF THE
PARENTS IN OUR DISTRICT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF BILINGUAL EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS FROM T. K. TWO GRADES.
EIGHT OUR TWO WAY BILINGUAL
PROGRAM IS GROWING FASTER THAN
WE CAN HOUSE IT.
AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
OVERFLOW CHILDREN FROM THAT.
SCHOOL -- YES THE CHILDREN ARE
COMING AND FAMILIES WANT TO SEE
BILINGUAL EDUCATION BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THAT'S ONE OF THREE BI LEVEL
COACHES IN OUR DISTRICT WE SEE
THE NEEDS.
WE ACTUALLY RECRUIT ARE
BILINGUAL FRIENDS FROM OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
YEAR ROUND WHICH DOESN'T HELP
THOSE STUDENTS OR THOSE PROGRAMS.
WE NEED MORE TEACHERS.
AND WE CAN'T FIND THEM WE LOOKED
WE WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY IS TO
TRY TO RECRUIT AND THERE WERE
FEWER TEACHERS WHO ARE CERTIFIED
BILINGUAL TO RECRUIT FROM.
SO THAT LEADS US TO ANOTHER
PROBLEM. THIRTEEN OF THE SEVENTY
THREE STUDENTS IN THE BILINGUAL
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PIPELINE THAT YOU HAVE ALREADY
FUNDED.
OUR FROM OUR DISTRICT.
FLUENT SPEAKING PASSIONATE
BILINGUAL TEACHERS HAVE BEGUN TO
REDEDICATE THEMSELVES TO THE
VISION OF A BI LITERATE
COMMUNITY.
OUR PARA PROFESSIONALS WHO WANT
TO BECOME EDUCATORS BUT DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDING.
NEED TO HAVE SOME FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY THE OUR NEXT
WITNESS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANA AND
COMMITTEES FROM EARLY AGE
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF LEAVE BEHIND ME THE
DIRECTOR OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION -- WHO HAD
TO LEAVE EARLY -- THERE IS AS
STATED BY THE AUTHOR THIS BILL
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR THE START
OF AN EXPANSION OF DUAL
IMMERSION PROGRAMS BEGINNING IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD AND I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANT IN NEED
FOR THESE THE IMPORTANCE ANY FOR
THESE INVESTMENTS. TO A LANGUAGE
LEARNERS REPRESENT 60% OF
CHILDREN BIRTH TO AGE FIVE IN
OUR STATE AND STUDIES SHOW THE
DRAWING WHICH ON YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN DUAL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS EARLY IN THEIR ACADEMIC
CAREER.
OUTPERFORM THEIR PEERS AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL COMPARED TO STUDENTS
IN ENGLISH ONLY PROGRAMS -- THE
PROGRAM IN THE FRESNO COUNTY
RUNS IS THE LIGHT HOUSE FOR
EARLY EACH THE LIGHT HOUSE FOR
CHILDREN EARLY EDUCATION CENTER
WHICH OFFERS DUAL LANGUAGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN
THROUGH PRESCHOOL -- IN THE
PROGRAM THEY'VE SEEN A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON CHILDREN'S ORAL
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS
THE NUMBER ONE PREDICTOR OF
LATER SCHOOL ACHIEVEMENT.
THEY'VE ALSO SEEN INCREDIBLE
GAINS IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH.
AS A DUAL LANGUAGE PROGRAM
PROVIDER FRESNO COUNTY IS
EXPERTS TO BE THE LIGHT HOUSE IS
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND THE
CHALLENGES FACED IN ESTABLISHING
A QUALITY EDUCATION PROGRAM --
AS REFERENCE MINAKO WITNESS.
AB TEN TWELVE AND WOULD PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING THESE BARRIERS.
AND TO ESTABLISH A SOUND FISCAL
FOUNDATION FOR EFFECTIVE IN
QUALITY TO A LANGUAGE PROGRAMS
BEGINNING IN PRESCHOOL WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WELL DONE -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC THIS YEAR
AGO CITY AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION WORK CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M WITH BROAD HAS
ALSO FROM -- CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND WE ARE CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AND WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
A SINGLE OPPOSITION -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISS SMITH.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
THE SPONSORS FOR THIS VERY
TIMELY PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE DECIDED TO GO
A WHOLE HEARTEDLY INTO DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION OFFERINGS AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS.
AND WITH THAT I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND MISS
MCCARTY WISHES SECOND YOU HAVE
CALM YEAH A SECOND AND ALSO I
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER THIS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IN
THE BUDGET AS YOU KNOW MISTER
DONALD. TO INVEST IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN TWO
LANGUAGE INSTRUCTION IN THE
VOTERS SPOKE LOUD AND CLEAR IT
PROP FIFTY EIGHT THIS ISN'T.
THE BILINGUAL EDUCATION FROM
TWENTY YEARS AGO THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE OUR LEARNERS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW ARE LITERATE
IN MORE THAN ONE LANGUAGE THAT'S
A FUTURE IN THIS GLOBAL
WORKPLACE SO.
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THIS IS A BILL THAT HAS A MONEY
COSTS I KNOW WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS AS WE GO ALONG.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- THE MOTION IS.
YET ONE MORE YOU GUYS LEVEL IS
JUST A QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE I
KNOW WE HAVE TIME ISSUES --
WOULD LIKE WHICH IS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
ALL.
WHATEVER THE LANGUAGES MOST
PEOPLE THINK THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT BI LINGUAL.
IT'S SPANISH AND ENGLISH THAT IS
THE MAJORITY BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL THE LANGUAGES.
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- OFFER A
CANTONESE PROGRAM THERE ARE ALSO
ARMENIAN PROGRAMS DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES SO IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
YOUR POPULATION VIETNAMESE COME
I MEAN ARE YOU LOOKING.
YEAH ARE YOU LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF DOING IT
OTHER THAN JUST.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A CHALLENGE
TO TRY TO FIND BILINGUAL
TEACHERS OBVIOUSLY.
AND IF EVERYONE HAS TO HAVE A
BILINGUAL TEACHER THAT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE -- I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME GERMAN PROGRAMS WHERE.
WHERE WHERE THERE'S A TRADE OFF
EVERY EVERY WEEK IN SO THAT ONLY
HALF OF THE STAFF AS THE HIT
SPEAK GERMAN AND THEY DO
EXTREMELY WELL?
YOU KNOW SO THAT I THINK BECAUSE
I THINK IT DELAYS US TO KEEP
THINKING THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE IT
A A A TEACHER WHO SPEAKS TWO
LANGUAGES IN EVERY CLASSROOM.
AND DOG I WAS IMPRESSED WITH THE
THE EINSTEIN ACADEMY IN SAN
DIEGO AND HAD SOME FRIENDS KIDS
IN AND WHERE.
EVERY OTHER WEEK ONE WEEK THEY
WERE WITH THE GERMAN TEACHER THE
NEXT WEEK THEY WERE WITH THE
ENGLISH SPEAKING TEACHER AND THE
REALITY WAS THAT IF THEY ONLY
pGERMAN.
AND THE KIDS ALL CAME UP
BILINGUAL SO I'M JUST SAYING
THAT NUMBER OF MODELS TO LOOK AT
AND SO RATHER THAN SLOW US DOWN
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL IN FAVOR OF IT.
WE NEED LOOK AT SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVE MODELS RATHER THAN
EVERY TEACHER HAVING TO BE IN
SCHOOL VIOLENCE.
YEAH BUT I SUPPORT THE THE
EFFORTS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING WE'LL LOOK
INTO THAT.
TOO CAN YOU DID AGREE TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS.
YES OKAY WITH THAT -- WITH THAT
WITH THAT -- AS CHAIR WE HAVE
SEEN THE LANGUAGE BUT WE DO I'VE
GOT A WHOLE LIST OF AMOUNTS HERE
YOU JUST PRESENTED YOU JUST TOLD
ME EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS YOU
ACCEPT THE MEMBERS ARE NOT.
I DO OKAY BUT I HAVE A FRIEND
THAT'S GONNA.
OKAY.
SO THE MOTION IS -- DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- AS AMENDED --
PLEASE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE OKAY.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YEAR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
CALLER I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I BILL IS FIVE OH TODAY'S
OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- THAT MISS
A REVERSE I SEE YOU OUT THERE
DON'T SEEM AS GONZALEZ.
SHE WOULD BE UP HAS SHE BEEN
HERE BUT YOU BETTER GET UP TO
THAT MICROPHONE BECAUSE I KNOW
HER [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NO -- MISS REVERSES AB --
SIXTEEN TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR BUT AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN I ONE THIRTY
FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT AND
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL -- TODAY I'M
HAPPY POST TO BE AMENDED THE
BILL WILL APPLY ONLY TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF BULLYING AND
WILL ALLOW THEM TO TRANSFER. TO
ANOTHER SCHOOL WITHIN THE
DISTRICT AS LONG AS THE OTHER
SCHOOL HAS THE CAPACITY TO
ACCEPT A NEW STUDENT.
IF THERE ARE NO OPTIONS TO
TRANSFER WITHIN THE DISTRICT
THIS MEASURE WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
STUDENT WAS A VICTIM OF BULLYING
TO APPLY FOR A TRANSFER OUTSIDE
OF THE DISTRICT.
WHICH THE SCHOOL OF ORIGIN
CANNOT REJECT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW.
THAT ALLOWS STUDENTS TO TRANSFER
WITHIN AND OUT OF THE DISTRICT.
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT A
TRANSFER WILL BE GRANTED.
GIVEN THE DATA PROVING THE
PREVALENCE OF BULLYING AND THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS HOUSE.
ON STUDENT SUCCESS AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN WILL PROVIDE MORE
ASSURANCE TO BOTH THE STUDENTS.
AND THE PARENTS AND THEY WILL BE
ALLOWED TO ATTEND A NEW SCHOOL --
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE WITH ME MIKE BELOW WHO
REPRESENTS THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL OKAY THANK YOU.
REAL QUICK OKAY I I HAD YOU ON
OUR REVERSE NOT.
TELL REVES -- CAM HE NEEDS TO
PUT IN OUR EVERY TIME YOU WRITE
HIS NAME.
DOWN IN THIS BUILDING -- SO
WHERE AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE IS AT AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN SO GOOD
KIDS WHO RUN AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE SO YOU DIDN'T PICK UP
THAT I CALLED THE WRONG BILL
NUMBER BUT I DID AT SOME POINT
SO WITH THAT YOUR WITNESS THANK
YOU OKAY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
VERY VERY BRIEFLY MIKE BELOVED
FOR GOVERNED FOR CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE.
IN WORKING WITH US ON THIS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THE
LARGE AND GROWING PROBLEM OF
BULLYING THIS MAKES IT A LITTLE
EASIER FOR A STUDENT TO CHANGE
SCHOOLS AFTER A PROVEN.
THAT DEMONSTRATION OF BULLYING --
AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JERRY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE WERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
PLUS YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION OVER IT AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SINGLE COMMON FOR MANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THE MOVE BY MISS SMITH SECOND MY
MISTER MCCARTY -- THE MOTION IS --
SUPPORT AS AMENDED.
I'M SORRY TO PASS.
AND YOU DO ACCEPT THEM AS YOU
STATED THAT A PLEASE CALL YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
IT HAS AS AMENDED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS IS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
O'DONNELL.
HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KALRA [inaudible]
KARAI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I CLOSE FIVE ALSO IS OUT
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE -- TO SECONDS OUT
MISS GONZALEZ I DON'T SEE HER.
I'VE GOT OUR REAVIS.
OKAY -- NOT HERE MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE.
UP NEXT.
AND THEN YEAH.
YOU MAY PERCEIVE IN RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS SUPPORTED BOTH BY
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
BY CHARTER SCHOOL ADVOCATES.
AND YOU KNOW I I I I I HAD
BUSLOADS OF OF SUPPORTERS HERE
BUT I THINK THEYALL WENT HOME
READY.
SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
VERY LONG DAY THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL.
CONSIDERATION I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
NINE THE BILL THAT REFERS TO
WHAT MAKES YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND WHAT MISTER MCCARTY REFERRED
TO EARLIER THAT.
WE WOULD BE AVOIDING A LOT OF
THE ALL THESE PROBLEMS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY IF
WE HAD FULL AND FAIR FUNDING FOR
ALL SCHOOLS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL THAT I AM PRESENTING
IT PROPOSES A ROAD MAP TO GET
CALIFORNIA BACK TO WHERE WE USED
TO BE.
AMONG THE TOP TEN IN THE NATION
AND K. THROUGH TWELVE PER PEOPLE
SPENDING.
THIS BILL -- PAPA PROPOSES FULL
AND FAIR FUNDING FOR ALL SCHOOL
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF
WHERE YOU LIVE.
THERE ARE THREE MAIN POINTS THAT
I WANT TO BRIEFLY EMPHASIZE
BEFORE TURN OVER TO MY MY
WITNESS BECAUSE MY SECOND WHEN
THIS ONE ALREADY.
BUT THE FIRST POINT I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT THIS IS NOT A
NEW IDEA WE DID THIS BEFORE WHEN
WE ADOPTED THE LCF AT THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND
TWENTY THIRTEEN SOME OF US
INCLUDING -- DOCTOR WEBER AND
AND MISTER O'DONNELL AND AND
MYSELF WE WERE HAND THE
LEGISLATURE AT THAT TIME WHEN WE
ADOPTED LC FF.
AND AT THAT TIME AS YOU WELL
KNOW MISTER CHAIR WE ADOPTED
FUNDING TARGETS TO GET
CALIFORNIA BACK -- THEN TO WHERE
WE USED TO BE BEFORE THE BUDGET
CUTS THE LEGISLATURE HAD TO MAKE
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
GOVERNOR BROWN PUSHED THOSE --
THE DEAD TWENTY THIRTEEN FUNDING
TARGETS THESE FUNDING TARGETS
THAT WE ADOPTED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN PROVIDED THE ROAD MAP
OR THE BENCHMARK SPIKE WHICH ME
MEASURE WE MEASURE OUR PROGRESS
TOWARD ACHIEVING.
OUR GOAL AND THANKS TO A STRONG
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE RESTORED
THIRTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE MET
THE FUNDING TARGETS TWO YEARS
AHEAD OF THE GOVERNOR'S TIMELINE.
THIS BILL PROPOSES WHAT I'M
CALLING L. C. F. F. TWO POINT NO.
NOW THAT WE MET OUR FIRST ROUND
OF FUNDING TARGETS RESTORE
EDUCATION FUNDING CUTS MADE
DURING THE RECESSION WE NEED A
NEW SET OF FUNDING GOALS TO GET
CALIFORNIA BACK TO THE TOP TEN
IN THE NATION.
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING.
WE DID THIS BEFORE WE CAN DO IT
AGAIN.
SECOND POINT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THIS BILL PROPOSES A ROAD MAP
NOT AN APPROPRIATION WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE SCHOOL FUNDING IS
ULTIMATELY DETERMINED BY THE
BUDGET BILL THAT WE PASSED EVERY
YEAR.
THIS BILL PROVOKED OPPOSES THE
PLAN WITH FUNDING TYPE TARGETS
TO GUIDE OUR FUTURE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS THIS BILL DOES NOT
BY ITSEF CREATE A THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR OBLIGATION.
FINAL POINT IT'S A TIME LINE FOR
THESE FUNDING TARGETS GOVERNOR
BROWN'S BASED GRANT FUNDING
TARGETS WAS DALLAS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN BUT HE CREATED AN EIGHT
YEAR TIMELINE TO CHIEF.
HAS FUNDING TARGETS THAT TIME
LINE WAS NOT WRITTEN IN STATUTE
SIMILARLY THIS BILL DOES NOT.
HAVE A TIME LINE WRITTEN IN
STATUTE BUT IN TERMS OF THE YOU
KNOW HOW WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THE
FUNDING TARGETS THAT AS PART OF
THE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE ARE HAVING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND THE BUDGET CHAIRS BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT I'M NOT
PROPOSING A THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IT ELSE YET THE
FUNDING.
IN ONE YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND LET ME TURN OVER --
TO TO MY WITNESSES SUPPORT WE
HAVE ELK GROVE UNIFIED
SUPERINTENDENT CHRISTOPHER
HOFFMAN WHO HAS BEEN VERY
PATIENTLY WAITING FOR HIS TURN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR YES SIR --
SO MY NAME IS CHRIS FOR OFTEN ON
THE PRIDE SUPERINTENDENT OAK
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
AND I THINK YOU FOR HEARING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TODAY -- I
ALSO THINK OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SUSHI FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
AUTHORIZING UNEXPLAINED AB
THIRTY NINETY TONIGHT -- UNDER
REAL CFF DISTRICTS WERE ASKED TO
COLLABORATE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS LOCALLY AND DEVELOP
MULTI YEAR PLANS DEVELOPED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS ALL
STUDENTS.
AND AS WELL AS DOLLARS CAME BACK --
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT SO THE
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE -- TO INCREASE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS INCLUDE
FIVE MAJOR AREAS I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU TONIGHT.
NEW THINGS TO THE DISTRICT THE
OFFICE OF FAMILY COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE
WE'RE NOW ABLE TO DO THAT AND
ENGAGE WITH OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE OFFICE OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
AGAIN A NEW DEPARTMENT IS BUILT
IN THE DISTRICT THAT SERVING OUR
STUDENTS ARE STAFF ACROSS THE
DISTRICT.
WE ALSO BUILT UP ON THINGS WE
ALREADY KNEW WERE WORKING
INSTEAD OF JUST CREATING NEW --
WE EXPAND OUR QUITE OUR K.
TWELVE LITERACY PROGRAMS WITH AN
INTENSE FOCUS ARCADE THREE
EDUCATION -- MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT INCLUDING P.
B. I. S. AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING SERVICES OF AN EXPANDED
ACROSS ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS.
WE'VE ALSO DID EXPANDED LEARNING
EXPAND OF ARNICA SUMMER SCHOOL
INTERCESSION BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS WELL AS ON
LINE OF CREDIT RECOVERY ALL
THESE THINGS ARE NOW IN PLACE.
BUT WITHOUT INCREASE FUNDING --
THROUGH WHAT IS PROPOSING
PROPERTY PROP THIRTY NINE WE
CAN'T TAKE THIS FORWARD WE HAVE
TO STAY WHERE WE ARE FOR IT WORK
WE'VE MADE GREAT PROGRESS BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS TO THE
NEXT LEVEL AND SERVE THE NEXT
GROUP OF KIDS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS NECESSARY
WITH SUBSTANTIAL SUCCESS IS
ALREADY IN PLACE.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN EXPAND THAT
IS DUE FOR THE FUNDING AND THAT
WAY WE CAN BETTER SERVE OUR
FOSTER YOU OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND OTHER STUDENTS TO
HAVE.
A PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
THE REALITY IS THE CURRENT
FUNDING ONLY ALLOWS US TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR EXISTING ONGOING
FUNDING THINGS LIKE.
RAISES THINGS LIKE STIRS
EMPERORS THINGS LIKE SPECIAL LED
ENCROACHMENT INTO OUR BUDGET --
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO COVER AND THE CALL ONLY --
EXPENDITURES WILL ALLOW US TO DO
THAT BUT NOT ANYTHING ELSE --
WITH PROP THIRTY NINE SEASON AB
THIRTY NINE A REVIEW OF THAT
SENSE OF THE VOTERS LET THEM DO
SO WITH THAT WITH AB.
THIRTY NINE WE KNOW THIS IS A
ROAD MAP FOR ASPIRATIONAL
FUNDING WE KNOW WE'RE NOT GONNA
GET THIRTY FIVE MILLION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD JOB.
GOOD EVENING MICHELLE MY CANDOR
IT ON BEHALF OF THE TORRANCE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT -- HERE
IN SUPPORT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE LITERALLY SINCE
THEY ALL STEP UP WAS CREATED --
IT'S VERY WELL OF KNOWLEDGE THAT
BASS GRANTS ARE NOT SUFFICIENT --
WE ARE.
WE HAVE STRIVEN TO THOSE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AWAIT FUNDING
LEVELS AND WE KNOW THAT OUR
STUDENTS BE MORE AND DESERVE
MORE SO FOR THAT REASON WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE.
OF LCF TWO POINT NO THIS ROADMAP
TO BRING US -- TO THE NEXT LEVEL
OF L. CFF -- AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE --
AND THINK THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
STEVE WARD REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION IN CLOVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
LARA PRESTON ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SAYS THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN KERN COUNTY WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THEY LIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOLS FOR SOUND
FINANCE AN AVID IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SURELY DOUBT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
SERRA BOTCHES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
IT'S A DIRECTOR.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROUD CO SPONSOR A
BABY THIRTY NINE A RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
INTO THE GARAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
JULIE DUNCAN SUPERINTENDENT TRI
VALLEY ARE A P. REPRESENTING
DUBLIN LIVERMORE VALLEY JOINT
INPUTS AND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
NANCY TRIED ASSIST BEEN AWESOME
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA GRANGER SUPERINTENDENT E.
NERI R. O. P. REPRESENTING
CASTRO VALLEY HAYWARD SAN
LEANDRO IN SAN LORENZO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THEIR CLIENTS
ON BEHALF THE PALACE FOR HIS
PENINSULA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TASK VERY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THE ONLY INJURY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS.
BE AS FAMOUS AS GRAY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
SHERRI COBURN -- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION THE PEOPLE SERVICES
COALITION AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT.
MARTHA'S THEIR AGO CITY AS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN NOW
WE HAVE A SUPPORT AS AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE BELIEVE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS I BELIEVE
WILL TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION AND
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK GOODNESS THAT WAS GONNA BE
HARD TO CONTROL MY FACE ON YES.
NOT IN OPPOSITION OKAY
[inaudible]
JOINT AUTHORS.
DOES IT YEAH I I TOO AM PROUD TO
BE A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS ONE
AND I'M I THINK THE AUTHOR.
WE GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE.
STOCKS ARE I HAD.
YEAH I JUST A QUICK COMMENT BY
THE WAY THERE WAS A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION BUT THEY DIDN'T.
COURAGE TO COME TALK BUT THEY DO
RAISE AN INTERESTING ISSUE
MAKING SURE WE SPEND OUR MONEY.
AND EQUITABLE MANNER BUT BUT
LOOK I I'M A JOINT AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE WITH YOU I'M ALL
FOR ABOUT FOUR AYE.
BUT IT'S IT'S A PROMISE UNLESS
WE STEP IT UP ON THE BACK AND
IT'S IT'S A PIECE OF PAPER
LITERALLY IN FOR THOSE PEOPLE
CAN I MEAN SAY.
PASSED THIS MEASURES WE CAN FUND
OUR SCHOOLS YEAH THAT'S KINDA
HALF THERE.
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
HOW WE'RE GONNA DO THIS BECAUSE
SOME WOULD SAY YOU KNOW YOU DID
TAKE A LOOK AT WASTE FRAUD AND
ABUSE IN STATE GOVERNMENT AND
REDIRECT BUT BUT ALSO SAY -- WE
COULD SHUT DOWN THE UC CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO NAY
COMMISSION PROGRAM.
SHUT DOWN EVERY PRISON.
AND HE SAT DOWN EVERY PRESCHOOL
AND CHILDCARE PROGRAM AS THIRTY
FIVE THAT'S LIKE THIRTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS.
CELL IT IS NOT QUITE ENOUGH JUST
TO LOOK.
INTERNALLY WE HAVE SO WE NEED TO
GO HAVE A REAL TALK WITH THE
VOTERS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND SAY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS AND AND WE'RE
FORTY FIRST THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE FUNDING.
THAT'S OKAY.
BUT OTHERWISE WE IN A STEP UP
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE FUND OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ADEQUATELY AND SO
I'M FOR THAT AND NO.
WE'RE TALKING -- TO TO TO YOU
AND MANY OTHER LAWMAKERS AND
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THIS AND
THAT'S REALLY.
THE CONVERSATION THAT'S THE REAL
CONVERSATION THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT'S IT'S I
DON'T WANT IT YOU KNOW THE
LITTLE AT ALL BUT I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO STEP UP WITH THE
OTHER PIECE OF THE PACKAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MCCARTY I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE FIGHT HARD ESPECIALLY FOR
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO A CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT.
HI CAN.
I CLOSE MY EYES FOREVER.
THANK YOU MISTER PERSON ONE OF
THE ONE COMING QUICKLY.
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
APPROACH?
IS IT'S US FIGHTING FOR EACH
OTHER AS OPPOSED TO US.
FIGHTING AGAINST EACH OTHER.
I'LL BE IN A VARIETY BILLS I
WANNA ONLY ONE RAISES HILLARY'S
BUT YOU'RE SPEAKING ALL STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL STUDENTS NEED TO BE OUR
DESERVED.
OF ADEQUATE SCHOOL FUNDING SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
BROAD APPROACH AND PERSPECTIVE --
THE MOTION IS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
WHAT ARE YOU MAY -- YOU MAY
CLOSE AND I I WASN'T HERE WHEN
THEY PASSED I'LL SEE IF I WAS
AFTER.
ALL THAT'S RIGHT YOU'RE YOU'RE
NOT AS OLD AS I AM.
ALL RIGHT I ASKED FOR I WAS.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN AND APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
AYE.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
HIGHLY NO KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THE I. SMITH SMITH I WEBER
WEBER I THE LAST FOUR VOTE SO IT
IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT AUTHOR IS -- NO TO MISS
CONSULT -- ISSUES HERE -- SHE
DID SHOW UP THE GUY WILL GO WITH --
PILOT IN EIGHT AB FIVE HUNDRED
BY MS GONZALEZ.
WHEN YOU GET RESERVE FOR MR
GARCIA AFTERWARDS?
YES.
THANK YOU.
AB -- FIVE HUNDRED GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO PROVIDE CERTIFIED ACADEMIC
AND CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF FULLY PAID
LEAVE DUE TO PREGNANCY
MISCARRIAGE CHILDBIRTH AND
RECOVERY.
IN A WORKFORCE THAT IS OVER 70%
FEMALE CURRENT LAW DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST WOMEN WHO CHOOSE TO HAVE
CHILDREN FORCES IN TO DEPLETE
ANY PAID LEAVE THEY'VE ACCRUED
AND SACRIFICE OUR FINANCIAL
SECURITY IN ORDER TO TAKE
NECESSARY TIME OFF DURING OR
AFTER THE PREGNANCY.
I'VE.
WAS REMOVED AND SECOND THANK YOU
AB FIVE HUNDRED WOULD HELP
ENSURE -- THAT ALL TEACHERS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE PROFESSORS AND
OTHER SCHOOL EMPLOYEES COULD I
ACTUALLY HAVE PAID LEAVE WITHOUT
DEPLETING ALL OF THEIR VACATION
SICK TIME AND THEN OF COURSE
JUST RELYING DIFFERENT OKAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- BUT YOUR WITNESS.
THIS IS WHERE MEMBERS BRIAN HOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS WERE PROD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
I HAD TO EXCELLENCE FEMALE
TEACHERS LINED UP FOR TH FOR A
WITNESS TESTIMONIES BUT THEY HAD
TO TAKE A FLIGHT BACK HOME SO
I'M GONNA KEEP MY TESTIMONY VERY
BRIEF -- AND I'M HERE TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SEVERAL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP AS
YOU MENTIONED IN.
THE NATION ABOUT THREE OUT OF
FOUR TEACHERS ARE WOMEN --
THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH
SHOWING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
RESULTS IN EMPLOYEES STAYING IN
THE WORK FORCE WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH US
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SORRY.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF LABOR
FEDERATION SORRY.
RIGHT ARE THERE ARE DOZENS
SUPPORT.
SEEING OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF WILL
THEIR OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND THE TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
HAS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES ARE
OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL.
I WOULD NOT DISPUTE ANYTHING
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ OR
HER WITNESSES SAID IN THE
PRESENTATION -- AT LEAST ONE AND
I BELIEVE NOW TWO OR THREE OF
OUR DISTRICTS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
DO YOU OFFER -- PAID LEAVE
RETURN IT EASILY -- BUT THAT WAS
A CHEAP THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS -- ULTIMATELY--
WE BELIEVE THAT IS THE RIGHT
VENUE -- FOR THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WE AGREE WITH THE SIMPLE
STATEMENT THAT GOVERNOR BROWN.
MADE IN HIS VETO MESSAGE LAST
YEAR THAT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS IS THE BEST
VENUE -- TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT LEAVE POLICIES.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION THEY'RE ABOUT JUST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION.
PLAY MONEY I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
THE SCHOOLS ACCESS MY ABILITY
FUND IN OPPOSITION.
LARA PRESIDENT'S DECISION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN OPPOSITION.
MADONNA WHAT DISSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU -- SEE NO MORE
OPPOSITION OVER HERE BEHIND THE
RAIL.
SAY NO COMMENT FROM ANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL HI THIS
IS A AN INTERESTING A TOUGH ONE
TO OPPOSE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE --
BUT I APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
AND AND YOU KNOW SPEAKING TO THE
FISCAL IMPACT -- BUT AGAIN I
THINK THIS IS A REASONABLE BILL.
TO GIVE -- PEOPLE TIME OFFER
THIS ISSUE -- HAVE BABIES YOU
KNOW.
EVERY OTHER PROFESSION GETS IT
WHY SHOULD A TEACHER ABOUT THAT --
BUT I'LL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE.
I ASKED WHERE I'VE A IN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
HOLD ON I'VE GOT THE WRONG TO
PREPARATIONS. TO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL EIN KILEY.
KILEY NOW.
KALRA.
CALLER I AM MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
HI.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS
NOT -- WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THIS IS MR GARCIA'S BILL
IT'S AB. SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN FOUR THREE OKAY --
SEVEN FOUR THREE YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WRITE THEIR STUFF DOWN HERE I
TELL YOU THIS IS SOME A SLOPPY
AS WORK THAT I WOULD NEVER HAVE
TO MY OWN CLASSROOM.
I AM SO SORRY EITHER WAY IS THIS
MY WRITING.
THIS WILL BE HIS PAPER SENT BACK
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T PUT IN OUR
BEFORE HIS NAME.
BUT EITHER WAY -- FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTEEN I I JUST WANT TO START
BY ADMITTING THAT THE ONLY NON A
I EVER GOT GRAMMAR SCHOOL WAS IN
HANDWRITING I'M SORRY.
AB SEVEN EARLY.
THREE THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS I
WOULD START BY SAYING THE AUTHOR
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS EXCEPT
WRITTEN STATEMENTS FOR SELF
ADMINISTERING ASTHMA INHALERS
FROM A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
WHOSE CONTRACT WITH THE HEALTH
PLAN FROM OUT OF STATE.
INCLUDING MEXICO WITH MEXICO AS
OUR SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR BORDER
ENTITIES SUCH AS IMPERIAL COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN MANY
OTHERS USES PROXIMITY TO OFFER
EMPLOYEES BI NATIONAL INSURANCE.
WITH A HIGH FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
HEALTH CARE IN THIS COUNTRY MANY
PLACE OUGHT TO RECEIVE MEDICAL
CARE FOR THEMSELVES.
AND THEIR CHILDREN IN MEXICO.
DO THE CURRENT STATE AND SCHOOL
MEDICAL POLICIES PRESCRIBE
MEDICATIONS FROM MEXICO CANNOT
BE ALLOWED OR TO MINISTER TO
CHILDREN WHILE THEY ARE
ATTENDING SCHOOL THIS POLICY HAS
LEFT MANY SCHOOL CHILDREN FACING
LIFE THREATENING CONDITIONS
BECAUSE THEY HAD RESTRICTED
ACCESS TO ASTHMA INHALERS.
WITH THE GOAL PROMOTING
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS EXCEPT
WRITTEN STATEMENTS FOR SELF
ADMINISTERING ASTHMA INHALERS
FROM OTHER STATE OR COUNTY.
I'VE WITNESS TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
AFTER THE HEAD ON I AM A MOTHER
OF TWO CHILDREN WHO HAVE ASTHMA --
I ALSO WORKED WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WORKING FOR THE PAST FIFTY YEARS
WITH SEVENTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
I AM -- ONE OF THOSE -- FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE TO GO TO
MEXICO MY CHILDREN ARE NOT ABLE
TO BRING MEDICATION TO SCHOOL --
AND FOR THAT REASON AND INNER
STAYS HOME.
AS WE KNOW ASTHMA IS A LIFE
THREATENING CONDITION -- WE HAVE
A LOT OF IMPACT THEIR COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A HIGH PREVALENCE OF
ASTHMA IN OUR COMMUNITY WE NEED
THIS MEDICATION WITH THE
STUDENTS AT ALL TIME -- I DO
HAVE A CHILD THAT IT THAT THAT
IS -- SCARED TO TAKE HIS
MEDICATION TO SCHOOL HE SAID HE
WOULD BE A VERY BIG TROUBLE IF
HE DOES TAKE HIS CREDENTIALS HE
HE'S HERE TODAY -- I DO ALSO
HAVE A SUPPORT FOR MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IMPERIAL COUNTY A
LOT OF HEALTH NURSES ARE WAITING
FOR THE FOOT TODAY TO TO SEE --
YOUR SUPPORT -- IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT ALL STUDENTS TAKE
MEDICATION TO SCHOOL REGARDLESS
WHERE WE ARE SEEN OUR MEDICAL
PROVIDER.
THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU CHARTER MEMBERS MAKING
ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I
INITIALLY WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT WORK TO THE OUT WITH
THE AUTHOR TO CRAFT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT NEAR THE BILL TO
ONLY.
IN RELEASE OF BI NATIONAL
INSURANCE PLANS -- AND WITHOUT
RIVER OPPOSITION BUT REALLY JUST
HERE IF THEY'RE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER -- SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX LEASE ON
BEHALF OF COMMIT THIS WEEK OR
LIE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANDREW WILLIS I AM A
STUDENT OF FRANK RIGHT MIDDLE
SCHOOL MPO CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JIMMY FROM UNIT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY I DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
YEAH THE DEARBORN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES ARE NOT
WE ACTUALLY STARTED OUT WITH A
OPPOSE OF LESS AMEND.
AND FIGHTS TO YOUR CONSULT AND
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT.
SOME AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL BE
TAKING AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK -- THE SOMEONE'S -- STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US AS WELL AND
SO ARE AT THIS POINT TIME WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO
CARE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE WILL
REMOVE OR OPPOSITION WHEN WE SEE
THE BILL IN PRINT WE DO HAVE ONE
SMALL ISSUE WITH THE WRITTEN
STATEMENT WE TALK TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULT ABOUT THAT.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THAT.
PEACE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SINGLE COMMENTS READY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I MEAN AS A CO AUTHOR
AND REPRESENTING THE BORDER
COMMUNITY WE HAVE A DOUBLE
WHAMMY WE HAVE -- HIGHER ASTHMA
RATES THAN PROBABLY ANYWHERE IN
THE STATE AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE WORKING FAMILIES I HAVE
TO RELY ON HEALTH CARE ACROSS
THE BORDER AND SO THIS HELP
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND I RESPECT
LAST NIGHT OUT.
THE MOVE IN SECOND AS A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSES LE LET
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I BILLS FIVE VOTED IS OUT
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE. TO TO MR.
CHOOSE THE SISTER GABRIEL AS TO
BILLS.
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE IS AB
.
SIX TWO FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY 2%
EIGHTY SIX TWO FOUR WHICH WAR
CRIER SCHOOLS THAT CHOOSE TO
ISSUE STUDENT ID CARDS TO
INCLUDE ON THOSE CARDS PHONE
NUMBERS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOTLINES
THIS LEGISLATION BUILDS ON SB
NINE SEVEN TWO WHICH WILL SOON
REQUIRE STUDENT ID CARDS IN
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE THE NUMBER
FOR THE NATIONAL SUICIDE.
PREVENTION LIFELINE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE FACING A
CHALLENGING SITUATION INVOLVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR SEXUAL HEALTH.
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION THAT MAY BE
ESSENTIALTO THEIR PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL WELL BEING.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A REAL AN
URGENT NEED FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION.
STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE THAT ONE
IN THREE TEENS WILL EXPERIENCE
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE ONE IN NINE
GIRLS WILL EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR ABUSE BEFORE AGE
EIGHTEEN AN STI RATES CONTINUE
TO RISE SOMEONE CALIFORNIA'S
TEENS AND YOUNG ADULTS.
IN SHORT IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES INCLUDING INFORMATION
SUPPORT COUNSELING AND TREATMENT
REGARDING SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
AB SIX TWO FOUR WOULD MAKE THIS
INFORMATION MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHOSE INTERNET USAGE MAY BE
MONITORED BY AN ABUSER.
I'M FORCING ONE OF MY WITNESSES
HAD TO LEAVE BUT WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS LEE ENTRE
CLARK HARVEY PHD BUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD EVENING -- I'M LEON CLICK
HARVEY FROM C. B. HA WE
REPRESENT THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR ON HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND DO
NOT ALWAYS HAVE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION ABOUT REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH.
EFFECTS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CAN BE LONG
LASTING AND COULD AFFECT A
STUDENT'S MENTAL.
NO WAY STUDENTS DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO READ ONLY
ACCESS INFORMATION AND RESOURCES
THAT CAN HELP THEM COPE WITH
THESE ISSUES.
SO WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
GREATER ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT
PROMOTE BETTER MENTAL HEALTH AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING THE ANCILLARY ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING IN SUPPORT.
SHERRI COBURN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION BUT I DO WANT TO
KNOW THE YOU DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS YES THEY DID THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THAT PRIVATE
SCHOOL SERVICE STUDENTS AGREE
SEVENTY TWELVE POINT A CENTRAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOTLINE ON
STUDENT ID.
SO I KNOW I SEE OPPOSITION
LETTER UP HERE.
AND I THINK YOU OF YOU ADDRESS
THAT ON THE THE PRIVATE SCHOOL
SIDE.
CLICK RELIGIOUS SCHOOL SIGN.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RAY BURNELL.
AND I SERVE AS THE EDUCATION
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE.
AS THE OFFICIAL PUBLIC POLICY
VOICE THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN OUR
STATE WE ARE OPPOSED TO A. B..
SIX TWO FOUR OUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE THE
MANDATED INCLUSION.
OF MULTIPLE HOTLINE NUMBERS
REGARDLESS HOW WORTHY WOULD
DIMINISH THE EFFICACY OF THE
ONLY NUMBER NOW REQUIRED ON
STOOD IDENTIFICATION CARDS.
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
HOTLINE.
ADOLESCENT SUICIDE AND SELF
INFLICTED INJURY.
IS AN UNPARALLELED NATIONAL
CRISIS.
DEATH FROM SUICIDE AMONG
CHILDREN YOUNGER THAN SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD GREW 84% THE LAST
DECADE.
AND INCREASED BY 210031% FOR
GIRLS AGE.
TEN TO FOURTEEN SUICIDEIS THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN AGE TEN TO FOURTEEN AND
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH. FOR THOSE AGE.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR NEARLY
ONE IN.
FIVE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE. 9% HAVE
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE ONE OR MORE
TIMES.
EVERY LIES IS PRECIOUS AND MUST
BE PROTECTED ESPECIALLY WHEN
MOST WEAK AND VULNERABLE.
REQUIRING ONLY THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE ON
ID'S HELP PREVENT IMMINENT DEATH
AMONG OUR YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK
OF KILLING THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHY THE SINGLE NUMBER WAS
REQUIRED ON STUDENTS ID'S WITH
UNANIMOUS APPROVAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND WITH
UNIVERSAL SUPPORT AMONG OUR
STATE'S PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES.
THIS NUMBER GIVE STUDENTS
CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE.
IN OTHER STUDENTS WHO KNOW
CLASSMATES THEY MAY BE DOING SO.
I DEDICATED RESOURCE TO
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS VITAL
SUPPORTS NECESSARY TO CHAIR
CHALLENGE AND CHERISH THEIR LIFE.
WE SHOULD NOT TO DISTRACT FROM
THIS RESOURCE AS AB SIX TWO FOUR
WOULD DO AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
NOVO SO CAN I ASK YOU WHAT ARE
YOU ASKING FOR WHAT WHAT DO YOU
WANT NOT ONE THIS BILL I'M
CONFUSED.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
I KNOW THAT BUT WHAT WHAT.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU OPPOSED TO IN
THE BILL THE ADDITION OF ANY
NUMBERS IN ADDITION TO THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE OKAY SO
YOU DON'T WANT THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT HOTLINE ADDED?
AT A LOCAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE AT IT CORRECT CORRECT
OKAY UNDERSTOOD SORRY I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YES THAT IS
CORRECT.
OKAY THANK YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS MATT SHARP I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH ALLIANCE DEFENDING
FREEDOM OVER FORTY YEARS AGO THE
SUPREME COURT RULED STRUCK DOWN
A NEW HAMPSHIRE LAW THAT
REQUIRED IT CITIZENS TO HAVE
PLAYED DISPLAY THE STATE MOTTO
ON LICENSE PLATE.
HOLDING THAT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS A
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT NOT TO BE
A CAREER OF THE STATE'S MESSAGE
AND JUST LAST YEAR THE SUPREME
COURT STRUCK DOWN A CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT REQUIRED PRO LIFE
PREGNANCY CENTERS. TO POST
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR ABORTION
REFERRALS.
SB SIX TWENTY FOUR SUFFERS THE
SAME CONSTITUTIONAL FLAWS
BECAUSE IT COMPELS RELIGIOUS
SCHOOLS STUDENTS AND STAFF TO
USE ID BADGES THE COMMUNICATE
MESSAGES THEY MAY FIND
OBJECTIONABLE.
UNDER THE BILL A PRIVATE COLLEGE
THAT ENDORSES A PRODI UP PRO
LIFE IDEOLOGY WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO DESIGN PRINT AND DISTRIBUTE
STUDENT ID CARDS.
INCLUDE THE TELEPHONE NUMBER FOR
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
HOTLINE.
USING THREAT OF LOSING STATE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID THE
PRIVATE INSTITUTION MUST
SURRENDER ITS VOICE IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE THE STATE'S PREFERRED
IDEOLOGY.
GET THE HARMS OF AB SIX TWENTY
FOUR ARE NOT LIMITED TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS STUDENTS AT BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
LIKE LAST FORCED TO BECOME
CARRIERS OF THE STATE'S IDEOLOGY.
ON ISSUES OF SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
STUDENTS PUBLICLY USER ID'S TO
CHECK IN AT SCHOOL PURCHASE
LUNCHES AND GAIN ACCESS TO
SCHOOL EVENTS SOME SCHOOLS EVEN
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO WEAR THEIR
ID'S AS A SAFETY PRECAUTION.
BUT UNDER AB SIX TWENTY FOUR A
TEENAGE GIRL WHO STARTS A PRO
LIFE CLUB AT OUR SCHOOL WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DALY KERRY USE AND
EVEN WHERE A TELEPHONE NUMBER
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
AND THIS COMPELLED SPEECH
REQUIREMENT CUTS BOTH WAYS I
SOME PRO CHOICE STUDENTS MAY
OBJECTIVE THEIR SCHOOL CHOSE TO
USE A LOCAL PRO LIFE PREGNANCY
CENTER IS THE HOTLINE.
I'M TO PUBLISH ON STUDENT ID'S
THIS LAW WILL INEVITABLY LEAD TO
COSTLY LITIGATION AGAINST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT THEY WILL ALMOST
INEVITABLY LOSE.
REQUIRING STUDENTS TO BE
MESSENGERS ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNMENT IDEOLOGY OPENS A
PANDORA'S BOX BECAUSE ANY
MESSAGE FORCED ON STUDENTS BY
THE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO BE
CONTROVERSIAL TO SOME.
IF THE STATE WANTS TO PROMOTE A
HOTLINE IT HAS A NUMERAL WAYS TO
DO SO BILLBOARDS AD CAMPAIGNS
FLYERS BUT WHAT IT CANNOT DO IS
FORCE PRIVATE PARTIES TO SPEAK
ITS MESSAGE ON ITS BEHALF THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY WELL DONE AND
WITHIN TWO MINUTES -- WITH THAT
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION YES PHILLIP
ASKING ME WILLIAM JOSEPH
UNIVERSITY WHAT ARE OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AS ONE OTHER THERE
THERE ARE TWO SIDES THIS BILL IS
A SEVEN TWELVE PORTION.
AND THERE'S A HIGHER EDUCATION
PORTION WHICH IS GOING TO BE
DISCUSSED IN THE HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ADDRESS THAT TODAY -- WITH THAT
I'M GOING -- TO THERE'S MORE
THEIR OPPOSITION ANSWER YEAH
GREG BURKE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
JONATHAN KELLERMAN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION OPPOSED.
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT --
ECONOMY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS IS COLOR RESTRICT KILEY.
GOOD EVENING MISTER GARRETT ALSO
I'M.
I I UNDERSTAND THAT THE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. SEVEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE BUT TAKEN OUT OF THE BILL
BUT THE PRIVATE COLLEGES ARE
STILL IN THERE SO IS THERE A
PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT YOU KNOW IS
THAT IS GOING BE DISCUSSING
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE SAYS
NO THIS IS NOT.
COMMITTEE FOR THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DISCUSS THE HIGHER IT
PROVISIONS BECAUSE THAT'S GOING
TO BE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
SO WELL WE ARE VOTING ON THE
BILL TODAY SIZE WILLIAMS YEAH MY
SUGGESTION IS THAT YOU DON'T
KNOW.
IF I HAD A MODEL LIKE JUST ASK
THANK YOU BUT AGAIN.
THIS IS THE PURVIEW OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IS K. TWELVE WELL I'LL LEAVE IT
UP.
TO ME THAT IF I HAVE TO LISTEN
ON THE CHAIR I'M GONNA SPEAK THE
PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE IS IS
K..
TWELVE THE PURVIEW OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION THE HIGHER EDUCATION
THE HIRED COMMITTEE IS HIGHER
EDUCATION SO THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THOSE
POLICY CONCEPTS ARE I'M SURE YOU
HAVE CONCERNS.
YOU'VE GOT EXPRESSLY AUTHOR
INDIVIDUALLY OUTSIDE OF THIS
TERM.
I DON'T WANNA GET INTO THAT
DEBATE TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THAT PORTION OF THE
BILL TODAY WORK WE'RE WE'RE
DISCUSSING THE CAGE WALL
PORTIONS.
AND HE HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO THE K. TWELVE
PORTION DID YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT -- I'M HAPPY TO MOVE ON I
SINCE WE BOTH ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT IT THEN IN WITH YOU OFF
LINE AND I'LL DEFER TO THE CHAIR
I I LISTEN.
I JUST WE'RE NOT GOING TO AMEND
ANY PART OF BILL THAT SPEAKS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION PROVISIONS
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PURVIEW OF
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
SO THERE'S NO NEED TO DISCUSS
THEM HERE TODAY.
AGREED THANK YOU.
I AM I HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS -- SO THERE'S THAT
CASES MENTIONING WAS MUCH OF THE
TESTIMONY IN ITS AND SOME OF THE
MATERIALS I RELATED TO THIS BILL
I NATIONAL TO THE FAMILY AND
LIFE ADVOCATES -- VIVA SERRA
HIGH SUPREME COURT DECISION
STRUCK DOWN -- PREVIOUS
CALIFORNIA STATUTE AT THE
REQUIRED AT PRIVATE CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS TO POST
NOTICES REGARDING WHERE TO
OBTAIN -- ACCESS TO ABORTION --
STRUCK DOWN ON FIRST AMENDMENT
GROUNDS COURSE ABOUT COMPELLING
INDIVIDUALS TO SPEAK A
PARTICULAR MESSAGE SAYS NOTICES
ALTER THE CONTENT OF THEIR
SPEECHES COMPELLED SPEECH SO.
I HOW WOULD YOU DO WITH THIS
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS IS
CONSTITUTIONAL UNDER THAT
DECISION OR HOW WOULD YOU
DISTINGUISH IT.
YEAH I'M SO I THINK IT -- IF
FALL SQUARELY OUTSIDE OF THE NEW
FLU DECISION -- SO THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS GOING ON HERE THAT
ARE FOR TO KNOW FIRST OF ALL
THERE'S NO COMPELLED SPEECH
ISSUE HERE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT IN CALIFORNIA ISSUE
ID CARDS.
SO THAT ALONE OBVIATES THE ISSUE
THE SECOND PART OF THIS IS WE
ACTUALLY HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
A NUMBER OF DISTINGUISHED
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW EXPERTS
INCLUDING LIKE ELEVEN WHO IS A
CLARK -- TO FORMER JUSTICE
ANTHONY KENNEDY IS NOW A
PROFESSOR AT UC IRVINE ALSO THE
DEAN OF UC BERKELEY LOST HER OWN
INSURANCE KEEP BOTH OF THEM ALL
BEHIND ON THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
THE BILL THEY THINK THAT THERE'S
VERY VERY CLEAR DISTINCTIONS
BETWEEN.
WHAT WAS GOING ON AND NAY FLOCK
IN HERE WERE SIMPLY ASKING FOR
NUMBER TO BE PRINTED ON THE BACK
OF THE ID CARD SO WE ARE VERY
VERY CONFIDENT OF THIS BILL'S
CONSTITUTIONALITY?
OKAY SO I I GUESS.
THE WAY I MIGHT TAKE SOME ISSUE
WITH THAT IS IF THE SCHOOL IS
REQUIRED THE STUDENTS WHERE THE
IDEA.
AND THERE'S SPEECH ON THE ID
THAT IS RUNS AGAINST A CORE
BELIEF OF THE STUDENTS DO YOU
THINK THAT RAISES FIRST I'M
CONCERNS.
NO I MEAN WE WE REQUIRE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO DO THINGS ALL THE TIME
RIGHT AND THERE'S COMPETE WE SEE
WE SEE EXAMPLES OF CONSULT
COMPELLED SPEECH ALL THE TIME IN
YOUR LICENSE PLATE IS COME
COMPELLED SPEECH THE THE LABELS
ON A WINE BOTTLE OR BE --
BORROWER COMPELLED SPEECH SO
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF
EXAMPLES OF COMPELLED SPEECH
THAT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY
PERMISSIBLE IT'S NOT THAT ANY
COMPELLED SPEECH IS
IMPERMISSIBLE IT'S JUST DOESN'T
FALL WHICH SIDE OF THE WIND AS A
PHONE I THINK PUTTING A PHONE
NUMBER.
WHICH A PHONE NUMBER ALONE ON
THE BACK OF ID CARD CLEARLY
FALLS ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CITED ONLINE.
GOT IT SO IT WAS SO WHAT IS THE
TYPE OF COMPELLED SPEECH I GUESS
I DIDN'T HEAR HOW YOU
DISTINGUISHED THE THE THE
PREVIOUS STATUTE ON THAT BASIS.
I'M I'M SORRY I DON'T FULLY FALL
SO ON THE BASIS OF THE TYPE OF
SPEECH ISSUE IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
A PRETTY SIMILAR TYPE OF SPEECH
ISSUE HERE.
AS WITH -- WHAT WAS CALLED THE
FACT ACT NO I MEAN THERE I MEAN
THE THE FAX IN THOSE CASES COULD
NOT BE MORE DIFFERENT ENCOURAGE
YOU TO GO BACK AND READ THE
NESTLE DECISION TO GET A LITTLE
BIT OF A FLAVOR OF THAT?
HERE THIS IS SIMPLY REQUIRING
SIMPLE FACTUAL INFORMATION IT'S
NOT REQUIRING A IN IN THE FACT
ACT AS I AS I RECALL THE THE
COMPELLED SPEECH ISSUE REQUIRED
SOMEBODY TO ACTUALLY COMMUNICATE
A MESSAGE.
HERE IS SIMPLEA FACTUAL PIECE
OF INFORMATION I ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER THERE'S NO
IDEOLOGY THERE IT'S A SIMPLE
FACTUAL PIECE OF INFORMATION SO
IT'S VERY VERY DIFFERENT THAN
THE FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF
NETWORK.
OKAY I WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
CONCERN THAT WAS OUT ALSO RAISED
A ONE OF THE WITNESSES -- THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE OF LIMITING THE
EFFICACY OF THE IS THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE THIS IS A
BILL FROM CENTER PORTANTINO LAST
YEAR -- YOU HEARD SOME
STATISTICS I MEAN IT'S AN ISSUE
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON QUITE A BIT
WE'VE HAD THIS.
RISING YOU SUICIDES IT'S REALLY
TRAGIC I THINK THERE'S IF YOU'RE
A CLEVERNESS THAT SHOWS YOU KIND
OF HAVE A JUMBLE OF INFORMATION
IT.
EVEN IF SOME OF IT'S GOOD
INFORMATION HERE AT AND YOU KNOW
YOU IF YOU REDUCE THE SALIENCE
OF OF THE INFORMATION THAT'S
THERE SO HOW DO YOU RESPOND.
YEAH AND I AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK -- THE OPPOSITION WE HAD A
VERY VERY -- RESPECTFUL AND AN
APPROPRIATE CONVERSATION -- I DO
AND I APPRECIATE THEM COMING
INTO RAISING CONCERNS IN THE
MANNER THAT THEY DID I THINK WE
I JUST RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ON
THIS POINT WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT.
WITH FOUR NUMBERS YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN FIND THE NUMBER THAT THEY
NEED I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
OVER AGAIN OVERWHELMED OR
CONFUSED ANYBODY.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE HAD A
CONVERSATION PERHAPS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO PUT THAT ITEM AND
READ OR BOLD IT OR DO SOMETHING
ELSE TO TO CALL OUT THE THE
SUICIDE LIFELINE BUT WE WE HAVE
A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR ABILITY TO FIND
THE LINE.
THAT THEY NEED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU DOING THIS.
ALL RIGHT QUESTION.
WHAT REMAINS NOW I I'M LOOKING
AT THE AMENDMENTS AND SO MUCH
HAS BEEN TAKEN OUT SO WHAT IS
THE?
WHAT REMAINS AT THIS POINT?
THEY SHOULD YOUR ADVOCATING FOR
THANK YOU DOCTOR SO WHAT WE TOOK
OUT WISE -- THE APPLICATION OF
THE BILL TWO K. THROUGH TWELVE
RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS I'M SORRY
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE RELIGIOUS
SCHOOLS ALSO EVER IT APPLY STILL --
TO SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC
AND THEN HIGHER ED BOTH PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC.
BUT IT ALSO SAYS YOU'RE REMOVING
THE AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
DOMESTIC HOTLINE.
AND THE SEXUAL ASSAULT LINE.
CHAU WHAT WHAT WHAT WE HAD IN
THE BILL WE WANTED TO GIVE
FLEXIBILITY -- IF FOLKS WOULD
RATHER IS THAT TO SAY THAN HAVE
THE NATIONAL HOTLINE YOU WANTED
TO PRINT A LOCAL HOTLINE.
WE'VE REMOVED THAT FOUR SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE BUT IT WOULD GIVE
FOR EXAMPLE IF SAN DIEGO STATE
WANTED TO HAVE A A CAMPUS --
SEXUAL ASSAULT HOTLINE RATHER
THAN THE NATIONAL LINE WOULD
STILL GIVE SAN DIEGO STATE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT SO WE
PRESERVE THAT FLEXIBILITY AT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION LEVEL BUT FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS JUST TO MAKE IT
EASIER -- SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE
THAT THEY'LL HAVE THE NATIONAL
HOTLINE OKAY SO THE HAVE THE
NATIONAL RATHER THAN THE LOCAL
SO THAT WAS THE ONLY CHANGE YES
OKAY.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
YOU MISTER CABLE AND I I JUST.
I THE THESE ARE THESE ARE
IMPORTANT PROVISION OF AND ADD
TO THE STEW NINETIES I'M VERY
SUPPORT OF THEM BUT I JUST HOPE
THAT NEXT YEAR WE DON'T HAVE TEN
MORE THESE BILLS.
SO THAT OTHER NUMBERS BECOME
ALMOST IMMATERIAL NOT EVEN
REVERSIBLE OF STUDENT ID WHICH
IS ONLY A BIG.
SO I HOPE YOU'LL BE MY CHAMPION
NEXT YEAR TO HELP ME PUSH BACK.
WHEN I GET TEN BILLS AT ONCE
PEOPLE WANT TO ADD?
NUMBERS ON TO THE STUDENT ID
THESE ARE IMPORTANT.
I'M WITH YOU BUT WHO KNOWS WHAT
THEY WANT TO HAVE NEXT.
SO WITH THAT -- THE MOTION IS DO
YOU AGREE TO THE AMENDMENTS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION THERE'S BEEN A MOVE --
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CLOSE.
I LOOK FOR TO WORKING ARM IN ARM
WITH YOU ON THAT I THINK THESE
ARE NUMBERS THAT WE SELECTED
BECAUSE THEY CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM
IMPLICATIONS ON A STUDENT'S.
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL WELL BEING I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD PLACE TO
DRAW THE LINE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN AND HIGHER EDUCATION.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I AND WEBER.
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTED
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE OUR TWO MORE -- YOU HAVE
ONE MORE -- OKAY SORRY -- WE
HAVE -- AB ABSOLUTELY. EIGHTY
SIX SIX SIX AND THAT'S WHY I AND
NUMBER.
TEN WE'RE REALLY HAPPY THOSE
NUMBERS WORDS THOSE RELIGIOUS
GUYS GOING TO BE BACK.
YEAH WE SHOULD.
I HAVE A STAFFER WHO LIKES A
CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
SIX SIX SIX A BILL THAT REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A MODEL
REFERRAL PROTOCOLS. TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS I
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE IS NO
DOUBT AWARE OF THE STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA.
TEACHERS ARE OFTEN THE FIRST TO
NOTICE CHANGES IN STUDENT
BEHAVIOR THAT CAN SIGNAL MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES GET EDUCATORS
REPORT A LACK OF PREPAREDNESS IN
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CONSULT WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AND EDUCATION EXPERTS TO
DESIGN A MENTAL HEALTH REFER A
PROTOCOL FOR VOLUNTARY USE BY
SCHOOLS TO ENSURE THAT STUDENT
PLEASE WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND TRAINING. TO BETTER ADDRESS
DID MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFIED AS AN EXPERT
ON THE ISSUE SHERRY COBURN
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- AS YOU KNOW
ONE IN FIVE STUDENTS -- SUFFER
FROM MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES --
SCHOOL NURSES SPEND OVER 30% OF
THEIR TIME PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AS A PRIMARY
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL IN
SCHOOLS WE'RE OFTEN FIRST TO
ASSESS.
AND IDENTIFY SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS
OF MENTAL HEALTH OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
THESE ISSUES WHICH AFFECT
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT ATTENDANCE
AND SUCCESS IN SCHOOL THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A PROCESS IS
NECESSARY FOR IDENTIFYING
PROBLEMS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
HAVING A REFERRAL PROTOCOL. FOR
STAFF WILL LIKELY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT RECEIVE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS.
THIS IS ALSO NECESSARY FOR THE
ORDERING REFERRAL AND
PRESCRIPTION PROCESS FOR THE
ELLIE MEDI CAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM -- TO READ BRING DOWN
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR STUDENT
SERVICES WE ARE SO IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE AS PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
WE UNDERSTAND HOW BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES.
CAN IMPACT A STUDENT SUCCESS IN
SCHOOL A PREVENTION AND EARLY
EVEN INTERVENTION PROCESS WILL
SIS SCHOOL STAFF IN ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE ISSUES AND IN FACT
MY OWN SON WAS SUICIDAL.
IN SCHOOL AND IN BECAUSE HE WAS
REFERRED TO A NURSE WHO KNEW
WHAT TO DO HE WAS ABLE TO GET
HELP SO THIS PERSONALLY TOUCHES.
HOME.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT TONY
TO CARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
KATHY VAN AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
IN SPORTS BILL.
THE INJURY TO BE OF THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING AND SUPPORT.
JIMMY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT DESPITE
THE BILL NUMBER.
SANDRA BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN ANY OPPOSITION.
A SCENE OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I'M HAPPY
TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS SAW
SOME BILLS ARE PERSONAL PEOPLE
THIS ONE'S PROFESSIONAL TO ME.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A BILL I RAN A
COUPLE YEARS AGO NOT ON BEHALF
OF ANY ADVOCACY GROUP BUT MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM
WHERE AND I SAW THAT THERE
WEREN'T PROTOCOLS WHEN YOU WERE
NOTICING A STUDENT THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOME CHALLENGES.
CERTAINLY THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
TEACHER DIAGNOSING OR TREATING.
BUT WE NEED A PATH FOR STUDENTS
TO FIND RESOURCES AND I YOU KNOW
I'M NOT CONFIDENT.
THAT THAT EXISTS ON EVERY SCHOOL
SITE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MEANS HOW DO WE GET
THE STUDENT WE THINK MIGHT HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES TO A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING
ON AND HOPEFULLY ADDRESS SOME.
JUST HANDING THEM OFF TO A
COUNSELOR ISN'T ENOUGH THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME PROTOCOLS
ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO SO I'M.
I'M VERY POSITIVE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU WITH THAT ANY.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER SMITH.
HI JUST LIKE I THINK THE THE
AUTHOR AND CHAIR ON THIS ONE YOU
KNOW IF I'M HEARING CONSISTENTLY
ACROSS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
I REPRESENT FROM LEADERSHIP AND
FROM TEACHERS SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING OF THEIR STUDENTS IS
LIKE THE PARAMOUNT CONCERN RIGHT
NOW IT'S GIVING THEM THIS ONE
OTHER.
TOOL THIS ONE OTHER MEASURE OF
SUCCESS WITH OUR STUDENTS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT ON THIS
AND I'M OF THE BILL.
THE MOVE IN SECOND MOVE AYE
MISMAS SECOND AYE MR MCCARTY --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATE.
NOW I'M GONNA LOVE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CLOSE I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN AND APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE SIX OF SIX WAS IT IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FILE
AND FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
BY MISTER CHAN.
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN MR CHAN YOU MAY.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
EVENING YOUR NUMBERS I WANNA
START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE HELP
ON THIS BILL MAKES UP ALL THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AB SEVEN FIFTY REQUIRE ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE AT LEAST ONE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER THE PRESENT ON
EACH CAMPUS DEAR RIVER SCHOOL
HOURS AND WHATEVER PRINCIPLES
AND PEOPLES ARE PRESENT ON
CAMPUS.
THIS BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
FUNDING FOR THESE OFFICERS NOW
COME FROM LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA BILL CFF RATHER BEFORE
THERE'S A STATE MANDATE AND
THEREFORE IT IS NOT TAKING AWAY
ANY EXISTING SCHOOL FUNDING.
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS NATION WIDE A
HEARTBREAKING WE NEED TO BE
PROACTIVE IN OUR APPROACH TO
PROTECTING OUR STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA USE ALL TOOLS AT ITS
DISPOSAL PREVENT SCHOOL BASED
TRAGEDIES HAVING A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER ON EACH CAMPUS
WILL NOT FIX ALL SCHOOL SAFETY
RELATED ISSUES BUT IT IS A START.
THIS WILL SHOW THEIR STUDENTS AT
THE STATE CARES ABOUT THEIR
SAFETY WHILE BEING.
ON LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED STAFFER DRAFTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS EXPLAINED
THAT THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
RELY STUDENTS WITH PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL SECURITY.
THIS ALSO ENCOURAGES SCHOOLS
LOOK AT ALL STAFFING NEEDS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER.
COULD YOU MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IS STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES.
UP WITH THAT -- WILL ALREADY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS.
THE SHARP FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL CHILDREN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
LEARNING WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT
THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY AND
PARENTS SHOULD FEEL THAT SCHOOLS
PLACE WHERE THEIR CHILDREN WILL
BE PROTECTED FROM HARM.
THE MISSION OF EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN HAS TO START WITH
PROVIDING A SAFE PLACE TO LEARN.
THAT SAID WE DISAGREE AS TO HOW
TO MAKE SURE OUR SCHOOLS ARE
SAFE.
THE ACLU RECENTLY ISSUED A
NATIONAL REPORT TITLED COPS AND
NO COUNSELORS HOW THE LACK OF
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH STAFF IS
HARMING STUDENTS.
THAT REPORT CALLS ATTENTION TO
THE LACK OF ADEQUATE NUMBERS OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT STAFF WHO
ARE A KEY PART OF IMPROVING
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND MAKING
SCHOOLS SAFER.
THE DATA USED FOR THAT REPORT
SHOW THAT OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN SCHOOLS WHERE
THERE IS A FULL TIME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
AT THE SCHOOL BUT NO COUNSELOR.
FOR MANY STUDENTS WITH THE
PRESENCE OF A OF SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER CAN MAKE SCHOOL FEEL
MORE LIKE A DETENTION CENTER
THAN A SCHOOL A PLACE WHERE THEY
ARE SEEN AS SUSPECTS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE VIDEOS OF
STUDENTS PUSHED OR THROWN TO THE
GROUND BY THE OFFICERS AND THEIR
SCHOOL SOMETIMES FOR OFFENSES AS
MINOR AS PUT FAILING TO PUT A
CELL PHONE AWAY.
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO REDUCE THE PRESENCE OF POLICE
IN OUR SCHOOLS NOT TO INCREASE
AT WE KNOW HOW TO KEEP SCHOOL
SAFE.
WE NEED TO MAKE OUR SCHOOLS AND
A WELCOMING INCLUSIVE PLACES
THAT SUPPORT THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF THE STUDENTS
AND THAT HAVE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO BUILD COMMUNITY AND
ADDRESS CONFLICT WITH NON
PUNITIVE METHODS.
LET'S FOCUS ON PROVIDING SCHOOLS
WITH THOSE RESOURCES RATHER THAN
INVESTING IN EXPENSIVE MEASURES
THAT WILL JUST MAKE THINGS WORSE
THANK YOU ASKED FOR YOUR NOVEL.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STANDARD FOR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT AB SEVEN FIFTY
COULD LEAD TO CONTRACTING OUT OF
CLASSIFIED POSITIONS.
I'M MORE STILL REVIEWING THOSE
OF THE AUTHORS OFFICE DID SHARE
THAT THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE FLEXIBILITY --
TO CONTRACT WITH OUTSIDE
AGENCIES I'M HOWEVER EDUCATION
CODE DOES ALLOW CONTRACTING OUT
OF CLASSIFIED SERVICES IN
SPECIFIC INSTANCES WHERE CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET.
AND SOME OF THOSE CONDITIONS ARE
PROJECTS TO PROTECT CLASSIFIED
JOBS AND THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN OTHERS UP THE OPPOSITION
WILL BRING A BEHIND THE THE REAL
OF THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS --
BUT MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SUMMER FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD -- I APPRECIATE YOUR
TRYING TO DO I THINK THE
INTENTION KNOWING YOU.
ARE CERTAINLY IS GENUINE --
SOMEONE THAT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
JUST RECALL MY OWN.
UPBRINGING AND BE IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND HAVING FENCING AROUND AND
CAMPUS THAT ALONE -- HAD HAS
EMOTIONAL -- BUT THE MOST TIMES
TO USE HAVING TAUGHT IN HIGH
SCHOOLS AND FOR EXAMPLE IN DC
WHERE.
I STUDENTS AT THE WATER METAL
DETECTORS GOING TO THE SCHOOL --
YOU KNOW I JUST I THINK IT -- IT
SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE
ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE TRYING.
TO CHANGE THIS SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE -- CULTURE THAT'S BEEN
CREATED OVER MANY DECADES
UNFORTUNATELY WE NEED MORE
COUNSELORS BUT OPERATIONAL
NURSES AND MORE TEACHERS IN THE
SCHOOLS BEFORE WE REQUIRE --
THEM TO HAVE MORE SECURITY
OFFICERS SO JUST RESPECTFULLY I
WON'T GO TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY
BUT STILL PUSHING.
THANK YOU MISTER CARTER.
YEAH I THINK YOU AYE AYE I MET
WITH YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR DIALOGUE IN YOUR HISTORY
TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU.
HAVE WORK WITHIN YOUR PRIOR LIFE
AND I'M HAVING A TOUGH TIME
ESPECIALLY AFTER LAST BILL.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR
MORE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND THEY AND THE
COUNSELOR RATIO IS IS --
DISGRACE AND YOU KNOW IT'S
GETTING WORSE IN SOME DISTRICTS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY LAYING OFF
COUNSELORS IN THESE
PROFESSIONALS AND YOU KNOW I SAW
A BUNCH OF YOUNG PEOPLE HERE AT
THE CAPITOL FEW WEEKS AGO THE
SIGNS AND THEY SAID WHAT THEY
WANTED MORE COUNSELORS NOT
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS AND SO.
I THINK IT'S HARD WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE AND TALK TO THEM
AND SUPPORT THEM.
AT THE SAME TIME.
FOCUS ON THIS BUT I WILL NOTE
THAT -- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
BEAUTIES OF LCF AFTER FRANKLY
NOT ENOUGH MONEY AS WE KNOW
WE'RE STILL FORTY FIRST NATION
FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS WAS THAT.
IT'S UP TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES IF
THEY THINK THIS IS A PRIORITY.
THEY CERTAINLY CAN CAN STEP UP
AND FOCUS THEIR THEIR RESOURCES
HERE -- I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORT TO TAKE IT OUT OF THAT
MOVIE TO MANDATE BUT IT'S IT ONE
MORE DOLLAR GOING TO PAY A STATE
MANDATE WHETHER I'LL SET UP OR
NOT HE'S IS A DOLLAR THAT WE
WON'T HAVE. TO TO POTENTIALLY
OVER APPROPRIATE NINETY EIGHT I
MEAN MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT HEALTH NINETY
IT SHOULDN'T BE.
SHOULDN'T BE -- YOU KNOW.
THE END ALL THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON OVER A PER PER OVER
APPROPRIATING SO.
IT DOES PUT PRESSURE ON US IN
HERE IS THAT -- I DON'T THINK
OUR PURPOSE SO -- I WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FOR IT LET ME SEE IF I'M IF I'M
CLEAR ON THIS THIS BEGAN
ORIGINALLY AS A MANDATE.
EVERYBODY HAD TO HAVE AT LEAST.
ONE NOW IT JUST SAYS THAT IS
THAT YOU YOU CAN HAVE.
ONE OR YOU CAN DO IT BUT YOU'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO DO IT IS THAT
CORRECT. FOR ASKING THAT -- ALL
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN EVERY SCHOOL
CAMPUS HAVE AN SRO WHEN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE CHANGE FROM A
SIMILAR BILL AS TO THE LAST YEAR.
ARE THOSE PRESENTED BY SOMEONE
JAMES GALLAGHER WAS THE S. R. O.
COULD BE ARMED OR UNARMED IT
WOULD BE UP TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY'LL BE.
CHOOSING A DECIDING SUCH.
OKAY SO.
BASICALLY THE RECORD YOUR
ORIGINAL ONE WAS TO REQUIRE
THE AMENDMENT SAY IT INTENT TO
AN URGE SCHOOLS TO CONSIDER
OVERALL STAFFING LEVELS TO
ENSURE AB ONE IS NOT THERE
ANYMORE JUST.
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
URGED TO CONSIDER IT IS THAT
CORRECT MISTER CHAIR.
WELL WE HAVE A DID THE
AMENDMENTS.
IT IS A MANDATE. FOR AN SRO PER
SCHOOL -- SOLIS WAS IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
IT TO BE CLEAR IT IS A MANDATE
IT IS A MANDATE OKAY THEN AB I
THOUGHT IT'D GONE RECOMMENDATION
THEN I I WOULD MANDATE IT MOST
OF MY SCHOOLS HAVE AS SORROWS
BUT I DON'T THINK I WANT TO
MANDATE THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE --
ONE I WOULD MIND IF YOU KNOW
THEY WANT TO CONSIDERED WHICH
THEY CAN'T AT THIS POINT BUT IT
BECOMES DIFFICULT TO MANDATE --
S. ARE ALL WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
OTHER THINGS ON CAMPUS SO ANYWAY
BUT THANK YOU I THOUGHT IT WAS
HAD BEEN CHANGED SO THIS
LANGUAGE IS VERY.
THANK YOU -- I I I THINK YOU FOR
THE BILL I THINK THERE'S SOME
THINGS YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT
AS FAR AS LIKE EIGHTY A WHAT IS
THE ATTENDANCE OF THE SCHOOL.
AS EVERY SCHOOL REALLY NEED THAT.
SOME OF OUR LARGER SCHOOLS LIKE
THE HIGH SCHOOL I CAME FROM HEAD.
TO OKAY BUT THEY AREN'T ALWAYS
ON CAMPUS AS WELL I THINK PEOPLE
NEED TO REALIZE -- THEY'RE OFTEN
DRIVING AROUND THE CAMPUS
BECAUSE THINGS HAPPEN AROUND THE
CAMPUS DURING THE DAY AND
CERTAINLY THE BEGINNING TODAY
AND FOR SURE AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
SO TO SAY WE DON'T NEED THESE ON
OUR CAMPUSES AT ALL IS A VERY
UNDER EDUCATED PERSPECTIVE THAT
IS SOMEONE WHO HAS NOT SEEN THE
TRAGEDY.
THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
FROM MY HIGH SCHOOL MORE THAN
ONCE.
AND I'D LOVE TO THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT.
ACTIVE PRESENCE FROM PLACE RIGHT
AROUND THE SCHOOL IN PARTICULAR --
DURING THOSE THOSE THOSE THOSE
MORE VULNERABLE HOURS BEFORE AND
AFTER SCHOOL IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
AND I THINK HAVING A A AN
OFFICER ON CAMPUS HELPS A LOT TO
KNOW IN OFTENTIMES YOU KNOW THEY
AREN'T THEY THEY ARE.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE THE VISION
THAT IS SOMEHOW WALKING AROUND
THE CLASSROOMS AND READY TO
CATCH A BUS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PERFORMING ANY DISCIPLINE ON
CAMPUS UNLESS IT'S PROBABLY SOME
SERIOUS CRIME.
BUT VERY RARELY WHAT A POLICE
OFFICER EVER ENGAGES STUDENTS
WITH REGARD TO THE TO SOMETHING
THE STUDENT DID AT SCHOOL AGAIN
UNLESS IT WERE A SERIOUS CRIME
SO -- THESE OFFICERS.
TO PROVIDE SAFETY AT OUR
CAMPUSES LISTEN MY SCHOOL FIVE
THOUSAND KIDS PLUS RIGHT THAT'S
A SMALL CITY.
YEAH BUT YOU A SMALL CITY OF
FIVE THOUSAND AS MORE POLICE
OFFICERS THAT BUT DO WE NEED
MORE COUNSELORS ABSOLUTELY WE
NEED MORE COUNSELORS WILL YOU
NEED BE COPS ON CAMPUS -- GRANT
YOU THAT BUT TO SAY WE DO NOT
NEED ANY COPS ON CAMPUS IS IS A
VERY UNEDUCATED PERSPECTIVE AND
I THINK PUTS CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
YOU KNOW IN IN IN AN UNSAFE SPOT
I HAVE.
A DAUGHTER HIGH SCHOOL QUE I
WANNA.
POLICE OFFICER ON OUR CAMPUS AND
I KNOW THAT IN OUR CITY IN THE
PAST I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TODAY WHEN I MATCH IS
STILL THE CITY ACTUALLY FUNDS
THAT POLICE OFFICER.
ON THE CAMPUS BECAUSE THEY SEE
IT AS A NET BENEFIT FOR THE FOR
THE ENTIRE CITY TO HAVE A A
PRESENCE ON CAMPUS AND ALSO.
YOU KNOW DURING A LITTLE HOURS
TO DRIVE AROUND THE SCHOOL TO
HAVE THAT PRESENCE SO WITH THAT
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
BILL BUT AGAIN I THIS IS VERY
COSTLY.
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT -- AND
AGAIN I WANT MORE COUNSELORS AND
COPS BUT STILL I WANT COPS WITH
THAT -- THERE'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED I BELIEVE KNOW IF.
WE HAVE A VOTE MOTION.
YOU MUST KNOW ALL SECOND.
IT'S TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT -- TIME SORRY DID NOT CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TIME I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE MR MCLARTY'S COMMENTS
DR WEBBER'S AND ALSO MISTER
KALRA AS IN THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD PART OF
THIS.
FROM MY BACKGROUND IS EDUCATOR
I'VE YOU SEE MY DOCTORATE FROM
USC YET I DON'T HAVE TO PAY MY
WAY AND BY THE WAY.
BUT I DID GET MY DOCTORATE FROM
U. S. C. AND ONE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD AND THE
ACADEMIC JOURNALS THAT WE HAD.
WAS BY DOCTOR PATIENT GARCIA AND
IT TALKED ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AS
RELATIONS ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND ALTERNATIVE THE THESIS THE
IMPETUS OF THAT ACADEMIC DURABLE
WAS WHEN STUDENTS DON'T FEEL
SAFE IT REDUCES OUR ABILITY TO
LEARN.
AND I TRULY BELIEVE HAS A FORMER
RESERVE DEPUTY AS A FORMER
EDUCATOR MYSELF.
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE SAFE
IN A SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
MAKING SURE THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP
IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
SECURE.
IN ADDITION TO A LOT OF ESTARá
OWNS THEIR MORE THAN SOMEONE IS
JUST A SOURCE OF SECURITY.
THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL THEY'RE
THE BIG BROTHERS AND BIG SISTERS
ON CAMPUS AND THEIR SURROGATE
MOTHER AND FATHER SO THIS REALLY
MY INTENT TO CREATE A INDICATION
ENVIRONMENT.
HOUSE WERE SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT IS
SAFE FOR ALL KIDS AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT I APPRECIATE --
THE CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE I
CERTAINLY WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH
YOU CONTINUING ON THIS BILL.
I SAY WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY AS
WHEN I WROTE THE HEARING AT THAT
POINT THEY'RE MORE THAN JUST
POLICE OFFICERS OR ASST.
SOME TYPE OF OFFICER BECAUSE THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THINGS
THAT HAPPEN OUTSIDE THE SCHOOL
OFTEN COME INTO THE SCHOOL AND
THINGS THAT HAPPEN INSIDE THE
SCHOOL OFTEN GO OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL.
ESPECIALLY IN SUMMER MORE DENSER
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEY CAN OTHER
FINGER ON THE PULSE TO HELP
ADDRESS THEM VERY PROACTIVELY
BEFORE THEY BECOME A TRAGEDY SO
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I'D KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING [inaudible]
SO.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES FAILED.
YOUR TIME MISTER THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOTOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB FOR THIRTEEN BY MISTER --
JONES SAWYER.
MISTER JONES STORY MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF AB FOUR ONE THREE CHANGES.
REFERENCES OF AT RISK TO AT
PROMISE IN THE EDUCATION AND
PENAL CODES.
AT RISK IS A STIGMATIZED LABEL
THAT IS CREATED AN EX
EXPECTATION OF FAILURE FAILURE
AND FOCUSES.
ON THE LIKELIHOOD OF USE
BECOMING ANOTHER STATISTIC THIS
IS A MINDSET THAT IS ALL TOO
PERVASIVE IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES.
AT THE STATE WE NEED TO BE MORE
INTENTIONAL WITH THE LANGUAGE WE
USE AND BE AWARE OF THE MESSAGE
THAT IT SENDS TO BOTH THE
STUDENTS AND THE PROFESSIONALS
WORKING WITH THEM.
IMAGINE OUR STUDENTS ATTENDING
AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT IS
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE VIEWED AS
AT RISK.
RISK IS SOMETHING WE ACTUALLY
TRY TO AVOID OFTENTIMES IS
SOMETHING WE WANT NOTHING TO DO
WITH OUR WILL MINIMIZE ALL AT
ALL COSTS.
THIS LABEL SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
DESCRIBE THE POTENTIAL OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH.
BY CHANGING THIS LANGUAGE WE DO
TWO THINGS. ONE WE'RE SENDING A
MESSAGE TO PROFESSIONALS WORKING
WITH STUDENTS THAT WE NEED TO
INVEST IN IT IN EIGHT GIVES
EVERY CHILD POSSESSES AND TO
WE'RE TELLING THE STUDENT THAT
THEY'RE WORTH IT.
AND THAT WE BELIEVE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED WORDS MATTER.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
FOLLOW THE PRESIDENT WE HAVE
ALREADY SET USING PEOPLE FIRST
LANGUAGE AND THE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES COMMUNITY.
AND TRANSITION TO THE STRENGTH
BASED APPROACH OF AT PROMISED
THE STUDENTS ARE MORE THAN THEIR
SITUATION AND THEY NEED TO BE
TREATED AS SUCH.
BY USING A MORE POSITIVE MINDSET
AB FOR THIRTEEN ENCOURAGES
TEACHERS TO EMPOWERS STUDENTS
AND EMPHASIZED THEIR IMMENSE
POTENTIAL TO SUCCEED RATHER THAN
FOCUS ON WHAT THEY LACK FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE BOAT WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
IS ARE ANY SOBRE FROM AS I. A.
TECH AND PAM GIVES OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON MANY SILVA --
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS
SAITEK I ALSO SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
REACHING OUT PROMISE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION WE PICKED THAT TITLE
BECAUSE WORDS ARE POWERFUL.
AND SHOWERING UNDER PERFORMING
STUDENTS WITH POSITIVE LANGUAGE
LIKE AT PROMISE NOT ONLY
INCREASES THE CONFIDENCE AND
PERSISTENCE.
IT ALL THE DATE ALSO SHOWS THAT
INCREASES EDUCATE ALSO
EDUCATIONAL ASSESSMENT OUTCOMES
AS WELL.
THE FOCUS ON DEFICIT LOW IS
EXPECTATIONS LOWERED
EXPECTATIONS LEAD TO FILL YOUR
DISENGAGEMENT.
HAVE PROMISED FOCUSES ON THE
POTENTIAL OF A STUDENT WE
RECOGNIZE POTENTIAL STUDENTS
HAVE HIGHER EXPECTATIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEY DEMONSTRATE
STRONGER OUTCOMES AB FOR
THIRTEEN SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
WORK AT ADDRESSING TRAUMA.
BUILDING MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY
RELATIONSHIPS AND RECOGNIZING
THE INHERENT VALUES OF STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WE ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIPSON
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
DR TO AVERAGE ONE OF WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
KNOW AS THE MEMBER SAID AND AS
OUR CO SPONSOR SAID WORDS MATTER.
I RECENTLY ATTENDED AN EVENT
WHERE I VOLUNTEERED TO HELPS
SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO WERE
CONSIDERED AT RISK AND I WAS
VERY DISMAYED TO SEE A POSTER.
REFERRING TO THEM AS SUCH THEY
WERE AT RISK STUDENTS AND THIS
IS WHAT THE PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED
TO DO WAS THIS SUPPOSED TO SERVE
TO SERVE THEM.
AND I FELT THIS MADE ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE IN LIGHT OF THIS BILL I
THOUGHT ONE OF THE STUDENTS
FEELING.
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE VOLUNTEERING AND EDUCATORS
HAVE AN INTEREST IN SEEING THE
BEST IN THE CHILDREN.
THAT WE ARE SERVING.
IT'S THE CHILDREN'S VIEW OF
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY SEE A
POSTER LIKE THAT IMAGINE IF IT
SAID SERVING AT PROMISE YOU WHEN
THEY WALK INTO THE DOOR OF SUCH
A PROGRAM.
SO IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
FEEL A CHANGE IN THE LAW WOULD
BE HELPFUL BUT ALSO IT THE
CHANGE IN THE WAY WE SPEAK ABOUT
THESE USE OF WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
THEM FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JEFF PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION
SAYING OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER KALRA MOVE THE BILL AND
YOU KNOW ALL OF THIS BILL I'M
GONNA GET WHENEVER I GET A
CHANCE WANNA SIGN ON THIS BILL
IS BEEN MOVED THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A SECOND MISMAS SECONDS
I SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT -- THE
MOTION IS.
PUBLIC TO PASS TO PUBLIC SAFETY --
YOU MAKE THE BEST HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
VERY CLOSE THAT'S MY COLORLESS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY O'DONNELL AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KALRA.
ALL RIGHTS MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I AND WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I HAS FOUR VOTES THE BILLS
OUT.
THANK YOU.
SO WILL NOT BE MOVING TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER BELLS AS
STARTING WITH FILE NUMBER FOUR
AB FORTY EIGHT ON CHAIR
O'DONNELL.
WAS MISTER CHAIR -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB FORTY EIGHT IS A
VEHICLE FOR TO SCHOOL FACILITY
BONDS ONE IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM IS A HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT IS BASED
ON A PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN STATE SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND DEVELOPERS.
STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LOCAL FUNDS AND DEVELOPER
FEES.
TOGETHER THESE FUNDS HAVE BUILT
NEW SCHOOLS MODERNIZE AGING
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE SAFE AND UPDATED.
AND SUPPORTED VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS.
THESE FUNDS ALSO HELP THE
ECONOMY BY GENERATING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
VOTERS SUPPORTED STATE FACILITY
BONDS IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND TWO THOUSAND SIX THE
LAST BOND PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
WAS PASSED TEN YEARS LATER.
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN DUE TO THE LIKELY
W
MODERNIZATION FUNDS FOR
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE ARE
ALREADY DEPLETED THAT'S THE ONE
JUST PASSED PROPOSITION FORTY
FIFTY ONE THOSE ARE ALREADY
COMPLETED AND CLIMB.
THE NEED IS GREAT WE ALL KNOW
FACILITIES MATTER IN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND STUDENT
MOTIVATION THEY SET THE TONE FOR
THE SCHOOL NAME.
THIS BILL PLACES A KATE THROUGH
FOURTEEN BOND ON THE MARCH THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY ELECTION
AND ANOTHER ONE ON THE NOVEMBER
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO GENERAL
ELECTION.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS WILL BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
IN ADDITION TO THE BASIC
PROGRAMS NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION CT IN CHARTERS
THIS BILL ADDRESSES MORE RECENT
NEEDS INCLUDING DISASTER
ASSISTANCE.
TESTING AND REMEDIATION AND LEAD
IN AND OF LEAD AND WATER.
REPLACEMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD BUILDINGS AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS THE STATE'S
CARTER TO ROUTE CONTRIBUTION AND
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE HOUSE AND SAFE
FACILITIES.
CONDUCIVE. TO LEARNING AND HERE
TO RIDE A SHORT TESTIMONY IS
ERIC POCKY.
AREAS -- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION A JEFF
BECKER WITH THE FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THANK YOU
FOR STAYING.
RESEARCH SAYS THAT ADEQUATE AND
I'M SORRY ERIC BALK AT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
AT RESEARCH SAYS THAT ADEQUATE
IN MODERN FACILITIES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS SIMPLY
CANNOT FULFILL THEIR ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL IF ATTENTION IS NOT
GIVEN TO ENSURE FACILITIES ARE
CLEAN SAFE AND SECURE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF PARTICIPATE IN THE
STATE PROGRAM IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND THEY'VE DONE SO
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
THIS PARTNERSHIP IS BENEFITTED
MORE THAN SIX MILLION STUDENTS.
IN TALKING WITH OUR MEMBERS
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
PROP AB.
FORTY EIGHT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PASSAGE OF LOCAL BONDS AND
REVIEW FACILITIES MASTER PLAN
YOU'LL QUICKLY RECOGNISE THE
VOLUME WORK THAT STILL
OUTSTANDING AND HE DID.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A NEED TO
CONSTRUCT NEW SCHOOL BUILDINGS
IN AREAS A GROWTH.
RECONFIGURE EXISTING FIGURE --
FACILITIES TO GREAT LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS THAT MEET SCHOOLS
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION.
UPDATE BUILDING SYSTEMS PROVIDES --
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS AND THE LIST
GOES ON FOR THESE REASONS THE
SBA SUPPORTS AB.
FORTY EIGHT GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M JEFF BECKER AND THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES AND
OPERATIONS FOR THE FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
AND ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING OR CASH.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL FOR INTRODUCING
AB FORTY EIGHT AND INVOLVING
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS.
YOU FOR IT SAID SCHOOLS NEED A
BOND IN TWENTY TWENTY AND AGAIN
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
APPLICATIONS FOR PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDS HAVE
ALREADY EXCEEDED AVAILABLE BOND
AUTHORITY.
AND DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS TO THE STATE THE
SOONER THERE'S A NEW FACILITY
BOND.
THE SMALLER THE UNFUNDED BACKLOG
WILL BE.
CASH APPRECIATES THE PROGRAM
CHANGES CONTAINED IN THE BILL
FOR DISASTER ASSISTANCE
REPLACING VERY OLD BUILDINGS
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND
ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE INCLUDING HEALTH
FACILITIES AS PART OF A JOINT
USE PROGRAM IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES REGARDING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
FINALLY CASH LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH AUTHOR IN
STAKEHOLDERS ON FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP REFORMS AND OTHER
ISSUES AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO HAVE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IAN
PEDIA REPRESENTING THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION THE SCHOOL
FACILITY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COUNTY
SCHOOL FACILITIES CONSORTIUM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YVONNE COTTRELL WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
GOOD EVENING RICHARD LION ON
BEHALF OF THE HOME BUILDERS
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
OF FUNDING PARTNER IN THE
GROWING AREAS OF THE STATE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE GARAGE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION MARICOPA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ATASCADERO%
UNIFIED AND FOR NO UNIFIED IN
SUPPORT.
SERRA BUT JUST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
A BILL KIßM REPRESENTING THAT
TO DOES THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION.
JUST HAVE TO COMMEND THE GREAT
OUT REGION WORK BY THE STAFF ON
THIS BILL.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
EASY COALITION WITH THE
INCLUSION OF JOINT USE
FACILITIES SET ASIDE AND THERE
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING THE ANGELA READ ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SAN
BERNARDINO DISTRICT ADVERT
ASSEMBLY TO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION ON
SUPPORT.
MATT PATTON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THE CALL RISE CALVARY
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER GONNA LIVE.
I THINK -- IT'S TIME TO PUT --
THESE MEASURES ON THE BALLOT
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND FULL SUPPORT.
THE MEASURE THAT WE HAD THE
BALLOTS TO THE YEARS AGO IT'S
ALREADY NOT ENOUGH.
AND WE NEED TO STEP IT UP NOT
JUST FOR OF COURSE -- NEW
CLASSROOMS WITH OUR ENROLLMENT
CALIFORNIA BUT TO START AGING
FACILITIES AND TO MAKE SURE THAT.
OUR CLASSROOMS MEET THE NEEDS OF
EDUCATION IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SO I'M ALL WITH YOU ON
THIS.
I HAVE ONE ISSUE THAT THE YOU
KNOW I'VE TALKED TO YOU ABOUT IS --
WE GO FOR HISTORICALLY THEY'VE
BEEN EITHER A K. FOURTEEN BOND.
OR SOMETIMES A CASE SIXTEEN BOND
AND I'M ASKING THAT WE PUT ONE
LITTLE LETTER AT THE BEGINNING A
P.. FOR OUT REALLY EDUCATION AND
THAT'S FOR PUBLIC EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR STATE
STATE FUNDED PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
AT PUBLIC FACILITY SO.
I HAVE ANOTHER MEASURE THAT TIME
WORKING WITH AS YOU KNOW AND YOU
KNOW -- THINKING ABOUT IT'S IT'S
GOING FORWARD BETTER TO TO TO
TEAM UP WITH THIS ONE ON YOU SO
HOPE WE CAN MAKE THAT --
PARTNERSHIP AND AND WE'RE GOING.
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DR WEBER.
YES I HAVE.
I'M AND YOU KNOW WHAT ALWAYS IN
FAVOR BONDS AND BECAUSE OF
FACILITIES ARE. FOR EVERY NEED
OF REPLACEMENT AND UPGRADE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT COMES ALONG
AND I KIDS DESERVE TO HAVE NICE
LOOKING FACILITIES -- ONE OF THE
THINGS WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT WHEN
WE DOING BOND MEASURES WE DID
WITH THE OR YOU COULD JUST
CONSTRUCTION WHATEVER WE TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE THAT IT CREATES
JOBS.
AND OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE
BOARD I WOULD JUST SIMPLY LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE US TO RECOGNIZE
THAT OFTENTIMES.
LIKE MANY COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT
OUT OF THAT IN PARTICULAR
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE
APPRENTICESHIPS.
THE BONDS THE CONTRACTS THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND OFTENTIMES
NOT BENEFIT FROM THE BOND THAT
WE PUT OUT THERE.
AND SO I KNOW PROP TWO OH NINE
IS A OR WHATEVER WHATEVER BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB I THINK IT OUT WHICH THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I TO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SPORTS FACTOR YOU'RE GOING
FORWARD WITH THIS I REPRESENT
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE THE COMMUNITY
STEP UP RIGHT OUR COMMUNITIES
LOVE OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS.
TIME FOR THE STATE TO STEP UP
AGAIN WITH THE MATCH THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTRIBUTING SO --
THAT BEING SAID HIM OPPORTUNE
CLOSE.
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE A MEMBERS WE
HAVE MOTION.
SO I GET I HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
SECRETARY KALRA PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO HIGHER
EDUCATION O'DONNELL.
RIGHT O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I FIVE VOTES THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU.
THE MANAGER OF A GOOD MOVE AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX PLEASE DON'T.
YEP ALREADY -- I THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY FOR BEING.
AN AUTHOR ON THIS AS WELL -- I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL FACILITATE
THE DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BY ENSURING THAT AVAILABLE
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS ARE USED
EFFECTIVELY.
WE KNOW THAT YOUTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS ARE MORE LIKELY
WE KNOW THAT YOUTH WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL. TO ENGAGE
IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
RISK TAKING BEHAVIOS.
RULES RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS BUT GENERALLY LACK THE
LACK LACK ACCESS TO THE
NECESSARY FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THE SERVICES ARE
EXPENSIVE AND THEY NEED TO BE.
CONDUCTED BY PROFESSIONALS.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
COMMISSION OVERSEES THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACTOR MHSAA
WHICH FUNDS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
THROUGH A 1% TAX ON PERSONAL
INCOMES ABOVE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
A PORTION OF THE M. HSA FUNDS
ARE TO BE USED FOR PREVENTION
AND EARLY PREVENTION FOR
CHILDREN IN YEARS.
IN MANY CASES SCHOOLS ARE UNDER
WELLER UNAWARE OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE FUNDS OR
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO ACCESS THEM
TO MEET THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
OF THEIR STUDENTS.
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO
SUPPORT COUNTIES IN ADDRESSING
KEY MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
INCLUDING SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP TOOLS TO
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY A MENTAL HEALTH
EXPENDITURES ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS WILL ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND MORE
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND FUNNY
AVAILABLE TO MEET LOCAL NEEDS.
FINALLY AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
WILL ESTABLISH AN INNOVATION AND
AGAIN CURATOR. TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO INNOVATIVE COUNTY
SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS WRITING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS AND WITH ME. TO TO TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE A DOCTOR TOBY
EWING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
AND YVONNE -- CARILLO OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT MINISTRY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MANAGED TO BE DOING I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION FOR
SET UP TO BE HERE THIS EVENING --
SO THE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
THE COMMISSION REALLY HAS BEEN
WORKING TO PUT IN PLACE TOOLS
AND STRATEGIES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING IN OUR
COUNTIES AND WHERE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE.
THE COMMISSION HAS PRIORITIZE
SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH AS A TOPIC
THAT WE NEED TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO
IS REALLY EQUIPPED THE STATE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING
AND WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND WHEN
THEY'RE AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE TO PUT IN PLACE
STRATEGIES THAT CAN SUPPORT THE
KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
NECESSARY BETWEEN OUR COUNTIES?
AND OUR SCHOOLS AND OTHER
PARTNERS PARTNERS AND I WOULD
AND I WOULD ADD IN IN REFERENCE
TO MR MCCARTY'S COMING EARLIER
THAT WOULD INCLUDE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONS AND OTHER KINDS OF
PARTNERS FOR THAT KEY.
PRIOR TO THAT THE K. TWELVE OF
THE CASE SIXTEEN CONVERSATION.
IT ALSO IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO ENGAGE
THOSE PARTNERS TO THINK ABOUT
CREATIVE AND INNOVATIVE WAYS
THAT WE CAN RE THINK HOW WE
DELIVER CARE IN WAYS IT'S MORE
HUMAN CENTERED.
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE PAST THAT
THE HISTORICAL TRADITIONAL WAYS
OF OFTEN STYLING CARE BASED ON A
DIAGNOSIS ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
AND REALLY THINK ABOUT
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES THE DROP ON THE
STRENGTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
SUCH AS OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
COUNTIES WITHOUT THE COMMISSION
IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE THINK IT SIGNALS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
REALLY PARTNER WITH THE COUNTIES.
TO NOT JUST UNDERSTAND IS
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT WORKING
BUT TO PUT IN PLACE THE
STRATEGIES TO STRENGTHEN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WITH THAT
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING -- MY NAME IS EVEN
CARRY ON WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
AND AUTHORS IN THE COMMITTEES
RECOGNITION OF THE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT THAT'S FACING
OUR YOUTH I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AXIS SUPPORTS A. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BECAUSE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS.
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED.
IT WILL DO THIS BY INCREASING
STAKEHOLDERS ABILITY. TO
EVALUATE THE EFFICACY OF
SERVICES FUNDED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
BY INCORPORATING STUDENT
CENTERED METRICS A. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX WILL INCREASE THE
FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AT SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WILL HELP TO
BREAK DOWN SILOS BETWEEN
EDUCATION AND COUNTY PROVIDERS.
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
PLEASE TRY TO CARE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
JIMMY FROM IN A DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS.
FANTASTIC REAR MOTION A SECOND
JUDGE CLOSE.
YES YOU WERE ASKED WHAT I
THOUGHT I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES THE THE SUPPORT FOR
STAYING SO LATE.
THANK YOU I WITH THAT BIAS.
FOR NINE VERY GOOD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO HEALTH
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I'D KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA.
COLORIZED MCCARTY.
MCCARTY EYES SMITH SMITH I AND
WEBER.
WEBER AYE. SIX VOTES THE BILLS
OUT.
MR DOWN MOVING ON TO FILE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE AB.
THIRTEEN OH THREE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB THIRTEEN OH THREE
WHICH INCREASES THE FUNDING FOR
CRITICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS TWO
TO FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
PER YEAR FOR THE ONE ONE LOCAL
MATCH.
THIS BILL ALSO CONSOLIDATES K.
TWELVE CT PROGRAMS BY SHIFTING
TO K. TWELVE PORTION OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES BACK TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
HIGH QUALITY CAREER TECHNOLOGY
KENSHIN'S IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
GAIN THE SKILLS THEY NEED TO
ENTER THE WORKFORCE OR MARK ON
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
TRAINING.
THE STRENGTH OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY DEPENDS ON SKILLED
WORKFORCE A SKILLED WORKFORCE
AND SEAT HE PROGRAMS ARE
ESSENTIAL.
ARE ESSENTIAL PART OF BUILDING
THAT WORKFORCE AND I I WAS IN MY
CLASSROOM I CAN SAY THAT.
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT
STUDENTS NEED MULTIPLE PATHS TO
SUCCESS.
WE SHOULD NOT TRACK THEM.
WE SHOULD MAKE THEM ALL YOU KNOW
RATE COLLEGE READY BUT THE SAME
TIME WE SHOULDN'T MANDATE THAT
THEY CAUGHT THEY ALL GO TO
COLLEGE.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET PROVIDING
ONGOING FUNNY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE C. T. PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS WATER FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM -- CLEARLY THERE IS A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FOR FUNNY ON
GOING FUNDING TO SUPPORT HIGH
QUALITY C. T. PROGRAMS ARE IS
ALSO A CLEAR NEED TO CONSOLIDATE.
THE K. TWELVE CT PROGRAMS TO
AVOID SIGNIFICAN HURDLES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT.
AT BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS AND HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN OH THREE
US -- WHEN SKILLS THAT -- NO --
MAYBE NOT -- LINDA GRANGER
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE EATEN R.
O. P. AND JULIE DUNCAN TRI
VALLEY R. O. P..
I WITH THAT BEFORE I TURN OVER
TO MY WITNESSES I ALSO WANT TO
THANK CHAIRMAN CARTY.
WHO IS VERY ACTIVE IN SUPPORT OF --
FUNDING C. T. AS CHAIR OF BUDGET
SUB TO THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT
WITHOUT MY WITNESSES MANAGER.
THE GRAINGER SUPERINTENDENT WITH
EATING AREA REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM AND I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THREE THINGS
THAT I HAVE THINK OF BEEN
EFFECTIVE UNDER THE SEA TAKE
PROGRAM. ONE IS THE ALLOCATION
MODEL GIVEN THAT IT IS BASED ON
EIGHTY EIGHT IT PROVIDES FOR A
MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. TO ONGOING FUNDING
WITH ANNUAL ACCOUNTABILITY
INSURERS THAT WE MAINTAIN IN
PROGRESS.
NAME PROGRESS TOWARD EVERY
PROGRAM MEETING HIGH QUALITY
STANDARD FORT CTP. THREE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
REGIONAL MODEL OF DELIVERY
THROUGH THE COUNTIES LEVERAGES
STAFFING TO PROVIDE TAILOR
CONTENT TO THE FIELD BASED ON
THE NEEDS OF THE REGION.
CONTRAST THAT WITH THE STRONG
WORK FORCE MODEL ONGOING
STATEWIDE FUNDING HAS BEEN
TURNED INTO A ONE TIME REGIONAL
COMPETITIVE GRANTS AND YOU CAN
ONLY APPLY IF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AGREES TO WORK WITH YOU.
YET THE ALLOCATION IS PARTIALLY
BASED ON EIGHTY A OF THE REGION
THIS CREATES AN ACCESS AND
EQUITY ISSUE.
GRANTS ARE ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE STRONG WORK FORCE REGIONS
AND THEY WERE NOT SET UP TO HAVE
THE STRUCTURE OR KNOWLEDGE OF K.
TWELVE NEEDED TO MANAGE THIS
PROGRAM WHY CREATING ANOTHER
SYSTEM WHEN WE HAVE THE CD.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS AN ISSUE SEVEN
OF THE METRICS ARE LAGGING
INDICATORS ASSESSED ONLY AFTER
THE STUDENT ENTERS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR COMPLETE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTING FOR STUDENTS WHO
ENTER DIRECTLY INTO UNIVERSITY.
JOIN THE MILITARY OR TRADE
SCHOOL OR GO TO WORK IF WE WANT
A COORDINATED SYSTEMATIC
DELIVERY OF C. D. E. IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE FOR IT TO BE UNDER
ONE SYSTEM THROUGH THE C. T. E. --
THROUGH THIS YOU TAKE PROGRAM
UNDER THE CD THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULIE DUNCAN AND I AM
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF TRI VALLEY
R. O. P. AND I REPRESENT CREW
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FOR DUBLIN
UNIFIED LAMAR VALLEY JOINT
UNIFIED IN PLEASANTON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AS SUPER TENET GRANGER STATED ON
GOING FUNDING WITH ANNUAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ENABLES YOU TO
MAINTAIN AND IMPROVE CD PROGRAM
SYSTEMATICALLY.
THE WAY IN WHICH THE INCENTIVE
GRANT WAS DESIGNED.
THE SYSTEM PUTS IT -- PUT IN
PLACE BY THE CITY OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AND ABLE DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE
THE TRAINING.
AND THE TOOLS TO DEVELOP
MAINTAIN AND ENHANCE THEIR C. T.
PROGRAMS.
IN ALL MY YEARS IN EDUCATION
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE IMPRESSED
WITH THE LEVEL SUPPORT AND
CONSISTENCY AT ALL LEVELS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
IN REGARDS THE INCENTIVE GRANT.
THE METRICS WERE CLEAR AND
FOCUSED ON THE ELEMENTS THAT
MAKE UP A HIGH QUALITY C. T.
PROGRAM WHICH DO INCLUDE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
THROUGH ARTICULATIONS DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND WITH EMPLOYERS
THROUGH INDUSTRY ADVISORY
COMMITTEES WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH INCLUDE
INTERNSHIPS AND CERTIFICATIONS.
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY IS ALIGNED
TO THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
INDICATOR.
I UNDERSTAND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT OF ED WERE
HANDED THE STRONG FORCE
LEGISLATION AND HAD TO MAKE THE
BEST WITH WHAT THEY WERE GIVEN.
HOWEVER WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
CORRECT WHAT MOST SEE IS AN
ACCESS AND EQUITY ISSUE IN PLACE
ALL THE C. T. E. DOLLARS FOR
KATE TROLL THROUGH THE CD TO THE
AND C. D. E. INCENTIVE GRANT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
PLEASE IF I'VE GOT A WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALLING THE HALF OF
DOCTOR ALMA HARVEST THE ORANGE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT.
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING THE ANGELA REED
SKEWS ME ON BEHALF OF CARE OP
THE ASSOCIATION OF CAREER IN
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS THANKS.
HELLO THEY LONNIE I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SCHOOLS FOR SOUND
FINANCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS -- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ALSO CO CHAIR OF THE
GET REAL COALITION THAT WAS PART
OF THE EFFORT TO GET TO SEE TAKE
PASSAGE.
IN THAN INITIALLY SO WE'RE GLAD
FOR THIS EXPANSION AND WE'RE
HERE SUPPORT THANK YOU -- BALK
AT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
NANCY TRIES TO SPIN OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION MANAGERS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
WELL THE BILL SECOND.
RIGHT IN MOTION A SECOND SIR
DOLLARS LIKE CLOSE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE AND MCCARTY HI MCCARTY
I'D SMITH SMITH AYE AND WEBER.
WEBER I SIX VOTES THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO MOVED.
WHATEVER IS GONNA CONNEX SO
WOULD NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE STILL
HAVE BILLS.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN.
VOTED UPON.
YES WHEN I SURELY KNOWS AND SO
WITH THE AGREEMENT OF THE VICE
CHAIR WE ARE ALLOWING THREE
MEMBERS TO WAY PRESENTATION ON
THE FOLLOWING BILLS.
THOSE BILLS ARE FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY
MR ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR A.
B. SIXTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER
REAVIS.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX BY MISTER KALRA.
AND I WILL ASK FOR ANY SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
IT -- AND THEN WE'LL CALL THEM.
SO WE'LL GO BILL BY BILL OFFERS
WILL TAKE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX MINUS OR ONE IS THERE
ANY.
ANYBODY IT WISHES TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THIS TIME.
I'M EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SIX AT
THE END OF THE RE ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
AND CHILDREN NOW SPONSORS OF THE
BILL SPORTS ARTS TALK.
WE'RE ON A FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
RIGHT NOW -- SORRY I JUST HEARD
A STATE STAY THERE.
DON'T GO FOURTEEN SIXTY SIXTEEN
OF SUPPORTER OPPOSITION AND WE
HAVE.
SOME OF THOSE ARE MOVED AND
SECONDED A SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH AMENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
HI O'DONNELL I KILEY.
KILEY I'D KALRA.
OUR EYES MCCARTY HI MCCARTY EYES
SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER AYE.
THOSE OUT IT HAS A ZERO TWO SIX
SIX OUT -- WELL MODIFY ITEM
THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY MISTER REAVIS --
DOES ANYBODY WISH.
TO OUT ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
SINGLE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SINGLE COMMON TO
EMOTION SO MOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
BY MISTER MCCARTY SECTOR-LIMóN
SMITH -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YEAR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN.
A N APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
KALRA.
COLORIZED MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE AYES SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
YES SIX VOTERS OUT THAT'S AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY FOUR NOW GOING TO
FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
I MUST KALRA MISTER KALRA --
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AGAIN -- AT
THE NOTED SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
SEC GOOD EVENING LEE ANGELA READ
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- I OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND AND FORTY AND THE I AM
CHILDREN NOW SPONSORS THE BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY SINGLE
OPPOSITION BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SAY NO COMMENT TO
EMOTION [inaudible]
REMOTE. SEVEN SECONDED IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I WEBER.
WEBER AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE. ZERO SIX VOTES IT IS OUT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO LEAVE
TO COMPLETE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES.
IT IS NOT GOING.
SO I THINK THAT.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THAT.
IT IS TO IT YEAH ALMOST CAN'T
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADD
ONS MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO ADD
ON ANY BILL PLEASE STAY SEATED
WITH YOUR MICROPHONES ON WITH
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED